hi everyone welcome to this data science
2022 full course video by simplyloan in
this video you will learn all the
necessary skills that will help you
become a data scientist in 2022
our highly experienced instructors will
take you through this course
data scientists are some of the highly
paid professionals in the world they
work on data from multiple sources to
derive insights
now let's look at the topics that we'll
be covering in this video
so we will start by looking at the
basics of data science from a short
animated video
then you will learn the data science
process steps their applications and
then look at the top five python
libraries for data science
next you will understand the top
algorithms that data scientists use to
build predictive models so you will
learn about linear regression logistic
regression and symbol learning methods k
nnn clustering principal component
analysis and other techniques
after that we will touch upon some of
the crucial concepts in deep learning
using tensorflow and keras
finally you will get an idea about the
top data science interview questions
that are frequently asked in the
interviews so let's get started
are you one of the many who dreams of
becoming a data scientist keep watching
this video if you're passionate about
data science because we will tell you
how does it really work under the hood
emma is a data scientist let's see how a
day in her life goes while she's working
on a data science project
well it is very important to understand
the business problem first in our
meeting with the clients emma asks
relevant questions understands and
defines objectives for the problem that
needs to be tackled she is a curious
soul who asks a lot of eyes one of the
many traits of a good data scientist
now she gears up for data acquisition to
gather and scrape data from multiple
sources like web servers logs databases
apis and online repositories oh it seems
like finding the right data takes both
time and effort after the data is
gathered comes data preparation this
step involves data cleaning and data
transformation data cleaning is the most
time consuming process as it involves
handling many complex scenarios here
emma deals with inconsistent data types
misspelled attributes missing values
duplicate values and what not then in
data transformation she modifies the
data based on defined mapping rules in a
project etl tools like talent and
informatica are used to perform complex
transformations that helps the team to
understand the data structure better
then understanding what you actually can
do with your data is very crucial for
that emr does exploratory data analysis
with the help of eda she defines and
refines the selection of feature
variables that will be used in the model
development but what if emma skips this
step she might end up choosing the wrong
variables which will produce an
inaccurate model thus exploratory data
analysis becomes the most important step
now she proceeds to the core activity of
a data science project such as data
modeling she repetitively applies
diverse machine learning techniques like
k n decision tree knife base to the data
to identify the model that best fits the
business requirement she trains the
models on the training data set and
tests them to select the best performing
model emma prefers python for modeling
the data however it can also be done
using r and sas well the trickiest part
is not yet over visualization and
communication emma meets the clients
again to communicate the business
findings in a simple and effective
manner to convince the stakeholders she
uses tools like tableau power bi and
qlikview that can help her in creating
powerful reports and
finally maintains the model she tests
the selected model in a pre-production
environment before deploying it in the
production environment which is the best
practice right after successfully
deploying it she uses reports and
dashboards to get real-time analytics
further she also monitors and maintains
the project's performance well that's
how emma completes the data science
project we have seen the daily routine
of a data scientist is a whole lot of
fun has a lot of interesting aspects and
comes with its own share of challenges
now let's see how data science is
changing the world data science
techniques along with genomic data
provides a deeper understanding of
genetic issues in reaction to particular
drugs and diseases logistic companies
like dhl fedex have discovered the best
rules to ship the best suited time to
deliver the best mode of transport to
choose thus leading to cost efficiency
with data science it is possible to not
only predict employee attrition but to
also understand the key variables that
influence employee turnover also the
airline companies can now easily predict
flight delay and notify the passengers
beforehand to enhance their travel
experience well if you're wondering
there are various roles offered to a
data scientist like data analyst machine
learning engineer deep learning engineer
data engineer and of course data
scientist the median base salaries of a
data scientist can range from 95 000 to
165 000
so that was about the data science are
you ready to be a data scientist if yes
then start today the world of data needs
you that's all from my side today thank
you for watching comment below the next
topic that you want to learn and
subscribe to simply learn to get the
latest updates on more such interesting
videos thank you and keep learning
so what are the prerequisites for
data science there are three essential
traits required for to be a data
scientist one is curiosity you need to
be able to ask questions the first step
in data science is asking question what
is the problem you are trying to solve
if you ask the right question only then
you'll get the right answer very often
this is a very crucial step where a lot
of data science projects fail because
you're you may be asking the wrong
question and then obviously when you get
the answer that's not the answer you're
looking for so it is very important that
you ask the right question needless to
say then the second part or the second
trait is common sense so you need to be
creative you need to come up with ways
to use the data that you have and try to
solve the business problem on hand in
many cases you may not have all the data
that you need in many cases the data may
be incomplete so that is where you need
to come up with ways what are the best
ways to fill these gaps wherever this is
missing and that's where common sense
comes into play last but not least after
doing all this analysis if you're unable
to communicate the results in the right
way the whole exercise will fail so
communication is a key trait for a data
scientist maybe technically you may be a
genius but then if you are unable to
communicate those results in a proper
way once again that will not help so
these are the three main traits
curiosity common sense and communication
skills in a way you can say these are
the three c's okay so what are the other
prerequisites first one so machine
learning machine learning is the
backbone of data science data science
involves quite a bit of machine learning
in addition to the basic statistics that
we do so a data scientist needs to have
a good hang or need to be very good at
data science the second part is
modeling so modeling is also a part of
machine learning in a way but you need
to be
good at identifying what are the
algorithms that are more suitable to
solve a given problem what models can we
use and
how do we train these models and so on
and so forth so that is the second
component then statistics statistics is
like the core foundation of data science
so you need to understand statistics and
you need to have a good hang of
statistics in order to be a good data
scientist and this will also help in
getting good results programming is to
some extent required at least some
program or the other would be required
as a part of executing the data science
project the most common programming
languages are python and r python
specially is becoming a very popular
programming language in data science
because of its ease of learning because
of the multiple
libraries that it supports for
performing data science and
machine learning and so on so python is
by far one of the most popular languages
in data science if any one of you is
wanting to learn a new language that
should be python and then of course you
need to
understand databases how databases work
and how to handle databases how to get
data out of databases and so on so these
are some of the key components of data
science now coming to the tools and
skills that are used in data science
these are some of the skills from a
language perspective it is python or r
and from a skills perspective in
addition to some of the programming
languages it would help if you have a
good knowledge or good understanding of
statistics and what are the tools that
are used in data analysis sas is one of
the most popular tools it's been there
for very long time and
that's the reason it is very popular and
however this is compared to most of the
other tools it is a proprietary software
whereas python and r are mostly open
source the other tools are like jupiter
jupiter notebooks you have r studio
these are more development environments
and development tools so jupyter
notebooks is a interactive development
environment
similarly rstudio is for performing or
writing our code and performing
analytics and
performing data analysis and machine
learning activities you can perform in
rstudio it has a very nice ui and
initially r was not so popular primarily
because it did not have user interface
and rstudio is a relatively new edition
and after the advent of rstudio r became
extremely popular and there are other
tools like matlab and of course some
people do with excel as well as far as
data warehousing is concerned some of
the skills that are required are etl so
in order to extract data and
transform load etl stands for extract
transform load so you have data in the
databases like your erp system or a crm
system you need to extract that and then
do some transformations and then load it
into your warehouse so that all the data
from various sources looks uniform then
you need some sql skills which is
basically querying the data writing sql
queries hadoop is another important
skill especially if you are handling
large amounts of data and also
one of the specialities of hadoop is it
can be used for handling unstructured
data as well so it can be used for large
amounts of structured and unstructured
data then spark is a excellent computing
engine for performing data analysis or
machine learning in a distributed mode
so if you have large amount of data the
combination of spark and hadoop can be
extremely powerful so you store your
data in hadoop hdfs and use spark as
your computation engine it works in a
distributed mode similar to hadoop
like a cluster so that those are
excellent skills for data warehousing
and there are some standard tools that
are available like informatica data
stage talent and also aws redshift if
you want to do some on the cloud i think
aws redshift is again a good tool data
visualization tools for data
visualization some of the skills that
would be required are let's say r u r
provides some very good visualization
capabilities especially for for
developing during development and then
you have python libraries matplotlib and
so on which provides very powerful
visualization capabilities and that is
from skills perspective whereas tools
that can be used are tableau is a very
very popular visualization tool again
that's a proprietary tool so it's a
little expensive maybe but excellent
capabilities from a visualization
perspective then there are tools like
cognos which is an ibm product which
provides very good visualization
capabilities as well and then coming to
the machine learning part of it the
skills required there are python which
is more for programming part and then
you will need some
mathematical skills like algebra linear
algebra especially and then statistics
and maybe a little bit of calculus and
so on and the tools that are used for
machine learning are spark mlib and
apache mahou and on cloud if you want to
do something
you can use microsoft azure ml studio as
well so these are by no means an
exhaustive list there are actually many
many tools and probably a few more
skills also maybe there but this is this
gives a quick overview like a
summarizing of summarization of the
tools and skills now moving on to the
life of a data scientist what does a
data scientist do during the course of
his work so let's see so typically a
data scientist is given a problem a
business problem that he needs to solve
and in order to do that if you remember
from the previous slide he basically
asks the question as to what is the
problem that he needs to solve so that
is the first thing he has got the
problem then the next thing is to gather
the data that is required to solve this
problem so he goes about looking for
data from anywhere it could be the
enterprise very often the data is not
provided in the nice format that he
would like to have it or we would like
to have it so
first step is to get whatever data that
is possible what is known as raw data in
whatever format so it could be
enterprise data it could be it is a
probably a requirement to go and get
some public data in some cases so all
that raw data is collected and then that
is processed and analyzed and in
prepared into a format in which it can
be used and then it is fed into the
analytic system be it a machine learning
algorithm or a statistical model and we
get the output and then he puts these
output in a proper format for presenting
it to the stakeholders and communicating
those insights or the results to the
stakeholders so this is a very high
level
view of like a a day in the life of a
data scientist so gathering data raw
data performing some quick analysis on
that and maybe processing or
manipulating this data to bring it into
a certain good format so that it can be
used for the analysis feeding this into
that analysis system that has been
designed be it mathematical models
machine learning models and then
get the results the insights and then
present it in a nice way so that the
stakeholders can understand how about
machine learning algorithms so let's see
what are the various machine learning
algorithms that would be required for a
data scientist so these are a few of the
algorithms again there's not an
exhaustive list
we have regression is one of the
supervised learning models or techniques
so in case of regression you try to
let's say
come up with a continuous number so the
difference between regression and let's
say a classification is that in case of
classification those are discrete values
whereas here we are talking about
regression where you let's say you are
trying to predict the temperature which
is a continuous value or the share price
which is a continuous value so that is
regression so you need to know what is
regression how to perform regression and
we need to understand clustering so
clustering is one of the
unsupervised learning techniques in this
case there is no label data that is
available and you get some data and then
you want to put this into some shape so
that you can analyze it and you try to
make sense out of it let's say you have
one example is you have a list of
cricketers and
they have not been marked as bowlers and
batsmen or all renders or whatever right
so you just have their names and maybe
how many runs this code how many wickets
they have taken and so on but there is
no readily available information saying
that okay this person is a batsman this
person is a bowler and so on so i'm
talking about cricket hopefully most of
you are familiar with the game of
cricket so how do we find out so then we
put this into a clustering mechanism and
then the system will say that okay these
are the people who are all who have all
scored good amount of runs so they
belong to one cluster these are all the
people who have taken good amount of
wickets so they belong to one cluster
and maybe here are some people who have
taken good amount of wickets and they
have made good amount of runs so they
may be belonging to one group and then
we take a look at it and then we label
them as okay people who have all
together and those who have you know
scored many runs they have we label them
as batsmen people have taken a lot of
wickets we label them as bowlers and
people who have taken
good amount of wickets and also made
some good runs we label them as all
rounders but the system will just say
okay this is cluster one cluster two
cluster 3 the names we give we human
beings have to give the names now
decision tree is used for what is known
as classification primarily it can also
be used for regression but by and large
it is used for classification and here
again it's a very
logical
way in which the algorithm goes about
classifying the various inputs one of
the biggest advantages of decision tree
is that it's very easy to understand and
it's very easy to explain why a certain
object has been classified in a certain
way compared to maybe some of the other
mechanisms like say support vector
machines or
logistic regression and so on so that's
the advantage of dictionary but that is
also very popular algorithm then we have
support vector machines primarily for
classification purpose and
then we have naive bayes this is a
statistical probability based
classification method so these are a few
algorithms there are a few more that are
not listed here but there are some more
algorithms as well and by the way there
are
more detailed or there are detailed
videos about each of these algorithms
available you can check in the playlist
so now let's talk about the life cycle
of a data science project okay the first
step is the concept study in this step
it involves understanding the business
problem asking questions get a good
understanding of the business model meet
up with all the stakeholders understand
what kind of data is available and all
that is a part of the first step so here
are a few examples we want to see what
are the various specifications and then
what is the end goal
what is the budget is there an example
of this kind of a problem that has been
maybe solved earlier so all this is a
part of the concept study and another
example could be a very specific one to
predict the price of a 1.35 carat
diamond and there may be relevant
information inputs that are available
and we want to predict the price the
next step in this process is data
preparation data gathering and data
preparation also known as data munching
or sometimes it is also known as data
manipulation so what happens here is the
raw data that is available may not be
usable in its current format for various
reasons so that is why in this step a
data scientist would explore the data he
will take a look at some sample data
maybe there are millions of records pick
a few thousand records and see how the
data is looking are there any gaps is
the structure appropriate to be fed into
the system are there some columns which
are probably
not adding value may not be required for
the analysis very often these are like
names of the customers they will
probably not add any value or much value
from an analysis perspective the
structure of the data maybe the data is
coming from multiple data sources and
the structures may not be matching what
are the other problems there may be gaps
in the data so the data all the columns
all the cells are not filled if you're
talking about structured data there are
several blank records or blank columns
so
if you
use that data directly you'll get errors
or you will get inaccurate results so
how do you either get rid of the data or
how do you fill this gaps with something
meaningful so all that is a part of data
munching or data manipulation so these
are some additional
sub topics within that so data
integration is one of them if there are
any conflicts in the data there may be
data may be redundant data resident
redundancy is another issue there may be
you have let's say data coming from two
different systems and both of them have
customer table for example customer
information so when you merge them there
is a duplication issue so how do we
resolve that so that is one data
transformation as i said there will be
situations where data is coming from
multiple sources and then when we merge
them together they may not be matching
so we need to do some transformations to
make sure everything is similar we may
have to do some data reduction if the
data size is too big you may have to
come up with ways to reduce it
meaningfully without losing information
then data cleaning so there will be
either wrong values or you know values
or there are missing values so how do
you handle all of that a few examples of
very specific stuff so there are missing
values how do you handle missing values
or null values here in this particular
slide we are seeing three types of
issues one is missing value then you
have null value you see the difference
between the two right so in the missing
value there is nothing blank null value
it says null now the system cannot
handle if there are null values
similarly there is improper data so it's
supposed to be numeric value but there
is a string or a non-numeric value so
how do we clean
and prepare the data so that our system
can work flawlessly so there are
multiple ways and there is no one common
way of doing this it can vary from
project to project it can vary from what
exactly is the problem we're trying to
solve it can vary from data scientist to
data scientist organization to
organizations so these are like some
standard practices people come up with
and and of course there will be a lot of
trial and error somebody would have
tried out something and it worked and
will continue to use that mechanism so
that's how we need to take care of data
cleaning now what are the various ways
of doing you know if values are missing
how do you take care of that now if the
data is too large and
only a few records have some missing
values then it is okay to just get rid
of those entire rows for example so if
you have a million records and out of
which 100 records don't have full data
so there are some missing values in
about 100 cards so it's absolutely fine
because it's a small percentage of the
data so you can get rid of the entire
records which are missing values but
that's not a very common situation very
often you will have multiple or at least
a large number of data set for example
out of million records you may have 50
000 records which are like having
missing values now that's a significant
amount you cannot get rid of all those
records your analysis will be inaccurate
so how do you handle such situations so
there are again multiple ways of doing
it one is you can probably if a
particular values are missing in a
particular column you can probably take
the mean value for that particular
column and fill all the missing values
with the mean value so that first of all
you don't get errors because of missing
values and second you don't get results
that are way off because these values
are completely different from what is
there so that is one way then a few
other could be either taking the median
value or depending on what kind of data
we are talking about so something
meaningful we will have put in there if
we are doing some
machine learning activity then obviously
as a part of data preparation you need
to split the data into training and test
data set the reason being if you try to
test with a data set which the system
has already seen as a part of training
then it will tend to give reasonably
accurate results because it has already
seen that data and that is not a good
measure of the accuracy of the system so
typically you take the entire data set
the input data set and split it into two
parts and again the ratio can vary from
person to person individual preferences
some people like to split it into 50 50
some people like it as 63 63.33
and 33.3 is basically two third and one
third and some people do it as 80 20 80
for training and 24 testing so you split
the data perform the training with the
80 percent and then use the remaining 20
for testing all right so that is one
more data preparation activity that
needs to be done before you start
analyzing or applying the data or
putting the data through the model then
the next step is model planning now this
models can be statistical models this
could be machine learning model so you
need to decide what kind of models
you're going to use again it depends on
what is the problem you're trying to
solve if it is a regression problem you
need to think of a regression algorithm
and come up with a regression model so
it could be linear regression or if
you're talking about classification then
you need to pick up an appropriate
classification algorithm like logistic
regression or decision tree or svm and
then you need to train that particular
model so that is the model building or
model planning process and the cleaned
up data has to be fed into the model and
apart from cleaning you may also have to
in order to determine what kind of model
you will use
you have to perform some exploratory
data analysis to understand the
relationship between the various
variables and
see if the data is appropriate and so on
right so that is the additional
preparatory step that needs to be done
so a little bit of details about
exploratory data analysis so what
exactly is exploratory data analysis
basically to as the name suggests you're
just exploring you just receive the data
and you're trying to explore and
find out what are the data types and
what is the is the data clean in in each
of the columns what is the maximum
minimum value so for example there are
out of the box functionality available
in tools like r so if you just ask for a
summary of the table it will tell you
for each column it will give some
details as to what is the mean value
what is the maximum value and so on and
so forth so this exercise or this
exploratory analysis is to get an
understanding of your data and then you
can take steps to during this process
you find that a lot of missing values
you need to take steps to fix those you
will also get an idea about what kind of
model to be used and so on and so forth
what are the various techniques used for
exploratory data analysis typically
these would be
visualization techniques like you use
histograms uh you can use box plots you
can use scatter plots so
these are very quick ways of identifying
the patterns or a few of the trends of
the data and so on and then once your
data is ready you you decided on the
model what kind of model what kind of
algorithm you're going to use if you're
trying to do machine learning you need
to pass your 80 percent the training
data or rather you use that training
data to train your model and the
training process itself is iterative so
the training process you may have to
perform multiple times and once the
training is done and you feel it is
giving good accuracy then you move on to
test so you take the remaining 20 of the
data remember we split the data into
training and test so the test data is
now used to check the accuracy or how
well our model is performing and if
there are further issues let's say and
model is still
during testing and the accuracy is not
good then you may want to retrain your
model or use a different model so this
whole thing again can be iterative but
if the test process is passed or if the
model passes the test then it can go
into production and it will be deployed
all right so what are the various tools
that we use for
model planning r is an excellent tool in
a lot of ways whether you're doing
regular statistical analysis or machine
learning or any of these activities are
in along with our studio provides a very
powerful environment to do data analysis
including visualization it has a very
good integrated visualization of plot
mechanism which can be used for doing
exploratory data analysis and then later
on to do analysis detailed analysis and
machine learning and so on and so forth
then of course you can write python
programs python offers a rich library
for performing data analysis and machine
learning and so on matlab is a very
popular tool as well especially during
education so this is a very easy to
learn tool so matlab is another
tool that can be used and then last but
not least sas sas is again very powerful
it is a preparatory tool and it has all
the components that are required to
perform very good statistical analysis
or perform data science so those are the
various tools that would be required for
or that that can be used for model
building and
so the next step is model building so we
have done the planning part we said okay
what is algorithm we are going to use
what kind of model we are going to use
now we need to actually train this model
or build the model rather so that it can
then be deployed so what are the various
uh ways or what are the various types of
model building activities so it could be
let's say in this particular example
that we have taken you want to find out
the price of 1.35 carat diamond so this
is let's say a linear regression problem
you have data for various carets of
diamond and you use that information you
pass it through a linear regression
model or you create a linear regression
model which can then predict your price
for 1.35 carat so this is one example of
model building and then little bit
details of how linear regression works
so linear regression is basically coming
up with a relation between an
independent variable and a dependent
variable so it is pretty much like
coming up with equation of a straight
line which is the best fit for the given
data so like for example here y is equal
to mx plus c so y is the dependent
variable and x is the independent
variable we need to determine the values
of m and c for our given data so that is
what the training process of this model
does at the end of the training process
you have a certain value of m and c and
that is used for predicting the values
of any new data that comes all right so
the way it works is we use the training
and the test data set to
train the model and then validate
whether the model is working fine or not
using test data and
if it is working fine then it is taken
to the next level which is put in
production if not the model has to be
retrained if the accuracy is not good
enough then the model is retrained maybe
with more data or you come up with a
newer model or algorithm and then repeat
that process so it is an iterative
process once the training is completed
training and test then this model is
deployed and we can use this particular
model to determine what is the price of
1.35 carat diamond remember that was our
problem statement so now that we have
the best fit for this given data we have
the price of 1.35 carat diamond which is
10 000. so this is one example of how
this whole process works now how do we
build the model there are multiple ways
you can use python for example and use
libraries like pandas or numpy to build
the model and implement it this will be
available as a separate tutorial a
separate video in this playlist so
stay tuned for that moving on once we
have the results the next step is to
communicate this results to the
appropriate stakeholders so which is
basically taking this results and
preparing like a presentation or a
dashboard and communicating these
results to the concerned people so
finishing or getting the results of the
analysis is not the last step but you
need to as a data scientist take this
results and present it to the team that
has given you this problem in the first
place and explain your findings explain
the findings of this exercise and
recommend maybe what steps they need to
take in order to overcome this problem
or solve this problem so that is the
pretty much once that is accepted and
the last step is to operationalize so if
everything is fine your data scientist
presentations are accepted then they put
it into practice and thereby they will
be able to improve or solve the problem
that they stated in step one okay so
quick summary of the life cycle you have
a concept study which is basically
understanding the problem asking the
right questions and trying to see if
there is enough data to solve this
problem and then even maybe gather the
data then data preparation the raw data
needs to be manipulated you need to do
data munching so that you have a data in
a certain proper format to be used by
the model or our analytics system and
then you need to do the model planning
what kind of a model what algorithm you
will use for a given problem and then
the model building so the exact
execution of that model it happens in
step four and
you implement and execute that model and
put the data through the analysis in
this step and then you get the results
this results are then communicated
packaged and presented and communicated
to the stakeholders and once that is
accepted that is operationalized so that
is the final step now in the end let's
take a quick look at the demand for data
scientists data science is an area of
great demand the demand for data
scientists is currently huge and the
supply is very low so there is a huge
gap so what are some of the industries
with high demand for data scientists i
think gaming is definitely one area
where it's a industry which is consumer
facing industry and a lot of people play
games and growing industry and it
requires a lot of data science so that
is an area where data scientists are in
demand then we have healthcare for
example data science is used for
diagnosis and several other activities
within healthcare predicting for example
a disease so healthcare is definitely
finance definitely banks insurance
companies all of these there is a huge
demand for data scientists marketing is
like a horizontal functionality across
all industries there's a demand for data
scientists there then of course in
technology area so pretty much all of
these areas there is a lot of demand
globally there is a huge demand so this
is a very very critical skill that would
be required currently as well as in the
future
so we talk about solving problems with
data science
we have to ask possible questions and
the desired algorithms and these really
are uh kind of an overview of some of
the terminology you'll want to know in
data science
so we talk about that how much or how
many we're talking about regression
regression basically means a number if
you've ever seen stock charts you see
[Music]
the guess at what the next sales price
is or buy price is
that's all on your regression side
is it a orb classification
is that a dog or a cat that my photo
took a picture of how is this organized
clustering this is where we take things
that look alike and put them together so
that we can then make predictions on it
how difference is this
just like you have clustering you have
the opposite anomaly detection how do we
find things that don't fit in where the
outliers what are things we might need
to look at that aren't in our model
and what to do next reinforced learning
this is probably the newest market is
how do we set something up whereas the
data comes in it learns from the new
data as to what the next action is going
to take
most of these are combined so we talk
about regression classification
clustering anomaly detection reinforced
learning
a lot of times when you put your model
together you might have multiple parts
of this we might look at the clustering
of data
and then feed it into a classification
is this a
bad loan to make it the bank or is this
a good loan to give
and from there we might start looking at
when we start clustering these things as
good and bad and what kind of setup is
we then might run it through a
regression model to say hey what is the
amount dollar amount this person
should be allowed to take a loan out
and you can see that all of these start
coming in and then
a lot of the models
reinforce learning
we talk about like bank loans and things
like that once a year
they have to rerun those algorithms and
so that's like a human run reinforced
learning
now we're starting to automate that so
that as the data comes in real time the
models start updating themselves
they start figuring out a way to solve
new problems as they occur
and of course in robotics reinforced
learning is one of the biggest growing
fields
logarithms used in data science linear
regression
logistic regression when you're looking
at both of these
think numbers we're talking regression
models and so linear regression figures
out the best line through the data maybe
it's looking for a curved line
logistic regression starts looking at
data
on a continuum
so that it goes to an exponential you
have a spot where it might be one or the
other and then you know what it is as it
goes to one side or the other
decision tree
wonderful tool if you
used to call it a hack now it's becoming
mainstream to look at the back end what
made the decision so it's really easy to
trace back to how you arrived at the
decision decision trees are kind of nice
that way
nearest neighbors k nearest neighbors is
your clustering k means clustering
hierarchical clustering
so hierarchical starts dividing them and
builds a hierarchy where the k-means and
the k-nearest neighbor look for things
that kind of connect each other how
close are they in data format
db scan another form of clustering your
data principle component analysis so we
start breaking up and looking at the
different components in our data coming
in these are all algorithms used in data
science and there are more these are
kind of the mainline ones and each one
of these has many settings which you can
play with
to build a better model to predict your
data and where you want it to go
python is the most widely used
programming language today when it comes
to solving data science tasks and
challenges python never ceases to
surprise its audience most data
scientists out there are already
leveraging the power of python every day
hi i'm apeksha from simplylearn and well
after some thought and a bit more
research i was finally able to narrow
down my choice of top python libraries
for data science what are they let's
find out so let's talk about this
amazing library tensorflow which is also
one of my favorites so tensorflow is a
library for high performance numerical
computations with around 35 000 github
commits and a vibrant community of
around 1500 contributors and it's used
across various scientific domains it's
basically a framework where we can
define and run computations which
involves tensors and tensors we can see
are partially defined computational
objects again where they will eventually
produce a value that was about
tensorflow let's talk about the features
of tensorflow so tensorflow is majorly
used in deep learning models and neural
networks where we have other libraries
like torch and thiano also but
tensorflow has hands down better
computational graphical visualizations
when compared to them also tensorflow
reduces the error largely by 50 to 60
percent in neural machine translations
it's highly parallel in a way where can
train multiple neural networks and
multiple gpus for highly efficient and
scalable models this parallel computing
feature of tensorflow is also called
pipelining also tensorflow has the
advantage of seamless performance as
it's backed by google it has quicker
updates frequent new releases with the
latest of features now let's look at
some applications tensorflow is
extensively used in speech and image
recognition text based applications time
series analysis and forecasting and
various other applications involving
video detection so favorite thing about
tensorflow that it's already popular
among the machine learning community and
most are open to trying it and some of
us are already using it now let's look
at an example of a tensorflow model in
this example we will not dive deep into
the explanation of the model as it is
beyond the scope of this video so here
we are using amnest dataset which
consists of images of handwritten digits
handwritten digits can be easily
recognized by building a simple
tensorflow model let's see how when we
visualize our data using matplotlib
library the inputs will look something
like this then we create our tensorflow
model to create a basic tensorflow model
we need to initialize the variables and
start a session then after training the
model we can validate the data and then
predict the accuracy this model has
predicted 92 accuracy let's see which is
pretty well for this model so that's all
for tensorflow if you need to understand
this tutorial in detail then you can go
ahead and watch our deep learning
tutorial from simply learn as shown in
the right corner interesting right let's
move on to the next library now let's
talk about a common yet a very powerful
python library called numpy numpy is a
fundamental package for numerical
computation in python it stands for
numerical python as the name suggests it
has around 18 000 comments on github
with an active community of 700
contributors it's a general purpose
array processing package in a way that
it provides high performance
multi-dimensional objects called arrays
and tools for working with them also
numpy addresses the slowness problem
partly by providing these
multi-dimensional arrays that we talked
about and then functions and operators
that operate efficiently on these arrays
interesting right now let's talk about
features of number it's very easy to
work with large arrays and mattresses
using numpy numpy fully supports object
oriented approach for example coming
back to nd array once again it's a class
possessing numerous methods and
attributes ndra provides for larger and
repeated computations numpy offers
vectorization it's more faster and
compact than traditional methods i
always wanted to get rid of loops and
vectorization of numpy clearly helps me
with that now let's talk about the
applications of numpy numpy along with
pandas is extensively used in data
analysis which forms the basis of data
science it helps in creating the
powerful n-dimensional array whenever we
talk about numpy the mention of the
array we cannot do it without the
mention of the powerful n-dimensional
array also number is extensively used in
machine learning when we are creating
machine learning models as in where it
forms the base of other libraries like
sci-fi scikit-learn etc when you start
creating the machine learning models in
data science you will realize that all
the models will have their bases numpy
or pandas also
when number is used with scipy and
matplotlib it can be used as a
replacement of matlab now let's look at
a simple example of an array in numpy as
you can see here there are multiple
array manipulation routines like there
are basic examples where you can copy
the values from one array to another we
can give a new shape to an array from
maybe one dimensional we can make it as
a two-dimensional array we can return a
copy of the array collapsed into one
dimension now let's look at an example
where this is a jubilee notebook and we
will just create a basic array and
for detailed explanation you can watch
our other videos which targets on these
explanations of each libraries so first
of all whenever we are using any library
in python we have to import it so now
this np is the alias which we will be
using let's create a simple array
let's look what is the type of this
array
so this is an end array type of array
also let's look what's the shape of this
array
so this is a shape of the array now here
we saw that we can expand the shape of
the array
so this is where you can change the
shape of the array using all those
functions now let's create another using
arrange functions if i give arrange 12
it will give me a 1d array of 12 numbers
like this now we can reshape this array
to 3 comma 4 or we can write it here
itself
so this is how our range function and
the reshape function works for numpy now
let's discuss the next library which is
scipy so this is another free and open
source python library extensively used
in data science for high level
computations so this library as the name
suggests stands for scientific python
and it has around 19 000 comments on
github with an active community of 600
contributors it is extensively used for
scientific and technical computations
also as it extends numpy it provides
many user-friendly and efficient
routines for scientific calculations now
let's discuss about some features of
sci-fi so sci-fi has this collection of
algorithms and functions which is built
on the numpy extension of python
secondly it has various high-level
commands for data manipulation and
visualization also the ndmh function of
scipy is very useful in
multi-dimensional image processing and
it includes built-in functions for
solving differential equations linear
algebra and many more so that was about
the features of scipy now let's discuss
its applications so cyber is used in
multi-dimensional image operations it
has functions to read images from disk
into number arrays to write arrays to
discuss images resize images etc solving
differential equations fourier
transforms then optimization algorithms
linear algebra etc let's look at a
simple example to learn what kind of
functions are there in sci by here i'm
importing the constants package of scipy
library so in this package it has all
the constants
so here i am just mentioning c or h or
any and this library already knows what
it has to fetch like speed of light
planck's constant etc so this can be
used in further calculations data
analysis is an integral part of data
science data scientists spend most of
the day in data munching and then
cleaning the data also hence mention of
pandas is a must in data science life
cycle yes pandas is the most popular and
widely used python library for data
science along with numpy and matplotlib
the name itself stands for python data
analysis with around 17 000 comments on
github and an active community of 1200
contributors it is heavily used for data
analysis and cleaning as it provides
fast flexible data structures like data
frames series which are designed to work
with structured data very easily and
intuitively now let's talk about some
features of pandas so panas offers this
eloquent syntax and rich functionalities
like there are various methods in pandas
like drop n a fill n a which gives you
the freedom to deal with missing data
also panas provides a powerful apply
function which lets you create your own
function and run it across a series of
data now forget about writing those for
loops while using pandas also this
library's high level abstraction over
low level numpy which is written in pure
c then it also contains these high level
data structures and manipulation tools
which makes it very easy to work with
pandas like their data structures and
series now let's discuss the
applications of pandas so panas is
extensively used in general data
wrangling and data cleaning then pandas
also finds its usage in edl jobs for
data transformation and data storage as
it has excellent support for loading csv
files into its data frame format then
pandas is used in a variety of academic
and commercial domains including
statistics finance neuroscience
economics web analytics etc then pandas
is also very useful in time series
specific functionality like date range
generation moving window linear
regression date shifting etc now let's
look at a very simple example of how to
create a data frame so data frame is a
very useful data structure in pandas and
it has very powerful functionalities so
here i'm only enlisting important
libraries in data science you can
explore more of our videos to learn
about these libraries in detail so let's
just go ahead and create a data frame
i'm using jupyter notebook again and in
this before using pandas here i'm
importing the pandas library
let me go and run this so in data frame
we can import a file a csv file excel
files there are many functions doing
these things and we can also create our
own data and put it into data frame so
here i am taking random data and putting
in a data frame also i'm creating an
index and then also giving the column
names so pd is the alias we've given
pandas random data of 6x4 index which is
taking a range of six numbers and column
name i'm giving as abcd now let's go
ahead and look at it
so here it has created a data frame with
my column names abcd
my list has six numbers zero to five and
a random data of six by four so data
frame is just another table with rows
and columns where you can do various
functions over it also i can go ahead
and describe this data frame to see so
it's giving me all these functionalities
where count and mean and standard
deviation etc okay so that was about
pandas now let's talk about next library
and the last one so matplotlib for me is
the most fun library out of all of them
why because it has such powerful yet
beautiful visualizations we'll see in
the coming slides plot and matplotlib
suggests that it's a plotting library
for python it has around 26 000 comments
on github and a very vibrant community
of 700 contributors and because of such
graphs and plots that it produces it's
majorly used for data visualization and
also because it provides an object
oriented api which can be used to embed
those plots into our applications let's
talk about the features of matplotlib
the pi plot module of matplotlib
provides matlab-like interface so
matplotlib is designed to be as usable
as matlab with an advantage of being
free and open source also it supports
dozens of back-ends and output types
which means you can use it regardless of
which operating system you're using or
which output format you wish pandas
itself can be used as wrappers around
matplotlib's api so as to drive
matplotlib via cleaner and more modern
apis also when you start using this
library you will realize that it has a
very little memory consumption and a
very good runtime behavior now let's
talk about the applications of
matplotlib it's important to discover
the unknown relationship between the
variables in your data set so this
library helps to visualize the
correlation analysis of variables also
in machine learning we can visualize 95
percent confidence interval of the model
just to communicate how well our model
fits the data then mat modular finds its
application and outlier detection using
scatter plot etc and to visualize the
distribution of data to gain instant
insights now let's make a very simple
plot to get a basic idea i've already
imported the libraries here so this
function matplotlib inline will help you
show the plots in the jupiter notebook
this is also called a magic function i
won't be able to display my plots in the
jupiter notebook if i don't use this
function i am using this function in
numpy to fix random state for
reproducibility now i'll take my n as 30
and will assign random values to my
variables so this function is generating
30 random numbers here i'm trying to
create a scatter plot so i want to
decide the area
let's
put this so this is multiplying 30 with
random numbers to the power 2 so that we
get the area of the plot which we will
see in just a minute so using the
scatter function and the alias of
matplotlib as plt i've created this if i
don't use this and i have very small
circles as my scatter plot it's colorful
it's nice so that's one very easy plot i
suggest that you explore more of
matplotlib and i'm sure you will enjoy
it let's create a histogram so i'm using
my the style as gg plot and assigning
some values to these variables any
random values
now we are assigning bars and colors and
alignment to the plot and here we get
the graph so we can create different
type of visualizations and plots and
then work upon them using matplotlib and
it's just that simple so that was about
the leading python libraries in the
field of data science but along with
these libraries data scientists are also
leveraging the power of some other
useful libraries for example like
tensorflow keras is another popular
library which is extensively used for
deep learning and neural network modules
keras drafts both tensorflow and theano
backends so it is a good option if you
don't want to dive into details of
tensorflow then scikit learn is a
machine learning library it provides
almost all the machine learning
algorithms that you need and it is
designed to interpolate with numpy and
sci-by then we have c bond which is
another library for data visualization
we can say that seaborn is an
enhancement of matplotlib as it
introduces additional blood types
and let's understand linear regression
and dig into the theory
understanding linear regression
linear regression is the statistical
model used to predict the relationship
between independent and dependent
variables by examining two factors
the first important one is which
variables in particular are significant
predictors of the outcome variable and
the second one that we need to look at
closely is how significant is the
regression line to make predictions with
the highest possible accuracy if it's
inaccurate we can't use it so it's very
important we find out the most accurate
line we can get
since linear regression is based on
drawing a line through data we're going
to jump back and take a look at some
euclidean geometry the simplest form of
a simple linear regression equation with
one dependent and one independent
variable is represented by y equals
m times x plus c and if you look at our
model here we plotted two points on here
x1 and y1 x2 and y2 y being the
dependent variable remember that from
before and x being the independent
variable so y depends on whatever x is m
in this case is the slope of the line
where m equals the difference in the y 2
minus y 1 and x2 minus x1 and finally we
have c which is the coefficient of the
line or where it happens to cross the
zero axes
let's go back and look at an example we
used earlier of linear regression we're
going to go back to plotting the amount
of crop yield based on the amount of
rainfall and here we have our rainfall
remember we cannot change rainfall and
we have our crop yield which is
dependent on the rainfall so we have our
independent and our dependent variables
we're going to take this and draw a line
through it as best we can through the
middle of the data and then we look at
that we put the red point on the y axis
is the amount of crop yield you can
expect for the amount of rainfall
represented by the green dot so if we
have an idea what the rainfall is for
this year and what's going on then we
can guess how good our crops are going
to be and we've created a nice line
right through the middle to give us a
nice mathematical formula let's take a
look and see what the math looks like
behind this
let's look at the intuition behind the
regression line now before we dive into
the math and the formulas that go behind
this and what's going on behind the
scenes
i want you to note that when we get into
the case study and we actually apply
some python script that this map that
you're going to see here is already done
automatically for you you don't have to
have it memorized it is however good to
have an idea what's going on so if
people reference the different terms
you'll know what they're talking about
let's consider a sample data set with
five rows and find out how to draw the
regression line we're only going to do
five rows because if we did like the
rainfall with hundreds of points of data
that would be very hard to see what's
going on with the mathematics so we'll
go ahead and create our own two sets of
data and we have our independent
variable x and our dependent variable y
and when x was 1 we got y equals 2 when
x was
2 y was 4 and so on and so on if we go
ahead and plot this data on a graph we
can see how it forms a nice line through
the middle you can see where it's kind
of grouped going upwards to the right
the next thing we want to know is what
the means is of each of the data coming
in the x and the y the means doesn't
mean anything other than the average so
we add up all the numbers and divide by
the total so 1 plus 2 plus 3 plus four
plus five over five equals three and the
same for y we get four if we go ahead
and plot the means on the graph we'll
see we get three comma four which draws
a nice line down the middle a good
estimate
here we're going to dig deeper into the
math behind the regression line now
remember before i said you don't have to
have all these formulas memorized or
fully understand them even though we're
going to go into a little more detail of
how it works and if you're not a math
whis and you don't know if you've never
seen the sigma character before which
looks a little bit like an e that's
opened up that just means summation
that's all that is so when you see the
sigma character it just means we're
adding everything in that row and for
computers this is great because as a
programmer you can easily iterate
through each of the xy points and create
all the information you need so in the
top half you can see where we broken
that down into pieces and as it goes
through the first two points it computes
the squared value of x the squared value
of y and x times y and then it takes all
of x and adds them up all of y adds them
up all of x squared adds them up and so
on and so on and you can see we have the
sum of equal to 15 the sum is equal to
20 all the way up to x times y where the
sum equals 66. this all comes from our
formula for calculating a straight line
where y equals the slope times x plus
the coefficient c so we go down below
and we're going to compute more like the
averages of these and we'll explain
exactly what that is in just a minute
and where that information comes from is
called the square means error but we'll
go into that in detail in a few minutes
all you need to do is look at the
formula and see how we've gone about
computing it line by line instead of
trying to have a huge
set of numbers pushed into it and down
here you'll see where the slope m equals
and then the top part if you read
through the brackets you have the number
of data points times the sum of x times
y which we computed one line at a time
there and that's just the 66 and take
all that and you subtract it from the
sum of x times the sum of y and those
have both been computed so you have 15
times 20. and on the bottom we have the
number of lines times the sum of x
squared easily computed as 86 for the
sum minus i'll take all that and
subtract the sum of x squared and we end
up as we come across with our formula
you can plug in all those numbers which
is very easy to do on the computer you
don't have to do the math on a piece of
paper or calculator and you'll get a
slope of 0.6 and you'll get your c
coefficient if you continue to follow
through that formula you'll see it comes
out as equal to 2.2 continuing deeper
into what's going behind the scenes
let's find out the predicted values of y
for corresponding values of x using the
linear equation where m equals 0.6 and c
equals 2.2 we're going to take these
values and we're going to go ahead and
plot them we're going to predict them so
y equals 0.6 times where x equals 1 plus
2.2 equals 2.8 so on and so on and here
the blue points represent the actual y
values and the brown points represent
the predicted y values based on the
model we created the distance between
the actual and predicted values is known
as residuals or errors
the best fit line should have the least
sum of squares of these errors also
known as e-square if we put these into a
nice chart where you can see x
and you can see why what we actual
values were and you can see why i
predict it you can easily see where we
take y minus y predicted and we get an
answer what is the difference between
those two and if we square that y minus
y prediction squared we can then sum
those squared values that's where we get
the 0.64 plus the 0.36 plus 1 all the
way down until we have a summation
equals 2.4 so the sum of squared errors
for this regression line is 2.4 we check
this error for each line and conclude
the best fit line having the least e
square value in a nice graphical
representation we can see here where we
keep moving this line through the data
points to make sure the best fit line
has the least square distance between
the data points and the regression line
now we only looked at the most commonly
used formula for minimizing the distance
there are lots of ways to minimize the
distance between the line and the data
points like sum of squared errors sum of
absolute errors root mean square error
etc what you want to take away from this
is whatever formula is being used you
can easily using a computer programming
and iterating through the data calculate
the different parts of it that way these
complicated formulas you see with the
different summations and absolute values
are easily computed one piece at a time
up until this point we've only been
looking at two values x and y well in
the real world it's very rare that you
only have two values when you're
figuring out a solution so let's move on
to the next topic
multiple linear regression let's take a
brief look at what happens when you have
multiple inputs so in multiple linear
regression we have well we'll start with
the simple linear regression where we
had y equals m plus x plus c and we're
trying to find the value of y now with
multiple linear regression we have
multiple variables coming in so instead
of having just x we have x1 x2 x3 and
instead of having just one slope each
variable has its own slope attached to
it as you can see here we have m1 m2 m3
and we still just have the single
coefficient so when you're dealing with
multiple linear regression you basically
take your single linear regression and
you spread it out so you have y equals
m1 times x1 plus m2 times x2
so on all the way to m to the nth x to
the nth and then you add your
coefficient on there implementation of
linear regression now we get into my
favorite part let's understand how
multiple linear regression works by
implementing it in python if you
remember before we were looking at a
company and just based on its rnd trying
to figure out its profit we're going to
start looking at the expenditure of the
company we're going to go back to that
we're going to predict his profit but
instead of predicting it just on the r d
we're going to look at other factors
like administration costs marketing
costs
and so on and from there we're going to
see if we can figure out what the profit
of that company is going to be to start
our coding we're going to begin by
importing some basic libraries and we're
going to be looking through the data
before we do any kind of linear
regression we're going to take a look at
the data to see what we're playing with
then we'll go ahead and format the data
to the format we need to be able to run
it in the linear regression model and
then from there we'll go ahead and solve
it and just see how valid our solution
is so let's start with importing the
basic libraries now i'm going to be
doing this in anaconda jupiter notebook
a very popular ide i enjoy it it's such
a visual to look at and so easy to use
just any id for python will work just
fine for this so break out your favorite
python ide so here we are in our jupyter
notebook let me go ahead and paste our
first piece of code in there and let's
walk through what libraries we're
importing first we're going to import
numpy as np and then i want you to skip
one line and look at import pandas as pd
these are very common tools that you
need with most of your linear regression
the numpy which stands for number python
is usually denoted as np and you have to
almost have that for your sk learn
toolbox you always import that right off
the beginning pandas although you don't
have to have it for your sklearn
libraries it does such a wonderful job
of importing data setting it up into a
data frame so we can manipulate it
rather easily and it has a lot of tools
also in addition to that so we usually
like to use the pandas when we can and
i'll show you what that looks like the
other three lines are for us to get a
visual of this data and take a look at
it so we're going to import
matplotlibrary.pipelot as plt and then
seaborn as sns seaborn works with the
matplot library so you have to always
import matplot library and then seaborn
sits on top of it and we'll take a look
at what that looks like you could use
any of your own plotting libraries you
want there's all kinds of ways to look
at the data these are just very common
ones and the seaborne is so easy to use
it just looks beautiful it's a nice
representation that you can actually
take and show somebody and the final
line is the amber signed matplot library
inline that is only because i'm doing an
inline ide my interface in the anaconda
jupiter notebook requires i put that in
there or you're not going to see the
graph when it comes up let's go ahead
and run this it's not going to be that
interesting so we're just setting up
variables in fact it's not going to do
anything that we can see but it is
importing these different libraries and
setup the next step is load the data set
and extract independent and dependent
variables now here in the slide you'll
see companies equals pd.read csv and it
has a long line there with the file at
the end 1000 companies dot csv you're
going to have to change this to fit
whatever setup you have and the file
itself you can request just go down to
the commentary below this video and put
a note in there and simply learn we'll
try to get in contact with you and
supply you with that file so you can try
this coding yourself so we're going to
add this code in here and we're going to
see that i have companies equals
pd.reader underscore csv and i've
changed this path to match my computer c
colon slash simply learn slash 1000
underscore companies dot csv and then
below there we're going to set the x
equals to companies under the i location
and because this is companies as a pd
data set i can use this nice notation
that says take every row that's what the
colon the first colon is comma except
for the last column that's what the
second part is or we have a colon minus
one and we want the values set into
there so x is no longer a data set a
pandas data set but we can easily
extract the data from our pandas data
set with this notation and then y we're
going to set equal to the last row well
the question is going to be what are we
actually looking at so let's go ahead
and take a look at that and we're going
to look at the companies dot head which
lists the first five rows of data and
i'll open up the file in just a second
so you can see where that's coming from
but let's look at the data in here as
far as the way the panda sees it when i
hit run you'll see it breaks it out into
a nice setup this is what panda is one
of the things pandas is really good
about is it looks just like an excel
spreadsheet you have your rows and
remember when we're programming we
always start with zero we don't start
with one so it shows the first five rows
zero one two three four and then it
shows your different columns r d spend
administration marketing spend state
profit it even notes that the top are
column names it was never told that but
pandas is able to recognize a lot of
things that they're not the same as the
data rows why don't we go ahead and open
this file up in a csv so you can
actually see the raw data so here i've
opened it up as a text editor and you
can see at the top we have rnd spend
comma administration comma marketing
spin comma state comma profit carriage
return i don't know about you but i go
crazy trying to read files like this
that's why we use the pandas you could
also open this up in an excel and it
would separate it since it is a comma
separated variable file but we don't
want to look at this one we want to look
at something we can read rather easily
so let's flip back and take a look at
that top part the first five row now as
nice as this format is where i can see
the data to me it doesn't mean a whole
lot maybe you're an expert in business
and investments and you understand what
uh 165 349 dollars and 20 cents compared
to the administration cost of
seven dollars 136
eighty cents so on so on it helps to
create the profit of a hundred ninety
two thousand two hundred sixty one and
eighty three cents that makes no sense
to me whatsoever no pun intended so
let's flip back here and take a look at
our next set of code where we're going
to graph it so we can get a better
understanding of our data and what it
means so at this point we're going to
use a single line of code to get a lot
of information so we can see where we're
going with this let's go ahead and paste
that into our notebook and see what we
got going and so we have the
visualization and again we're using sns
which is pandas as you can see we
imported the map plot library dot pi
plot as plt which then the seaborn uses
and we imported the seaborn as sns and
then that final line of code helps us
show this in our
inline coding without this it wouldn't
display and you could display it to a
file in other means and that's the matte
plot library in line with the amber sign
at the beginning so here we come down to
the single line of code seaborn is great
because it actually recognizes the panda
data frame so i can just take the
companies dot core for coordinates and i
can put that right into the seaborn and
when we run this we get this beautiful
plot and let's just take a look at what
this plot means if you look at this plot
on mine the colors are probably a little
bit more purplish and blue than the
original one we have the columns and the
rows we have r and d spending we have
administration we have marketing
spending and profit and if you cross
index any two of these since we're
interested in profit if you cross index
profit with profit it's going to show up
if you look at the scale on the right
way up in the dark why because those are
the same data they have an exact
correspondence so rnd spending is going
to be the same as rnd spending and the
same thing with administration costs so
right down the middle you get this dark
row or dark
diagonal row that shows that this is the
highest corresponding data that's
exactly the same and as it becomes
lighter there's less connections between
the data so we can see with profit
obviously profit is the same as profit
and next it has a very high correlation
with r d spending which we looked at
earlier and it has a slightly less
connection to marketing spending and
even less to how much money we put into
the administration so now that we have a
nice look at the data let's go ahead and
dig in and create some actual useful
linear regression models so that we can
predict values and have a better profit
now that we've taken a look at the
visualization of this data we're going
to move on to the next step instead of
just having a pretty picture we need to
generate some hard data some hard values
so let's see what that looks like we're
going to set up our linear regression
model in two steps the first one is we
need to prepare some of our data so it
fits correctly and let's go ahead and
paste this code into our jupyter
notebook and what we're bringing in is
we're going to bring in the sklearn
pre-processing where we're going to
import the label encoder and the one hot
encoder to use the label encoder we're
going to create a variable called label
encoder and set it equal to capital l
label capital e encoder this creates a
class that we can reuse for transferring
the labels back and forth now about now
you should ask what labels are we
talking about let's go take a look at
the data we processed before and see
what i'm talking about here if you
remember when we did the companies dot
head and we printed the top five rows of
data we have our columns going across we
have column zero which is r and d
spending column one which is
administration
column two which is marketing spending
and column three is state
and you'll see under state we have new
york california florida now to do a
linear regression model it doesn't know
how to process new york it knows how to
process a number so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to
change that new york california and
florida and we're going to change those
to numbers that's what this line of code
does here x equals and then it has the
colon comma 3 in brackets the first part
the colon comma means that we're going
to look at all the different rows so
we're going to keep them all together
but the only row we're going to edit is
the third row and in there we're going
to take the label coder and we're going
to fit and transform the x also the
third row so we're going to take that
third row we're going to set it equal to
a transformation and that transformation
basically tells it that instead of
having a
new york it has a zero or one or a two
and then finally we need to do a one hot
encoder which equals one hot inc or
categorical features equals three and
then we take the x and we go ahead and
do that equal to one hot encoder fit
transform x to array this final
transformation preps our data for us so
it's completely set the way we need it
as just a row of numbers even though
it's not in here let's go ahead and
print x and just take a look at what
this data is doing you'll see you have
an array of arrays and then each array
is a row of numbers and if i go ahead
and just do row 0 you'll see i have a
nice organized row of numbers that the
computer now understands we'll go ahead
and take this out there because it
doesn't mean a whole lot to us it's just
a row of numbers
next on setting up our data we have
avoiding dummy variable trap this is
very important why because the computer
has automatically transformed our header
into the setup and it's automatically
transferring all these different
variables so when we did the encoder the
encoder created two columns and what we
need to do is just have the one because
it has both the variable and the name
that's what this piece of code does here
let's go ahead and paste this in here
and we have x equals x colon comma one
colon all this is doing is removing that
one extra column we put in there when we
did our one hot encoder and our label
encoding let's go ahead and run that and
now we get to create our linear
regression model and let's see what that
looks like here and we're going to do
that in two steps the first step is
going to be in splitting the data
now whenever we create a predictive
model of data we always want to split it
up so we have a training set and we have
a testing set that's very important
otherwise we'd be very unethical without
testing it to see how good our fit is
and then we'll go ahead and create our
multiple linear regression model and
train it and set it up let's go ahead
and paste this next piece of code in
here and i'll go ahead and shrink it
down a size or two so it all fits on one
line so from the sk learn module
selection we're going to import train
test split and you'll see that we've
created four completely different
variables we have capital x train
capital x test smaller case y train
smaller case y test
that is the standard way that they
usually reference these when we're doing
different models
you usually see that a capital x and you
see the train and the test and the lower
case y what this is is x is our data
going in that's our rnd spin our
administration our marketing and then
why which we're training is the answer
that's the profit because we want to
know the profit of an unknown entity
that's what we're going to shoot for in
this tutorial the next part train test
split we take x and we take y we've
already created those x has the columns
with the data in it and y has a column
with profit in it and then we're going
to set the test size equals 0.2 that
basically means twenty percent
so twenty percent of the rows are going
to be tested we're going to put them off
to the side so since we're using a
thousand lines of data that means that
200 of those lines we're going to hold
off to the side to test for later and
then the random state equals zero we're
going to randomize which ones it picks
to hold off to the side we'll go ahead
and run this it's not overly exciting
because it's setting up our variables
but the next step is the next step we
actually create our linear regression
model now that we got to the linear
regression model we get that next piece
of the puzzle let's go ahead and put
that code in there and walk through it
so here we go we're going to paste it in
there and let's go ahead and since this
is a shorter line of code let's zoom up
there so we can get a good look and we
have from the sklearn the linear
underscore model we're going to import
linear regression now i don't know if
you recall from earlier when we were
doing all the math let's go ahead and
flip back there and take a look at that
do you remember this where we had this
long formula on the bottom and we were
doing all this summarization and then we
also looked at uh setting it up with the
different lines and then we also looked
all the way down to multiple linear
regression where we're adding all those
formulas together all of that is wrapped
up in this one section so what's going
on here is i'm going to create a
variable called regressor and the
regressor equals the linear regression
that's a linear regression model that
has all that math built in so we don't
have to have it all memorized or have to
compute it individually and then we do
the regressor fit in this case we do x
train and y train because we're using
the training data x being the data in
and y being profit what we're looking at
and this does all that math for us so
within one click and one line we've
created the whole linear regression
model and we fit the data to the linear
regression model and you can see that
when i run the regressor it gives an
output linear regression it says copy x
equals true fit intercept equals true in
jobs equal one normalize equals false
it's just giving you some general
information on what's going on with that
regressor model now that we've created
our linear regression model let's go
ahead and use it and if you remember we
kept a bunch of data aside so we're
going to do a y predict variable and
we're going to put in the x test and
let's see what that looks like scroll up
a little bit paste that in here
predicting the test set results so here
we have y predict equals regressor dot
predict x test going in and this gives
us y predict now because i'm in jupiter
inline i can just put the variable up
there and when i hit the run button
it'll print that array out i could have
just as easily done print y predict so
if you're in a different ide that's not
an inline setup like the jupiter
notebook you can do it this way print y
predict and you'll see that for the 200
different test variables we kept off to
the side it's going to produce 200
answers this is what it says the profit
are for those 200 predictions but let's
don't stop there let's keep going and
take a couple look we're going to take
just a short detail here and calculating
the coefficients and the intercepts this
gives us a quick flash at what's going
on behind the line we're going to take a
short detour here and we're going to be
calculating the coefficient and
intercepts so you can see what those
look like what's really nice about our
regressor we created is it already has a
coefficients for us we can simply just
print regressor dot coefficient
underscore when i run this you'll see
our coefficients here and if we can do
the regressor coefficient we can also do
the regressor intercept and let's run
that and take a look at that this all
came from the multiple regression model
and we'll flip over so you can remember
where this is going into where it's
coming from you can see the formula down
here where y equals m1 times x1 plus m2
times x2 and so on and so on plus c the
coefficient so these variables fit right
into this formula y equals slope one
times column one variable plus slope two
times column two variable all the way to
the m into the n and x to the n plus c
the coefficient or in this case you have
minus 8.89 to the power of 2 etc etc
times the first column and the second
column and the third column and then our
intercept is the minus 1 0 3 0 0 9 point
boy it gets kind of complicated when you
look at it this is why we don't do this
by hand anymore this is why we have the
computer to make these calculations easy
to understand and calculate now i told
you that was a short detour and we're
coming towards the end of our script as
you remember from the beginning i said
if we're going to divide this
information we have to make sure it's a
valid model that this model works and
understand how good it works so
calculating the r squared value that's
what we're going to use to predict how
good our prediction is and let's take a
look what that looks like in code and so
we're going to use this from
sklearn.metrics we're going to import r2
score that's the r squared value we're
looking at the error so in the r2 score
we take our y test versus our y predict
y test is the actual values we're
testing that was the one that was given
to us so we know are true the y predict
of those 200 values is what we think it
was true and when we go ahead and run
this we see we get a 0.935
that's the r2 score now it's not exactly
a straight percentage so it's not saying
it's 93 correct but you do want that in
the upper 90s oh and higher shows that
this is a very valid prediction based on
the r2 score and if r-squared value of
0.91 or 9-2 as we got on our model
remember it does have a random
generation involved this proves the
model is a good model which means
success yay we successfully trained our
model with certain predictors and
estimated the profit of the companies
using linear regression
so where does logistic regression fit
into the overall machine learning
process machine learning is divided into
two types mainly two types there is a
third one called reinforcement learning
but we will not talk about that right
now so one is supervised learning and
the other is unsupervised learning
unsupervised learning uses techniques
like clustering and association and
supervised learning uses techniques like
classification and regression now
supervised learning is used when you
have labeled data you have historical
data then you use supervised learning
when you don't have labeled data then
you used unsupervised learning it's in
supervised learning there are two types
of techniques that are used
classification and regression based on
what is the kind of problem we are
solved let's say we want to take the
data and classify it it could be binary
classification like a zero or a one an
example of classification we have just
seen whether the passenger has survived
or not survived like a zero or one that
is known as binary classification
regression on the other hand is you need
to predict a value what is known as a
continuous value classification is for
discrete values regression is for
continuous values let's say you want to
predict a share price or you want to
predict the temperature that will be
there what will be the temperature
tomorrow that is where you use
regression whereas classification are
discrete values is will the customer buy
the product or will not buy the product
will you get a promotion or you will not
get a promotion i hope you're getting
the idea or it could be multi-class
classification as well let's say you
want to build an image classification
model so the image classification model
would take an image as an input and
classify into multiple classes whether
this image is of a cat or a dog or an
elephant or a tiger so there are
multiple classes so not necessarily
binary classification so that is known
as multi-class classification so we are
going to focus on classification because
logistic regression is one of the
algorithms used for classification now
the name may be a little confusing in
fact whenever people come across
logistic regression it always causes
confusion because the name has
regression in it but we are actually
using this for performing classification
okay so yes it is logistic regression
but it is used for classification and in
case you are wondering is there
something similar for regression yes for
regression we have linear regression
keep that in mind so linear regression
is used for regression logistic
regression is used for classification so
in this video we are going to focus on
supervised learning and within
supervised learning we are going to
focus on classification and then within
classification we are going to focus on
logistic regression algorithm so first
of all classification so what are the
various algorithms available for
performing classification the first one
is decision tree there are of course
multiple algorithms but here we will
talk about a few decision trees are
quite popular and very easy to
understand and therefore they use for
classification then we have k nearest
neighbors this is another algorithm for
performing classification and then there
is logistic regression and this is what
we are going to focus on in this video
and we are going to go into little bit
of details about logistic regression all
right what is logistic regression as i
mentioned earlier positive regression is
an algorithm for performing binary
classification so let's take an example
and see how this works let's say your
car has not been serviced for quite a
few years and now you want to find out
if it is going to break down in the near
future so this is like a classification
problem find out whether your car will
break down or not so how are we going to
perform this classification so here's
how it looks if we plot the information
along the x and y axis x is the number
of years since the last service was
performed and why is the probability of
your car breaking down and let's say
this information was this data rather
was collected from several car users
it's not just your car but several car
users so that is our labeled data so the
data has been collected and
for for the number of years and when the
car broke down and what was the
probability and that has been plotted
along x and y axis so this provides an
idea or from this
graph we can find out whether your car
will break down or not we'll see how so
first of all the probability can go from
zero to one as you all aware probability
can be between zero and one and as we
can imagine it is intuitive as well as
the number of years are on the lower
side maybe one year two years or three
years till after the service the chances
of your car breaking down are very
limited right so for example chances of
your car breaking down the probability
of your car breaking down within two
years of your last service are 0.1
probability similarly 3 years is maybe
0.3 and so on but as the number of years
increases let's say if it was 6 or seven
years there is almost a certainty that
your car is going to break down that is
what this graph shows so this is an
example of a application of the
classification algorithm and we will see
in little details how exactly logistic
regression is applied here one more
thing needs to be added here is that the
dependent variable's outcome
is discrete so if we are talking about
whether the car is going to break down
or not so that is a discrete value the y
that we are talking about the dependent
variable that we are talking about what
we are looking at is whether the car is
going to break down or not yes or no
that is what we are talking about so
here the outcome is discrete and not a
continuous value so this is how the
logistic regression curve looks let me
explain a little bit what exactly
how exactly we are going to
uh determine the class at the outcome
rather so for a logistic regression
curve a threshold has to be said saying
that because this is a probability
calculation remember this is a
probability calculation and the
probability itself will not be 0 or 1
but based on the probability we need to
decide what the outcome should be so
there has to be a threshold like for
example 0.5 can be the threshold let's
say in this case so any value of the
probability below 0.5 is considered to
be 0 and any value above 0.5 is
considered to be 1. so an output of
let's say 0.8 will mean that the car
will break down so that is considered as
an output of 1 and let's say
an output of 0.29 is considered as 0
which means that the car will not break
down so that's the way logistic
regression works now let's do a quick
comparison between logistic regression
and linear regression because they both
have the term regression in them so it
can cause confusion so let's try to
remove that confusion so what is linear
regression linear regression is a
process is once again an algorithm for
supervised learning however here you're
going to find a continuous value you're
going to determine a continuous value it
could be the price of a real estate
property it could be your hike how much
hike you're going to get or it could be
a stock price these are all continuous
values these are not discrete compared
to a yes or no kind of a response that
we are looking for in logistic
regression so this is one example of a
linear regression let's say at the hr
team of a company tries to find out what
should be the salary hike of an employee
so they collect all the details of their
existing employees their ratings and
their salary hikes what has been given
and that is the labeled information that
is available and the system learns from
this it is trained and it learns from
this labeled information so that when a
new employee's information is fed based
on the rating it will determine what
should be the height so this is a linear
regression problem and a linear
regression example now salary is a
continuous value you can get 5 000 500
5600 it is not discrete like a cat or a
dog or an apple or a banana these are
discrete or a yes or no these are
discrete values right so this way you're
trying to find continuous values is
where we use linear regression so let's
say just to extend on the scenario we
now want to find out whether this
employee is going to get a promotion or
not so we want to find out if that is a
discrete problem right a yes or no kind
of a problem in this case we actually
cannot use linear regression even though
we may have labeled data so this is the
label data so based on the employee
rating these are the ratings and then
some people got the promotion and this
is the ratings for which people did not
get promotion that is a no and this is
the rating for which people got
promotion we just plotted the data about
whether a person has got an employer's
got promotion or not yes no right so
there is nothing in between and what is
the employees rating okay and ratings
can be continuous that is not an issue
but the output is discrete in this case
whether employee got promotion yes no
okay so if we try to plot that and we
try to find a straight line this is how
it would look and as you can see it
doesn't look very right because looks
like there will be lot of errors thus
root mean square error if you remember
for linear regression would be very very
high and also the the values cannot go
beyond zero or beyond one so the graph
should probably look somewhat like this
clipped at zero and one but still the
straight line doesn't
look right therefore instead of using a
linear equation we need to come up with
something different and therefore the
logistic regression model looks somewhat
like this so we calculate the
probability
and if we plot that probability not in
the form of a straight line but we need
to use some other equation we will see
very soon what that equation is then it
is a gradual process right so you see
here people with some of these ratings
are not getting any promotions and then
slowly uh
at certain rating they get promotion so
that is a gradual process and
this is how the math behind logistic
regression looks so we are trying to
find the odds for a particular event
happening and this is the formula for
finding the odds so the probability of
an event happening divided by the
probability of the event not happening
so p if it is the probability of the
event happening probability of the
person getting a promotion and divided
by the probability of the person not
getting a promotion that is one minus p
so this is how you measure the odds now
the values of the odds range from 0 to
infinity so when this probability is 0
then the odds will the value of the odds
is equal to 0 and when the probability
becomes 1 then the value of the odds is
1 by 0 that will be infinity but the
probability itself remains between 0 and
1. now this is how an equation of a
straight line looks so y is equal to
beta0 plus beta1 x where beta0 is the
y-intercept and beta1 is the slope of
the line if we take the odds equation
and take a log of both sides then this
would look somewhat like this and the
term logistic is actually derived from
the fact that we are doing this we take
a log of px by 1 minus px this is an
extension of the calculation of odds
that we have seen right and that is
equal to beta0 plus beta1 x which is the
equation of the straight line and now
from here if you want to find out the
value of p x you will see we can take
the exponential on both sides and then
if we solve that equation we will get
the equation of p x like this p x is
equal to 1 by 1 plus e to the power of
minus beta 0 plus beta 1 x and recall
this is nothing but the equation of the
line which is equal to y y is equal to
beta 0 plus beta1 x so that this is the
equation also known as the sigmoid
function and this is the equation of the
logistic regression all right and if
this is plotted this is how the sigmoid
curve is obtained
so let's compare linear and logistic
regression how they are different from
each other let's go back so linear
regression is solved or used to solve
regression problems and logistic
regression is used to solve
classification problems so both are
called regression but linear regression
is used for solving regression problems
where we predict continuous values
whereas logistic regression is used for
solving classification problems where we
have had to predict discrete values the
response variables in case of linear
regression are continuous in nature
whereas here they are categorical or
discrete in nature and
linear regression helps to estimate the
dependent variable when there is a
change in the independent variable
whereas here in case of logistic
regression it helps to calculate the
probability or the possibility of a
particular event happening and linear
regression as the name suggests is a
straight line that's why it's called
linear regression whereas logistic
regression is a sigmoid function and the
curve is the shape of the curve is s
it's an s-shaped curve this is another
example of application of logistic
regression in weather prediction whether
it's going to rain or not rain now keep
in mind both are used in weather
prediction if we want to find the
discrete values like whether it's going
to rain or not rain that is a
classification problem we use logistic
regression but if you want to determine
what is going to be the temperature
tomorrow then we use linear regression
so just keep in mind that in weather
prediction we actually use both but
these are some examples of logistic
regression so we want to find out
whether it's going to be rain or not
it's going to be sunny or not it's going
to snow or not these are all logistic
regression examples a few more examples
classification of objects this is a
again another example of logistic
regression now here of course one
distinction is that these are
multi-class classification so logistic
regression is not used in its original
form but it is used in a slightly
different form so we say whether it is a
dog or not a dog i hope you understand
so instead of saying is it a dog or a
cat or an elephant we convert this into
saying so because we need to keep it to
binary classification so we say is it a
dog or not a dog is it a cat or not a
cat so that's the way logistic
regression can be used for classifying
objects otherwise there are other
techniques which can be used for
performing multi-class classification in
healthcare logistic regression is used
to find the survival rate of a patient
so they take multiple parameters like
trauma score and age and so on and so
forth and they try to predict the rate
of survival
all right now finally let's take an
example and see how we can apply
logistic regression to predict the
number that is shown in the image so
this is actually a live demo i will take
you into jupiter notebook and
show the code but before that let me
take you through a couple of slides to
explain what we are trying to do so
let's say you have an eight by eight
image and there the image has a number
one two three four and you need to train
your model to predict what this number
is so
how do we do this so the first thing is
obviously in any machine learning
process you train your model so in this
case we are using logistic regression so
and then we provide a training set to
train the model and then we test how
accurate our model is with the test data
which means that like any machine
learning process we split our initial
data into two parts training set and
test set with the training set we train
our model and then with the test set we
test the model then we get good accuracy
and then we use it for for inference
right so that is typical methodology of
uh training testing and then deploying
of machine learning models so let's uh
take a look at the code and see what we
are doing so i will not go line by line
but just take you through some of the
blocks so first thing we do is import
all the libraries and then we basically
take a look at the images and see what
is the total number of images we can
display using matplotlib some of the
images or a sample of these images and
then we split the data into training and
test as i mentioned earlier
and we can do some exploratory analysis
and
then we build our model we train our
model with the training set and then we
test it with our test set and find out
how accurate our model is using the
confusion matrix the heat map and use
heat map for visualizing this and i will
show you in the code what exactly is the
confusion matrix and how it can be used
for finding the accuracy in our example
we go we get an accuracy of about 0.94
which is pretty good or 94 which is
pretty good all right so what is the
confusion matrix this is an example of a
confusion matrix and
this is used for identifying the
accuracy of a
classification model or like a logistic
regression model so the most important
part in a confusion matrix is that first
of all this as you can see this is a
matrix and the size of the matrix
depends on how many outputs we are
expecting right
so
the most important part here is that the
model will be most accurate when we have
the maximum numbers in its diagonal like
in this case that's why it has almost 93
94 percent because the diagonal should
have the maximum numbers and the others
other than diagnose the cells other than
the diagonals should have very few
numbers so here that's what is happening
so there is a two here there are there's
a one here but most of them are along
the diagonal this what does this mean
this means that the number that has been
fed is zero and the number that has been
detected is also zero so the predicted
value and the actual value are the same
so along the diagonals that is true
which means that let's let's take this
diagonal right if the maximum number is
here that means that like here in this
case it is 34 which means that 34 of the
images that have been fed or rather
actually there are two
misclassifications in there so 36 images
have been fed which have number four and
out of which 34 have been predicted
correctly as number four and one has
been predicted as number eight and
another one has been predicted as number
nine so these are two misclassifications
okay so that is the meaning of saying
that the maximum number should be in the
diagonal so if you have all of them so
for an ideal model which has let's say
100 accuracy everything will be only in
the diagonal there will be no numbers
other than zero in all other cells so
that is like a hundred percent accurate
model okay so that's a just of how to
use this matrix how to use this
confusion matrix i know the name
is a little funny sounding confusion
matrix but actually it is not very
confusing it's very straightforward so
you are just plotting what has been
predicted and what is the labeled
information or what is the actual data
that's also known as the ground truth
sometimes okay these are some fancy
terms that are used so predicted label
and the actual name that's all it is
okay yeah so we are showing a little bit
more information here so 38 have been
predicted and here you will see that all
of them have been predicted correctly
there have been 38 zeros and the
predicted value and the actual value is
exactly the same whereas in this case
right it has there are i think 37 plus 5
yeah 42 have been fed the images 42
images are of digit 3 and
the accuracy is only 37 of them have
been accurately predicted three of them
have been predicted as number seven and
two of them have been predicted as
number eight and so on and so forth okay
all right so with that let's go into
jupiter notebook and see how the code
looks so this is the code in
in jupyter notebook for logistic
regression in this particular demo what
we are going to do is train our model to
recognize digits
which are the images
which have digits from let's say 0 to 5
or 0 to 9 and
and then we will see how well it is
trained and whether it is able to
predict these numbers correctly or not
so let's get started so the first part
is as usual we are importing some
libraries that are required and
then the last line in this block is to
load the digits so let's go ahead and
run this code
then
here we will visualize the shape of
these digits so we can see here if we
take a look this is how the shape is
by 64. these are like eight by eight
images so that's that's what is
reflected in this shape now from here
onwards we are basically once again
importing some of the libraries that are
required like numpy and matplot and we
will take a look at
some of the sample images that we have
unloaded so this one for example creates
a figure and then we go ahead and take a
few sample images to see how they look
so let me run this code and so that it
becomes easy to understand so these are
about five images sample images that we
are looking at zero one two three four
so this is how the image is this is how
the data is okay and uh based on this we
will actually train our logistic
regression model and then we will test
it and see how well it is able to
recognize so the way it works is the
pixel information so as you can see here
this is an 8 by 8 pixel kind of a image
and
the each pixel whether it is activated
or not activated that is the information
available for each pixel now based on
the pattern of this activation and
non-activation of the various pixels
this will be identified as a zero for
example right similarly as you can see
so overall each of these numbers
actually has a different pattern of the
pixel activation and that's pretty much
that our model needs to learn
for which a number what is the pattern
of the activation of the pixels right so
that is what we are going to train our
model okay so the first thing we need to
do is to split our data into training
and test data set right so whenever we
perform any training we split the data
into training and test so that the
training data set is used to train the
system so we pass this probably multiple
times
and then we test it with the test data
set and the split is usually in the form
of there and there are various ways in
which you can split this data it is up
to the individual preferences in our
case here we are splitting in the form
of 23 and 77. so when we say test size
as
20.23 that means 23 percent of that
entire data is used for testing and the
remaining 77 percent is used for
training so there is a readily available
function which is uh called train test
split so we don't have to write any
special code for the splitting it will
automatically split the data based on
the proportion that we give here which
is test size so we just give the test
size automatically training size will be
determined and
we pass the data that we want to split
and the the results will be stored in x
underscore train and y underscore train
for the training data set and what is x
underscore train these are these are the
features right which is like the
independent variable and why underscore
train is the label right so in this case
what happens is we have the input value
which is or the features value which is
in x underscore train and since this is
the labeled data for each of them each
of the observations we already have the
label information saying whether this
digit is a zero or a one or a two so
that this is what will be used for
comparison to find out whether the the
system is able to recognize it correctly
or there is an error for each
observation it will compare with this
right so this is the label so the same
way x underscore train y underscore
train is for the training data set x
underscore test y underscore test is for
the test data set okay so let me go
ahead and execute this code as well and
then we can go and check quickly what is
the how many entries are there and in
each of these so x underscore train the
shape is 13 83
by 64 and y underscore train has 1383
because there is nothing like the second
part is not required here and then x
underscore test shape
we see is 414 so actually there are 414
observations in test and 1383
observations in train so that's
basically what these four lines of code
are are saying okay then we import the
logistic regression library
and which is a part of scikit learn so
we we don't have to implement the
logistic regression process itself we
just call these the function and let me
go ahead and execute that so that
we have the logistic regression library
imported now we create an instance of
logistic regression right so logistic
regr is a is an instance of logistic
regression and then we use that for
training our model so let me first
execute this code so these two lines so
the first line basically creates an
instance of logistic regression model
and then the second line is where we are
passing our data the training data set
and this is our
the predictors and uh this is our target
we are passing this data set to train
our model all right so
once we do this in this case the data is
not large but by and large the training
is what takes usually a lot of time so
we spend in machine learning activities
in machine learning projects we spend a
lot of time for the training part of it
okay so here the data set is relatively
small so it was pretty quick so all
right so now our model has been trained
using the training data set and
we want to see how accurate this is so
what we'll do is we will test it out in
probably faces so let me first try out
how well this is working for
one image okay i will just try it out
with one image my the first entry in my
test data set and see whether it is
correctly predicting or not so
and in order to test it so for training
purpose we use the fit method there is a
method called fit which is for training
the model and once the training is done
if you want to test for
a particular value new input you use the
predict method okay so let's run the
predict method and we pass this
particular image and
we see that the shape is or the
prediction is four so let's try a few
more let me see for the next 10 uh seems
to be fine so let me just go ahead and
test the entire data set okay that's
basically what it will do so now we want
to find out how accurately this has
performed so we use the score method to
find what is the percentages of accuracy
and we see here that it has performed up
to 94 to accurate okay so that's on this
part now what we can also do is we can
also see this accuracy using what is
known as a confusion matrix so let us go
ahead and try that as well
so that we can also visualize how well
this model has uh done so let me execute
this piece of code which will basically
import some of the libraries that are
required and
we we basically create a confusion
matrix and instance of confusion matrix
by running confusion matrix and passing
these values so we have so this
confusion underscore matrix method takes
two parameters one is the y underscore
test and the other is the prediction so
what is the y underscore test these are
the labeled values which we already know
for the test data set and predictions
are what the system has predicted for
the test data set okay so this is known
to us
and this is what the system has
the model has generated so we kind of
create the confusion matrix and we will
print it and this is how the confusion
matrix looks as the name suggests it is
a matrix and
the key point out here is that the
accuracy of the model is determined by
how many numbers are there in the
diagonal the more the numbers in the
diagonal the better the accuracy is
okay and first of all the total sum of
all the numbers in this whole matrix is
equal to the number of observations in
the test data set that is the first
thing right so if you add up all these
numbers that will be equal to the number
of
observations in the test data set and
then out of that the maximum number of
them should be in the diagonal that
means the accuracy is pretty good if the
the numbers in the diagonal are less and
in all other places there are a lot of
numbers uh which means the accuracy is
very low the diagonal indicates a
correct prediction that this means that
the actual value is same as the
predicted value here again actual values
same as the predicted value and so on
right so the moment you see a number
here that means the actual value is
something and the predicted value is
something else right similarly here the
actual value is something and the
predicted value is something else so
that is basically how we read the
confusion matrix now how do we find the
accuracy you can actually add up the
total values in the diagonal so it's
like 38 plus 44 plus 43 and so on and
divide that by the total number of test
observations that will give you the
percentage accuracy using a confusion
matrix now let us visualize this
confusion matrix in a slightly more
sophisticated way uh using a heat map so
we will create a heat map with some
we'll add some colors as well it's uh
it's like a more visually
visually more appealing so that's the
whole idea so if we let me run this
piece of code and this is how the heat
map looks
and as you can see here the diagonals
again are all the values are here most
of the values so which means reasonably
this seems to be reasonably accurate and
yeah basically the accuracy score is 94
percent this is calculated as i
mentioned by adding all these numbers
divided by the total test value so the
total number of observations in test
data set okay so this is the confusion
matrix for logistic regression
all right so now that we have seen the
confusion matrix let's take a quick
sample and see how well uh the system
has classified and we will take a few
examples of the data so if we see here
we picked up randomly a few of them so
this is number four which is the actual
value and also the predicted value both
are four
this is an image of zero so the
predicted value is also zero actual
value is of course zero
then this is the image of nine
so this has also been predicted
correctly 9 and actual value is 9 and
this is an image of 1 and again this has
been predicted correctly as like the
actual value okay so this was a quick
demo of logistic regression how to use
logistic regression to identify
images
need for confusion matrixes
classification models have multiple
output categories
most error measures will tell us the
total error in our model
but we cannot use it to find out
individual instances of errors in our
models so you have your input coming in
you have your classifier
it measures the error and it says oh
53 of these are correct but we don't
know which 53 percent are correct is it
53 percent correct uh on guessing on the
spam is it 23 guessing on spam and
27 guessing on what's not spam this is
where the confusion matrix comes in
so during the classification we also
have to overcome the limitations of
accuracy accuracy can be misleading for
classification problems
if there is a significant class
imbalance a model might predict the
majority class for all cases and have a
high accuracy score
and so you can see here we have our
email coming in and there's two spams
the classifier comes in and goes hey it
only catches one of those spams and it
misclassifies one that's not spam
so our model predicted eight out of ten
instance and will have an accuracy of
eighty percent but is it classifying
correctly
a confusion matrix represents a table
layout of the different outcomes of
prediction
and results of a classification problem
and helps visualize its outcomes
and so you see here we have our
simple chart predicted and actual
the confusion matrix
helps us identify the correct
predictions of a model for different
individual classes as well as the errors
so you'll see here that the values
predicted by our classifier are along
the rows this is what we're going to
guess it is or our model is guessing
what this is based on its training so
we've already trained the model
to guess whether it's spam or not spam
or whatever it is you're working on
and then the actual values of our data
set are along the columns
so this is the actual value that's
supposed to be
people who can speak english will be
classified as positives so because they
have a remember 01. do you speak english
yes no and you could extend this that
they might have do you speak
french do you speak whatever languages
and so you might have a whole lot of
classifiers that you would look at each
one of these people who cannot speak
english will be classified as negatives
so there'll be a zero so you know zero
ones
the number of times our actual positive
values are equal to predicted positive
values gives us true positive tp
the number of times our actual negative
values are equal to predictive negative
values gives us true negative t in
the number of times our model wrongly
predicts negative values as positives
gives us a false positive
fp
and you'll see when you're working with
these a lot
you know memorizing that is false
positive you can easily figure out what
that is and pretty soon you're just
looking at the fp or the tp depending on
what you're working on and the number of
times our model wrongly predicts
positive values as negatives gives us a
false negative fp
now i'm going to do a quick step out
here
let's say you're working in the medical
and we're talking about cancer
do you really want a bunch of false
negatives
you want zero under false negative
so when we look at this confusion matrix
if you have five percent false positives
and five percent false negatives it'd be
much better to even have
20 false positives because they go in
and test it and zero false negatives
the same might be true if you're working
on uh say
a car driving is this a safe place for
the car to go
well you really don't want any false
positives you know yes this is safe
right over the cliff
so again when you're working on the
project or whatever it is you're working
on this chart suddenly has huge value
we were talking about spam email
how many important emails say from your
banking overdraft charge coming in that
you want to be
a true a false negative you don't want
it to go in the spam folder
likewise you want to get as much of the
spam out of there but you don't want to
miss anything really important
confusion matrix metrics are performance
measures which help us find the accuracy
of our classifier
there are four main metrics
accuracy precision
recall and f1 score the f1 score is the
one i usually hear the most and accuracy
is usually what you put on your chart
uh when you're sending in front of the
shareholders how accurate is it people
understand accuracy
um
f1 score is a little bit more on the
math side and so you got to be a little
careful when you're quoting f1 scores in
the when you're sitting there with all
the shareholders because a lot of them
will just glaze over so confusion matrix
metrics are performance measures which
help us find the accuracy of our
classifier there are four main metrics
accuracy the accuracy is used to find
the portion of the correctly classified
values it tells us how often our
classifier is right it is the sum of all
true values divided by the total values
and this makes sense
again it's one of those things
i don't want to fall you know what
depends on what you're looking for are
you looking for
not to miss any spam mails are you
looking to drive down the road and not
run anybody over
precision
is used to calculate the model's ability
to classify positive values correctly it
answers the question when the model
predicts a positive value how often is
it right
it is the true positive divided by the
total number of predicted positive
values again in this one uh depends on
what project you're working on whether
this is what you're going to be focusing
on
so recall it is used to calculate the
model's ability to predict positive
values
how often
does the model actually predict the
correct positive values
it is the true positives divided by the
total number of actual positive values
and then your f1 score it is the
harmonic mean of recall and precision it
is useful when you need to take both
precision and recall into account
consider the following two confusion
matrix derived from two different
classifier
to figure out which one performs better
we can find the confusion matrix for
both of them
and you can see we're back to
does it classify whether they can speak
english or
or non-speaker they speak some they
don't know the english language and so
we put these two uh
confusion matrixes out here we can go
ahead and do the math behind that we can
look up the accuracy that's a tpn plus
tn over the tf plus tn plus fp
plus fn and so we get an accuracy of
0.812
and we have a precision
if you do the precision which is your tp
truth positive over tp plus fp
we get
0.891
and if we do the recall
we'll end up with the 0.825 that's your
tp over tp plus fn
and then of course your f1 score which
is 2 times precision times recall over
precision plus recall
and we get the 0.857
and if we do that um with another model
let's say we had two different models
and we're trying to see which one we
want to use
for whatever reason
we might go ahead and compute the same
things we have our accuracy our
precision and our recall and our f1
score
and as we're looking at this we might
look at the accuracy because that's
really what we're interested in is
how many people
are we able to
classify as being able to speak english
i really don't want to know
if i'm you know i i really don't want to
know if they're non-speakers
i'd rather miss 10 people speaking
english instead of 15. and so you can
see from these charts we'd probably go
with the first model because it does a
better job guessing who speaks english
and has a higher accuracy because in
this case that is what we're looking for
so uh with that we'll go ahead and pull
up a demo so you can see what this looks
like in the python setup in in the
actual coding for this we'll go into
anaconda navigator if you're not
familiar with anaconda it's a really
good tool to use as far as doing display
in demos and for quick development as a
data scientist i just love the package
now if you're going to do something
heavier lifting
there's some limitations with anaconda
and with the setup but in general you
can do just about anything in here with
your python
and for this we'll go with jupiter
notebook
jupiter lab is the same as jupiter
notebook you'll see they now have
integration with pycharm if you work in
pycharm
certainly there's a lot of other
integrations that
anaconda has and we've opened up
my simply learn files i work on and
create a new file called confusion
matrix demo
and the first thing we want to note is
the data we're working with
here i've opened it up in a wordpad or
notepad or whatever
uh you can see it's got a row of
uh headers
comma separated and then all the data
going down below
and then i save this in the same file so
i don't have to remember what path i'm
working on
of course if you have your data
separated and you're working with a lot
of data you probably want to put it into
a different folder or file depending on
what you're doing
and the first thing we're going to do is
go ahead and import our tools
we're going to use the pandas that's our
data frame
if you haven't had a chance to work with
the data frame please review panda's
data frame and go into simply learn you
can pull up the pandas data frame
tutorial on there
and then we're going to use
the scikit framework which is all
denoted as sklearn
and i can just pull this in you can see
here's the
scikit-learn.org
with the stable version that you can
import into your python
and from here we're going to use the
train test split
for splitting our data we're going to do
some pre-processing
we're going to do use the logistic
regression model that's our actual
machine learning model we're using
and then what this court this particular
setup is about is we're going to do the
accuracy score the confusion matrix and
the classifier report
so let me go ahead and run that and
bring all that information in
and just like we open the file we need
to go ahead and load our data in here
so we're going to go ahead and do our
pandas read csv
and then just because we're in jupyter
notebook we can just put data to read
the data in here a lot of times we'll
actually let me just do this i prefer to
do the
just the head of the date or the top
part
and you can see we have age sex
i'm not sure what cp stands for
test bps cholesterol
so a lot of different measurements
if you were in this domain you want to
know what all these different
measurements mean
i don't want to focus on that too much
because
when we're talking about data science a
lot of times you have no idea what the
data means if you've ever looked up the
breast cancer measurement it's just a
bunch of measurements and numbers
unless you're a doctor you have no idea
what those measurements mean
but if it's your specialty and your
domain you better know them so we're
going to go ahead and create y and it's
going to we're going to set it equal to
the target
so here's our target value here
and there's either 1 or 0.
so we have a classifier if you're
dealing with one zero true false what do
you have you have a classifier
and then our x is going to be
everything except for
the target so we're going to go ahead
and drop the target axis equals 1.
remember that's columns versus the index
or rows axis equals 0 would would give
you an error but you would drop like row
2.
and then we'll go ahead and just print
that out so you can see what we're
looking at and
here we have
y data x data and you can see from the x
data we have the x head and we can go
ahead and just do print
the
y head data
and run that
so this is all loading the data that
we've done so far if there's a confusion
in there go back and rewind the tape and
review it and then we need to go ahead
and split our data into our x train
x test y train y test
and then keep in mind you always want to
split the data before we do the scalar
and the reason is is that
you want the scalar on the training data
to be set on the training data data or
fit to it
but not on the test data
think of this as being out in the field
you're not you could actually alter your
results uh so it's always important to
do make sure whatever you do to the
training data
or whatever
fit you're doing is always done on the
training not on the test and then we
want to go ahead and scale the data
now we are working with um
linear regression model and i'll mention
this here in a minute when we get to the
actual model
uh so some sometimes you don't need to
scale when you're working with linear
regression models it's not going to
change your result as much as say a
neural network where it has a huge
impact
but we're going to go ahead and take
here's our x train x test y train y test
we create our scalar we go ahead and
scale
the scale is going to fit the x train
and then we're going to go ahead and
take our x train and transform it
and then we also need to take our x test
and transform it based on the scale on
here so that our x is now between that
nice minus one to one and so this is all
uh our pre
data setup
and
hopefully
uh all of that looks fairly familiar to
you if you've done a number of our other
classes and you're up to the setup on
here
and then we want to go ahead and do is
create our model and we're going to use
the logistic regression model
and from the logistic regression model
we're going to go ahead and fit our x
train and y train
and then we'll run our predicted value
on here
and let's go ahead and run that and so
now we are we actually have like our x
test and our prediction so if you
remember from
our matrix
we're looking for the actual versus the
prediction and how those compare
and
if i take us back up here you're going
to notice that we imported the accuracy
score
the confusion matrix and the
classification report
and there's of course our logistic
regression the model we're using for
this
and i did mention it's going to talk a
little bit about scalar and the
regression model
the scalar on a lot of your regression
models your basic mass standard
regression models and i'd have to look
it up for the logistic regression model
when you're using a standard regression
model you don't need to scale the data
it's already just built in by the way
the model works
in most cases uh but if you're in a
neural network and you're there's a lot
of other different setups then you
really want to take this and fit that on
there
and so we can go in and do the accuracy
uh
and this is if you remember correctly we
were looking at the accuracy
with the english speaking uh so this is
saying our accuracy
as to whether this person is i believe
this is the heart data set
um
it's going to be accurate about 85
percent of the time as far as whether
it's going to predict the person's going
to have a heart condition
or the one as it comes up with the zero
one on there
which would mean at this point that you
have an 85 percent uh being correct on
telling someone they're extremely high
risk for a heart attack kind of thing
and so we want to go ahead and create
our confusion matrix and let me just do
that
of course the software does everything
for us so we'll go ahead and run this
and you can see right here
here's our 25
prediction uh correct predictions right
here
and if you remember from our slide i'll
just bring this over says a nice visual
we have our true positive
false positive
uh so we had 25 which were true that it
said hey this person is going to be high
risk at heart and we had four
that were still high risk that it said
we're false
so out of these 25 people or out of
these 29 people and that makes sense
because you have 0.85
out of 29 people it was correct on 25 of
them
and so uh here's our accuracy score we
were just looking at that our accuracy
is your true positive and your true
negative over all of them so how true is
it there's our accuracy coming up here
0.85 and then we have our nice matrix
generated from that
and you can see right here is a similar
matrix we had going for the from the
slide and this starts to this should
start asking questions at this point
so if you're in a board meeting or
you're working with this you really want
to start looking at this data here and
saying well
is this good enough is
this number of people and hopefully
you'd have a much larger data set in my
is my confusion matrix showing for the
true positive and false positive
is that acceptable for what we're doing
and of course if you're going to put
together whatever data you're putting
out you might want to separate the
true negative false positive false
negative true positive and you can
simply do that by doing the confusion
matrix
and then of course the ravel part lets
you
set that up so you can just split that
right up into a nice tuple and the final
thing we want to show you here in the
coding
on this part
is the confusion matrix metrics
and so we can come in here and just use
the matrix equals classification report
the y test and the predict
and then we're going to take that
classification report and go ahead and
print that out
and you can see here it does a nice job
giving you your accuracy
your micro average your weighted average
you have your precision your recall your
f1 score and your support all in one
window so you can start looking at this
data and saying oh okay
our precision is at .83
0.87 for getting a a positive and 0.83
for the negative side for a zero
and we start talking about whether this
is a valid information or not to use
and when we're looking at a heart attack
prediction we're only looking at one
aspect what's the chances of this person
having a heart attack or not
you might have something where we went
back to the languages maybe you also
want to know whether they speak english
or hindi
or french and you can see right here
that we can now
take our confusion matrix and just
expand it as big as we need to depending
on how many different classifiers we're
working on
what is a decision tree let's go through
a very simple example before we dig in
deep decision tree is a tree shape
diagram used to determine a course of
action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision or
current or reaction let's start with a
simple question how to identify a random
vegetable from a shopping bag so we have
this group of vegetables in here and we
can start off by asking a simple
question is it red and if it's not then
it's going to be the purple fruit to the
left probably an eggplant if it's true
it's going to be one of the red fruits
is the diameter greater than 2 if false
is going to be a what looks to be a red
chili and if it's true it's going to be
a bell pepper from the capsicum family
so it's a capsicum
problems that decision tree can solve so
let's look at the two different
categories the decision tree can be used
on it can be used on the classification
the true false yes no and it can be used
on regression where we figure out what
the next value is in a series of numbers
or a group of data in classification the
classification tree will determine a set
of logical if-then conditions to
classify problems for example
discriminating between three types of
flowers based on certain features in
regression a regression tree is used
when the target variable is numerical or
continuous in nature we fit the
regression model to the target variable
using each of the independent variables
each split is made based on the sum of
squared error
before we dig deeper into the mechanics
of the decision tree let's take a look
at the advantages of using a decision
tree and we'll also take a glimpse at
the disadvantages the first thing you'll
notice is that it's simple to understand
interpret and visualize it really shines
here because you can see exactly what's
going on in a decision tree little
effort is required for data preparation
so you don't have to do special scaling
there's a lot of things you don't have
to worry about when using a decision
tree it can handle both numerical and
categorical data as we discovered
earlier and non-linear parameters don't
affect its performance so even if the
data doesn't fit an easy curved graph
you can still use it to create an
effective decision or prediction
if we're going to look at the advantages
of a decision tree we also need to
understand the disadvantages of a
decision tree the first disadvantage is
overfitting overfitting occurs when the
algorithm captures noise in the data
that means you're solving for one
specific instance instead of a general
solution for all the data high variance
the model can get unstable due to small
variation in data low bias tree a highly
complicated decision tree tends to have
a low bias which makes it difficult for
the model to work with new data
decision tree important terms before we
dive in further we need to look at some
basic terms we need to have some
definitions to go with our decision tree
and the different parts we're going to
be using we'll start with entropy
entropy is a measure of randomness or
unpredictability in the data set for
example we have a group of animals in
this picture there's four different
kinds of animals and this data set is
considered to have a high entropy you
really can't pick out what kind of
animal it is based on looking at just
the four animals as a big clump of
entities so as we start splitting it
into subgroups we come up with our
second
definition which is information gain
information gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy after the data set
is split so in this case based on the
color yellow we've split one group of
animals on one side as true and those
who aren't yellow as false as we
continue down the yellow side we split
based on the height true or false equals
10 and on the other side height is less
than 10 true or false and as you see as
we split it the entropy continues to be
less and less and less and so our
information gain is simply the entropy
e1 from the top and how it's changed to
e2 in the bottom and we'll look at the
deeper math although you really don't
need to know a huge amount of math when
you actually do the programming in
python because they'll do it for you but
we'll look on the actual math of how
they compute entropy finally we went on
the different parts of our tree and they
call the leaf node leaf node carries the
classification or the decision so it's
the final end at the bottom the decision
node has two or more branches this is
where we're breaking the group up into
different parts and finally you have the
root node the topmost decision node is
known as the root node
how does a decision tree work wonder
what kind of animals i'll get in the
jungle today maybe you're the hunter
with the gun or if you're more into
photography you're a photographer with a
camera so let's look at this group of
animals and let's try to classify
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree so
the problem statement is to classify the
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree the
data set is looking quite messy and the
entropy is high in this case so let's
look at a training set or a training
data set and we're looking at color
we're looking at height and then we have
our different animals we have our
elephants our giraffes our monkeys and
our tigers and they're of different
colors and shapes let's see what that
looks like and how do we split the data
we have to frame the conditions that
split the data in such a way that the
information gain is the highest note
gain is the measure of decrease in
entropy after splitting so the formula
for entropy is the sum that's what this
symbol looks like that looks like kind
of like a e funky e of k where i equals
1 to k k would represent the number of
animals the different animals in there
where value or p
value of i would be the percentage of
that animal times the log base 2 of the
same the percentage of that animal let's
try to calculate the entropy for the
current data set and take a look at what
that looks like and don't be afraid of
the math you don't really have to
memorize this math just be aware that
it's there and this is what's going on
in the background and so we have three
giraffes two tigers one monkey two
elephants a total of eight animals
gathered and if we plug that into the
formula we get an entropy that equals
three over eight so we have three
giraffes a total of eight times the log
usually they use base two on the log so
log base two of three over eight plus in
this case this hits yellow fence two
over eight two elephants over total of
eight times log base two two over eight
plus one monkey over total of eight log
base two one over eight and plus two
over eight of the tigers log base two
over eight and if we plug that into our
computer our calculator i obviously
can't do logs in my head we get an
entropy equal to 0.571
the program will actually calculate the
entropy of the data set similarly after
every split to calculate the gain now
we're not going to go through each set
one at a time to see what those numbers
are we just want you to be aware that
this is a formula or the mathematics
behind it gain can be calculated by
finding the difference of the subsequent
entropy values after a split now we will
try to choose a condition that gives us
the highest gain we will do that by
splitting the data using each condition
and checking that the gain we get out of
them the condition that gives us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split can you guess what that
first split will be just by looking at
this image as a human it's probably
pretty easy to split it let's see if
you're right if you guessed the color
yellow you're correct let's say the
condition that gives us the maximum gain
is yellow so we will split the data
based on the color yellow if it's true
that group of animals goes to the left
if it's false it goes to the right the
entropy after the splitting has
decreased considerably however we still
need some splitting of both the branches
to attain an entropy value equal to zero
so we decided to split both the nodes
using height as the condition since
every branch now contains single label
type we can say that entropy in this
case has reached the least value and
here you see we have the giraffes the
tigers the monkey and the elephants all
separated into their own groups this
tree can now predict all the classes of
animals present in the data set with a
hundred percent accuracy that was easy
use case loan repayment prediction let's
get into my favorite part and open up
some python and see what the programming
code in the scripting looks like in here
we're going to want to do a prediction
and we start with this individual here
who's requesting to find out how good
his customers are going to be whether
they're going to repay their loan or not
for his bank and from that we want to
generate a problem statement to predict
if a customer will repay loan amount or
not and then we're going to be using the
decision tree algorithm in python let's
see what that looks like and let's dive
into the code in our first few steps of
implementation we're going to start by
importing the necessary packages that we
need from python and we're going to load
up our data and take a look at what the
data looks like so the first thing i
need is i need something to edit my
python and run it in so let's flip on
over and here i'm using the anaconda
jupiter notebook now you can use any
python ide you like to run it in but i
find the jupyter notebook's really nice
for doing things on the fly and let's go
ahead and just paste that code in the
beginning and before we start let's talk
a little bit about what we're bringing
in and then we're going to do a couple
things in here we have to make a couple
changes as we go through this first part
of the import the first thing we bring
in is numpy as np that's very standard
when we're dealing with mathematics
especially with uh very complicated
machine learning tools you almost always
see the numpy come in for your num your
number it's called number python it has
your mathematics in there in this case
we actually could take it out but
generally you'll need it for most of
your different things you work with and
then we're going to use pandas as pd
that's also a standard the pandas is a
data frame setup and you can liken this
to taking your basic data and storing it
in a way that looks like an excel
spreadsheet so as we come back to this
when you see np or pd those are very
standard uses you'll know that that's
the pandas and i'll show you a little
bit more we explore the data in just a
minute then we're going to need to split
the data so i'm going to bring in our
train test and split and this is coming
from the sklearn package cross
validation in just a minute we're going
to change that and we'll go over that
too and then there's also the sk.tree
import decision tree classifier that's
the actual tool we're using remember i
told you don't be afraid of the
mathematics it's going to be done for
you well the decision tree classifier
has all that mathematics in there for
you so you don't have to figure it back
out again and then we have
sklearn.metrics for accuracy score we
need to score our setup that's the whole
reason we're splitting it between the
training and testing data and finally we
still need the sklearn import tree and
that's just the basic tree function is
needed for the decision tree classifier
and finally we're going to load our data
down here and i'm going to run this and
we're going to get two things on here
one we're going to get an error and two
we're going to get a warning let's see
what that looks like so the first thing
we had is we have an error why is this
error here well it's looking at this it
says i need to read a file and when this
was written
the person who wrote it
this is their path where they stored the
file
so let's go ahead and fix that
and i'm going to put in here my file
path i'm just going to call it full file
name
and you'll see it's on my c drive and
this is very lengthy setup on here where
i stored the data2.csv file
don't worry too much about the full path
because on your computer will be
different
the data.2 csv file was generated by
simplylearn
if you want a copy of that you can
comment down below and request it here
in the youtube
and then if i'm going to give it a name
full file name
i'm going to go ahead and change it here
to full
file name so let's go ahead and run it
now and see what happens
and we get a warning
when you're coding
understanding these different warnings
and these different errors that come up
is probably the hardest lesson to learn
so let's just go ahead and take a look
at this and use this as a opportunity to
understand what's going on here
if you read the warning it says the
cross validation is depreciated so it's
a warning on it's being removed
and it's going to be moved in favor of
the model selection
so if we go up here we have sklearn dot
cross validation and if you research
this and go to the sklearn site you'll
find out that you can actually just swap
it right in there with
model selection
and so when i come in here and i run it
again
that removes a warning
what they've done is they've had two
different developers develop it in two
different branches
and then they decided to keep one of
those and eventually get rid of the
other one that's all that is and very
easy and quick to fix
before we go any further i went ahead
and opened up the data from this file
remember the the data file we just
loaded on here the data underscore two
dot csv
let's talk a little bit more about that
and see what that looks like both as a
text file because it's a comma separated
variable file and in a spreadsheet
this is what it looks like as a basic
text file you can see at the top they've
created a header and it's got one two
three four five columns and each column
has data in it and let me flip this over
because we're also going to look at this
uh in an actual spreadsheet so you can
see what that looks like and here i've
opened it up in the open office calc
which is pretty much the same as excel
and zoomed in and you can see we've got
our columns and our rows of data a
little easier to read in here we have a
result yes yes no we have initial
payment last payment credit score house
number
if we scroll way down
we'll see that this occupies a thousand
and one lines of code or lines of data
with the first one being a column and
then 1 000 lines of data
now as a programmer
if you're looking at a small amount of
data i usually start by pulling it up in
different sources so i can see what i'm
working with
but in larger data you won't have that
option it'll just be too too large so
you need to either bring in a small
amount that you can look at it like
we're doing right now or we can start
looking at it through the python code so
let's go ahead and move on and take the
next couple steps to explore the data
using python let's go ahead and see what
it looks like in python to print the
length and the shape of the data so
let's start by printing the length of
the database we can use a simple lin
function from python
and when i run this
you'll see that it's a thousand long and
that's what we expected there's a
thousand lines of data in there if you
subtract the column head this is one of
the nice things when we did the balance
data from the panda read csv
you'll see that the header is row 0 so
it automatically removes a row
and then shows the data separate it does
a good job sorting that data out for us
and then we can use a different function
let's take a look at that
and again we're going to utilize the
tools in panda
and since the balance underscored data
was loaded as a panda data frame
we can do a shape on it and let's go
ahead and run the shape and see what
that looks like
what's nice about this shape is not only
does it give me the length of the data
we have a thousand lines it also tells
me there's five columns so we were
looking at the data we had five columns
of data and then let's take one more
step to explore the data using python
and now that we've taken a look at the
length and the shape let's go ahead and
use the pandas module for head another
beautiful thing in the data set that we
can utilize so let's put that on our
sheet here and we have print data set
and balance data dot head and this is a
pandas print statement of its own so it
has its own print feature in there and
then we went ahead and gave a label for
a print job here of dataset just a
simple print statement
and we run that
and let's just take a closer look at
that let me zoom in here
there we go
pandas does such a wonderful job
of making this a very clean
readable data set so you can look at the
data you can look at the column headers
you can have it when you put it as the
head
it prints the first five lines of the
data
and we always start with zero so we have
five lines we have zero one two three
four instead of one two three four five
that's a standard scripting and
programming set as you wanna start with
the zero position and that is what the
data head does it pulls the first five
rows of data puts in a nice format that
you can look at and view very powerful
tool to view the data so instead of
having to flip and open up an excel
spreadsheet or open office cal or trying
to look at a word doc where it's all
scrunched together and hard to read you
can now get a nice open view of what
you're working with we're working with a
shape of a thousand long five wide so we
have five columns and we do the full
data head you can actually see what this
data looks like the initial payment last
payment credit scores house number so
let's take this now that we've explored
the data and let's start digging into
the decision tree so in our next step
we're going to train and build our data
tree and to do that we need to first
separate the date out we're going to
separate into two groups so that we have
something to actually train the data
with and then we have some data on the
side to test it to see how good our
model is remember with any of the
machine learning you always want to have
some kind of test set to weigh it
against so you know how good your model
is when you distribute it let's go ahead
and break this code down and look at it
in pieces
so first we have our x and y
where do x and y come from well x is
going to be our data
and y is going to be the answer or the
target you can look at source and target
in this case we're using x and y to
denote the data in and the data that
we're actually trying to guess what the
answer is going to be and so to separate
it we can simply put in x equals the
balance of the data.values the first
brackets
means that we're going to select all the
lines
in the database so it's all the data
and the second one says we're only going
to look at columns one through five
remember we always start with zero zero
is a yes or no
and that's whether the loan went default
or not so we want to start with one if
we go back up here that's the initial
payment and it goes all the way through
the house number
well if we want to look at one through
five we can do the same thing for y
which is the answers and we're going to
set that just equal to the zero row so
it's just the zero row and then it's all
rows going in there so now we've divided
this into two different data sets
one of them with the
data going in and one with the answers
next we need to split the data
and here you'll see that we have it
split into four different parts
the first one is your x training your x
test your y train your y test
simply put we have x going in where
we're going to train it and we have to
know the answer to train it with
and then we have x test where we're
going to test that data
and we have to know in the end what the
y was supposed to be
and that's where this train test split
comes in that we loaded earlier in the
modules this does it all for us and you
can see they set the test size equal to
0.3 so that's roughly 30 percent will be
used in the test and then we use a
random state so it's completely random
which rows it takes out of there and
then finally we get to actually build
our decision tree and they've called it
here clf underscore entropy that's the
actual decision tree or decision tree
classifier and in here they've added a
couple variables which we'll explore in
just a minute and then finally we need
to fit the data to that so we take our
clf entropy that we created and we fit
the x train and since we know the
answers for x-trade or the y-train we go
ahead and put those in and let's go
ahead and run this and what most of
these sklearn modules do is when you set
up the variable in this case we set the
clf entropical decision tree classifier
it automatically prints out what's in
that decision tree there's a lot of
variables you can play within here and
it's quite beyond the scope of this
tutorial to go through all of these and
how they work but we're working on
entropy that's one of the options we've
added that it's completely a random
state of 100 so 100
and we have a max depth of three
now the max depth if you remember above
when we were doing the different graphs
of animals means it's only going to go
down three layers before it stops and
then we have minimal samples of leafs is
five so it's going to have at least five
leafs at the end so i'll have at least
three splits i'll have no more than
three layers and at least five end
leaves with the final result at the
bottom now that we've created
our decision tree classifier not only
created it but trained it let's go ahead
and apply it and see what that looks
like so let's go ahead and make a
prediction and see what that looks like
we're going to paste our predict code in
here
and before we run it let's just take a
quick look at what's it's doing here
we have a variable y predict that we're
going to do
and we're going to use our
variable clf entropy that we created
and then you'll see dot predict and it's
very common in the sk learn modules that
their different tools have to predict
when you're actually running a
prediction
in this case we're going to put our x
test data in here
now if you delivered this for use in
actual commercial use and distributed it
this would be the new loans you're
putting in here to guess
whether the person is going to be uh pay
them back or not
in this case so we need to test out the
data and just see how good our sample is
how good of our tree does at predicting
the loan payments and finally since
anaconda jupiter notebook is it works as
a command line for python we can simply
put the y predict e n to print it i
could just as easily have put the print
and put brackets around y predict en to
print it out we'll go ahead and do that
it doesn't matter which way you do it
and you'll see right here that runs a
prediction this is roughly 300 in here
remember it's 30 percent of a thousand
so you should have about 300 answers in
here
and this tells you which each one of
those lines of our test went in there
and this is what our y predict came out
so let's move on to the next step we're
going to take this data and try to
figure out just how good a model we have
so here we go since sklearn does all the
heavy lifting for you and all the math
we have a simple line of code to let us
know what the accuracy is and let's go
ahead and go through that and see what
that means and what that looks like
let's go ahead and paste this in and let
me zoom in a little bit
there we go
so you have a nice full picture
and we'll see here we're just going to
do a print accuracy is
and then we do the accuracy score
and this was something we imported
earlier if you remember at the very
beginning let me just scroll up there
real quick so you can see where that's
coming from
that's coming from here down here from
sklearn.metrics
import accuracy score and you could
probably run a script make your own
script to do this very easily how
accurate is it how many out of 300 do we
get right and so we put in our y test
that's the one we ran the predict on and
then we put in our y predict e n that's
the answers we got
and we're just going to multiply that by
a hundred because this is just going to
give us an answer as a decimal and we
want to see it as a percentage
and let's run that and see what it looks
like
and if you see here we got an accuracy
of 93.6
so when we look at the number of loans
and we look at how good our model fit we
can tell people it has about a 93.6
fitting to it so just a quick recap on
that we now have accuracy set up on here
and so we have created a model that uses
the decision tree algorithm to predict
whether a customer will repay the loan
or not the accuracy of the model is
about 94.6 percent the bank can now use
this model to decide whether it should
approve the loan request from a
particular customer or not and so this
information is really powerful we may
not be able to as individuals understand
all these numbers because they have
thousands of numbers that come in but
you can see that this is a smart
decision for the bank to use a tool like
this to help them to predict how good
their profit's going to be off of the
loan balances and how many are going to
default or not
how does a random forest work as a whole
so to begin our
random forest classifier let's say we
already have built three trees and we're
going to start with the first tree that
looks like this just like we did in the
example this tree looks at the diameter
if it's greater than or equal to three
it's true otherwise it's false so one
side goes to the smaller diameter one
side goes to larger diameter and if the
color is orange it's going to go to the
right true we're using oranges now
instead of lemons and if it's red it's
going to go to the left false we build a
second tree very similar but split
differently instead of the first one
being split by a diameter this one when
they created it if you look at that
first bowl it has a lot of red objects
so it says is the color red because
that's going to bring our entropy down
the fastest and so of course if it's
true it goes to the left if it's false
it goes to the right and then it looks
at the shape false are true and so on
and so on and tree three is a diameter
equal to one and it came up with this
because there's a lot of cherries in
this bowl so that would be the biggest
split on there is is the diameter equal
to one that's going to drop the entropy
the quickest and as you can see it
splits it into true if it goes false and
they've added another category does it
grow in the summer and if it's false
it goes off to the left if it's true it
goes off to the right let's go ahead and
bring these three trees so you can see
them all in one image so this would be
three completely different trees
categorizing a fruit and let's take a
fruit now let's try this and this fruit
if you look at it we've blackened it out
you can't see the color on it so it's
missing data remember one of the things
we talked
that a about forest works really good if
you're missing data if you're missing
pieces so this fruit has an image but
maybe the person had a black and white
camera when they took the picture and
we're going to take a look at this and
it's going to have they put the color in
there so ignore the color down there but
the diameter equals three we find out it
grows in the summer equals yes and the
shape is a circle and if you go to the
right you can look at what one of the
decision trees did this is the third one
is the diameter greater than equal to
three is the color orange well it
doesn't really know on this one but if
you look at the value it say true and
you go to the right tree two classifies
it as cherries is a color equal red
is the shape of circle true it is a
circle so this would look at it and say
oh that's a cherry and then we go to the
other classifier and it says is the
diameter equal one well that's false
does it grow in the summer true so it
goes down and looks at as oranges so how
does this random forest work the first
one says it's an orange
the second one said it was a cherry and
the third one says it's an orange
and you can guess if you have two
oranges and one says it's a cherry when
you add that all together the majority
of the vote says orange so the answer is
it's classified as an orange even though
we didn't know the color and we're
missing data on it i don't know about
you but i'm getting tired of fruit so
let's switch and i did promise you we'd
start looking at a case example and get
into some python coding today we're
going to use the case the iris flower
analysis
this is the exciting part as we roll up
our sleeves and actually look at some
python coding before we start the python
coding we need to go ahead and create a
problem statement wonder what species of
iris do these flowers belong to let's
try to predict the species of the
flowers using machine learning in python
let's see how it can be done so here we
begin to go ahead and implement our
python code and you'll find that the
first half of our implementation is all
about organizing and exploring the data
coming in let's go ahead and take this
first step which is loading the
different modules into python and let's
go ahead and put that in our favorite
editor whatever your favorite editor is
in this case i'm going to be using the
anaconda jupiter notebook which is one
of my favorites certainly there's
notepad plus plus and eclipse and dozens
of others or just even using the python
terminal window any of those will work
just fine to go ahead and explore this
python coding so here we go let's go
ahead and flip over to our jupiter
notebook and i've already opened up a
new page for python 3 code and i'm just
going to paste this right in there and
let's take a look and see what we're
bringing into our python the first thing
we're going to do is from the
sklearn.datasets
import load iris now this isn't the
actual data this is just the module that
allows us to bring in the data the load
iris and the iris is so popular it's
been around since 1936 when ronald
fisher published a paper on it and
they're measuring the different parts of
the flower and based on those
measurements predicting what kind of
flower it is and then if we're going to
do a random forest classifier we need to
go ahead and import a random forest
classifier from the sklearn module so
sklearn dot ensemble import random force
classifier and then we want to bring in
two more modules
and these are probably the most commonly
used modules in python and data science
with any of the
other modules that we bring in and one
is going to be pandas we're going to
import pandas as pd pd is a common term
used for pandas and pandas is basically
creates a data format for us
where when you create a pandas data
frame it looks like an excel spreadsheet
and you'll see that in a minute when we
start digging deeper into the code panda
is just wonderful because it plays nice
with all the other modules in there and
then we have numpy which is our numbers
python and the numbers python allows us
to do different mathematical sets on
here we'll see right off the bat we're
going to take our np and we're going to
go ahead and seed the randomness with it
with 0. so
np.random.seed is seating that is 0.
this code doesn't actually show anything
we're going to go ahead and run it
because i need to make sure i have all
those loaded and then let's take a look
at the next module on here the next six
slides including this one are all about
exploring the data remember i told you
half of this is about looking at the
data and getting it all set so let's go
ahead and take this code right here the
script and let's get that over into our
jupiter notebook and here we go we've
gone ahead and run
the imports and i'm going to paste the
code down here
and let's take a look and see what's
going on the first thing we're doing is
we're actually loading the iris data and
if you remember up here we loaded the
module that tells it how to get the iris
data now we're actually assigning that
data to the variable iris and then we're
going to go ahead and use the df to
define data frame
and that's going to equal pd and if
remember that's pandas as pd so that's
our pandas
and panda data frame and then we're
looking at iris data
and columns equals iris feature names
and we're going to do the df head and
let's run this you can understand what's
going on here
the first thing you want to notice is
that our df has created what looks like
an excel spreadsheet and in this excel
spreadsheet we have set the columns so
up on the top you can see the four
different columns and then we have the
data iris.data down below it's a little
confusing without knowing where this
data is coming from so let's look at the
bigger picture and i'm going to go print
i'm just going to change this for a
moment and we're going to print all of
iris and see what that looks like
so when i print all of iris i get this
long list of information
and you can scroll through here and see
all the different titles on there
what's important to notice is that first
off there's a brackets at the beginning
so this is a python dictionary
and in a python dictionary
you'll have a key
or a label and this label pulls up
whatever information comes after it so
feature names which we actually used
over here under columns is equal to an
array of sepal length steeple width
pedal length pedal width these are the
different names they have for the four
different columns and if you scroll down
far enough you'll also see data down
here oh goodness it came up right
towards the top and data is equal to the
different data we're looking at
now there's a lot of other things in
here like target we're going to be
pulling that up in a minute and there's
also the names the target names which is
further down and we'll show you that
also in a minute let's go ahead and set
that back
to the head
and this is one of the neat features of
pandas and panda data frames
is when you do df.head or the
pandadataframe.head it'll print the
first five lines of the dataset in there
along with the headers if you have it in
this case we have the column header set
to iris features and in here you'll see
that we have zero one two three four in
python most arrays always start at zero
so when you look at the first five it's
going to be 0 1 2 3 4 not 1 2 3 4 5. so
now we've got our iris data imported
into a data frame let's take a look at
the next piece of code in here and so in
this section here of the code
we're going to take a look at the target
and let's go ahead and get this into our
notebook this piece of code so we can
discuss it a little bit more in detail
so here we are in our jupyter notebook
i'm going to put the code in here and
before i run it
i want to look at a couple things going
on so we have df species
and this is interesting because right
here you'll see where i have df species
in brackets which is uh the key code for
creating another column and here we have
iris.target now these are both in the
pandas setup on here so in pandas we can
do either one i could have just as
easily done iris and then in brackets
target depending on what i'm working on
both are acceptable let's go ahead and
run this code and see how this changes
and what we've done is we've added the
target from the iris data set
as another column on the end
now what species is this is what we're
trying to predict so we have our data
which tells us the answer for all these
different pieces and then we've added a
column with the answer that way when we
do our final setup we'll have the
ability to program our neural network to
look for these this different data and
know what a setosa is or a vera color
which we'll see in just a minute or
virginica those are the three that are
in there and now we're going to add one
more column i know we're organizing all
this data over and over again it's kind
of fun there's a lot of ways to organize
it what's nice about putting everything
onto one
data frame is i can then do a printout
and it shows me exactly what i'm looking
at and i'll show you where you where
that's different where you can alter
that and do it slightly differently but
let's go ahead and put this into our
script up to that now and here we go
we're going to put that down here
and we're going to run that
and let's talk a little bit about what
we're doing now we're exploring data
and one of the challenges is knowing how
good your model is did your model work
and to do this we need to split the data
and we split it into two different parts
they usually call it the training and
the testing and so in here we're going
to go ahead and put that in our database
so you can see it clearly and we've set
it df remember you can put brackets this
is creating another column is train so
we're going to use part of it for
training and this equals np remember
that stands for numpy
numpy.random.uniform
so we're generating a random number
between 0 and 1. and we're going to do
it for each of the rows that's where the
length df comes from so each row gets a
generated number and if it's less than
0.75 it's true and if it's greater than
0.75 it's false this means we're going
to take
75 percent of the data roughly because
there's a randomness involved and we're
going to use that to train it and then
the other 25 we're going to hold off to
the side and use that to test it later
on so let's flip back on over and see
what the next step is so now that we've
labeled our database for which is
training and which is testing
let's go ahead and sort that into two
different variables train and test and
let's take this code and let's bring it
into our project and here we go let's
paste it on down here and before i run
this let's just take a quick look at
what's going on here is we have up above
we created remember there's our def dot
head which prints the first five rows
and we've added a column is train at the
end and so we're going to take that
we're going to create two variables
we're going to create two new data
frames one's called train
one's called test 75 and train 25
percent and test
and then to sort that out
we're going to do that by doing df our
main original data frame with the iris
data in it
and if df is trained equals true
that's going to go in the train and if
df is train equals false it goes in the
test
and so when i run this
we're going to print out the number in
each one let's see what that looks like
and you'll see that it puts 118 in the
training module and it puts 32 in the
testing module which lets us know that
there was 150 lines of data in here so
if you went and looked at the original
data you could see that there's 150
lines and that's roughly 75 percent in
one and 25 for us to test our model on
afterward so let's jump back to our code
and see where this goes in the next two
steps
we want to do one more thing with our
data and that's make it readable to
humans
i don't know about you but i hate
looking at zeros and ones
so let's start with the features and
let's go ahead and
take those and make those readable to
humans and let's put that in our code
let's see here we go paste it in and
you'll see here we've done a couple very
basic things we know that the columns in
our data frame again this is a panda
thing the df columns
and we know the first four of them zero
one two three that'd be the first four
are going to be the features or the
titles of those columns and so when i
run this
you'll see down here that it creates an
index sepa length sepa width pedal
length and pedal width and this should
be familiar because if you look up here
here's our column titles going across
and here's the first four
one thing i want you to notice here is
that when you're in a command line
whether it's jupiter notebook or you're
running command line in the terminal
window if you just put the name of it
it'll print it out this is the same as
doing print
features
and the shorthand is you just put
features in here if you're actually
writing a code
and saving the script and running it by
remote you really need to put the print
in there but for this when i run it
you'll see it gives me the same thing
but for this we want to go ahead and
we'll just leave it as features because
it doesn't really matter
and this is one of the fun thing about
jupiter notebooks is i'm just building
the code as we go and then we need to go
ahead and create the labels for the
other part so let's take a look and see
what that
for our final step in prepping our data
before we actually start running the
training and the testing is we're going
to go ahead and convert the species on
here into something the computer
understands so let's put this code into
our script and see where that takes us
all right here we go we've set y equal
to pd dot factorize
train species of zero
so let's break this down just a little
bit we have our pandas right here pd
factorize what's factorized doing i'm
going to come back to that in just a
second
let's look at what train species is
and why we're looking at the group 0 on
there
and let's go up here and here is our
species
remember this on that we created this
whole column here for species
and then it has satoshi satosa satosa
setosa and if you scroll down enough
you'd also see virginica and veracolor
we need to convert that into something
the computer understands zeros and ones
so the train species
of zero because this is in the format of
a of an array of arrays so you have to
have the zero on the end
and then species is just that column
factorize goes in there looks at the
fact that there's only three of them so
when i run this you'll see that y
generates an array that's equal to in
this case it's the training set and it's
zeros ones and twos representing the
three different kinds of flowers we have
so now we have something the computer
understands and we have a nice table
that we can read and understand and now
finally we get to actually start doing
the predicting so here we go
we have
two lines of code oh my goodness that
was a lot of work to get to two lines of
code but there is a lot in these two
lines of code so let's take a look and
see what's going on here and put this
into our full script that we're running
and let's paste this in here and let's
take a look and see what this is we have
we're creating a variable clf and we're
going to set this equal to the random
forest classifier and we're passing two
variables in here and there's a lot of
variables you can play with as far as
these two are concerned they're very
standard
in jobs all that does is to prioritize
it not something to really worry about
usually when you're doing this on your
own computer you do in jobs equals two
if you're working in a larger or big
data and you need to prioritize it
differently this is what that number
does is it changes your priorities and
how it's going to run across the system
and things like that and then the random
state is just how it starts
0 is fine for here
but let's go ahead and run this
we also have clf.fit train features
comma y and before we run it let's talk
about this a little bit more clf
dot fit so we're fitting we're training
it we are actually creating our random
forest classifier right here this is the
code that does everything and we're
going to take our training set remember
we kept our test off to the side and
we're going to take our training set
with the features and then we're going
to go ahead and put that in and here's
our target the y
so the y is 0 1 and 2 that we just
created and the features is the actual
data going in that we put into the
training set let's go ahead and run that
and this is kind of an interesting thing
because it printed out the random force
classifier
and everything around it
and so when you're running this in your
terminal window or in a script like this
this automatically treats this like just
like when we were up here and i typed in
y and it printed out y instead of print
y
this does the same thing it treats this
as a variable and prints it out but if
you're actually running your code that
wouldn't be the case and what is printed
out is it shows us all the different
variables we can change and if we go
down here you can actually see in jobs
equals two
you can see the random state equals zero
those are the two that we sent in there
you would really have to dig deep to
find out all these different meanings of
all these different settings on here
some of them are self-explanatory if you
kind of think about it a little bit like
max features is auto so all the features
that we're putting in there is just
going to automatically take all four of
them whatever we send it it'll take some
of them might have so many features
because you're processing words there
might be like 1.4 million features in
there because you're doing legal
documents and that's how many different
words are in there at that point you
probably want to limit the maximum
features that you're going to process
and leaf nodes that's the end nodes
remember we had the fruit and we're
talking about the leaf nodes like i said
there's a lot in this we're looking at a
lot of stuff here so you might have in
this case there's probably only think
three leaf nodes maybe four you might
have thousands of leaf nodes at which
point you do need to put a cap on that
and say okay can only go so far and then
we're going to use all of our resources
on processing this
and that really is what most of these
are about is limiting the process and
making sure we don't overwhelm a system
and there's some other settings in here
again we're not going to go over all of
them warm start equals false warm start
is if you're programming it one piece at
a time externally since we're not we're
not going to have like we're not going
to continually to train this particular
learning tree and again like i said
there's a lot of things in here that
you'll want to look up more detail from
the sk learn and if you're digging in
deep and running a major project on here
for today though all we need to do is
fit our train our features and our
target y so now we have our training
model what's next if we're going to
create a model
we now need to test it remember we set
aside the test feature test group 25 of
the data so let's go ahead and take this
code and let's put it into our script
and see what that looks like okay here
we go
and we're going to run this
and it's going to come out with a bunch
of zeros ones and twos which represents
the three type of flowers the setosa the
virginica and the versacolor and what
we're putting into our predict is the
test features
and i always kind of like to know what
it is i am looking at
so real quick we're going to do test
features and remember features is an
array
of simple links simple width pedal
length pedal width so when we put it in
this way it actually loads all these
different columns that we loaded into
features so if we did just features let
me just do features in here seeing what
features looks like
this is just playing with the with
panda's data frames you'll see that it's
an index so when you put an index in
like this
into
test features into test
it then takes those columns and creates
a panda data frames from those columns
and in this case
we're going to go ahead and put those
into our predict
so we're going to put each one of these
lines of data
the 5.0 3.4
1.5.2 and we're going to put those in
and we're going to predict what our
new
forest classifier is going to come up
with and this is what it predicts it
predicts 0 0 0 1 2 1 1 2 2 2 and and
again this is the
flower type setosa virginica and
versacolor so now that we've taken our
test features
let's explore that let's see exactly
what that data means to us so the first
thing we can do with our predicts is we
can actually generate a different
prediction model when i say different
we're going to view it differently it's
not that the data itself is different so
let's take this next piece of code and
put it into our script
so we're pasting it in here and you'll
see that we're doing uh predict and
we've added underscore proba for
probability so there's our clf.predict
probability so we're running it just
like we ran it up here but this time
with this we're going to get a slightly
different result and we're only going to
look at the first 10.
so you'll see down here instead of
looking at all of them
which was what 27 you'll see right down
here that this generates a much larger
field on the probability and let's take
a look and see what that looks like
and what that means
so when we do the predict underscore
prabha
for probability it generates three
numbers so we had three leaf nodes at
the end and if you remember from all the
theory we did
this is the predictors the first one is
predicting a 1 for setosa it predicts a
0 for virginica and it predicts a 0 for
versa color and so on and so on and so
on and let's um you know what i'm going
to change this just a little bit let's
look at 10
to 20 just because we can
and we start to get a little different
of data and you'll see right down here
it gets to this one this line right here
and this line has 0 0.5 0.5
and so if we're going to vote and we
have two equal votes it's going to go
with the first one so it says uh setosa
gets zero votes virginica gets point
five votes versus color gets point five
votes but let's just go with the
virginica since these two are equal and
so on and so on down the list you can
see how they vary on here so now we've
looked at both how to do a basic predict
of the features and we've looked at the
predict probability
let's see what's next on here so now we
want to go ahead and start mapping names
for the plants we want to attach names
so that it makes a little more sense for
us and this we're going to do in these
next two steps we're going to start by
setting up our predictions and mapping
them to the name so let's see what that
looks like
and let's go ahead and paste that code
in here and run it and this goes along
with the next piece of code so we'll
skip through this quickly and then come
back to a little bit so here's iris
dot target names
and
if you remember correctly this was the
the names that we've been talking about
this whole time the setosa virginica
versus color and then we're going to go
ahead and do the prediction again we've
run that we could have just set a
variable equal to this instead of
re-running it each time but we're going
to run it again clf dot predict test
features remember that returns the zeros
the ones and the twos and then we're
going to set that equal to predictions
so this time we're actually putting it
in a variable and when i run this
it distributes it it comes out as an
array and the array is setosa satosa
satosa satosa setosa we're only looking
at the first five we could actually do
let's do the first 25 just so we can see
a little bit more on there and you'll
see that it starts mapping it to all the
different flower types the versa color
and the virginica in there and let's see
how this goes with the next one so let's
take a look at the top part of our
species in here and we'll take this code
and put it in our script
and let's put that down here and paste
it there we go and we'll go ahead and
run it
and let's talk about both these sections
of code here
and how they go together
the first one is our predictions and i
went ahead and did predictions through
25. let's just do five
and so we have setosa satoshi satosa
satoshi that's what we're predicting
from our test model
and then we come down here we look at
test species i remember i could have
just done test dot species dot head and
you'll see it says setosa satosa setosa
setosa and they match
so the first one is what our
forest is doing
and the second one is what the actual
data is now is we need to combine these
so that we can understand what that
means we need to know how good our
forest is how good it is at predicting
the features so that's where we come up
to the next step which is lots of fun
we're going to use a single line of code
to combine our predictions and our
actuals so we have a nice chart to look
at and let's go ahead and put that in
our script in our jupyter notebook here
let's see let's go ahead and paste that
in and then i'm gonna because i'm on the
jupiter notebook i can do a control
minus so you can see the whole line
there
there we go resize it
and let's take a look and see what's
going on here we're going to create in
pandas remember pd stands for pandas and
we're doing a cross tab this function
takes two sets of data
and creates a chart out of them so when
i run it you'll get a nice chart down
here
and we have the predicted species
so across the top you'll see the setosa
versus color virginica and the actual
species setosa versacolor virginica and
so the way to read this chart and let's
go ahead and take a look on how to read
this chart here when you read this chart
you have setosa where they meet you have
versus color where they meet and you
have virginica where they meet and
they're meeting where the actual and the
predicted agree
so this is the number of accurate
predictions so in this case it equals
30. if you had 13 plus 5 plus 12 you get
30. and then we notice here where it
says virginica but it was supposed to be
versacolor this is inaccurate so now we
have two two inaccurate predictions and
30 accurate predictions so we'll say
that the model accuracy is 93 that's
just 30 divided by 32 and if we multiply
it by a hundred we can say that it is 93
percent accurate so we have a 93
accuracy with our model i did want to
add one more quick thing in here on our
scripting before we wrap it up so let's
flip back on over to my script in here
we're going to take this line of code
from up above i don't know if you
remember it but predix equals the iris
dot target underscore names so we're
going to map it to the names
and we're going to run the prediction
and we read it on test features but you
know we're not just testing it we want
to actually deploy it so at this point i
would go ahead and change this
and this is an array of arrays this is
really important when you're running
these to know that
so you need the double brackets and i
could actually create data maybe let's
just do two flowers so maybe i'm
processing more data coming in and we'll
put two flowers in here
and then i actually want to see what the
answer are is so let's go ahead and type
in preds and print that out and when i
run this
you'll see that i've now predicted two
flowers that maybe i measured in my
front yard as versacolor and versacolor
not surprising since i put the same data
in for each one
this would be the actual
end product going out to be used on data
that you don't know the answer for
so that's going to conclude our
scripting part of this
today we're going to cover the k nearest
neighbors like referred to as k n n and
k n n is really a fundamental place to
start in the machine learning it's the
basis of a lot of other things and just
the logic behind it is easy to
understand and incorporated in other
forms of machine learning so today
what's in it for you why do we need k n
n
what is k n
how do we choose the factor k
when do we use k n n
how does k n algorithm work and then
we'll dive in to my favorite part the
use case predict whether a person will
have diabetes or not that is a very
common and popular used data set as far
as testing out models and learning how
to use the different models in machine
learning by now we all know machine
learning models make predictions by
learning from the past data available so
we have our input values our machine
learning model builds on those inputs of
what we already know and then we use
that to create a predicted output
is that a dog little kid looking over
there
watching the black cat cross their path
no deer you can differentiate between a
cat and a dog based on their
characteristics
cats
cats have sharp claws uses to climb
smaller lengths of ears meows and purrs
doesn't love to play around dogs they
have dull claws bigger length of ears
barks loves to run around you usually
don't see a cat running around people
although i do have a cat that does that
where dogs do and we can look at these
we can say we can evaluate the sharpness
of the claws how sharp are their claws
and we can evaluate the length of the
ears and we can usually sort out cats
from dogs based on even those two
characteristics
now tell me if it is a cat or a dog not
question usually little kids know cats
and dogs by now unless they live a place
where there's not many cats or dogs so
if we look at the sharpness of the claws
the length of the ears and we can see
that the cat has smaller ears and
sharper claws than the other animals its
features are more like cats it must be a
cat sharp claws length of ears it goes
in the cat group because knn is based on
feature similarity we can do
classification using knn classifier so
we have our input value the picture of
the black cat it goes into our trained
model and it predicts that this is a cat
coming out so what is knn what is the k
n algorithm
k nearest neighbors is what that stands
for is one of the simplest supervised
machine learning algorithms mostly used
for classification so we want to know is
this a dog or is not a dog is it a cat
or not a cat it classifies a data point
based on how its neighbors are
classified knn stores all available
cases and classifies new cases based on
a similarity measure and here we gone
from cats and dogs right into wine
another favorite of mine k n stores all
available cases and classifies new cases
based on a similarity measure and here
you see we have a measurement of sulfur
dioxide versus the chloride level and
then the different wines they've tested
and where they fall on that graph based
on how much sulfur dioxide and how much
chloride k and k n is a perimeter that
refers to the number of nearest
neighbors to include in the majority of
the voting process and so if we add a
new glass of wine there red or white we
want to know what the neighbors are in
this case we're going to put k equals 5.
we'll talk about k in just a minute a
data point is classified by the majority
of votes from its five nearest neighbors
here the unknown point would be
classified as red since four out of five
neighbors are red so how do we choose k
how do we know k equals five i mean
that's what's the value we put in there
so we're going to talk about it how do
we choose a factor k k n algorithm is
based on feature similarity choosing the
right value of k
is a process called parameter tuning and
is important for better accuracy so at k
equals three we can classify we have a
question mark in the middle as either a
as a square or not is it a square or is
it in this case a triangle and so if we
set k equals to three we're going to
look at the three nearest neighbors
we're going to say this is a square and
if we put k equals to 7 we classify as a
triangle depending on what the other
data is around and you can see as the k
changes depending on where that point is
that drastically changes your answer and
we jump here we go how do we choose the
factor of k you'll find this in all
machine learning choosing these factors
that's the face you get it's like oh my
gosh did i choose the right k did i set
it right my values in whatever machine
learning tool you're looking at so that
you don't have a huge bias in one
direction or the other and in terms of k
n n the number of k if you choose it too
low the bias is based on it's just two
noises it's right next to a couple
things and it's going to pick those
things and you might get a skewed answer
and if your k is too big then it's going
to take forever to process so you're
going to run into processing issues and
resource issues so what we do the most
common use and there's other options for
choosing k is to use the square root of
n so it is a total number of values you
have you take the square root of it in
most cases you also if it's an even
number so if you're using like in this
case squares and triangles if it's even
you want to make your k value odd that
helps it select better so in other words
you're not going to have a balance
between two different factors that are
equal so usually take the square root of
n and if it's even you add one to it or
subtract one from it and that's where
you get the k value from that is the
most common use and it's pretty solid it
works very well when do we use knn we
can use knn when data is labeled so you
need a label on it we know we have a
group of pictures with dogs dogs cats
cats data is noise free and so you can
see here when we have a class and we
have like underweight 140 23 hello kitty
normal that's pretty confusing we have a
high variety of data coming in so it's
very noisy and that would cause an issue
data set is small so we're usually
working with smaller data sets where you
might get into a gig of data if it's
really clean doesn't have a lot of noise
because k n is a lazy learner i.e it
doesn't learn a discriminative function
from the training set so it's very lazy
so if you have very complicated data and
you have a large amount of it you're not
going to use the knn but it's really
great to get a place to start even with
large data you can sort out a small
sample and get an idea of what that
looks like using the knn and also just
using for smaller data sets k n works
really good how does a k n algorithm
work consider a data set having two
variables height in centimeters and
weight in kilograms and each point is
classified as normal or underweight so
we see right here we have two variables
you know true false they're either
normal or they're not they're
underweight on the basis of the given
data we have to classify the below set
as normal or underweight using knn so if
we have new data coming in this says 57
kilograms and 177 centimeters is that
going to be normal or underweight to
find the nearest neighbors we'll
calculate the euclidean distance
according to the euclidean distance
formula the distance between two points
in the plane with the coordinates x y
and a b is given by distance d equals
the square root of x minus a squared
plus y minus b squared and you can
remember that from the two edges of a
triangle we're computing the third edge
since we know
the x side and the y side let's
calculate it to understand clearly so we
have our unknown point and we placed it
there in red and we have our other
points where the data is scattered
around the distance d1 is the square
root of 170 minus 167 squared plus 57
minus 51 squared which is about 6.7 and
distance 2 is about 13. and distance 3
is about 13.4 similarly we will
calculate the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
in the data set and because we're
dealing with small amount of data that's
not that hard to do it's actually pretty
quick for a computer and it's not a
really complicated mass you can just see
how close is the data based on the
euclidean distance hence we have
calculated the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
as shown where x1 and y1 equal 57 and
170 whose class we have to classify so
now we're looking at that we're saying
well here's the euclidean distance who's
going to be their closest neighbors now
let's calculate the nearest neighbor at
k equals 3 and we can see the three
closest neighbors puts them at normal
and that's pretty self-evident when you
look at this graph it's pretty easy to
say okay what you know we're just voting
normal normal normal three votes for
normal this is going to be a normal
weight so majority of neighbors are
pointing towards normal hence as per k n
algorithm the class of 57 170 should be
normal so a recap of knn positive
integer k is specified along with a new
sample we select the k entries in our
database which are closest to the new
sample we find the most common
classification of these entries this is
the classification we give to the new
sample so as you can see it's pretty
straightforward we're just looking for
the closest things that match what we
got so let's take a look and see what
that looks like in a use case in python
so let's dive into the predict diabetes
use case so use case predict diabetes
the objective predict whether a person
will be diagnosed with diabetes or not
we have a data set of 768 people who
were or were not diagnosed with diabetes
and let's go ahead and open that file
and just take a look at that data and
this is in a simple spreadsheet format
the data itself is comma separated very
common set of data and it's also a very
common way to get the data and you can
see here we have columns a through i
that's what one two three four five six
seven eight
eight columns with a particular
attribute and then the ninth column
which is the outcome is whether they
have diabetes as a data scientist the
first thing you should be looking at is
insulin well you know if someone has
insulin they have diabetes because
that's why they're taking it and that
could cause issue in some of the machine
learning packages but for a very basic
setup this works fine for doing the knn
and the next thing you notice is it
didn't take very much to open it up i
can scroll down to the bottom of the
data there's 768
it's pretty much a small data set you
know at 769 i can easily fit this into
my ram on my computer i can look at it i
can manipulate it and it's not going to
really tax just a regular desktop
computer you don't even need an
enterprise version to run a lot of this
so let's start with importing all the
tools we need and before that of course
we need to discuss what ide i'm using
certainly you can use any particular
editor for python but i like to use for
doing very basic visual stuff the
anaconda which is great for doing demos
with the jupiter notebook and just a
quick view of the anaconda navigator
which is the new release out there which
is really nice you can see under home i
can choose my application we're going to
be using python36 i have a couple
different versions on this particular
machine if i go under environments i can
create a unique environment for each one
which is nice and there's even a little
button there where i can install
different packages so if i click on that
button and open the terminal i can use a
simple pip install to install different
packages i'm working with let's go ahead
and go back under home and we're going
to launch our notebook and i've already
you know kind of like
the old cooking shows i've already
prepared a lot of my stuff so we don't
have to wait for it to launch because it
takes a few minutes for it to open up a
browser window in this case i'm going to
it's going to open up chrome because
that's my default that i use and since
the script is pre-done you'll see i have
a number of windows open up at the top
the one we're working in and since we're
working on the k n predict whether a
person will have diabetes or not let's
go and put that title in there
and i'm also going to go up here and
click on cell actually we want to go
ahead and first insert a cell below and
then i'm going to go back up to the top
cell and i'm going to change the cell
type to markdown that means this is not
going to run as python it's a markdown
language so if i run this first one it
comes up in nice big letters which is
kind of nice remind us what we're
working on and by now you should be
familiar with doing all of our imports
we're going to import the pandas as pd
import numpy is in p pandas is the
pandas data frame a numpy is a number
array very powerful tools to use in here
so we have our imports so we've brought
in our pandas our numpy our two general
python tools and then you can see over
here we have our trained test split by
now you should be familiar with
splitting the data we want to split part
of it for training our thing and then
training our particular model and then
we want to go ahead and test the
remaining data to see how good it is
pre-processing a standard scalar
preprocessor so we don't have a bias of
really large numbers remember in the
data we had like number of pregnancies
isn't going to get very large where the
amount of insulin they take can get up
to 256 so 256 versus 6 that will skew
results so we want to go ahead and
change that so they're all uniform
between -1 and 1. and then the actual
tool this is the k neighbors classifier
we're going to use
and finally the last three are three
tools to test all about testing our
model how good is it we just put down
test on there and we have our confusion
matrix our f1 score and our accuracy so
we have our two general python modules
we're importing and then we have our six
modules specific from the sk learn setup
and then we do need to go ahead and run
this so these are actually imported
there we go and then move on to the next
step and so in this set we're going to
go ahead and load the database we're
going to use pandas remember pandas is
pd and we'll take a look at the data in
python we looked at it in a simple
spreadsheet but usually i like to also
pull it up so that we can see what we're
doing so here's our data set equals
pd.read csv that's a pandas command and
the diabetes folder i just put in the
same folder where my ipython script is
if you put in a different folder you
need the full length on there we can
also do a quick length of the data set
that is a simple python command len for
length we might even let's go ahead and
print that we'll go print and if you do
it on its own line link that data set in
the jupyter notebook it'll automatically
print it but when you're in most of your
different setups you want to do the
print in front of there and then we want
to take a look at the actual data set
and since we're in pandas we can simply
do data set head and again let's go
ahead and add the print in there
if you put a bunch of these in a row you
know the data set 1 head data set 2 head
it only prints out the last one so i
usually always like to keep the print
statement in there but because most
projects only use one data frame panda's
data frame doing it this way doesn't
really matter the other way works just
fine and you can see when we hit the run
button we have the 768 lines which we
knew and we have our pregnancies it's
automatically given a label on the left
remember the head only shows the first
five lines so we have zero through four
and just a quick look at the data you
can see it matches what we looked at
before we have pregnancy glucose blood
pressure all the way to age and then the
outcome on the end and we're going to do
a couple things in this next step we're
going to create a list of columns where
we can't have zero there's no such thing
as zero skin thickness or zero blood
pressure zero glucose
any of those you'd be dead so not a
really good factor if they don't if they
have a zero in there because they didn't
have the data and we'll take a look at
that because we're going to start
replacing that information with a couple
of different things and let's see what
that looks like so first we create a
nice list as you can see we have the
values talked about glucose blood
pressure skin thickness
and this is a nice way when you're
working with columns is to list the
columns you need to do some kind of
transformation on a very common thing to
do and then for this particular setup we
certainly could use the there's some
panda tools that will do a lot of this
where we can replace the n a but we're
going to go ahead and do it as a data
set column equals dataset column.replace
this is this is still pandas you can do
a direct there's also one that's that
you look for your nan a lot of different
options in here but the
numpy n nan
n is what that stands for is none it
doesn't exist so the first thing we're
doing here is we're replacing the zero
with a numpy none there's no data there
that's what that says that's what this
is saying right here so put the zero in
and we're going to play zeros with no
data so if it's a zero that means the
person's well hopefully not dead
hopefully they just didn't get the data
the next thing we want to do is we're
going to create the mean which is the
integer from the data set from the
column dot mean where we skip n a's we
can do that that is a pandas command
there the skip n a so we're going to
figure out the mean of that data set and
then we're going to take that data set
column and we're going to replace all
the p n a n with the means why did we do
that and we could have actually just uh
taken this step and gone right down here
and just replaced zero and skip anything
were except you could actually there's a
way to skip zeros and then just replace
all the zeros but in this case we want
to go ahead and do it this way so you
can see that we're switching this to a
non-existent value then we're going to
create the mean well this is the average
person so if we don't know what it is if
they did not get the data and the data
is missing one of the tricks is you
replace it with the average what is the
most common data for that this way you
can still use the rest of those values
to do your computation and it kind of
just brings that particular value of
those missing values out of the equation
let's go ahead and take this and we'll
go ahead and run it doesn't actually do
anything so we're still preparing our
data if you want to see what that looks
like we don't have anything in the first
few lines just not going to show up but
we certainly could look at a row let's
do that let's go into our data set with
printed data set
and let's pick in this case let's just
do
glucose and if i run this this is going
to print all the different glucose
levels going down and we thankfully
don't see anything in here that looks
like missing data at least on the ones
it shows you can see it skipped a bunch
in the middle that's what it does if you
have too many lines in jupiter notebook
he'll skip a few and go on to the next
in a data set let me go and remove this
and we'll just zero out that
and of course before we do any
processing before proceeding any further
we need to split the data set into our
train and testing data that way we have
something to train it with and something
to test it on and you're going to notice
we did a little something here with the
pandas database code there we go my
drawing tool we've added in this right
here
off the data set and what this says is
that the first one in pandas this is
from the pd pandas it's going to say
within the data set we want to look at
the eye location and it is all rows
that's what that says so we're going to
keep all the rows but we're only looking
at 0 column 0 to 8. remember column 9
here it is right up here we put it in
here is outcome well that's not part of
the training data that's part of the
answer yes column nine but it's listed
as eight number eight so zero to eight
is nine columns so uh eight is the value
and when you see it in here zero this is
actually zero to seven it doesn't
include the last one and then we go down
here to y which is our answer and we
want just the last one just column eight
and you can do it this way with this
particular notation and then if you
remember we imported the train test
split that's part of the sklearn right
there and we simply put in our x and our
y
we're gonna do random state equals zero
you don't have to necessarily seat it
that's a seed number i think the default
is one when you seed it i'd have to look
that up and then the test size test size
is 0.2 that simply means we're going to
take 20 of the data and put it aside so
that we can test it later that's all
that is and again we're going to run it
not very exciting so far we haven't had
any print out other than to look at the
data but that is a lot of this is
prepping this data once you prep it the
actual lines of code are quick and easy
and we're almost there with the actual
writing of our knn we need to go ahead
and do a scale the data if you remember
correctly we're fitting the data in a
standard scalar which means instead of
the data being from you know 5 to 303 in
one column and the next column is 1 to
6. we're going to set that all so that
all the data is between -1 and 1. that's
what that standard scalar does keeps it
standardized and we only want to fit the
scaler with the training set but we want
to make sure the testing set is the x
test going in is also transformed so
it's processing it the same so here we
go with our standard scalar we're going
to call it sc underscore x for the
scalar and we're going to import the
standard scalar into this variable and
then our x train equals sc underscore x
dot fit transform so we're creating the
scalar on the x train variable and then
our x test we're also going to transform
it so
we've trained and transformed the x
train and then the x test
isn't part of that training it isn't
part of that of training the transformer
it just gets transformed that's all it
does and again we're going to go and run
this if you look at this we've now gone
through these steps all three of them
we've taken care of replacing our zeros
for key columns that shouldn't be zero
and we replace that with the means of
those columns that way that they fit
right in with our data models we've come
down here we split the data so now we
have our test data and our training data
and then we've taken and we've scaled
the data so all of our data going in no
no we don't tr we don't train the y part
the y train and y test that never has to
be trained it's only the data going in
that's what we want to train in there
then define the model using k neighbors
classifier and fit the train data in the
model so we do all that data prep and
you can see down here we're only going
to have a couple lines of code where
we're actually building our model and
training it that's one of the cool
things about python and how far we've
come it's such an exciting time to be in
machine learning because there's so many
automated tools let's see before we do
this let's do a quick length of and
let's do y we want let's just do length
of y
and we get 768 and if we import math we
do math dot square root let's do y
train there we go it's actually supposed
to be x train
before we do this let's go ahead and do
import math and do math square root
length of y test and when i run that we
get 12.409
i want to show you where this number
comes from we're about to use 12 is an
even number so if you know if you're
ever voting on things remember the
neighbors all vote don't want to have an
even number of neighbors voting so we
want to do something odd and let's just
take one away we'll make it 11. let me
delete this out of here this one the
reasons i love jupiter notebook is you
can flip around and do all kinds of
things on the fly so we'll go ahead and
put in our classifier we're creating our
classifier now and it's going to be the
k neighbors classifier n neighbors equal
11. remember we did 12 minus 1 for 11 so
we have an odd number of neighbors p
equals 2 because we're looking for is it
are they diabetic or not and we're using
the euclidean metric there are other
means of measuring the distance you
could do like square square means values
all kinds of measure this but the
euclidean's the most common one and it
works quite well it's important to
evaluate the model let's use the
confusion matrix to do that and we're
going to use the confusion matrix
wonderful tool and then we'll jump into
the f1 score
and finally accuracy score which is
probably the most commonly used quoted
number when you go into a meeting or
something like that so let's go ahead
and paste that in there and we'll set
the cm equal to confusion matrix y test
y predict so those are the two values
we're going to put in there and let me
go ahead and run that and print it out
and the way you interpret this is
you have the y predicted which would be
your title up here you could do let's
just do p r e d
predict it across the top
and actual going down actual
it's always hard to to write in here
actual that means that this column here
down the middle that's the important
column and it means that our prediction
said 94 and prediction in the actual
agreed on 94 and 32 this number here
the 13 and the 15 those are what was
wrong so you could have like three
different if you're looking at this
across three different variables instead
of just two you'd end up with the third
row down here and that column going down
the middle so in the first case we have
the the and i believe the zero has a 94
people who don't have diabetes the
prediction said that 13 of those people
did have diabetes and were at high risk
and the 32 that had diabetes it had
correct but our prediction said another
15 out of that 15 it classified as
incorrect so you can see where that
classification comes in and how that
works on the confusion matrix then we're
going to go ahead and print the f1 score
let me just run that and you see we get
a 0.69 in our f1 score
the f1 takes into account both sides of
the balance of false positives where if
we go ahead and just do the accuracy
account and that's what most people
think of is it looks at just how many we
got right out of how many we got wrong
so a lot of people when you're a data
scientist and you're talking to other
data scientists they're going to ask you
what the f1 score the f score is if
you're talking to the general public or
the decision makers in the business
they're going to ask what the accuracy
is and the accuracy is always better
than the f1 score but the f1 score is
more telling it lets us know that
there's more false positives than we
would like on here but 82 percent not
too bad for a quick flash look at
people's different statistics and
running an sk learn and running the knn
the k nearest neighbor on it so we have
created a model using knn which can
predict whether a person will have
diabetes or not or at the very least
whether they should go get a checkup and
have their glucose checked regularly or
not the print accuracy score we got the
eight one eight was pretty close to what
we got and we can pretty much round that
off and just say we have an accuracy of
eighty percent it tells us it is a
pretty fair fit in the model
why support vector machine so in this
example last week my son and i visited a
fruit shop dad is that an apple or a
strawberry so the question comes up what
fruit do they just pick up from the
fruit stand after a couple of seconds
you could figure out that it was a
strawberry so let's take this model a
step further and let's uh why not build
a model which can predict an unknown
data and in this we're going to be
looking at some sweet strawberries or
crispy apples we want to be able to
label those two and decide what the
fruit is and we do that by having data
already put in so we already have a
bunch of strawberries we know our
strawberries and they're already labeled
as such we already have a bunch of
apples we know our apples and are
labeled as such then once we train our
model that model then can be given the
new data and the new data is this image
in this case you can see a question mark
on it and it comes through and goes it's
a strawberry in this case we're using
the support vector machine model svm is
a supervised learning method that looks
at data and sorts it into one of two
categories and in this case we're
sorting the strawberry into the
strawberry site at this point you should
be asking the question how does the
prediction work before we dig into an
example with numbers let's apply this to
our fruit scenario we have our support
vector machine we've taken it and we've
taken labeled sample of data
strawberries and apples and we draw on a
line down the middle between the two
groups this split now allows us to take
new data in this case an apple and a
strawberry and place them in the
appropriate group based on which side of
the line they fall in and that way we
can predict the unknown as colorful and
tasty as the fruit example is let's take
a look at another example with some
numbers involved and we can take a
closer look at how the math works in
this example we're going to be
classifying men and women and we're
going to start with a set of people with
a different height and a different
weight and to make this work we'll have
to have a sample data set a female where
you have their height and weight 174 65
174 88 and so on and we'll need a sample
data set of the male they have a height
179 90 180 to 80 and so on let's go
ahead and put this on the graph so you
have a nice visual so you can see here
we have two groups based on the height
versus the weight and on the left side
we're going to have the women on the
right side we're going to have the men
now if we're going to create a
classifier let's add a new data point
and figure out if it's male or female so
before we can do that we need to split
our data first we can split our data by
choosing any of these lines in this case
we draw on two lines through the data in
the middle that separates them in from
the women but to predict the gender of a
new data point we should split the data
in the best possible way and we say the
best possible way because this line has
a maximum space that separates the two
classes here you can see there's a clear
split between the two different classes
and in this one there's not so much a
clear split this doesn't have the
maximum space that separates the two
that is why this line best splits the
data we don't want to just do this by
eyeballing it and before we go further
we need to add some technical terms to
this we can also say that the distance
between the points in the line should be
as far as possible in technical terms we
can say the distance between the support
vector and the hyperplane should be as
far as possible and this is where the
support vectors are the extreme points
in the data set and if you look at this
data set they have circled two points
which seem to be right on the outskirts
of the woman and one on the outskirts of
the men and hyperplane has a maximum
distance to the support vectors of any
class now you'll see the line down the
middle and we call this the hyperplane
because when you're dealing with
multiple dimensions it's really not just
a line but a plane of intersections and
you can see here where the support
vectors have been drawn in dashed lines
the math behind this is very simple we
take d plus the shortest distance to the
closest positive point which would be on
the min side and d minus is the shortest
distance to the closest negative point
which is on the women's side the sum of
d plus and d minus is called the
distance margin or the distance between
the two support vectors that are shown
in the dashed lines and then by finding
the largest distance margin we can get
the optimal hyperplane once we've
created an optimal hyperplane we can
easily see which side the new data fits
in and based on the hyperplane we can
say the new data point belongs to the
male gender hopefully that's clear how
that works on a visual level as a data
scientist you should also be asking what
happens if the hyperplane is not optimal
if we select a hyperplane having low
margin then there is a high chance of
misclassification this particular svm
model the one we discussed so far is
also called referred to as the ls vm so
far so clear but a question should be
coming up we have our sample data set
but instead of looking like this what if
it looked like this where we have two
sets of data but one of them occurs in
the middle of another set you can see
here we have the blue and the yellow and
then blue again on the other side of our
data line in this data set we can't use
a hyperplane so when you see data like
this it's necessary to move away from a
1d view of the data to a two-dimensional
view of the data and for the
transformation we use what's called a
kernel function the kernel function will
take the 1d input and transfer it to a
two dimensional output as you can see in
this picture here the 1d when
transferred to a 2-dimensional makes it
very easy to draw a line between the two
data sets what if we make it even more
complicated how do we perform an svm for
this type of data set here you can see
we have a two dimensional data set where
the data is in the middle surrounded by
the green data on the outside in this
case we're going to segregate the two
classes we have our sample data set and
if you draw a line through it's
obviously not an optimal hyperplane in
there so to do that we need to transfer
the 2d to a 3d array and when you
translate it into a three-dimensional
array using the kernel you can see where
you can place a hyperplane right through
it and easily split the data before we
start looking at a programming example
and dive into the script let's look at
the advantage of the support vector
machine we'll start with high
dimensional input space or sometimes
referred to as the curse of
dimensionality we looked at earlier one
dimension two dimension three dimension
when you get to a thousand dimensions a
lot of problems start occurring with
both algorithms that have to be adjusted
for the svm automatically does that in
high dimensional space one of the high
dimensional space one high dimensional
space that we work on is sparse document
vectors this is where we tokenize the
words and document so we can run our
machine learning algorithms over them
i've seen ones get as high as 2.4
million different tokens that's a lot of
vectors to look at and finally we have
regularization parameter the realization
parameter or lambda is a parameter that
helps figure out whether we're going to
have a bias or overfitting of the data
whether it's going to be over fitted to
a very specific instance or is going to
be biased to a high or low value with
the svm it naturally avoids the
overfitting and bias problems that we
see in many other algorithms these three
advantages of the support vector machine
make it a very powerful tool to add to
your repertoire of machine learning
tools now we did promise you a used case
study we're actually going to dive into
some python programming and so we're
going to go into a problem statement and
start off with the zoo so in the zoo
example we have family members going to
the zoo we have the young child going
dead is that a group of crocodiles or
alligators well that's hard to
differentiate and zoos are a great place
to start looking at science and
understanding how things work especially
as a young child and so we can see the
parents sitting here thinking well what
is the difference between a crocodile
and an alligator well one crocodiles are
larger in size alligators are smaller in
size snout width the crocodiles have a
narrow snout and alligators have a wider
snout and of course in the modern day
and age the father is sitting here
thinking how can i turn this into a
lesson for my son and he goes let a
support vector machine segregate the two
groups i don't know if my dad ever told
me that but that would be funny now in
this example we're not going to use
actual measurements and data we're just
using that for imagery and that's very
common in a lot of machine learning
algorithms and setting them up but let's
roll up our sleeves and we'll talk about
that more in just a moment as we break
into our python script so here we arrive
in our actual coding and i'm going to
move this into a python editor in just a
moment but let's talk a little bit about
what we're going to cover first we're
going to cover in the code the setup how
to actually create our svm and you're
going to find that there's only two
lines of code that actually create it
and the rest of it is done so quick and
fast that it's all here in the first
page and we'll show you what that looks
like as far as our data because we're
going to create some data i talked about
creating data just a minute ago and so
we'll get into the creating data here
and you'll see this nice correction of
our two blobs and we'll go through that
in just a second and then the second
part is we're going to take this and
we're going to bump it up a notch we're
going to show you what it looks like
behind the scenes but let's start with
actually creating our setup i like to
use the anaconda jupiter notebook
because it's very easy to use but you
can use any of your favorite python
editors or setups and go in there but
let's go ahead and switch over there and
see what that looks like so here we are
in the anaconda python notebook or
anaconda jupiter notebook with python
we're using python 3. i believe this is
3.5 but it should be work in any of your
3x versions and
you'd have to look at the sklearn and
make sure if you're using a 2x version
an earlier version let's go and put our
code in there and one of the things i
like about the jupiter notebook is i go
up to view and i'm going to go ahead and
toggle the line numbers on to make it a
little bit easier to talk about and we
can even increase the size because this
is edited in this case i'm using google
chrome explorer and that's how it opens
up for the editor although anyone any
like i said any editor will work now the
first step is going to be our imports
and we're going to import four different
parts the first two i want you to look
at are line one and line two are numpy
as np and matplot library dot pi plot as
plt now these are very standardized
imports when you're doing work the first
one is the numbers python we need that
because part of the platform we're using
uses that for the numpy array and i'll
talk about that in a minute so you can
understand why we want to use a numpy
array versus the standard python array
and normally it's pretty standard setup
to use np for numpy the map plot library
is how we're going to view our data so
this has you do need the np for the sk
learn module but the map plot library is
purely for our use for visualization and
so you really don't need that for the
svm but we're going to put it there so
you have a nice visual aid and we can
show you what it looks like that's
really important at the end when you
finish everything so you have a nice
display for everybody to look at and
then finally we're going to i'm going to
jump one ahead to line number four
that's the sklearn
sklearn.datasets.samplesgenerator
import make blobs and i told you that we
were going to make up data and this is a
tool that's in the sk learning to makeup
data i personally don't want to go to
the zoo get in trouble for jumping over
the fence and probably get eaten by the
crocodiles or alligators as i work on
measuring their snouts and width and
length
instead we're just going to make up some
data and that's what that make blobs is
it's a wonderful tool if you're ready to
test your setup and you're not sure
about what data you're going to put in
there you can create this blob and it
makes it real easy to use and finally we
have our actual svm the sk learn import
svm on line three so that covers all our
imports we're going to create remember i
use the make blobs to create data and
we're going to create a capital x and a
lowercase y equals make blobs in samples
equals 40. so we're going to make 40
lines of data it's going to have two
centers with a random state equals 20.
so each each each group is going to have
20 different pieces of data in it and
the way that looks is that we'll have
under x
an x y plane so i have two numbers under
x and y will be 0 1. that's the two
different centers so we have yes or no
in this case alligator or crocodile
that's what that represents and then i
told you that the actual sk learner the
svm is in two lines of code and we see
it right here with clf equals
svm.svc kernel equals linear and i set
sequel to one although in this example
since we are not regularizing the data
because we want to be very clear and
easy to see i went ahead you can set it
to a thousand a lot of times when you're
not doing that but for this thing linear
because it's a very simple linear
example we only have the two dimensions
and it'll be a nice linear hyperplane
will be a nice linear line instead of a
full plane so we're not dealing with a
huge amount of data and then all we have
to do is do clf dot fit x comma y and
that's it clf has been created and then
we're going to go ahead and display it
and i'm going to talk about this display
here in just a second but let me go
ahead and run this code and this is what
we've done is we've created two blobs
you'll see the blue on the side and then
kind of an orangish on the other side
that's our two sets of data they
represent one represents crocodiles and
one represents alligators and then we
have our measurements in this case we
have like the width and length of the
snout and i did say i was going to come
up here and talk just a little bit about
our plot and you'll see plt that's what
we imported we're going to do a scatter
plot that means we're just putting dots
on there and then look at this notation
i have the capital x and then in
brackets i have a colon comma 0. that's
from numpy if you did that in a regular
array you'll get an error in a python
array you have to have that in a numpy
array it turns out that our make blobs
returns a numpy array and this notation
is great because what it means is the
first part is the colon means we're
going to do all the rows that's all the
data in our blob we created under
capital x and then the second part has a
comma 0. we're only going to take the
first value and then if you notice we do
the same thing but we're going to take
the second value remember we always
start with zero and then one so we have
column zero and column one and you can
look at this as our x y plots the first
one is the x plot and the second one is
the y plot so the first one is on the
bottom 0 2 4 6 8 and 10 and then the
second one x of the one is the 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 going up the left hand side s
equals 30 is just the size of the dot so
we can see them it says real tiny dots
and then the c map equals plt.cm.paired
and you'll also see the c equals y
that's the color we're using two colors
zero one and that's why we get the nice
blue and the two different colors for
the alligator and the crocodile now you
can see here that we did this the actual
fit was done in two lines of code a lot
of times there'll be a third line where
we regularize the data we set it between
like minus one and one and we reshape it
but for this it's not necessary and it's
also kind of nice because you can
actually see what's going on and then if
we wanted to we wanted to actually run a
prediction let's take a look and see
what that looks like and to predict some
new data and we'll show this again as we
get towards the end of digging in deep
you can simply assign your new data in
this case i am giving it a width and
length 3 4 and a width of length 5 6.
and note that i put the data as a set of
brackets and then i have the brackets
inside and the reason i do that is
because when we're looking at data it's
designed to process a large amount of
data coming in we don't want to just
process one line at a time and so in
this case i'm processing two lines and
then i'm just going to print and you'll
see clf dot predict new data so the clf
and the dot predict part is going to
give us an answer and let's see what
that looks like and you'll see 0 1. so
predicted the first one the 3 4 is going
to be on the one side and the 5 6 is
going to be on the other side so one
came out as an alligator and one came
out as a crocodile now that's pretty
short explanation for the setup but
really we want to dug in and see what
it's going on behind the scenes and
let's see what that looks like
so the next step is to dig in deep and
find out what's going on behind the
scenes and also put that in a nice
pretty graph
we're going to spend more work on this
and we did actually generating the
original model and you'll see here that
we go through a few steps and i'll move
this over to our editor in just a second
we come in we create our original data
it's exactly identical to the first part
and i'll explain why we redid that and
show you how not to redo that and then
we're going to go in there and add in
those lines we're going to see what
those lines look like and how to set
those up and finally we're going to plot
all that on here and show it and you'll
get a nice graph with the what we saw
earlier when we were going through the
theory behind this where it shows the
support vectors and the hyperplane and
those are done where you can see the
support vectors as the dashed lines and
the solid line which is the hyperplane
let's get that into our jupiter notebook
before i scroll down to a new line i
want you to notice line 13 has plot show
and we're going to talk about that here
in just a second but let's scroll down
to a new line down here and i'm going to
paste that code in and you'll see that
the plot show has moved down below let's
scroll up a little bit and if you look
at the top here of our new section one
two three
and four is the same code we had before
and let's go back up here and take a
look at that we're going to fit the
values on our svm and then we're going
to plot scatter it and then we're going
to do a plot show so you should be
asking why are we redoing the same code
well when you do the plot show that
blanks out what's in the plot so once
i've done this plot show i have to
reload that data now we could do this
simply by removing it up here re-running
it and then coming down here and then we
wouldn't have to rerun these first four
lines of code now in this it doesn't
matter too much and you'll see the plot
show was down here and then removed
right there on line five i'll go ahead
and just delete that out of there
because we don't want to blank out our
screen we want to move on to the next
setup so we can go ahead and just skip
the first four lines because we did that
before and let's take a look at the ax
equals plt.gca
now right now we're actually spending a
lot of time just graphing that's all
we're doing here okay so this is how we
display a nice graph with our results in
our data ax is very standard note used
variable when you talk about plt and
it's just setting it to that axis the
last axis in the plt they can get very
confusing if you're working with many
different layers of data on the same
graph and this makes it very easy to
reference the ax so this reference is
looking at the plt that we created and
we already mapped out our two blobs on
and then we want to know the limits so
we want to know how big the graph is we
can find out the x limit and the y limit
simply with the get x limit and get y
limit commands which is part of our
metplot library and then we're going to
create a grid and you'll see down here
we have we've set the variable xx equal
to np.line space x limit 0 x limit 1
comma 30 and we've done the same thing
for the y space and then we're going to
go in here and we create a mesh grid and
this is a numpy command so we're back to
our numbers python let's go through what
these numpy commands mean with the line
space and the mesh grid we've taken x x
small x x equals np line space and we
have our x limit 0 and our x limit 1 and
we're going to create 30 points on it
and we're going to do the same thing for
the y axis now this has nothing to do
with our evaluation it's all we're doing
is we're creating a grid of data and so
we're creating a set of points between 0
and the x limit we're creating 30 points
and the same thing with the y and then
the mesh grid loops those all together
so it forms a nice grid so if we were
going to do this say between the limit 0
and 10 and do 10 points we would have a
0 0 1 1 0 1 0 2 0 3 0 4 to 10 and so on
you can just imagine a point at each
corner one of those boxes and the mesh
grid combines them all so we take the yy
and the xx we created and creates the
full grid and we've set that grid into
the yy coordinates and the x coordinates
now remember we're working with numbi
and python we like to separate those we
like to have instead of it being x comma
1 you know x comma y and then x2 comma
y2 and this in the next set of data it
would be a column of x's and a column of
y's and that's what we have here is we
have a column of y's and we put it as a
capital yy and a column of x's capital x
x with all those different points being
listed and finally we get down to the
numpy v stack just as we created those
in the mesh grid we're now going to put
them all into one array x y array now
that we've created the stack of data
points we're going to do something
interesting here we're going to create a
value z and the z equals the clf that's
our that's our support vector machine we
created and we've already trained and we
have a dot decision function and we're
going to put the x y in there so here we
have all this data we're going to put
that x y in there that data and we're
going to reshape it and you'll see that
we have the x x dot shape in here this
literally takes the xx resets it up
connected to the y and the z value lets
us know whether it is the left hand side
is going to generate three different
values the z value does and it'll tell
us whether that data is a support vector
to the left the hyperplane in the middle
or the support vector to the right so it
generates three different values for
each of those points and those points
have been reshaped so they're right on a
line on those three different lines so
we've set all of our data up we've
labeled it to three different areas and
we've reshaped it and we've just taken
30 points in each direction if you do
the math you have 30 times 30 so it's
900 points of data and we separated
between the three lines and reshaped it
to fit those three lines we can then go
back to our map plot library we've
created the ax and we're going to create
a contour and you'll see here we have
contour capital xx capital yy these have
been reshaped to fit those lines z is
the labels so now we have the three
different points with the labels in
there and we can set the colors equals k
and i told you we had three different
labels but we have three levels of data
the alphas just makes it kind of
see-through so it's only 0.5 of the
value in there so when we graph it the
data will show up from behind it
wherever the lines go and finally the
line styles this is where we set the two
support vectors to be dash dash lines
and then a single one is just a straight
line that's what all that setup does and
then finally we take our ax dot scatter
we're going to go ahead and plot the
support vectors but we've programmed it
in there so that they look nice like the
dash dash line and the dashed line on
that grid and you can see here when we
do the clf dot support vectors we are
looking at column zero and column one
and then again we have the s equals one
hundred so we're gonna make them larger
and the line width equals one face
colors equals none let's take a look and
see what that looks like when we show it
and you can see we get down to our end
result it creates a really nice graph we
have our two support vectors and dashed
lines and they have the near data so you
can see those two points or in this case
the four points where those lines nicely
cleave the data and then you have your
hyperplane down the middle which is as
far from the two different points as
possible creating the maximum distance
so you can see that we have our nice
output for the size of the body and the
width of the snout and we've easily
separated the two groups of crocodile
and alligator congratulations you've
done it we've made it of course these
are pretend data for our crocodiles and
alligators but this hands-on example
will help you to encounter any support
vector machine projects in the future
and you can see how easy they are to set
up and look at in depth so what is
k-means clustering k-means clustering is
an unsupervised learning algorithm in
this case you don't have labeled data
unlike in supervised learning so you
have a set of data and you want to group
them and as the name suggests you want
to put them into clusters which means
objects that are similar in nature
similar in characteristics need to be
put together so that's what k means
clustering is all about the term k is
basically is a number so we need to tell
the system how many clusters we need to
perform so if k is equal to two there
will be two clusters if k is equal to
three three clusters and so on and so
forth that's what the k stands for and
of course there is a way of finding out
what is the best or optimum value of k
for a given data we will look at that so
that is k means clustering so
let's take an example k-means clustering
is used in many many scenarios but let's
take an example of cricket the game of
cricket let's say you received
data of a lot of players from maybe all
over the country or all over the world
and this data has information about
the runs scored by the people ordered by
the player and the wickets taken by the
player and based on this information we
need to cluster this data into two
clusters batsman and bowlers so this is
an interesting example let's see how we
can perform this so we have the data
which consists of primarily two
characteristics which is the runs and
the wickets so the bowlers basically
take wickets and the batsmen score runs
there will be of course a few bowlers
who can
score some runs and similarly there will
be some batsmen who will who would have
taken a few wickets but with this
information we want to cluster those
players into batsmen and bowlers so how
does this work let's say this is how the
data is so there are information there
is information on the y-axis about the
run score and on the x-axis about the
wickets taken by the players so if we do
a quick plot this is how it would look
and
when we do the clustering we need to
have the clusters like shown in the
third diagram rtms we need to have a
cluster which consists of people who
have scored high runs which is basically
the batsman and then we need a cluster
with people who have taken a lot of
wickets which is typically the bowlers
there may be a certain amount of overlap
but we will not talk about it right now
so with k-means clustering we will have
here that means k is equal to two and we
will have two clusters which is batsman
and bowlers so how does this work the
way it works is the first step in
k-means clustering is the allocation of
two centroids randomly so two points are
assigned as so-called centroids so in
this case we want two clusters which
means k is equal to two so two points
have been randomly assigned as centroids
keep in mind
these points can be anywhere there are
random points they are not initially
they are not really the centroids
centroid means it's a central point of a
given data set but in this case when it
starts off it's not really the centroid
okay so these points though in our
presentation here we have shown them one
point closer to these data points and
another closer to these data points they
can be assigned randomly anywhere okay
so that's the first step the next step
is to determine the distance of each of
the data points
from each of the
randomly assigned centroids so for
example we take this point and find the
distance from the centroid and the
distance from this centroid this point
is taken and the distance is found from
this centroid and this center and so on
and so forth so for every point the
distance is measured from both the
centroids
and then
whichever distance is less that point is
assigned to that centroid so for example
in this case visually it is very obvious
that all these data points are assigned
to this centroid and all these data
points are assigned to this centroid and
that's what is represented here in blue
color and in this yellow color the next
step is to actually determine
the central point or the actual centroid
for these two clusters so we have this
one
initial cluster this one initial cluster
but as you can see these points are not
really the centroid centroid means it
should be the central position of this
data set central position of this data
set so that is what needs to be
determined as the next step so the
central point of the actual centroid is
determined and the original randomly
allocated centroid is repositioned to
the actual centroid of these new
clusters and this process is actually
repeated now what might happen is some
of these points may get reallocated in
our example that is not happening
probably but it may so happen that the
distance is found between each of these
data points once again with these
centroids and if there is if it is
required some points may be reallocated
we will see that in a later example but
for now we will keep it simple so this
process is continued till the centroid
repositioning stops and that is our
final cluster so this is our so after
iteration we come to this position this
situation where the centroid doesn't
need any more repositioning and that
means our algorithm has converged
convergence has occurred and we have the
cluster two clusters we have the
clusters with a centroid so this process
is repeated the process of calculating
the distance and repositioning the
centroid is repeated till the
repositioning stops which means that the
algorithm has converged and we have the
final cluster with the data points and
the centroids so this is what you're
going to learn from this session we will
talk about the types of clustering what
is k-means clustering application of
k-means clustering k-means clustering is
done using distance measure so we will
talk about the common distance measures
and then we will talk about how k-means
clustering works and go into the details
of k-means clustering algorithm and then
we will end with a demo and a use case
for k-means clustering so let's begin
first of all what are the types of
clustering there are primarily two
categories of clustering hierarchical
clustering and then partitional
clustering and each of these categories
are further subdivided into
agglomerative and divisive clustering
and k-means and fuzzy c means clustering
let's take a quick look at what each of
these types of clustering are
in hierarchical clustering the clusters
have a tree-like structure and
hierarchical clustering is further
divided into agglomerative and divisive
agglomerative clustering is a bottom-up
approach we begin with each element as a
separate cluster and merge them into
successively larger clusters so for
example we have a b c d e f we start by
combining b and c from one cluster d e
and e form one more then we combine d e
and f one more bigger cluster and then
add bc to that and then finally a to it
compared to that divisive clustering or
divisive clustering is a top-down
approach we begin with the whole set and
proceed to divide it into successively
smaller clusters so we have abcdef we
first take that as a single cluster and
then break it down
into a b c d
e and f
then we have partitional clustering
split into two subtypes k means
clustering and fuzzy c means in k means
clustering the objects are divided into
the number of clusters mentioned by the
number k that's where the k comes from
so if we say k is equal to 2 the objects
are divided into two clusters c1 and c2
and the way it is done is the features
or characteristics are compared and all
objects having similar characteristics
are clubbed together so that's how k
means clustering is done we will see it
in more detail as we move forward and
fuzzy c means is very similar to k means
in the sense that it clubs objects that
have similar characteristics together
but while in k means clustering two
objects cannot belong to or any object a
single object cannot belong to two
different clusters in c means objects
can belong to more than one cluster so
that is the primary difference between k
means and fuzzy c means so what are some
of the applications of k-means
clustering k-means clustering is used in
a variety of examples or variety of
business cases in real life
starting from academic performance
systems search engines and wireless
sensor networks and many more so let us
take a little deeper look at each of
these examples academic performance so
based on the scores of the students
students are categorized into a b c and
so on clustering forms a backbone of
search engines when a search is
performed the search results need to be
grouped together the search engines very
often use clustering to do this
and similarly in case of wireless sensor
networks the clustering algorithm plays
the role of finding the cluster heads
which collects all the data in its
respective cluster so clustering
especially k means clustering uses
distance measure so let's take a look at
what is distance measure so while these
are the different types of clustering in
this video we will focus on k-means
clustering so distance measure tells how
similar some objects are so the
similarity is measured using what is
known as distance measure and what are
the various types of distance measures
there is euclidean distance there is
manhattan distance then we have squared
euclidean distance measure and cosine
distance measure these are some of the
distance measures supported by k-means
clustering let's take a look at each of
these
what is euclidean distance measure this
is nothing but the distance between two
points so we have learnt in high school
how to find the distance between two
points this is a little sophisticated
formula for that but we know a simpler
one is square root of y2 minus y1 whole
square plus x2 minus x1 whole square so
this is an extension of that formula so
that is the euclidean distance between
two points what is the squared euclidean
distance measure it's nothing but the
square of the euclidean distance as the
name suggests so instead of taking the
square root
we leave the square as it is and then we
have manhattan distance measure in case
of manhattan distance it is the sum of
the distances across the x-axis and the
y-axis
and note that we are taking the absolute
value so that the negative values don't
come into play so that is the manhattan
distance measure then we have cosine
distance measure in this case we take
the angle between the two vectors formed
by joining the points from the origin so
that is the cosine distance measure okay
so that was a quick overview about the
various distance measures that are
supported by k-means now let's go and
check how exactly k-means clustering
works
okay so this is how k means clustering
works this is like a flowchart of the
whole process there is a starting point
and then we specify the number of
clusters that we want now there are a
couple of ways of doing this we can do
by trial and error so we specify a
certain number maybe k is equal to 3 or
4 or 5 to start with and then as we
progress we keep changing until we get
the best clusters or there is a
technique called elbow technique whereby
we can determine the value of k what
should be the best value of k how many
clusters should be formed so once we
have the value of k we specify that and
then the system will assign that many
centroids so it picks randomly that to
start with randomly that many points
that are considered to be the centroids
of these clusters and then it measures
the distance of each of the data points
from these centroids and assigns those
points to the corresponding centroid
from which the distance is minimum so
each data point will be assigned to the
centroid which is closest to it and
thereby we have k number of initial
clusters however this is not the final
clusters the next step it does is
for the new groups for the clusters that
have been formed it calculates the main
position thereby calculates the new
centroid position the position of the
centroid moves compared to the randomly
allocated one so it's an iterative
process once again the distance of each
point is measured from this new centroid
point and if required the data points
are reallocated to the new centroids and
the mean position or the new centroid is
calculated once again if the centroid
moves then the iteration continues which
means the convergence has not happened
the clustering has not converged so as
long as there is a movement of the
centroid this iteration keeps happening
but once the centroid stops moving which
means that the cluster has converged or
the clustering process has converged
that will be the end result so now we
have the final position of the centroid
and the data points are allocated
accordingly to the closest centroid i
know it's a little difficult to
understand from this simple flowchart so
let's do a little bit of visualization
and see if we can explain it better
let's take an example if we have a data
set for a grocery shop so let's say we
have a data set for a grocery shop and
now we want to find out how many
clusters this has to be spread across so
how do we find the optimum number of
clusters there is a technique called the
elbow method so when these clusters are
formed there is a parameter called
within sum of squares and the lower this
value is the better the cluster is that
means
all these points are very close to each
other so we use this within sum of
squares as a measure to find the optimum
number of clusters that can be formed
for a given data set so we create
clusters or we let the system create
clusters of a variety of numbers maybe
of 10
10 clusters and for each value of k the
within ss is measured and the value of k
which has the least amount of within ss
or wss
that's taken as the optimum value of k
so this is the diagrammatic
representation so we have on the y axis
the within sum of squares or wss and on
the x-axis we have the number of
clusters so as you can imagine if you
have k is equal to one which means all
the data points are in a single cluster
the within s value will be very high
because they are probably scattered all
over the moment you split it into two
there will be a drastic fall in the
within ss value that's what is
represented here but then as the value
of k increases the decrease the rate of
decrease
will not be so high it will continue to
decrease but probably the rate of
decrease will not be high so that gives
us an idea so from here we get an idea
for example the optimum value of k
should be
either two or three or at the most four
but beyond that
increasing the number of clusters is not
dramatically changing the value in wss
because that pretty much gets stabilized
okay now that we have got the value of k
and let's assume that these are our
delivery points the next step is
basically
to assign two centroids randomly so
let's say c1 and c2 are the centroids
assigned randomly now the distance of
each
location from the centroid is measured
and each point is assigned to the
centroid which is closest to it so for
example
these points are very obvious that these
are closest to c1 whereas this point is
far away from c2 so these points will be
assigned which are close to c1 will be
assigned to c1 and these points or
locations which are close to c2 will be
assigned to c2 and then so this is the
how the initial grouping is done this is
part of c1 and this is part of c2 then
the next step is to calculate the actual
centroid of this data because remember
c1 and c2 are not the centroids they
have been
randomly assigned points and only thing
that has been done was the data points
which are closest to them have been
assigned
but now in this step the actual centroid
will be calculated which may be for each
of these data sets somewhere in the
middle so that's like the main point
that will be calculated and the centroid
will actually be positioned or
repositioned there
same with c2
so the new centroid for this group is c2
in this new position and c1 is in this
new position
once again the distance of each of the
data points is calculated from these
centroids now remember it's not
necessary that the distance still
remains the or each of these data points
still remain in the same group by
recalculating the distance it may be
possible that some points get
reallocated like so you see this
so this point earlier was closer to c2
because c2 was here
but after recalculating repositioning it
is observed that this is closer to c1
than c2 so this is the new grouping so
some points will be reassigned and again
the centroid will be calculated and if
the centroid doesn't change so that is
the repetitive process iterative process
and if the centroid doesn't change once
the centroid stops changing that means
the algorithm has converged and this is
our final cluster with this as the
centroid c1 and c2 as the centroids
these data points as a part of each
cluster so i hope this helps in
understanding the whole process
iterative process of k-means clustering
so let's take a look at
the k-means clustering algorithm let's
say we have x1 x2 x3 n number of points
as our inputs and we want to split this
into k clusters or we want to create k
clusters so the first step is to
randomly pick k points and call them
centroids they are not real centroids
because centroid is supposed to be a
center point but they are just called
centroids and we calculate the distance
of each and every input point from each
of the centroids so the distance of x1
from c1 from c2 c3 each of the distances
we calculate and then find out which
distance is the lowest and assign x1 to
that particular random centroid repeat
that process for x2 calculate its
distance from each of the centroids c1
c2 c3 up to ck and find which is the
lowest distance and assign x2 to that
particular centroid same with x3 and so
on so that is the first round of
assignment that is done now we have k
groups because there are we have
assigned the value of k so there are k
centroids
and so there are k groups all these
inputs have been split into k groups
however remember we picked the centroids
randomly so they are not real centroids
so now what we have to do we have to
calculate the actual centroids for each
of these groups which is like the mean
position which means that the position
of the randomly selected
centroids will now change
and they will be
the main positions of this newly formed
k groups and once that is done we once
again repeat this process of calculating
the distance right so this is what we
are doing as a part of step four we
repeat step two
and three so we again calculate the
distance of x one
from the centroid c1
c2 c3 and then c which is the lowest
value and assign x1 to that
calculate the distance of x2 from c1 c2
c3 or whatever
up to ck and find whichever is the
lowest distance and assign x2 to that
centroid and so on in this process there
may be some reassignment x1 pro was
probably assigned to cluster c2 and
after doing this calculation maybe now
x1 is assigned to c1 so that kind of
reallocation may happen so we repeat the
steps 2 and 3 till the position of the
centroids don't change or stop changing
and that's when we have convergence
so let's take a detailed look at each of
these steps so we randomly pick k
cluster centers we call them centroids
because they are not initially they are
not really the centroids so we let us
name them c1 c2 up to ck and then step
two we assign each data point to the
closest center so what we do we
calculate the distance of each x value
from each c value so the distance
between
x1 c1 distance between x1 c2 x1 c3 and
then we find which is the lowest value
right that's the minimum value we find
and assign x1 to that particular
centroid then we go next to x2 find the
distance of x2 from c1 x2 from c2 x2
from c3 and so on up to ck and then
assign it to the point or to the
centroid which has the lowest value and
so on so that is step number two in step
number three we now find the actual
centroid for each group so what has
happened as a part of step number two we
now have all the points all the data
points
grouped into k groups because we we
wanted to create k clusters right so we
have k groups each one may be having a
certain number of input values need not
be equally distributed by the way based
on the distance we will have k groups
but remember the initial values of the
c1 c2 were not really the centroids of
these groups right we assign them
randomly so now in step three we
actually calculate the centroid of each
group which means the original point
which we thought was the centroid will
shift to the new position which is the
actual centroid for each of these groups
okay and we again calculate the distance
so we go back to step two which is what
we calculate again the distance of each
of these points from the newly
positioned centroids and if required we
reassign these points to the new
centroids so as i said earlier there may
be a reallocation so we now have a new
set or a new group we still have k
groups
but the number of items and the actual
assignment may be different from what
was in step
to here okay so that might change then
we perform step three once again to find
the new centroid of this new group so we
have again a new set of clusters new
centroids and new assignments
we repeat this step two again once again
we find and then it is possible that
after iterating through three or four or
five times the centroid will stop moving
in the sense that when you calculate the
new value of the centroid that will be
same as the original value or there will
be very marginal change so that is when
we say convergence has occurred and that
is our final cluster that's the
formation of the final cluster
all right so let's see a couple of demos
of k-means clustering we will actually
see some live demos in
python notebook using pattern notebook
but before that let's find out what's
the problem that we are trying to solve
the problem statement is let's say
walmart wants to open a chain of stores
across the state of florida and
it wants to find the optimal store
locations now the issue here is if they
open too many stores close to each other
obviously they will not make profit but
if they if the stores are too far apart
then they will not have enough sales
so how do they optimize this now
for an organization like walmart which
is an e-commerce giant
they already have the addresses of their
customers in their database so they can
actually use this information or this
data and use k-means clustering to find
the optimal location now before we go
into the python notebook and show you
the live code
i wanted to take you through very
quickly a summary of the code in the
slides and then we will go into the
python notebook so in this
block we are basically
importing all the required libraries
like numpy
matplotlib and so on
and we are loading the data that is
available in the form of let's say the
addresses
for simplicity's sake we will just take
them as some data points then the next
thing we do is quickly do a scatter plot
to see
how they are
related to each other with respect to
each other so in the scatter plot we see
that there are a few distinct
groups
already being formed so you can actually
get an idea about how the cluster would
look and how many clusters what is the
optimal number of clusters and then
starts the actual
k-means clustering process
so we will assign
each of these points to the centroids
and then check whether they are
the optimal distance which is the
shortest distance and assign each of the
points data points to the centroids and
then go through this iterative process
till the whole process converges and
finally we get an output like this
so we have four distinct clusters
and
which is we can say that this is how the
population is probably distributed
across florida state and
the centroids are like the location
where the store should be the optimum
location where the store should be so
that's the way we determine the best
locations for the store and that's how
we can help walmart find the best
locations for their stores in florida so
now let's
take this into python notebook let's see
how this looks when we are running
running the code live all right so this
is the code for k-means clustering in
jupiter notebook we have a few examples
here which we will demonstrate how
k-means clustering is used and even
there is a small implementation of
k-means clustering as well okay so let's
get started okay so this block is
basically importing the various
libraries that are required like
matplotlib and numpy and so on and so
forth which would be used as a part of
the code then we are going and creating
blobs which are similar to clusters now
this is a very neat feature which is
available in scikit-learn make blobs is
a nice feature which creates clusters of
data sets so that's a wonderful
functionality that is readily available
for us to create some test data kind of
thing okay so that's exactly what we are
doing here we are using make blobs and
we can specify how many clusters we want
so centers we are mentioning here so it
will go ahead and so we just mentioned
four so it will go ahead and create some
test data for us
and this is how it looks as you can see
visually also we can figure out that
there are four distinct classes or
clusters in this data set and that is
what make blobs actually
provides
now from
here onwards we will basically
run the standard k-means functionality
that is readily available so we really
don't have to implement k-means itself
the k-means functionality or the
function is readily available you just
need to feed the data and we'll create
the clusters so this is the code for
that
we import k-means and then we create an
instance of k-means and we specify the
value of k this n underscore clusters is
the value of k remember k means in k
means k is basically the number of
clusters that you want to create and it
is a
integer value so this is where we are
specifying that so we have k is equal to
and so that instance is created we take
that instance and as
with any other machine learning
functionality fit is what we use the
function or the method rather fit is
what we use to train the model here
there is no real training
kind of thing but that's the call okay
so we are calling fit and what we are
doing here we are just passing the data
so x has these values the data that has
been created
right so that is what we are passing
here
and
this will go ahead and create the
clusters and
then we are using
after doing uh fit we run the predict
which basically assigns for each of
these observations which cluster where
it belongs to all right so it will name
the clusters maybe this is cluster 1
this is 2 3 and so on or i will actually
start from 0
cluster 0 1 2 and 3 maybe and then for
each of the observations it will assign
based on which cluster it belongs to it
will assign a value so that is stored in
y underscore k means when we call
predict that is what it does
and we can take a quick look at these uh
y underscore k means or with the cluster
numbers that have been assigned for each
observation so this is the cluster
number assigned for observation 1 maybe
this is for observation 2 observation 3
and so on so we have how many about i
think 300 samples right so all the 300
samples there are 300 values here each
of them the cluster number is given and
the cluster number goes from zero to
three so there are four clusters so the
numbers go from zero one two three so
that's what is seen here okay now so
this was a quick example of generating
some dummy data and then clustering that
okay and this can be applied if you have
proper data you can just load it up into
x for example here and then run the
cable so this is the central part of the
k-means clustering program example so
you basically create an instance and you
mention how many clusters you want by
specifying this parameter and underscore
clusters and that is also the value of k
and then pass the data to get the values
now the next section of this code is the
implementation of a k-means now this is
kind of a rough implementation of the
k-means algorithm so we will just walk
you through i will walk you through the
code
at each step what it is doing and then
we will see a couple of more examples of
how k-means clustering
can be used in maybe some real-life
examples real-life use cases all right
so in this case here what we are doing
is basically implementing the k means
clustering and there is a function or a
library calculates for a given two pairs
of points it will calculate the the
distance between them and see which one
is the closest and so on so this is like
this is pretty much like what k means
does right so it calculates the distance
of each point or each data set from
predefined centroid and then based on
whichever is the lowest this particular
data point is assigned to that centroid
so that is basically available as a
standard function and we will be using
that here so as explained in the slides
the first step that is done in case of
k-means clustering is to randomly assign
some centroids so as a first step we
randomly allocate a couple of centroids
which we call here we are calling as
centers
and then we put this in a loop and we
take it through an iterative process
for each of the data points we first
find out using this function pairwise
distance argument for each of the points
we find out
which one which center or which randomly
selected centroid is the closest and
accordingly we assign the data or the
data point to that particular centroid
or cluster and once that is done for all
the data points
we calculate the new centroid by finding
out the mean position which is the
center position right so we calculate
the new centroid and then we check if
the new centroid is the coordinates or
the position is the same as the previous
centroid the positions we will compare
and if it is the same that means the
process has converged so remember we do
this process till the centroids or the
centroid doesn't move anymore right so
the centroid gets relocated each time
this reallocation is done so the moment
it doesn't change anymore the position
of the centroid doesn't change anymore
we know that convergence has occurred so
till then so you see here this is like
an infinite loop while true is an
infinite loop it only breaks when the
centers are the same the new center and
the old center positions are the same
and once that is uh done we return the
centers and the labels now of course as
explained this is not a very
sophisticated and advanced
implementation very basic implementation
because one of the flaws in this is that
sometimes what happens is the centroid
the position
will
keep moving but in the change will be
very minor so in that case
also with that is actually convergence
right so for example the change is
0.0001
we can consider that as convergence
otherwise what will happen is this will
either take forever or it will be never
ending so that's a small flaw here so
that is something additional checks may
have to be added here but again as
mentioned this is not the most
sophisticated implementation
this is like a kind of a rough
implementation of the k-means clustering
okay so if we execute this code this is
what we get as the output so this is the
definition of this particular function
and then we call that find underscore
clusters and we pass our data x and the
number of clusters which is four
and if we run that and plot it this is
the output that we get so this is of
course each cluster is represented by a
different color so we have a cluster in
green color yellow color and so on and
so forth and these big points here these
are the centroids this is the final
position of the centroids and as you can
see visually also this appears like a
kind of a center of all these points
here right similarly this is like the
center of all these points here and so
on so this is the example or this is an
example of an implementation of k-means
clustering
and
next we will move on to see a couple of
examples of how k-means clustering is
used in maybe some real life scenarios
or use cases in the next example or demo
we are going to see how we can use
k-means clustering to perform color
compression we will take a couple of
images so there will be two examples and
we will try to use k-means clustering to
compress the colors this is a common
situation
in image processing when you have an
image with millions of
colors but then you cannot render it on
some devices which may not have enough
memory so that is the
scenario where something like this can
be used
so
before again we go into the python
notebook let's take a look at quickly
the the code
as usual we import the libraries and
then we import the image and
then we will flatten it so the reshaping
is basically we have the image
information is stored in the form of
pixels and if the image is like for
example 427 by 640 and it has three
colors so that's the overall dimension
of the of the initial image we just
reshape it and
then feed this to our algorithm
and this will then create clusters of
only 16 clusters so this this colors
there are millions of colors and now we
need to bring it down to 16 colors so we
use k is equal to 16
and
this is how when we visualize this is
how it looks there are these are all
about 16 million possible colors the
input color space has 16 million
possible colors and we just
sub compress it to 16 colors so this is
how it would look when we compress it to
16 colors and this is how the original
image looks and
after compression to 16 colors this is
how the new image looks as you can see
there is not a lot of
information that has been lost
though
the image quality is definitely reduced
a little bit
so this is
an example which we are going to now see
in python notebook let's go into the
python node and once again as always we
will import some libraries and
load this image called
flower dot jpg okay so let we load that
and this is how it looks this is the
original image which has i think 16
million colors and this is the shape of
this image which is basically what is
the
shape is nothing but the overall size
right so this is 427 pixel by 640 pixel
and then there are three layers which is
this three basically is for rgb which is
red green blue so color image will have
that right so that is the shape of this
now what we need to do is data let's
take a look at how data is looking so
let me just create a new cell and show
you
what is in data basically we have
captured this information
so data is what let me just show you
here
all right so
let's take a look at
china what are the values in china and
if we see here this is how the data is
stored this is nothing but the pixel
values okay so this is like a matrix and
each one has about four for this 427 by
640 pixels all right so this is how it
looks now the issue here is these values
are
large the numbers are a large so we need
to normalize them to between zero and
one right so that's why we will
basically create one more variable which
is data which will contain the values
between zero and one and the way to do
that is divide by 255 so we divide china
by 255 and we get the new values in data
so let's just run this piece of code and
this is the shape so we now have also
yeah what we have done is we changed
using reshape we converted into the
three-dimensional into a two-dimensional
data set and let us also take a look at
how
let me just insert
uh probably a cell here
and take a look at how data is looking
all right so this is how data is looking
and now you see this is
the values are between zero and one
right so if you earlier noticed in case
of china the values were large numbers
now everything is between 0 and 1. this
is one of the things we need to do
all right so after that the next thing
that we need to do is to visualize this
and
we can take random set of maybe 10 000
points and plot it and check and see how
this looks let us just plot this
and so this is how the original the
color the pixel distribution is these
are two plots one is red against green
and another is red against blue and this
is the original distribution of the
color so then what we will do is we will
use k-means clustering to create just 16
clusters for the various colors and then
apply that to the image now
what will happen is since the data is
large because there are millions of
colors using regular k-means may be a
little time consuming so there is
another version of k-means which is
called mini batch gaming so we will use
that which is which processes in the
overall concept remains the same but
this basically processes it in smaller
batches that's the only thing okay so
the results will pretty much be the same
so let's go ahead and execute this piece
of code and also visualize this so that
we can see that there are this is how
the 16 colors
would look
so this is red against green and this is
red against blue there is
quite a bit of similarity between this
original color schema and the new one
right so it doesn't look very very
completely different or anything like
that now we apply this the newly created
colors to the image and we can take a
look uh how this is looking now we can
compare both the images so this is our
original image and this is our new image
so as you can see there is not a lot of
information that has been lost it pretty
much looks like the original image yes
we can see that for example here there
is a little bit uh it appears a little
dullish compared to this one right
because we kind of took off some of the
finer details of the color but overall
the high level information has been
maintained at the same time the main
advantage is that now this can be this
is an image which can be rendered on a
device which may not be that very
sophisticated now let's take one more
example with a different image in the
second example we will take an image of
the summer palace in china and we repeat
the same process this is a
high definition color image with
millions of colors and also
three-dimensional
now we will reduce that to 16 colors
using k-means clustering
and
we do the same process like before we
reshape it and then we cluster the
colors to 16
and then we render the image once again
and we will see that the color the
quality of the image
slightly deteriorates as you can see
here this has much finer details in this
which are probably missing here but then
that's the compromise because there are
some devices which may not be able to
handle
this kind of high density images
so let's run this chord in python
notebook all right so let's apply the
same technique for another picture which
is
even more intricate and has probably
much complicated color schema so this is
the image now once again we can take a
look at the shape which is 427 by 640 by
and this is the new data would look
somewhat like this compared to the
flower image so we have some new values
here
and we will also bring this as you can
see the numbers are much big so we will
much bigger so we will now have to
scale them down to values between 0 and
1 and that is done by
dividing by 255 so let's go ahead and do
that
and reshape it okay so we get a
two-dimensional matrix
and we will then as a next step we will
go ahead and visualize this how it looks
does the 16 colors
and this is basically how it would look
16 million colors and
now we can create the clusters
out of this the 16
k-means clusters we will create so this
is how the distribution of the pixels
would look with 16 colors
and then we go ahead and
apply this
and visualize how it is looking for with
the new just the 16 color so once again
as you can see this looks much richer in
color but at the same time and this
probably doesn't have as we can see it
doesn't look as rich as this one but
nevertheless the information is not lost
the shape and all that stuff and this
can be also rendered on a slightly a
device which is probably
not that sophisticated okay so that's
pretty much it so we have seen two
examples of how color compression can be
done
using k-means clustering
and we have also seen in the previous
examples of how to implement k-means the
code to roughly how to implement k-means
clustering and we use some sample data
using
blob to just execute the k-means
clustering all right so with that let's
move on
we talk about the principal component
analysis we're going to cover
dimensionality reduction
principle component analysis what is it
important pca terminologies and you'll
see it abbreviated normally as pca
principal component analysis pca
properties pca example and then we'll
pull up some python code in our jupyter
notebook and have some hands-on demo on
the pca and how it's used dimensionality
reduction dimensionality reduction
refers to the technique that reduces the
number of input variables in a data set
and so you can see on the table on the
right shows the orders made at an
automobile parts retailer the retailer
sells different automobile parts from
different companies and you can see we
have company b-packs isomax and they
have the item the tire the axle an order
id a price number and a quantity in
order to predict the future cells
we find out that using correlation
analysis
that we just need three attributes
therefore we have reduced the number of
attributes from five to three
and clearly we don't really care about
the part number i don't think the part
number would have an effect on how many
tires are bought
and even the store who's buying them
probably does not have an effect on that
in this case that's what they've
actually done is remove those and we
just have the item the tire the price
and the quantity one of the things you
should be taking away from this is in
the scheme of things
we are in the descriptive phase we're
describing the data
and we're pre-processing the data what
can we do to clean it up
why dimensionality reduction
well number one less dimensions for a
given data set means less computation or
training time that can be really
important if you're trying a number of
different models
and you're re-running them over and over
again and even if you have seven
gigabytes of data that can start taking
days to go through all those different
models
so this is huge this is probably the
hugest part as far as reducing
our data set
redundancy is removed after removing
similar entries from the data set
again pre-processing some of our models
like a neural network if you put in two
of the same data it might give them a
higher weight than they would if it was
just once you want to get rid of that
redundancy
it also increases the processing time if
you have multiple
data coming in
space required to store the data is
reduced
so if we're committing this into a big
data
pool we might not send the company that
bought it why would we want to store two
whole extra columns when we added into
that pool of data makes the data easy
for plotting in 2d and 3d plots this is
my favorite part
very important you're in your
shareholder meeting
you want to be able to give them a
really good
clear
and simplified version you want to
reduce it down to something people can
take in
it helps to find out the most
significant features and skip the rest
which also comes in in post scribing
leads to better human interpretation
that kind of goes with number four it
makes data easy for plotting you have a
better interpretation when we're looking
at it principle component analysis
so what is it
uh principal component analysis is a
technique for reducing the
dimensionality of data sets increasing
interpretability but at the same time
minimizing information loss so we take
some very complex data set with lots of
variables we run it through the pca
we reduce the variables we end up with a
reduced variable setup
this is very confusing to look at
because if you look at the end result
we have the different colors all lined
up so what we're going to take a look at
is let's say we have a picture here
let's say you are asked to take a
picture of some toddlers and you are
deciding which angle would be the best
to take the picture from so if we come
up here we look at this we say okay this
is you know one angle
we get the back of a lot of heads not
many faces
so we'll do it from here we might get
the one person up front smiling a lot of
the people in the class are missing so
we have a huge amount off to the right
of blank space maybe from up here again
we have the back of someone's head
and it turns out that the best angle to
click the picture from might be this
bottom left angle you look at it you say
hey that makes sense it's a good
um configuration of all the people in
the picture now when we're talking about
data it's not you really can't do it by
what you think is going to be the best
we need to have some kind of
mathematical formula so it's consistent
and so it makes sense in the back end
one of the projects i worked on many
years ago
has something similar to the iris if
you've ever done the iris data sets
probably one of the
most common ones out there where they
have the flower
and they're measuring the stamen
in the petals and they have width and
they have length of the petal
instead of putting through the width and
the length of the petal we could just as
easily do the
width-to-length ratio we can divide the
width by the length and you get a single
number where you had two
that's the kind of idea that's going on
into this in pre-processing and looking
at what we can do to bring the data down
the very simplified example on my
iris
pedal example
when we look at the similarity in pca we
find the best picture or projection of
the data points
and so we look down at from one angle
we've drawn a line down there
we can see these data points based on in
this case just two variables now keep in
mind we're usually talking about 36 40
variables almost all of your
business models usually have about 26 to
27 different variables they're looking
at
same thing with like a bank loan model
we're talking 26 to 36 different
variables they're looking at that are
going in
so we want to do is we want to find the
best view in this case we're just
looking at the x y
we look down at it and we have our
second
idea pc2 and again we're looking at the
x i this x y this time from a different
direction
here for our e's we can consider that we
get two principal components namely pc1
and pc2
comparing both the principal components
we find the data points are sufficiently
spaced in pc1
so if you look at what we got here we
have pc1 you can see along the line how
the data points are spaced versus the
spacing in pc2 and that's what they're
coming up with what is going to give us
the best look for these data points when
we combine them and we're looking at
them from just a single angle
whereas in pc2 they are less spaced
which makes the observation and further
calculations much more difficult
therefore we accept the pc one and not
the pc2 as the data points are more
spaced
now obviously the back end calculations
are a little bit more complicated when
we get into the math of how they decide
what is more valuable
this gives you an idea though that when
we're talking about this we're talking
about the perspective which would help
in understanding how pca analysis works
we want to go ahead and do is dive into
the important terminologies under a pca
and important terminology are views the
perspective through which data points
are observed
and so you'll hear that if someone's
talking about a pca presentation and
they're not taking the time to reduce it
to something that the average person
shareholders can understand you might
hear them refer to it as the different
views what view are we taking
dimension number of columns in a data
set are called the dimensions of that
data set
we talked about you'll hear features
dimensions
i was talking about features there's
usually when you're running a business
you're talking 25 26 27 different
features minimal and then you have the
principal component new variables that
are constructed as linear combinations
or mixtures of the initial variables
principal component is very important
it's a combination if you remember my
flower example it would be the
width over the length of the pedal as
opposed to putting both width and length
in you just put in the ratio instead
which is a single number versus two
separate numbers projections
the perpendicular distance between the
principal component and the data points
and that goes to that line we had
earlier it's that right angle line of
where those point how those points fall
onto the line important properties
important properties number of principal
components is always less than or equal
to the number of attributes
that just makes common sense
you're not going to do
10 principal properties with only three
features
you're trying to reduce them so it's
just kind of goofy but it is important
to remember that people will throw
weird code out there and just randomly
do stuff with instead of really thinking
it through principle components are
orthogonal
and this is what we're talking about
that right angle from the line
when we do pc1 we're looking at how
those points fall on to that line uh
same thing with pc2 we want to make sure
that pc1 does not equal pc2 we don't
want to have the same two principal
points uh when we do two points
the priority of principal components
decreases as their numbers
increase
this is important to understand
if you're going to create
one
principle
component
everything is summarized into that one
component as we go to two components the
priority
how much it holds value decreases as we
go down so if you have five different
points each one of those points is going
to have less value than just the one
point which has everything summarized in
it
how pca works
i said there was more in the back end we
talk about the math this is what we're
talking about is how does it actually
work
so now we have understanding that you're
looking at a perspective
now we want to see how that math side
works pca performs the following
operations in order to evaluate
the principal components for a given
data set
first we start with the standardization
then we have a covariance matrix
computation
and we use that to generate our i gene
vectors and i gene values
which is the feature vector and if you
remember the i gene vector is like a
translation for
moving the data
from x equals one to x equals two or
whatever we're altering it and the ign
value is the final value that we
generate
when we talk about standardization the
main aim of this step is to standardize
the range of the attributes so that each
one of them lie within similar
boundaries
this process involves removal of the
mean from the variable values and
scaling the data with respect to the
standard deviation
and you can see here we have z equals
the variable values minus the mean
over the standard deviation
the covariance matrix computation
covariance matrix is used to express the
correlation between any two or more
attributes in multi-dimensional data set
the covariance matrix has the entries as
the variance and the covariance of the
tribute values the variance is denoted
by var and the covariance is denoted by
cov
on the right we can see the covariance
matrix for two attributes and their
values
when we do a hands-on and look at the
code we'll do a display of this so you
can see what we're talking about and
what that looks like
for now you can just notice that this is
a matrix that we're generating with the
variance and then the covariance of x to
y
on the right side we can see the
covariance table for more than two
attributes in a multi-dimensional data
set
this is what i was talking about we
usually are looking at not just one
feature two features
we're usually looking at 25 30 features
going on
and so if we do a setup like this we
should see all those different features
as the different variables
covariance matrix tells us how the two
or more variables are related positive
covariance indicate that the value of
one variable is directly proportional to
the other variable
negative covariance indicate that the
value of one variable is inversely
proportional to the other variable that
is always important to note whenever
we're doing any of these matrixes that
we're going to be looking at that
positive and negative whether it's
inverted or not
and then we have the iogene values and
the i gene vectors
iogene values and hygiene vectors are
the mathematical value
that are extracted from the covariance
table
they are responsible for the generation
of a new set of variables from the old
set of variables which further lead to
the construction of the principal
components
i gene vectors do not change directions
after linear transformation
i gene values are the scalars or the
magnitude of the i gene vectors
and again this is just chain
transforming that data so we're going to
change uh the vector b
to the b
prime as denoted on the chart
and so when we have like multiple
variables how do we calculate that new
variable
and then we have feature vectors feature
vectors is simply a matrix that has igen
vectors of the components that we decide
to keep as the columns
here we decide whether we must keep or
discard the less significant principal
components that we have generated in the
above steps
this becomes really important as we
start looking at
the back end of this and we'll do this
in the demo
but one of the more important steps to
understand
and so we have the pca example consider
matrix x within rows or observations and
k columns or variables
now for this matrix we would construct a
variable space with as many dimensions
as the variable
but for our simplicity let's consider
this three dimensions for now
now each observation row of the matrix x
is placed in the k-dimensional variable
space such that the rows in the data
table form a swarm of points in this
space
now we find the mean of all the
observations and then place it along the
data points on the plot
the first principal component is a line
that best accounts for the shape of the
point swarm it represents the maximal
variance direction in the data
each observation may be projected onto
this line in order to get a coordinate
value along the pc1 this value is known
as a score
usually only one principal component is
insufficient to model the systematic
variation for a data set thus a second
principal axis is created
the second principle component is
oriented such that it reflects the
second largest source of variation in
the data while being orthogonal to pc1
pc2 also passes through the average
point
let's go ahead and pull this up and just
see what that means
inside our python scripting
i'm going to use the anaconda navigator
and i will be in python 3.6
for this example
i believe there's even like a 3.9 out
i tend to stay in 3.6 because a lot of
the models i use especially with the
neural networks are stable in 3 6.
and then we open up our
jupiter i'm in chrome and we go ahead
and create a new python three
and for ease of use uh our team in the
back was nice enough to put this
together for me
and we'll go and start with the
libraries the first thing i like to do
whenever i'm looking at
any new setup
well you know what let's do let's do the
libraries first we're going to do our
basic libraries which is matplot library
the plt from the matplot library pandas
our data frame
pd numpy our numbers array np
seaborn for graphing sns that goes with
the plot that actually sits on matplot
library so the seaborn sits on there
and then we have our amber sign because
we're in jupiter notebook map plot
library in line the newer version
actually doesn't require that but i put
it in there either
anyway just because i'm so used to it
and then we want to go ahead and take a
look at the data
and in this case we're going to pull in
certainly you can have lots of fun with
different data but we're going to use
the cancer data set
and one of the reasons the cancer data
set is it has like 36 35 different
features
so it's kind of fun to use that as our
base for this
and we'll go ahead and run this and look
at our keys
and the first thing we notice in our
keys for the cancer data set
is we have our data we have our target
our frame target names description
feature names and file name
so
what we're looking for in all this
is
let's take a look at the description
let's go in here and pull up the
description on here
i'm not going to spend a huge amount of
time on the description
because this is we don't want to get
into a medical domain we want to focus
on our pca setup
uh what's important is you start looking
at what the different attributes are
what they mean
um if you were in the medical field
you'd want to note all these different
things whether what they're measuring
where it's coming from
you can actually see the actual
different
measurements they're taking
no missing attributes
we page all the way to the bottom and
you're going to have your data in this
case our target
and if you dig deep enough to the target
let's actually do this
let's go ahead and print target names
real quick here i always like to just
take a look and see what's on the other
end of this
target
names
run that
yeah so the target name is is it
malignant or is it b9
so in other words is this
a dangerous growth or is it something we
don't have to worry about that's the
bottom line with the cancer in this case
and then we can go ahead and load our
data and you know let me go up a just a
notch here for easy of reading
it's hard to get that just right that's
all you have to do
uh so let's go ahead and look at our
data uh our we're gonna use our pandas
and we're going to go ahead and do our
data frame it's going to equal cancer
data columns equals cancer feature
equals feature names so remember up here
we already loaded the
names up of our of the features in there
what is going to come out of this let me
just see if we can get to that
it's at the top of target names
that's just this list of names here in
the setup
and we can go ahead and run this code
and it'll print the head and you can see
here we have the mean radius the mean
texture mean perimeter
i don't know about you this is a
wonderful data set if you're playing
with it because
like many of the data that most of the
data that comes in half the time we
don't even know what we're looking at
uh we're just handed a bunch of stuff as
a data scientist going what the heck is
this
and so this is a good place to start
because this has a number of different
features in there we have no idea what
these feature means or where they come
from we want to just look at the data
and figure that out
and now we actually are getting into the
pca side of it as we've noticed before
is difficult to visualize high
dimensional data
we can use pca to find the first two
principal components and visualize the
data this new two-dimensional space with
a single scatter plot
before we do this we need to go ahead
and scale our data
now
i haven't run this to see if you really
have to scale the data on this
but as just a general
run time i almost do that as the first
step of any modeling even if it's
premodeling as we're doing here
in neural networks that is so important
with pca visualization it's already
going to scale it when we do the means
and deviation inside the pca
but just in case it's always good to
scale it
and then we're going to take our pca
with the scikit learn uses very similar
process to other pre-processing
functions that come with scikit-learn
we instantiate a pca object find the
principal components using the fit
method then apply the rotation and
dimensionality reduction by calling
transform we can also specify how many
components we want to
keep when creating the pca object
and so the code for this
oops getting a little bit ahead
let me go and run this code
so the code for this
is from sk learn decomposition import
pca pca equals pca in components equals
and that's really important to note that
because we're only going to want to look
at two components
i would never go over four components
especially if you're going to demo this
with somebody else if you're showing
this to the shareholders
the whole idea is to reduce it to
something people can see
and then the pca fit we're going to is
going to take the scale data that we
generated up here
and then you can see we've created our
pca model with in components equals 2.
now whenever i use a new tool
i like to go in there and actually see
what i'm using so let's go to the scikit
uh web page for the pca
and you can see in here here's our call
statement it describes what all the
different setups you have on there
probably the biggest one to look at
would be
well the biggest one is your components
how many components do you want
which you have to put in there pretty
much
and then you also might look at the svd
solver it's on auto right now but you
can override that and do different
things with it it does a pretty good job
as it is
and if we
go down all the way down to
um
there we go to our methods
if you notice we have fit
and we have fit transform
nowhere in here is predict because this
is not used for prediction
it's used to look at the data again
we're in the describe setup
we're fitting the data we're taking a
look at it
we've already looked at our
minimum maximum we've already looked at
what's in each quarter we've done a full
description of the data this is part of
describing the data
that's the biggest thing i take away
when i come zooming in here and of
course i have examples of it down here
if you forget
and the biggest one of course is the
number of components
and then i mean the rest you can play
with
the actual solver whether you're doing a
full or randomize there's different
things it does pretty good on the auto
and now we can transform this data to
its first two principal components
and so we have our xpca
we're going to set that equal to pca
transform
scaled data
so there we go there's our first
transformation
and let's just go ahead and print the
scaled data shape and the xpca data
shape
and the reason we want to do this is
just to show us uh
what's going on here we've taken 30
features i think i said 36 or something
like that but it's 30
and we've compressed it down to two
features and we decided we wanted two
features and that's where this comes
from
we still have 569 data sets
i mean data rows data sets we still have
569 rows of data but instead of
computing 30 features we're now only
doing our model on two features
so let's go ahead and
plot these and take a look and see
what's going on
and
we're just going to use our plt figure
we'll set the figure size on here here's
our scatter plot
xpca
x underscore pca of
of one these are two different
perceptions we're using
uh and then
you'll see right here c for color cancer
equals target
and so remember we have zero we have one
and if i remember correctly zero was
malignant one was b9
uh so everything in the zero column is
gonna be one color and the other color
is gonna be one and then we're gonna use
the plasma map just kind of telling you
what color it is add some labels first
principle component second principal
component we'll go and run this
and you can see here
instead of having a chart one of those
heat maps with 30 different
columns in it
we can look at this and say hey this one
actually did a pretty good job
of separating the data
and a couple things when i'm looking at
this that i notice is first
we have a very clear area where it's
clumped together
where it's going to be benign
and we have a huge area it's still
clumped together more spread out where
it's going to be malignant or i think i
had that backwards
and then in the middle
because we're dealing with something in
this particular case cancer
we would try to separate i would be
exploring how to separate this middle
group out
in other words there's an area where
everything overlaps
and we're not going to have a clear
result on it just because those are the
people you want to go in there and have
extra tests
or treat it differently
versus going in and saying just cutting
into the can into the cancer so the body
absorbs it and it dissipates versus uh
actively going in there removing it
testing it going through chemo and all
the different things that's a big
difference you know as far as what's
going to happen here in that middle line
where the overlap is going to be huge
that's domain specific going back to the
data
we can see here uh clearly by using
these two components we can easily
separate these two classes
so the next step is what does that mean
interpreting the components
unfortunately with this great power of
dimensionality reduction comes the cost
of not being able to easily understand
what these components represent
i don't know what principle component
one looks work represents or second
principle
the components correspond to
combinations of original features the
components themselves are stored as an
attribute of the filtered pca object and
so we talk look at that we can go ahead
and do look at the pca components this
is in our model we built we've trained
it we can run that and you can see
here's the actual components uh it's the
two components have each have their own
array
and within the array you can see the
what the scores are using
and these actually give weight to what
features are doing what
so in this numpy matrix array each row
represents a principal component and
each column relates back to the original
features what's really neat about this
is we can now go in reverse
and drop this onto a heat map
and start seeing uh what this means and
so let me go ahead and just put this
down already got it down here
uh we'll go ahead and put this in here
we're going to use our
df comp data frame and we do our pca
components
and i want you to notice how easy this
is
we're going to set our columns equal to
cancer feature names
that just makes it really easy
and we're dumping it into a data frame
what's neat about a data frame is when
we get to seaborn it will pull that data
frame apart and
and set it up for us we want and so
we're just going to do the cn the
seaborn heat map
of our data frame composition and we'll
use the plasma coloring
and it creates a nice little
color graph here
you can see we have the mean radius and
all the different features along the
bottom
on the right
we have a scale so we can see we have
the dark colors all the way to the
really light colors which are what's
really shining there this is like the
primary stuff we want to look at
so this heat map in the color bar
basically represent the correlation
between the various features and the
principal component itself
so you know very powerful map to look at
and then you can go in here and we might
notice that the mean radius
look how how on the bottom of the map it
is
um on some of this
so you have some interesting
correlations here that change the
variations on that and what means what
this is more when you get to a post
scribe you can also use this to try to
guess as what these things mean and what
you want to change to get a better
result
feature selection in machine learning
today we're going to look at what's in
it for you the need for feature
selection
what is feature selection
feature selection methods
feature selection statistics
so the need for feature selection to
train a model we collect huge quantities
of data to help the machine learn better
consider a table which contains
information on old cars
the model decides which cars must be
crushed for spare parts and when we talk
about huge quantities of data there they
save everything from people's favorite
cat pictures to
and you can imagine there's so much data
out there even in a company they'll save
all these little pieces of information
about people and companies and
corporations
you need some way to sort through
because if you try to run your models on
all of it
you'll end up with these very clunky
models and they might have issues which
we'll talk about later but in this case
we're talking about cars and crushing
but not all this data will be useful to
us some classes or part of the data may
not contribute much to our model and can
be dropped and you can see right here we
have who was the owner of the car
in our data a car will not be crushed
based on its previous owner
so yeah that's kind of a clear cut you
can see that why would i care who owned
the car before once it's in the junkyard
and we're crushing the cars we're not
gonna really care about that
so here we have dropped the owner column
as it does not contribute to the model
having too much unnecessary data can
cause the model to be slow the model may
also learn from this irrelevant data and
be inaccurate
so feature selection is a process of
reducing the input variable to your
model by using only relevant data and
getting rid of the noise in the data
consider the database given below a
library wants to donate some old books
to make place in their shells for new
books we want to train a model to
automate this task
in this case the color of the book does
not matter and keeping it can cause a
model to learn to donate books based on
color we can remove this as a feature
using feature selection we can optimize
our model in several ways
and so the number one is to prevent
learning from noise and overfitting
that's actually the huge one because we
we don't want it to give us the wrong
prediction and that means also improved
accuracy
so instead of giving us a wrong
prediction we also want it to be as
close to the right answer as we can get
and we want to reduce the training time
it's an exponential growth in some of
these models so the each feature you add
in increases that much
more training time we talk about feature
selection methods we put together a nice
flowchart that shows the various methods
used for feature selection
and you have your basic feature
selection and then there is supervised
and unsupervised
under supervised there's intrinsic
wrapper method filter method
so we talk about unsupervised feature
selection refers to the method which
does not need the output label class for
feature selection and that was uh you
can see here under super unsupervised we
don't have i mean that's really a
growing market right now
unsupervised learning and so feature
selection is the same thing
supervised feature selection refers to
the method which uses the output label
class for the feature selection and if
you remember we looked at uh three
different
we have intrinsic wrapper and filter
method so we're going to start with the
filter method on this now remember we
know what the output is so we're going
to be looking at that output to see how
well it's doing versus the features in
this method features are dropped based
on their relation to the output or how
they are correlating to the output
you can see here we have a set of
features selecting best feature learning
algorithm and then performance
and so we want to find out which feature
correlates to the performance on the
output consider the example of book
classifier here we drop the color column
based on simple deduction
and that kind of sums it up in the in a
nutshell as we want to filter out things
that clearly do not go with what we're
looking for we look at the wrapper
method in the wrapper method we split
our data into subsets
and train a model using this based on
the output of the model we add and
subtract features and train the model
again
and you can see here in the wrapper
method we have a set of features we
generate a subset we run it through the
algorithm and we see how each one of
those subset of features performs
consider the book data set by using the
wrapper method we would use a subset of
different features to train the machine
and adjust the subset according to the
output and so you can see here let's say
we take name a number of times red and
we run just those and we look at the
output and if we looked at him with all
four inputs and look at the output we'd
see quite a different variation in there
and we might say you know what condition
of the book and color really doesn't
affect what we're looking for and you
can see here we've run it on condition
of the book and color
depending on the output of the model we
will choose our final set of features
these features will give us the best
result for our model
and it might come up that the name
number of times red is probably pretty
important
the intrinsic method
this method combines the qualities of
both filter and wrapper method to create
the best subset
the model will train and check the
accuracy of different subsets and select
the best among them
we kind of looked at a little overview
of some of the stuff
some of the common feature selection
algorithms based on which method they
belong to are given below
and you'll see is primarily under
supervised there's not like i said a lot
of unsupervised methods and the ones
that are usually used these methods
and finds a way to create a supervised
connection between the data
and we talk about supervised methods we
have our filter method which we talked
about and it uses like the pearson's
coefficient
t squared anova coefficient those are
all under the filter method
and in the wrapper method recursive
feature elimination so remember we're
choosing a subset and we want to go
through there and look at each one so
you're just doing a lot of loops or
recursive calculations to see which one
works best and which ones don't have an
impact on the output
and there's a lot of genetic algorithms
to go with this too on the wrapper
method and how they evaluate it and with
the intrinsic method
there's the two main ones we're looking
at is the lasso regularization
the lasso algorithms are basically your
standard
regression model so it's finding out how
these
different methods fit together and which
ones have the best
add together to have the least amount of
error
the other one used in the intrinsic
method is the decision tree it says hey
if this one is this one produces this
result this one produces this result yes
no which way do we go based on the input
and the output variables we can choose
our feature selection model so you have
your numeric input coming in you have a
numeric output if you use the pearson's
correlation coefficient or spearman's
rank coefficient
you can then
select what features you're going to
feed into that specific model and you
maybe have a numerical input and a
categorical input so we're going to be
looking more at anova correlation
coefficient or kindle's rank coefficient
and if you have a core categorical input
and a numerical output
we might be looking at anova correlation
coefficient in kindle's rank coefficient
so based on the input and the output
variables we can choose our feature
selection model and you can see we have
categorical to categorical we might be
looking at the
chi-squared test
contingency tables and mutual
information let's go and take a look and
see
in the python code what we're talking
about here
and i'm going to go ahead and use for my
ide the jupiter notebook in the and i
always launch it out of anaconda on here
and we'll go ahead and go up here and
create a new python 3 module
and we'll call it uh
feature
select
and since we're in python we're going to
be working mainly with your numpy your
pandas your matplot library so we have
our number array our data frame setup
which goes with the number array the
numpy the pandas data frame and then we
want to go ahead and graph everything so
we're going to import these three
modules
and then we put together some data
we're going to read this in it's kobe
bryant i guess he's a basketball player
our guys in the back we have a number of
them guys
both we have a lot of men and women so
it's probably a misnomer our team in the
back um they have some of them have a
liking for basketball and they know who
kobe bryant is and they want to learn a
little bit more about kobe bryant what's
going in for whatever is going on with
his game
in basketball so we're going to take a
look at him
uh and once we import the data we can
see what columns are available
uh original features count so we can see
how many features there are
um
the length of it and we'll actually have
a list of them and then print just uh
the data head the top five rows
and so when we do this
we can see from the csv file
we have 25 original features
our original features are your action
type combine shot type game event id and
so forth there's a lot of features in
here that they're recorded on all of his
shots this is we talk about like a
massive amount of data
i mean
people are sitting there and they record
all this stuff and they import this
stuff for different reasons
but depending on what we want to look at
do we really want all those features
maybe the question we're going to ask is
what's the chance of him making any one
specific shot
in right from the beginning we can look
at the some of these things and say team
name uh team name probably
i don't know maybe it does matter
because the other team might be really
good at defense uh
game date maybe we don't really want to
look at the game date team id definitely
not of importance in any of this
so we look at this we have 25 features
and some of these features just really
don't matter to us
we also have location x location y
latitude and longitude i'm guessing
that's the same data we've actually
imported the
the very similar data maybe they're
slightly zoned differently
but as far as our program we don't want
to repeat data some of the models when
you repeat data into them and this is
true for most models create a huge bias
they weigh that data over other data
so just at a glance these are the things
we're looking at we want to find out
well how do we get this these features
down and get rid of this bias and all
these
extraneous features that we don't really
want to
spend time running our models on and
programming on
and as i pointed out there's a location
x a location y latitude and longitude
let's take a look at that and see what
we're looking at here we'll go ahead and
create a plot of these
and we'll just plot we'll do a scatter
plot of location x and location y
and then we'll do a scatter plot of
data lawn data lat which is probably
longitude and latitude
and the scatter plot let's go ahead and
actually put a little title here
location and scatter on there
we'll just go ahead and plot these and
when you look at this
coming in
these two graphs are pretty identical
except they're flipped
and so when we look at the location from
which they're shooting from
they're probably the same
and at this point we can say okay we can
get rid of one of these sets of datas we
don't need both x and y and latitude and
longitude because it's the same data
coming in and as we look at this
particular data the latitude longitude
we might also ask does it really make a
difference which side of the court
you're on whether you're on the left
side or the right side
and so we might go ahead and explore
instead of looking at this as
x y we might look at it as a distance
and an angle and we can easily compute
that and you can see we can create our
data distance equals location x
plus the location y squared standard
euclidean geometry or
triangular geometry
hypotenuse squared equals the each side
squared
and then once we've done that
we can also compute the angle
so the data angle is based on the arc
tangent
and so forth on here so this is all this
is we're just going to compute the angle
here
and then set that up
pi over 2 to get our angle
and we'll go ahead and run that
and you'll see some errors run come up
and that's because when we took slices
over here we took a slice of a slice
um there's ways to fix that but it's
really not important for this example
so if you do see that you want to start
looking up here for um instead of data
location x of uh
not location x0
this would be like um i believe the term
is ilo dot ilocation if this was yeah
this is in pandas uh so there's
different things in there but for this
it doesn't really matter these are just
warnings that's all they are and then
let's combine our remaining minutes and
seconds column into one there's another
one so if you remember up here we're
trying to get rid of these columns
do we really need let me see if i can
find it on here there we go there's our
minutes remaining
um and then they had
what was it it was uh minutes remaining
and seconds column so there's also a
seconds column on here
let me see if i can find that one
this is where it really gets kind of
crazy because here's our seconds
remaining so you can see that here's our
minutes remaining this gets crazy when
you're looking at hundreds of these
features and you can see that if if i'm
going to
say
write a model that's going to predict a
lot of this and i want it to run in this
case it's a basketball and how good his
shots are as the data comes in let's say
i want to have it run on your phone if
i'm running it across hundreds of
features
it's going to just hang up on your phone
where if i can get it down to just a
handful
we'll actually be able to come in here
and run it on a smaller device and not
use up as much memory or processing
power
so we'll go ahead and take data
remaining time here
and data minutes remaining times 60 plus
data seconds remaining so we're just
going to combine those
and we'll go ahead and reprint our data
so we can see what we got
um
coming across we have our action type
combined and this is we do this a lot uh
we want to take a look at oops i got so
so zoomed in let me see if i can zoom
out just a little bit there we go
boom
all right so we come up here you can see
that we now have our distance our angle
remaining time which is now just a
number
uh that computes both the minutes and
seconds together
and we still have we've
we've been adding columns i thought you
said we're supposed to subtract columns
right
we're going to delete the obsolete
columns when we get to them so we're
just filtering out and this is a filter
method we're just filtering through the
things
that we really
don't need
and next let's go ahead and explore team
id and team name
let me just go ahead and run that and if
you look at this we have los angeles
lakers and then they have the team id
here and they're unique
there's not that's not really anything
that's going to come up
because that's
this particular
athletes
works for that team so it's the same on
every line so there's another thing we
can filter out on there team id and
tname is just useless uh the whole
column contains only one value each and
it's pretty much useless
let's go ahead and take a look at match
up an opponent that's an interesting one
and we see here that we have
the lal versus por and the opponent is
por and ind
again here's a lot of duplicate
information so
this basically contains the same
information on here
again we're filtering all this stuff out
and this is because we're only looking
at one athlete and this might change if
you're looking at multiple athletes that
kind of thing now these are easy to see
we might have something that looks more
like this
we might have something where we're
looking at the distance which we
computed and the shot distance are they
the same thing
and what we can do is we can plot that
and plot them against each other on here
and we see it just draws a nice straight
line
and so
again we're looking at the same
information
so again we're repeating stuff and we
really don't want to be running our
model on repeat information on here so
again it contains the same information
so now let's look at the shot zone area
shot zone basic shot zone range
so now we're looking at the zones and
what does that mean and we'll go ahead
and and do this also in a scatter plot
in this case we're going to just create
three of these side by side so we're
going to create
our plot figure side 20 by 10
and then we're going to define our
scatter plot by category feature and
we're going to do each one
set up on here give it a slightly
different color and so our shot zone
area is going to be plot uh subplot 131
scatter 131 is how that's read by the
way
meaning that
it's number one
um we have three across
and this is the first one down so one
one one our scatter plot by category is
going to be the shot zone area
we're going to plot that
and then we're going to do the
shot zone basic and then the shot zone
range and you just push them through our
definition so each of those areas go
through and you'll see one three one one
three two one three three again it's a
one by three
setup and then it's just a place on each
one and so we look at this we can see
that
these shots
they map out the same so it's very again
redundant information
that should be intuitive um when we're
looking at this
in this color graphs
it kind of helps you start looking at
something you it's very intuitive like
this is and you start to realize that
some of this stuff
you'll be looking for in data you might
not understand
and you'll see these circular patterns
where they match or they mostly match
and you start to realize
when you're looking at these that
they're repetitive data and then you
want to explore them more closely
depending on what domain you're working
in so we look at these we look at them
and they look just like the regions of
the court but we already have stored
this information in angle and distance
columns so we've seen this image before
we go back up here
and here's our the similar image
and repeating that image is down here
and so let's go ahead and drop some of
this in this stuff so now let's drop all
the useless columns
and we can drop the shot id team id team
name
shot zone area shot zone range shot zone
basic
the match up
the longitude and latitude for putting
that into distance
seconds remaining minutes remaining
because we combine that into one column
shot distance because we have just
distance on there location x location y
the game event id game id all this stuff
is just being dropped on here and we'll
just go ahead and loop through our drops
and this is a nice way of doing this
because as you're playing with this
this kind of data
putting your list into one setup helps
because then you're just writing it
through an iteration
and you can come back and change it you
might be playing with different models
and do this with models you might be
looking at all kinds of different things
that you can drop and add in as you test
these out and again we're working in the
filter method so this is a lot of human
interaction with the data and it takes a
lot of critical thinking to look at this
stuff and say what matches and what
doesn't and so we look at the remaining
features let me go ahead and just run
this
the original to the new count we had 25
features now we have 11 features you can
see that right there we just circle that
there's our 25 and there's uh old new
now we're down to 11. so we've cut it
down to less than half
and you can just see
the actual different information on here
and the remaining time
at this point we filtered it through and
then we'd move into the next process
which would be to run our model on this
and maybe we would drop
some of the features and see if it runs
better or worse and what happens
uh that's kind of would be the next step
on there versus the filter setup and
that would be one of the other setups
depending on which algorithm you use
so that wraps up our demo on
filter the feature selection and going
through and seeing how these different
features are being repeated in this
particular in a basketball
setup
we're going to cover reinforcement
learning today and what's in it for you
we'll start with why reinforcement
learning we'll look at what is
reinforcement learning
we'll see what the different kinds of
learning strategies are that are being
used today in computer models under
supervised versus unsupervised versus
reinforcement
we'll cover important terms specific to
reinforcement learning
we'll talk about markov's decision
process and we'll take a look at a
reinforcement learning example but we'll
teach a tic-tac-toe how to play
why reinforcement learning training a
machine learning model requires a lot of
data which might not always be available
to us
further the data provided might not be
reliable learning from a small subset of
actions will not help expand the vast
realm of solutions that may work for a
particular problem
you can see here we have the robot
learning to walk
very complicated setup when you're
learning how to walk and you'll start
asking questions like if i'm taking one
step forward and left
what happens if i pick up a 50-pound
object how does that change how a robot
would walk
these things are very difficult to
program because there's no actual
information on it until it's actually
tried out learning from a small subset
of actions will not help expand the vast
realm of solutions that may work for a
particular problem
and we'll see here learned how to walk
this is going to slow the growth that
technology is capable of machines need
to learn to perform actions by
themselves and not just learn off humans
and you see the objective climb a
mountain
a real interesting point here
is that as human beings we can go into a
very unknown environment
and we can adjust for it and kind of
explore and play with it
most of the models the non-reinforcement
models in computer
machine learning aren't able to do that
very well there's a couple of them that
can be used or integrated see how it
goes
is what we're talking about with
reinforcement learning so what is
reinforcement learning
reinforcement learning is a sub-branch
of machine learning that trains the
model to return an optimum solution for
a problem by taking a sequence of
decisions by itself
consider a robot learning to go from one
place to another
the robot is given a scenario must
arrive at a solution by itself the robot
can take different paths to reach the
destination
it will know the best path by the time
taken on each path it might even come up
with a unique solution all by itself
and that's really important is we're
looking for unique solutions we want the
best solution but you can't find it
unless you try it
so we're looking at
our different
systems our different model we have
supervised versus unsupervised versus
reinforcement learning and with the
supervised learning that is probably the
most controlled environment we have a
lot of different supervised learning
models whether it's linear regression
neural networks
there's all kinds of things in between
decision trees
the data provided is labeled data with
output values specified
and this is important because we talk
about supervised learning you already
know the answer for all this information
you already know the picture has a
motorcycle in it so you're supervised
learning you already know that
the outcome for tomorrow for you know
going back a week you're looking at
stock you can already have like the
graph of what the next day looks like so
you have an answer for it
and you have labeled data which is used
you have an external supervision and
solves problems by mapping labeled input
to no one output
so very controlled
unsupervised learning and unsupervised
learning is really interesting because
it's now taking part in many other
models they start with and you can
actually insert an unsupervised learning
model
in almost either supervised or
reinforcement learning as part of the
system which is really cool
data provided is unlabeled data the
outputs are not specified machine makes
its own predictions
used to solve association with
clustering problems unlabeled data is
used no supervision solves problems by
understanding patterns and discovering
output
so you can look at this and you can
think um some of these things go with
each other they belong together so it's
looking for what connects in different
ways and there's a lot of different
algorithms that look at this
when you start getting into those are
some really cool images that come up
of what unsupervised learning is how it
can pick out say
the area of a donut
one model will see the area of the donut
and the other one will divide it into
three sections based on its location
versus what's next to it so there's a
lot of stuff that goes in with
unsupervised learning
and then we're looking at reinforcement
learning probably the biggest industry
in today's market uh in machine learning
or growing market it's very it's very
infant stage
as far as how it works and what it's
going to be capable of
the machine learns from its environment
using rewards and errors used to solve
reward based problems
no predefined data is used no
supervision follows trail and error
problem solving approach
so again we have a random first you
start with a random i try this it
works and this is my reward doesn't work
very well maybe or maybe doesn't even
get you where you're trying to get it to
do and you get your reward back and then
it looks at that and says well let's try
something else
and it starts to play with these
different things finding the best route
so let's take a look at important terms
in today's reinforcement model
and this has become pretty standardized
over the last few years
so these are really good to know
we have the agent uh agent is the model
that is being trained via reinforcement
learning so this is your actual
entity that has however you're doing it
with using a neural network or a
cue table or whatever combination
thereof
this is the actual agent that you're
using this is the model
and you have your environment
the training situation that the model
must optimize to is called its
environment
and you can see here i guess we have a
robot who's trying to get chest full of
gyms or whatever and that's the output
and then you have your action this is
all possible steps that can be taken by
the model and it picks one action and
you can see here it's picked three
different routes to get to the chest of
diamonds and gyms
we have a state the current position
condition returned by the model
and you could look at this uh if you're
playing like a video game
this is the screen you're looking at so
when you go back here
the environment is a whole game board so
if you're playing one of those mobius
games
you might have the whole game board
going on uh but then you have your
current position where are you on that
game board what's around that what's
around you
if you were talking about a robot the
environment might be moving around the
yard
where it is in the yard and what it can
see what input it has in that location
that would be the current position
condition returned by the model and then
the reward to help the model move in the
right direction it is rewarded points
are given to it to appraise some kind of
action
so yeah you did good or didn't do as
good trying to maximize the reward and
have the best reward possible
and then policy policy determines how an
agent will behave at any time it acts as
a mapping between action and present
state
this is part of the model what what is
your action that you're you're going to
take what's the policy you're using to
have an output from your agent
one of the reasons they separate policy
as its own entity
is that you usually have a prediction
of a different options
and then the policy well how am i going
to pick the best based on those
predictions i'm going to guess at
different options
and we'll actually weigh those options
in and find the best option we think
will work
so it's a little tricky but the policy
thing is actually pretty cool how it
works
let's go and take a look at a
reinforcement learning example
and just in looking at this we're going
to take a look consider what a dog
that we want to train
so the dog would be like the agent so
you have your your puppy or whatever
and then your environment is going to be
the whole house or whatever it is where
you're training them and then you have
an action we want to teach the dog to
fetch
so action equals fetching
and then we have a little biscuit so we
can get the dog to perform various
actions by offering incentives such as a
dog biscuit as a reward
the dog will follow a policy to maximize
this reward and hence will follow every
command and might even learn new actions
like begging by itself
so you have a you know so we start off
with fetching it goes oh i get a biscuit
for that it tries something else you get
a handshake or begging or something like
that and it goes oh this is also reward
based and so it kind of explores things
to find out what will bring is biscuit
and that's very much like how a
reinforced model goes as it
looks for different rewards how do i
find can i try different things and find
a reward that works
the dog also will want to run around and
play an explorer's environment
this quality of model is called
exploration so there's a little
randomness going on in exploration
and explores new parts of the house
climbing on the sofa doesn't get a
reward in fact it usually gets kicked
off the sofa
so let's talk a little bit about
markov's decision process
is a reinforcement learning policy used
to map a current state to an action
where the agent continuously interacts
with the environment to produce new
solutions and receive rewards
and you'll see here's all of our
different uh vocabulary we just went
over we have a reward our state our
agent our environment interaction and so
even though the environment kind of
contains everything
that you you really when you're actually
writing the program your environment's
going to put out a reward and state that
goes into the agent the agent then looks
at this state or it looks at the reward
usually
first and it says okay i got rewarded
for whatever i just did or it didn't get
rewarded
and it looks at the state
and then it comes back and if you
remember from
policy the policy comes in
um and then we have a reward the policy
is that part that's connected at the
bottom
and so it looks at that policy and it
says hey
what's a good action that will probably
be similar to what i did or
sometimes are completely random but
what's a good action that's going to
bring me a different reward
so taking the time to just understand
these different pieces as they go
is pretty important in most of the
models today
and so a lot of them actually have
templates
based on this you can pull in and start
using
pretty straightforward as far as once
you start seeing how it works
you can see your environment
sends it says hey this is the agent did
this if you're a character in a game
this happened and it shoots out a reward
in a state the agent looks at the reward
looks at the new state and then takes a
little guess and says i'm going to try
this action and then that action goes
back into the environment it affects the
environment the environment then changes
depending on what the action was
and then it has a new state and a new
reward that goes back to the agent
so in the diagram shawn we need to find
the shortest path between node a and d
each path has a reward associated with
it and the path with a maximum reward is
what we want to choose
the nodes a b c d denote the nodes to
travel from node uh a to b
is an action reward is a cost of each
path and policy is each path taken
and you can see here a can go to b
or a can go to c right off the bat or go
right to d
and if explored all three of these
you would find that a going to d was a
zero reward
a going to c and d would generate a
different reward
or you could go a c b d there's a lot of
options here
and so when we start looking at this
diagram you start to realize
that even though today's reinforced
learning models do really good at
finding an answer they end up trying
almost all the different directions you
see
and so they take up a lot of work uh or
a lot of processing time for
reinforcement learning they're right now
in their infant stage and they're really
good at solving simple problems and
we'll take a look at one of those in
just a minute in the tic tac toe game
but you can see here
once it's gone through these and it's
explored it's gonna find the a c d
is the best reward it gets a full 30
points for it
so let's go ahead and take a look at a
reinforcement learning
demo
in this demo we're going to use
reinforcement learning to make a
tic-tac-toe game you'll be playing this
game against the machine learning model
and we'll go ahead and we're doing it in
python so let's go ahead and go through
i always not always actually have a lot
of python tools let's go through
anaconda which will open up a jupiter
notebook seems like a lot of steps but
it's worth it to keep all my stuff
separate and it's also has a nice
display when you're in the jupiter
notebook for doing python
so here's our anaconda navigator i open
up the notebook which is going to take
me to a webpage and i've gone in here
and created a new python folder in this
case i've already done it and enabled it
to change the name to tic-tac-toe and
then for this example
we're going to go ahead and
import a couple things we're going to
import numpy as np we'll go ahead and
import pickle numpy of course is our
number array and then pickle's just a
nice way sometimes for
storing different information different
states that we're going to go through on
here
and so we're going to create a class
called state we're going to start with
that
and there's a lot of lines of code to
this class that we're going to put in
here
don't let that scare you too much
there's not as much here
it looks like there's going to be a lie
here but there really is just a lot of
setup going on in the in our class state
and so we have up here we're going to
initialize it
we have our
board a tic tac toe board so we're only
dealing with nine spots on the board
uh we have player one player two
uh is end we're gonna create a board
hash
uh we'll look at that in just a minute
we're just to stir some information in
there symbol player equals one
so there's a few things going on as far
as the initialization
then something simple we're just going
to get the hash
of the board you get the information
from the board on there which is
columns and rows
we want to know when a winner occurs so
if you get three in a row that's what
this whole section here is for
let me go ahead and
scroll up a little bit
and you can get a copy of this code if
you send a note over to simplylearn
we'll send you over
this particular file and you can play
with it yourself and see how it's put
together
i don't want to spend a huge amount of
time on this because this is just some
real general python coding
uh but you can see here we're just going
through all the rows
and you add them together and if it
equals three three in a row same thing
with columns
diagonal so you gotta check the diagonal
that's what all this stuff does here is
it just goes through the different areas
actually let me go ahead and put
there we go
and then it comes down here and we do
our sum and it says true
minus three just says did somebody win
or is it a tie
so you gotta add up all the numbers on
there anyway just in case they're all
filled up
and next we also need to know available
positions um these are ones that don't
no one's ever used before this way when
you try something or the computer tries
something
it's not going to give it an illegal
move that's what the available positions
is doing
then we want to update our state
and so you have your position going in
we're just sending in the position that
you just chose and you'll see there's a
little user interface we put in there we
can
pick the row and column in there
and again
i mean this is a lot of code
so really it's kind of a thing you'd
want to go through and play with a
little bit and just read through it get
a copy of it a great way to understand
how this works
and here is a given reward
so we're going to give a reward result
equals self winner
this is one of the hearts of what's
going on here
is we have a result self.winner
so if there's a winner then we have a
result that the result equals one here's
our feedback
if it doesn't equal one then it gets a
zero so it only gets a reward in this
particular case
if it wins
and that's important to know because
different
systems of reinforced learning
do rewarding a lot differently depending
on what you're trying to do this is a
very simple example with a
three by three board
imagine if you're playing a video game
uh certainly you only have so many
actions but your environment is huge you
have a lot going on in the environment
and suddenly a reward system like this
is going to be just
it's going to have to change a little
bit it's going to have to have different
rewards and different setup and there's
all kinds of advanced ways to do that as
far as weighing you add weights to it
and so
they can add the weights up depending on
where the reward comes in so it might be
that you actually get a reward in this
case you get the reward at the end of
the game
and i'm spending just a little bit of
time on this this is an important thing
to note but there's different ways to
add up those rewards it might have like
if you take a certain path
um the first reward
is going to be weighed a little bit less
than the last reward because the last
reward is actually winning the game or
scoring or whatever it is
so this reward system gets really
complicated in some of the more advanced
setups
in this case though
you can see right here that they give a
a 0.1 and a 0.5 reward
just for getting picking the right value
and something that's actually valid
instead of picking an invalid value so
rewards again that's like key it's huge
how do you
feed the rewards back in
then we have a board reset that's pretty
straightforward it just goes back and
resets the board to the beginning
because it's going to try out all these
different things while it's learning
it's going to do it by trial and error
so you have to keep resetting it
and then of course there's the play we
want to go ahead and play rounds equals
depends on what you want to do on here
you can set this
different obviously set that to higher
level but this is just going to go
through and you'll see in here
that we have player 1 and player 2.
this is this is the computer playing
itself
one of the more powerful ways to learn
to play a game
or even learn something that isn't a
game is to have two of these models
that are basically trying to beat each
other and so they always they keep
finding explore new things this one
works for this one so this one tries new
things
it beats this we've seen this in chess i
think was a big one where they had the
two players in chess with reinforcement
learning
was one of the ways they trained one of
the top
computer chess playing algorithms
uh so this is just what this is it's
going to choose an action it's going to
try something and the more it try stuff
the more we're going to record the hash
we actually have a board hash where the
self get the hash
set up on here where it stores all the
information
and then once you get to a win
one of them wins it gets the reward
uh then we go back and reset and try
again and then kind of the fun part we
actually get down here is we're going to
play
with a human so we'll get a chance to
come in here and see what that looks
like
when you put your own information in
and then it just comes in here and does
the same thing it did above it gives it
a reward for its things
or sees if it wins or ties
looks at available positions all that
fun of fun stuff
and then finally we want to show the
board
so it's going to print the board out
each time
really
as an integration is not that exciting
what's exciting
in here is one looking at this reward
system whoops play one more up the
reward system is really the heart of
this how do you reward the different uh
setup
and the other one is when it's playing
it's got to take an action
and so
what it chooses for an action is also
the heart of reinforcement learning how
do we choose that action
and those are really
key to right now where reinforcement
learning is
in
today's technology is
figuring this out
how do we reward it and how do we guess
the next best action so we have our
environment and you can see the
environment is we're going to be or the
state
which is kind of like what's going on
we're going to return the state
depending on what happens
and we want to go ahead and create our
agent uh in this case our player so each
one is let me go and grab that
until we look at a class player um
this is where a lot of the magic is
really going on is what how is this
player figuring out how to maneuver
around the board and then the board of
course returns a state that it can look
at and reward
so we want to take a look at this we
have uh name
self-state this is class player and when
you say class player we're not talking
about a human player we're talking about
just
the computer players and this is kind of
interesting so remember i told you
depending on what you're doing there's
going to be a decay gamma
explore rate
these are what i'm talking about is how
do we train it
as you try different moves it gets to
the end the first move is important but
it's not as important as the last one
and so you could say that the last one
has the heaviest weight and then as you
as you get there the first one let's see
the first move gives you a five reward
the second gives you a two reward and
the third one gives you a ten reward
because that's the final ending you got
it
the ten is going to count more than the
first step
uh and here's our we're going to get the
board information coming in and then
choose an action this was the second
part that i was talking about that was
so important
so once you have your training going on
we have to do a little randomness and
you can see right here is our np random
uniform so it's picking out a
random number
take a random action
this is going to just pick which row and
which column it is
and so choosing the action this one you
can see we're just doing random states
um choice length of positions action
position
and then it skips in there and takes a
look at the board uh for p in positions
it's actually storing the different
boards each time you go through
so it has a record of what it did so it
can properly weigh the values
and this simply just depends a hash
state what's the last date append it to
the
to our states on here
here's our feedback
rewards the reward comes in and it's
going to take a look at this and say is
it none
what is the reward and here is that
formula remember i was telling you about
up here
um that was important because it has
decay gamma times the reward
this is where
as it goes through each step
and this is really important this is
this is kind of the heart of this of
what i was talking about earlier you
have step one
and this might have a reward of two
you have step two i should probably
should have done abc this has a step
three
uh step four
and so on until you get to step in
and this might have a reward of 10.
so reward a 10
we're going to add that but we're not
adding
let's say this one right here
let's see this reward here right before
10 was
um let's see it's also 10 it just makes
the
math easy
so we had 10 and 10.
we had 10 this is 10 and 10 n whatever
it is but it's time it's 0.9
so instead of putting a full 10 here
we only do 9 that's a
0.9
times
10.
and so this formula
um as far as the decay times the reward
minus the cell state value
uh it basically adds in it says here's
one or here's two i'm sorry i should
have done this abc would have been
easier
so the first move goes in here and it
puts two in here
then we have our self
set up on here you can see how this gets
pretty complicated in the math but this
is really the key is how do we train
our states and we want the the final
state the win to get the most points if
you win you get most points
and the first step gets the least amount
of points
so you're really training this almost in
reverse you're training you're training
it from the last place where you have
like it says okay this is now i was need
to sum up my rewards and i want to sum
them up going in reverse and i want to
find the answer in reverse kind of an
interesting
play on the mind when you're trying to
figure this stuff out
and of course we want to go ahead and
reset the board down here
save the policy
load policy
these are the different things that are
going in between the agent and the state
to figure out what's going on
let's go ahead and load that up
and then finally we want to go ahead and
create a human player
and the human player is going to be a
little different
in that you choose an action row and
column here's your action
uh if action is
if action in positions meaning positions
that are available
uh you return the action
if not it just keeps asking you until
you get the action that actually works
and then we're going to go ahead and
append to the hash state which we don't
need to worry about because it returns
the action up here
and feed forward
again this is because it's a human
um at the end of the game bat propagate
and update state values
this part isn't being done because
it's not programming uh
the model uh the model is getting its
own rewards
so we've gone ahead and loaded this in
here
so here's all our pieces and the first
thing we want to do
is set up p1 player 1
p2 player 2
and then we're going to send our players
to our state so now it has p1 p2
and it's going to play and it's going to
play 50 000 rounds
now we can probably do a lot less than
this and it's not going to get the full
results in fact you know what uh let's
go ahead and just do five
just to play with it because i want to
show you something here
oops
somewhere in there i forgot to load
something
there we go
i must just forgot to run this run
oops forgot a reference there for the
board rows and columns three by three
there is actually in the state it
references that we just tack it on on
the end it was supposed to be at the
beginning
so now i've only set this up
with
let's see where we go in here i've only
set this up to train
five times
and the reason i did that is we're going
to
uh
come in and actually play it and then
i'm going to change that and we can see
how it differs on there
there we go and then you make it through
a run and we're going to go ahead and
save the policy
so now we have our player 1 and our
player 2 policy
the way we set it up it has two separate
policies loaded up in there
and then we're going to come in here and
we're going to do player one is going to
be the computer experience rate zero
load policy one
human player human and we're going to go
ahead and play this i remember only went
through it
just one round of training in fact
minimal training and so it puts an x
there and i'm going to go ahead and do
row 0
column 1.
you can see this is very uh basic on
here
and
so i put in my 0 and then i'm going to
go zero block it zero
zero
and you can see right here it let me win
uh just like that i was able to win zero
two
and
whoo human wins
so i only trained it five times we're
going to run this again
and this time
instead of five let's do 5000 or 50 000
i think that's what the guys in the back
had
and this takes a while to train it
this is where reinforcement learning
really falls apart
look how simple this game is we're
talking about a three by three set of
columns
and so for me to train it on this
um i could do a q table which would take
which would go much quicker
you could build a quick q table with
almost all the different options on
there
and
you would probably get a the same result
much quicker
we're just using this as an example
so when we look at reinforcement
learning you need to be very careful
what you apply it to it sounds like a
good deal until you do like a large
neural network
where you're doing you set the neural
network to a learning increment of one
so every time it goes through it learns
and then you do your actions you pick
from the learning
setup and you actually try actions on
the learning setup until you get what
you think is going to be the best action
so you actually feed what you think is
right back through the neural network
there's a whole layer there which is
really fun to play with
and then it has an output well think of
all those processes i mean that is just
a huge amount of work it's going to do
let's go ahead and skip ahead here give
it a moment it's going to take a
minute or two to go ahead and run
now to train it
we went ahead and let it run and it took
a while this this took
i got a pretty powerful processor and it
took about five minutes plus to run it
and we'll go ahead and
run our player set up on here oops it
brought in the last
whoops i brought in the last round so
give me just a moment to re
do the policy save there we go i forgot
to save the policy back in there
and then go ahead and run our player
again
so we've saved the policy then we want
to go ahead and load the policy for p1
as the computer
and we can see the computer's gone in
the bottom right corner i'm going to go
ahead and go 1-1 which is the center
and it's gone right up the top and if
you ever played tic-tac-toe you know the
computer has me but we'll go ahead and
play it out
row 0
column two
there it is and then it's gone here and
so i'm gonna go ahead and go row zero
one
two
no zero one there we go and column zero
that's where i wanted
oh and it says okay you your action
there we go boom
uh so you can see here we've got a
didn't catch the win on this it said tie
um kind of funny they didn't catch the
win on there
but if we play this a bunch of times
you'll find it's going to win more and
more the more we train it the more the
reinforcement happens
this lengthy training process
is really the stopper on reinforcement
learning
as this changes reinforcement learning
will be one of the more powerful
packages evolving over the next decade
or two
in fact i would even go as far as to say
it is the most important
machine learning tool and artificial
intelligence tool out there
as it learns not only a simple tic tac
toe board but we start learning
environments and the environment would
be like in language
if you're translating a language or
something from one language to the other
so much of it is lost if you don't know
the context it's in what's the
environments it's in and so being able
to attach environment and context and
all those things together is going to
require reinforcement learning to do
so again if you want to get a copy of
the tic tac toe board it's kind of fun
to play with run it you can test it out
you can do
you know test it for different uh values
you can switch from p1 computer
where we loaded the policy one to load
the policy two and just see how it
varies there's all kinds of things you
can do on there
hello and welcome to this tutorial on
deep learning my name is mohan and in
the next about one one and a half hours
i will take you through what is deep
learning and
into tensorflow environment to show you
an example of deep learning now there
are several applications of deep
learning really very interesting and
innovative applications and one of them
is identifying the geographic location
based on a picture and how does this
work the way it works is pretty much we
train an artificial neural network with
millions of images which are tagged
their geolocation is tagged and then
when we feed a new picture it will be
able to identify the geolocation of this
new image for example you have all these
images especially with maybe some
significant monuments or
significant locations and you train with
millions of such images and then when
you feed another image it need not be
exactly one of those that you have
claimed it can be completely different
that is the whole idea of training it
will be able to recognize for example
that this is a picture from paris
because it is able to recognize the
eiffel tower so the way it works
internally if we have to look a little
bit under the heart as these images are
nothing but this is digital information
in the form of pixels so each image
could be a certain size it can be 256 by
256 pixel kind of a resolution and then
each pixel is either having a certain
grade of color and all that is fed into
the neural network and it then gets
trained in and it's able to based on
these pixels pixel information it is
able to get trained and able to
recognize the features and extract the
features and thereby it is able to
identify these images and the location
of these images and then when you feed a
new image it kind of based on the
training it will be able to figure out
where this image is from so that's the
way a little bit under the hood how it
works so what are we going to do in this
tutorial we will see what is deep
learning and what do we need for deep
learning and one of the main components
of deep learning is neural network so we
will see what is neural network what is
a perceptron and how to implement logic
gates like and or nor and so on using
perceptrons the different types of
neural networks and then applications of
deep learning and we will also see how
neural networks
works so how do we do the training of
and at the end we will end up with a
small demo code
which will take you through in
tensorflow now in order to implement
deep learning code there are multiple
libraries or development environments
that are available and tensorflow is one
of them so the focus at the end of this
would be on how to use tensorflow to
write a piece of code using python as a
programming language and we will take up
an example which is a very common one
which is like the hello world of deep
learning the handwriting number
recognition which is a mnist commonly
known as mnist database so we will take
a look at mnist database and how we can
train a neural network to recognize
handwritten numbers so that's what you
will see
in this particular
video so let's get started what is deep
learning deep learning is like a subset
of what is known as a high level concept
called artificial intelligence you must
be already familiar must have heard
about this term artificial intelligence
so artificial intelligence is like the
high level concept if you will and in
order to implement artificial
intelligence applications we use what is
known as machine learning and within
machine learning a subset of machine
learning is deep learning machine
learning is a little bit more
generic concept and deep learning is one
type of machine learning if you will and
we will see a little later in maybe the
following slides a little bit more in
detail how deep learning is different
from traditional machine learning but to
start with we can mention here that deep
learning uses one of the differentiators
between deep learning and traditional
machine learning is that deep learning
uses neural networks and we will talk
about what are neural networks and how
we can implement neural networks and so
on and so forth as a part of this
tutorial so a little deeper into deep
learning deep learning primarily
involves working with complicated
unstructured data compared to
traditional machine learning with where
we normally use structured data in deep
learning the data would be primarily
images or voice or maybe text files so
and it is large amount of data as well
and deep learning can handle complex
operations it involves complex
operations and the other difference
between traditional machine learning and
deep learning is that the feature
extraction happens pretty much
automatically in traditional machine
learning feature engineering is done
manually the data scientists we data
scientists have to do feature
engineering feature extraction but in
deep learning that happens automatically
and of course deep learning for large
amounts of data complicated unstructured
data deep learning gives very good
performance now as i mentioned one of
the secret
sources of deep learning is neural
networks let's see what neural networks
is neural networks is based on our
biological
neurons the whole concept of deep
learning and artificial intelligence is
based on human brain and human brain
consists of billions of tiny stuff
called neurons and this is how a
biological neuron looks and this is how
an artificial neuron look so neural
networks is like a simulation of our
human brain human brain has
billions of biological neurons and we
are trying to simulate the human brain
using artificial neurons this is how a
biological neuron looks it has dendrites
and the corresponding component with an
artificial neural network is or an
artificial neuron are the inputs they
receive the inputs through dendrites and
then there is the cell nucleus which is
basically the processing unit in a way
so in artificial neuron also there is a
piece which is an equivalent of this
cell nucleus and based on the weights
and biases we will see what exactly
weights in biases are as we move the
input gets processed and that results in
an output in a biological neuron the
output is sent through a synapse and in
an artificial neuron there is an
equivalent of that in the form of an
output and biological neurons are also
interconnected so there are billions of
neurons which are interconnected in the
same way artificial neurons are also
interconnected so this output of this
neuron will be fed as an input to
another neuron and so on now in neural
network one of the very basic
units is a perceptron so what is a
perceptron a perceptron can be
considered as one of the fundamental
units of neural networks it can consist
at least one neuron but sometimes it can
be more than one neuron but you can
create a perceptron with a single neuron
and it can be used to perform certain
functions it can be used as a basic
binary classifier it can be trained to
do some basic binary classification and
this is how a basic perceptron looks
like and this is nothing but a neuron
you have inputs x 1 x 2 x 2 x n and
there is a summation function and then
there is what is known as an activation
function and based on this input what is
known as the weighted sum the activation
function either gets gives an output
like a zero or a one so we say the
neuron is either activated or not so
that's the way it works so you get the
inputs these inputs are each of the
inputs are multiplied by a weight and
there is a bias that gets added and that
whole thing is fed to an activation
function and then that results in an
output and if the output is correct it
is accepted if it is wrong if there is
an error then that error is fed back and
the neuron then adjusts the weights and
biases to give a new output and so on
and so forth so that's what is known as
the training process of a neuron or a
neural network there's a concept called
perceptron learning so perceptron
learning is again one of the very basic
learning processes the way it works is
somewhat like this so you have all these
inputs like x1 to xn and each of these
inputs is multiplied by a weight and
then that sum this is the formula of the
equation so that's some w i x i
sigma of that which is a sum of all
these product of x and w is added up and
then a bias is added to that the bias is
not dependent on the input but are the
input values but the bias is common for
one neuron however the bias value keeps
changing during the training process
once the training is completed the
values of these weights w1 w2 and so on
and the value of the bias gets fixed so
that is basically the whole training
process and that is what is known as the
perceptron training so the weights and
biases keep changing till you get the
accurate output and the summation is of
course passed through the activation
function as you see here this w i x i
summation plus b
is passed through activation function
and then the neuron gets either fired or
not and based on that there will be an
output that output is compared with the
actual or expected value which is also
known as labeled information this is the
process of supervised learning so the
output is already known and
that is compared and thereby we know if
there is an error or not and if there is
an error the error is fed back and the
weights and biases are updated
accordingly till the error is reduced to
the minimum so this iterative process
is
known as perceptron learning or
perceptron learning rule and this error
needs to be minimized so till the error
is minimized
this iteratively the weights and biases
keep changing and that is what is the
training process so the whole idea is to
update the weights and the bias of the
perceptron till the error is minimized
the error need not be zero the error may
not ever reach zero but the idea is to
keep changing these weights and bias so
that the error is minimum the minimum
possible that it can have so this whole
process is an iterative process and this
is the iteration continues till either
the error is zero which is uh unlikely
situation or it is the minimum possible
within these given conditions now in
1943 two scientists warren mcculloch and
walter pitts came up with an experiment
where they were able to implement the
logical functions like and or and nor
using neurons and that was a significant
breakthrough in a sense so they were
able to come up with the most common
logical gates they were able to
implement some of the most common
logical gates which could take two
inputs like a and b and then
give a corresponding result so for
example in case of an and gate a
and b and then the output is a b in case
of an or gate it is a plus b and so on
and so forth and they were able to do
this using a single
layer perceptron now most of these gates
it was possible to use single layer
perceptron except for xor and we will
see why that is in a little bit so this
is how an and gate works the inputs a
and b the output should be fired or the
neuron should be fired only when both
the inputs are one so if you have zero
zero the output should be zero for zero
one it is again zero one zero again zero
and one one the output should be
one so how do we implement this with a
neuron so it was found that by changing
the values of weights it is possible to
achieve this logic so for example if we
have equal weights like 0.7 0.7 and then
if we take the sum of the weighted
products so for example 0.7 into 0 and
then 0.7 into 0 will give you 0 and so
on and so forth and in the last case
when both the inputs are 1 you get a
value which is greater than 1 which is
the threshold so only in this case the
neuron gets activated and the output is
there is an output in all the other
cases there is no output because the
threshold value is 1. so this is
implementation of an and gate using a
single perceptron or a single neuron
similarly an or gate in order to
implement an or gate in case of an or
gate the output will be one if either of
these inputs is one so for example zero
one will result in one or other in all
the cases it is one except for zero zero
so how do we implement this using a
perceptron once again if you have a
perceptron with weights for example one
point two now if you see here if in the
first case when both are zero the output
is zero in the second case when it is
zero and one one point two into zero is
zero and then one point two into one is
one and in the second case similarly the
output is one point two in this last
case when both the inputs are one the
output is 2.4 so during the training
process these weights will keep changing
and then at one point where the weights
are equal to w1 is equal to 1.2 and w2
is equal to 1.2 the system learns that
it gives the correct output so that is
implementation of or gate using a single
neuron or a single layer perceptron now
xor gate this was one of the challenging
ones they tried to implement an xor gate
with a single level perceptron but it
was not possible and therefore in order
to implement an xor so this was like a a
roadblock in the progress of
neural network however subsequently they
realized that this can be implemented an
xor gate can be implemented using
a multi-level perceptron or mlp so in
this case there are two layers instead
of a single layer and this is how you
can implement an xor gate so you will
see that x1 and x2 are the inputs and
there is a hidden layer and that's why
it is denoted as h3 and h4 and then you
take the output of that and feed it to
the output at o5 and provide a threshold
here so we will see here that this is
the numerical calculation so the weights
are in this case for x1 it is 20 and
minus 20 and once again 20 and minus 20.
so these inputs are fed into h3 and h4
so you'll see here for h3 the input is 0
1 1 1 and for h4 it is 1 0 1 1 and if
you now look at the output final output
where the threshold is taken as one if
we use a sigmoid with the threshold one
you will see that in these two cases it
is zero and in the last two cases it is
one so this is a implementation of xor
in case of x or only when one of the
inputs is one you will get an output so
that is what we are seeing here if we
have either both the inputs are one or
both the inputs are zero then the output
should be zero so that is what is an
exclusive or gate so it is exclusive
because only one of the inputs should be
one and then only you will get an output
of one which is satisfied by this
condition so this is a special
implementation xor gate is a special
implementation of perceptron now that we
got a good idea about perceptron let's
take a look at what is the neural
network so we have seen what is a
perceptron we have seen what is a neuron
so we will see what exactly is a neural
network so neural network is nothing but
a network of these neurons and they are
different types of neural networks there
are about five of them these are
artificial neural network convolutional
neural network then recursive neural
network or recurrent neural network deep
neural network and deep belief network
so and each of these types of neural
networks have a special you know they
can
solve special kind of problems for
example convolutional neural networks
are very good at performing image
processing and image recognition and so
on whereas rnn are very good for speech
recognition and also text analysis and
so on so each type has some special
characteristics and they can they're
good at performing certain special kind
of tasks what are some of the
applications of deep learning deep
learning is today used extensively in
gaming you must have heard about alphago
which is a game created by a startup
called deepmind which got acquired by
google and alphago is an ai which
defeated the human world champion lee
sedol in this game of go so gaming is an
area where deep learning is being
extensively used and a lot of
research happens in the area of gaming
as well in addition to that nowadays
there are neural networks or special
type called generative adversarial
networks which can be used for
synthesizing either images or music or
text and so on and they can be used to
compose music so the neural network can
be trained to compose a certain kind of
music and autonomous cars you must be
familiar with google google's
self-driving car and today a lot of
automotive companies are investing in
this space and deep learning is a core
component of this autonomous cars the
cars are trained to recognize for
example
the road
the lane markings on the road
signals
any objects that are in front any
obstruction and so on and so forth so
all this involves deep learning so
that's another major application and
robots we have seen several robots
including sofia you may be familiar with
sophia who was given a citizenship by
saudi arabia and there are several such
robots which are very human like and the
underlying technology in many of these
robots is deep learning medical
diagnostics and health care is another
major area where deep learning is being
used and within healthcare diagnostics
again there are multiple areas where
deep learning and image recognition
image processing can be used for example
for cancer detection as you may be aware
if cancer is detected early on it can be
cured and one of the challenges is in
the availability of specialists who can
diagnose cancer using these diagnostic
images and various scans and and so on
and so forth so the idea is to train
neural network to perform some of these
activities so that the load on the
cancer specialist doctors or oncologists
comes down and there is a lot of
research happening here and there are
already quite a few applications that
are claimed to be performing better than
human beings in this space can be
lung cancer it can be breast cancer and
so on and so forth so health care is a
major area where deep learning is being
applied let's take a look at the inner
working of a neural network so how does
an artificial neural network let's say
identify can we train a neural network
to identify the shapes like squares and
circles and triangles when these images
are fed so this is how it works any
image is nothing but it is a digital
information of the pixels so in this
particular case let's say this is an
image of 28 by 28 pixel and this is an
image of a square there's a certain way
in which the pixels are lit up and so
these pixels have a certain value maybe
from 0 to 256 and 0 indicates that it is
black or it is dark and 256 indicates it
is completely it is white or lit up so
that is like an indication or a measure
of the how the pixels are lit up and so
this is an image is let's say consisting
of information of
784 pixels so all the information what
is inside this image can be kind of
compressed into this 784 pixels the way
each of these pixels is lit up provides
information about what exactly is the
image so
we can train neural networks to use that
information and identify the images so
let's take a look how this works so each
neuron the value if it is close to 1
that means it is white whereas if it is
close to zero that means it is black now
this is a an animation of how this whole
thing works so these pixels one of the
ways of doing it is we can flatten
this image and take this complete 784
pixels and feed that as input to our
neural network the neural network can
consist of probably several layers there
can be a few hidden layers and then
there is an input layer and an output
layer now the input layer takes these
784 pixels as input the values of each
of these pixels and then you get an
output which can be
of three types or three classes one can
be a square a circle or a triangle now
during the training process there will
be initially obviously you feed this
image and it will probably say it's a
circle or it will say it's a triangle so
as a part of the training process
we then
send that error back and the weights and
the biases of these neurons are adjusted
till it correctly identifies that this
is a square that is the whole training
mechanism that happens out here
now let's take a look at a circle same
way
so you feed these 784 pixels there is a
certain pattern in which the pixels are
lit up
and the neural network is trained to
identify that pattern
and during the training process once
again it would probably initially
identify it incorrectly saying this is a
square or a triangle and then that error
is fed back
and the weights and biases are adjusted
finally till it finally gets the image
correct
so that is the training process so now
we will take a look at
same way a triangle
so now if you feed another image which
is consisting of triangles so this is
the training process now we have trained
our neural network to classify these
images into
a triangle or a circle and a square so
now this neural network can
identify these three types of objects
now if you feed another image and it
will be able to identify whether it's a
square or a triangle or a circle now
what is important to be observed is that
when you feed a new image it is not
necessary that
the image or the the triangle is exactly
in this position now the neural network
actually
identifies the patterns so even if the
triangle is let's say positioned here
not exactly in the middle but maybe at
the corner or in the side
it would still identify that it is a
triangle and that is the whole idea
behind pattern recognition so how does
this training process work this is a
quick view of how the training process
works so we have seen that a neuron
consists of inputs it receives inputs
and then there is a weighted sum which
is nothing but this x i wi summation of
that plus the
bias and this is then fed to the
activation function and that in turn
gives us a output now during the
training process initially obviously
when you feed these images when you send
maybe a square it will identify it as a
triangle and when you maybe feed a
triangle it will identify as a square
and so on so that error information is
fed back and initially these weights can
be random maybe all of them have zero
values and then it will slowly keep
changing so the as a part of the
training process the values of these
weights w1 w2 up to wn keep changing in
such a way that towards the end of the
training process it should be able to
identify these images correctly so till
then the weights are adjusted and that
is known as the training process so and
these weights are numeric values it
could be 0.5 0.25 0.35 and so on it
could be positive or it could be
negative and the value that is coming
here is the pixel value as we have seen
it can be anything between 0 to 1 you
can scale it between 0 to 1 or 0 to 256
whichever way 0 being black and 256
being white and then all the other
colors in between so that is the input
so these are numerical values this
multiplication or the product w i x i is
a numerical value and the bias is also a
numerical value we need to keep in mind
that the bias is fixed for a neuron it
doesn't change with the inputs whereas
the weights are one per input so that is
one important point to be noted so but
the bias also keeps changing initially
it will again have a random value but as
a part of the training process the
weights the values of the weights w1 w2
wn and
the value of b
will change
and ultimately once the training process
is complete these values are fixed for
this particular neuron w1 w2 up to wn
and plus the value of the b is also
fixed for this particular neuron and in
this way there will be multiple neurons
and each there may be multiple levels of
neurons here and that's the way the
training process works so this is
another example of multi-layer so there
are two hidden layers in between and
then you have the input layer values
coming from the input layer then it goes
through multiple layers hidden layers
and then there is an output layer and as
you can see there are weights and biases
for each of these neurons in each layer
and all of them gets keeps changing
during the training process and at the
end of the training process all these
weights have a certain value and that is
a trained model and those values will be
fixed once the training is completed all
right then there is something known as
activation function neural networks
consists of one of the components in
neural networks is activation function
and every neuron has an activation
function and there are different types
of activation functions that are used it
could be a relu it could be sigmoid and
so on and so forth and the activation
function is what decides whether a
neuron should be fired or not so whether
the output should be 0 or 1 is decided
by the activation function and the
activation function in turn takes the
input which is the weighted sum you
remember we talked about w i x i plus b
that weighted sum is fed as an input to
the activation function and then the
output can be either a zero or a one and
there are different types of activation
functions which are covered in an
earlier video you might want to watch
all right so as a part of the training
process we feed the inputs the label
data or the training data and then it
gives an output which is the predicted
output by the network which we indicate
as y hat and then there is a labeled
data because we for supervised learning
we already know what should be the
output so that is the actual output and
in the initial process before the
training is complete obviously there
will be error so that is measured by
what is known as a cost function so the
difference between the predicted output
and the actual output is the error and
the cost function can be defined in
different ways there are different types
of cost functions so in this case it is
like the average of the squares of the
error so
and then
all the errors are added which can
sometimes be called as sum of squares
sum of square errors or sse and that is
then fed as a feedback in what is known
as backward propagation or back
propagation and that helps in
the network adjusting the weights and
biases and so the weights and biases get
updated till this value the error value
or the cost function
is
minimum now there is a optimization
technique which is used here called
gradient descent optimization and this
algorithm
works in a way that the error which is
the cost function
needs to be minimized so there's a lot
of mathematics that goes behind this for
example they find the local minima the
global minima using
the differentiation and so on and so
forth but the idea is this so as a
training process as the as a part of
training the whole idea is to
bring down
the error which is like let's say this
is the function
the cost function at certain levels it
is very high the cost value of the cost
function the output of the cost function
is very high so
the weights have to be adjusted in such
a way and also the bias of course that
the cost function is minimized so there
is this optimization technique called
gradient descent that is used and this
is known as the learning rate now
gradient descent
you need to specify what should be the
learning rate and the learning rate
should be optimal because if you have a
very high learning rate then the
optimization will
not converge because at some point it
will cross over to the side on the other
hand if you have very low learning rate
then it might take forever to convert so
you need to come up with the optimum
value
of the learning rate and once that is
done using the gradient descent
optimization the error function
is reduced and that's like the end of
the training process all right so this
is another view of gradient descent so
this is how it looks this is your cost
function the output of the cost function
and that has to be minimized using
gradient descent algorithm and these are
like the parameters and weight could be
one of them so initially we start with
certain random values so cost will be
high and then the weights keep changing
and in such a way that the cost function
needs to come down and at some point it
may reach the minimum value and then it
may increase so that is where the
gradient descent algorithm decides that
okay it has reached a minimum value and
it will kind of try to stay here this is
known as the global minima now sometimes
these curves may not be just for
explanation purpose this has been drawn
in a nice way but sometimes these curves
can be pretty erratic there can be some
local minima here and then there is a
peak and then and so on so the whole
idea of gradient descent optimization is
to identify the global minima and to
find the weights and the bias at that
particular point so that's what is
gradient descent and then this is
another example so you can have these
multiple local minima so as you can see
at this point when it is coming down it
may appear like this is a minimum value
but then it is not this is actually the
global minimum value and the gradient is
an algorithm will make an effort to
reach this level and not get stuck at
this point so the algorithm is already
there and it knows how to identify this
global minimum and that's what it does
during the training process now in order
to implement deep learning there are
multiple platforms and languages that
are available but the most common
platform nowadays is tensorflow and so
that's the reason we have this tutorial
we've created this tutorial for
tensorflow so we will take you through a
quick demo of how to write a tensorflow
code using python and tensorflow is
an open source platform created by
google so let's just take a look at the
details of tensorflow and so this is a a
library a python library so you can use
python or any other languages it's also
supported in other languages like java
and r and so on but python is the most
common language that is used so
it is a library for
developing
deep learning applications especially
using neural networks and it consists of
primarily two parts if you will so one
is the tensors and then the other is the
graphs or the flow that's the way the
name that's the reason for this kind of
a name called tensorflow so what are
tensor sensors are like
multi-dimensional arrays if you will
that's one way of looking at it so
usually you have a one-dimensional array
so first of all you can have what is
known as a scalar which means a number
and then you have a one-dimensional
array something like this which means
this like a set of numbers so that is a
one dimension array then you can have a
two dimensional array which is like a
matrix
and beyond that sometimes it gets
difficult so this is a three dimensional
array but tensorflow can handle many
more dimensions so it can have
multi-dimensional arrays that is the
strength of tensorflow and which makes
computation deep learning computation
much faster and that's the reason why
tensorflow is used for developing deep
learning applications so tensorflow is a
deep learning tool and this is the way
it works so the data basically flows in
the form of tensors and the way the
programming works as well is that you
first create a graph of how to execute
it and then you actually
execute that particular graph in the
form of what is known as a session we
will see this in the tensorflow code as
we move forward so all the data is
managed or manipulated in tensors and
then the processing happens using these
graphs there are certain terms called
like for example ranks of a tensor the
rank of a tensor is like a dimensional
dimensionality in a way so for example
if it is scalar so there is just a
number just a one number the rank is
supposed to be zero and then it can be a
one dimensional
vector in which case the rank is
supposed to be one and then you can have
a two-dimensional
vector typically like a matrix then in
that case we say the rank is two and
then if it is a three-dimensional
array then rank is three and so on so it
can have more than three as well so it
is possible that you can store
multi-dimensional arrays in the form of
tensors so what are some of the
properties of tensorflow i think today
it is one of the most popular
platform tensorflow is the most popular
deep learning platform or library
it is open source
it's developed by google developed and
maintained by google but it is open
source one of the most important things
about tensorflow is that it can run
on cpus as well as gpus gpu is a
graphical processing unit just like cpus
central processing unit now in earlier
days gpu was used for primarily for
graphics and that's how the name has
come and
one of the reasons is that it cannot
perform generic activities very
efficiently like cpu
but it can perform
iterative actions or computations
extremely fast and much faster than a
cpu so they are really good for
computational activities and in deep
learning there is a lot of iterative
computation that happens so in the form
of matrix multiplication and so on so
gpus are very well suited for this kind
of computation and tensorflow supports
both gpu as well as cpu and there's a
certain way of writing code in
tensorflow we will see as we go into the
code and of course tensorflow can be
used for traditional machine learning as
well but then that would be an overkill
but just for understanding it may be a
good idea to start writing code for a
normal machine learning use case so that
you get a hang of how tensorflow code
works and then you can move into neural
networks so that is
just a suggestion but if you are already
familiar with how tensorflow works then
probably yeah you can go straight into
the neural networks part so in this
tutorial we will take the use case of
recognizing handwritten digits this is
like a hello world of deep learning and
this is a nice little mnist database is
a nice little database that has images
of handwritten digits nicely formatted
because very often in deep learning and
neural networks we end up spending a lot
of time in preparing the data for
training and with mnis database we can
avoid that you already have the data in
the right format which can be directly
used for training and mnist also offers
a bunch of
built-in utility functions that we can
straightaway use and call those
functions without worrying about writing
our own functions and that's one of the
reasons why mnist database is very
popular for training purposes initially
when people want to learn about deep
learning and tensorflow this is the
database that is used and it has a
collection of 70 000 handwritten digits
and
a large part of them are for training
then you have test just like in any
machine learning process and then you
have validation and all of them are
labeled so you have the images and their
label and these images they look
somewhat like this so they are
handwritten
images collected from a lot of
individuals people have these are
samples written by human beings they
have hand written these numbers these
numbers going from zero to nine so
people have written these numbers and
then the images of those have been taken
and formatted in such a way that it is
very easy to handle so that is mnis
database and the way we are going to
implement this in our
tensorflow is we will feed this data
especially the training data along with
the label information and the data is
basically these images are stored in the
form of the pixel information as we have
seen in one of the previous slides all
the images are nothing but these are
pixels
so an image is nothing but an
arrangement of pixels and the value of
the pixel either it is lit up or it is
not or in somewhere in between that's
how the images are stored and that is
how they are fed into the neural network
and for training once the network is
trained when you provide a new image it
will be able to identify within a
certain error of course and for this we
will use one of the simpler
neural network configurations called
soft max and for simplicity what we will
do is
we will flatten
these pixels so instead of taking them
in a two-dimensional arrangement we just
flatten them out so for example it
starts from here it is a 28 by 28 so
there are
784 pixels so pixel number one starts
here it goes all the way up to 28 then
29 starts here and goes up to 56 and so
on and the pixel number 784 is here so
we take all these pixels flatten them
out and feed them like one single line
into our
neural network and this is a what is
known as a softmax layer what it does is
once it is trained it will be able to
identify
what digit this is so there are in this
output layer there are 10
neurons each signifying a digit and at
any given point of time when you feed an
image only one of these 10 neurons gets
activated
so for example if this is strained
properly and
if you feed
a number nine like this
then this particular neuron gets
activated so you get an output from this
neuron let me just use
a pen or a laser to show you here okay
so you're feeding the number nine
let's say this has been trained and now
if you're feeding a number nine this
will get
activated now let's say you fade one to
the trained
network then this neuron will get
activated if you feed two this neuron
will get activated and so on i hope you
get the idea so this is one type of a
neural network or an activation function
known as soft max layer so that's what
we will be using here this is one of the
simpler ones for
quick and easy understanding
so
this is how the code would look we will
go into our lab environment in the cloud
and
we will show you there directly but very
quickly this is how the code looks and
let me run you through
briefly here and then we will go into
the jupyter notebook where the actual
code is and we will run that as well so
as a first step first of all we are
using python here and that's why the
syntax of the language is python and the
first step is to import the tensorflow
library so
and we do this by using this line of
code saying import tensorflow as tf df
is just for convenience so you can name
give any name and
once you do this tf is tensorflow is
available as an object in the name of tf
and then you can run its methods and
accesses its attributes and so on and so
forth and mnist database is actually an
integral part of tensorflow and that's
again another reason why we as a first
step we always use this example mnist
database example so you just simply
import mnist database as well using this
line of code and you
slightly modify this so that the labels
are in this format what is known as one
hot true which means that the label
information is stored like an array
and let me just
use pen to show what exactly it is so
when you do this one hot true what
happens is each label is stored in the
form of an array of
10 digits and let's say the number is
8 okay so in this case all the remaining
values there will be a bunch of zeros so
this is like array at position 0 this is
at position 1 position 2 and so on and
so forth let's say this is position 7
then this is position 8 that will be 1
because our input is 8 and again
position 9 will be zero okay so one hot
encoding this one hot encoding true will
kind of
load the data in such a way that the
labels are in such a way that only one
of the digits has a value of one and
that indicates so based on which
digit is one we know what is the label
so in this case the eighth position is
one therefore we know this sample data
the value is eight similarly if you have
a 2 here
let's say then the labeled information
will be somewhat like this so you have
your labels so you have this as 0 the
0th position the first position is also
0 the second position is one because
this indicates number two and then you
have third as zero and so on okay so
that is the significance of this one hot
true all right and then we can
check how the data is looking by
displaying the data and as i mentioned
earlier this is pretty much in the form
of digital form like numbers so all
these are like pixel values so you will
not really see an image in this format
but there is a way to visualize that
image i will show you in a bit and
this tells you how many images are there
in each set so the training there are 55
000 images in training and in the test
set there are 10 000 and then validation
there are 5000 so all together there are
70 000
images all right so let's
move on and we can
view the actual
image by
using the matplotlib library and this is
how you can view this is the code for
viewing the images and you can view them
in color or you can view them in
grayscale so the cmap is what tells in
what way we want to view it and what are
the maximum values and the minimum
values of the pixel values so these are
the max and minimum values so of the
pixel values so maximum is 1 because
this is a scaled value so 1 means it is
white and 0 means it is black and in
between is it can be anywhere in between
black and white
and the way to train the model there is
a certain way in which you write your
tensorflow code and
the first step is to create some
placeholders and then you create a model
in this case we will use the softmax
model one of the simplest ones and
placeholders are primarily to get the
data from outside into the neural
network so this is a very common
mechanism that is used and then of
course you will have variables which are
your you remember these are your weights
and biases so for in our case there are
10 neurons and
each neuron actually has
784 because each neuron takes all the
inputs if we go back to our slide here
actually every neuron takes all the 784
inputs right this is the first neuron it
has it receives all the 784 this is the
second neuron this also receives all the
700 so each of these inputs needs to be
multiplied with the weight and that's
what we are talking about here so these
are
this is a a matrix
of
values for each of the neurons and so it
is like a 10 by 784 matrix because there
are 10 neurons and similarly there are
biases now remember i mentioned
bias is only one per neuron so it is not
one per input unlike the weights so
therefore there are only 10 biases
because there are only 10 neurons in
this case so that is what we are
creating a variable for biases so this
is something little new in tensorflow
you will see unlike our regular
programming languages where everything
is a variable here the variables can be
of three different types you have
placeholders which are primarily used
for feeding data you have variables
which can change during the course of
computation and then a third type which
is not shown here are constants so these
are like fixed numbers all right so in a
regular programming language you may
have everything as variables or at the
most variables and constants but in
tensorflow you have three different
types placeholders variables and
constants and then you create what is
known as a graph so tensorflow
programming consists of graphs and
tensors as i mentioned earlier so this
can be considered ultimately as a tensor
and then the graph tells how to execute
the whole implementation so that the
execution is stored in the form of a
graph and in this case what we are doing
is we are doing a multiplication tf you
remember this tf was created as a
tensorflow object here one more level
one more so tf is available here now
tensorflow has what is known as a matrix
multiplication or matmal function so
that is what is being used here in this
case so we are using the matrix
multiplication of tensorflow so that you
multiply your input values x with w
right this is what we were doing x w
plus b you're just adding b and this is
in very similar to one of the earlier
slides where we saw sigma x i wi so
that's what we are doing here matrix
multiplication is multiplying all the
input values with the corresponding
weights and then adding the bias so that
is the graph we created and then we need
to define what is our loss function and
what is our optimizer so in this case we
again use the tensorflow's apis so tf.nn
softmax cross entropy with logits is the
api that we will use and reduce mean is
what is like the mechanism whereby which
says that you reduce
the
error and optimizer for doing deduction
of the error what optimizer are we using
so we are using gradient descent
optimizer we discussed about this in a
couple of slides
earlier and for that you need to specify
the learning rate you remember we saw
that there was a slide somewhat like
this and then you define
what should be the learning rate how
fast you need to come down that is the
learning rate and this again needs to be
tested and tried and to find out the
optimum level of this learning rate it
shouldn't be very high in which case it
will not converge or shouldn't be very
low because it will in that case it will
take very long so you define the
optimizer and then you call the method
minimize for that optimizer and that
will kick start the training process
and so far we've been creating the graph
and in order to actually execute that
graph we create what is known as a
session and then we run that session and
once the training is completed we
specify how many times how many
iterations we want wanted to run so for
example in this case we are saying
thousand steps so that is a exit
strategy in a way so you specify the
exit condition so training will run for
thousand iterations and once that is
done we can then evaluate the model
using some of the techniques
shown here so let us
get into the code quickly and see how it
works so this is our cloud environment
now you can install tensorflow on your
local machine as well i'm showing this
demo on our existing cloud but you can
also install tensorflow on your local
machine and there is a separate video on
how to set up your tensorflow
environment you can watch that if you
want to install your local environment
or you can go for
other any cloud service like for example
google cloud amazon or cloud labs any of
these you can use and
run and try the code okay so it has got
started
we will login
all right so this is our deep learning
tutorial uh code
and this is our tensorflow environment
and
so let's get started
the first we have seen a little bit of a
code walk through uh in the slides as
well now you will see the actual code in
action so the first thing we need to do
is import tensorflow and then we will
import the data and we need to adjust
the data in such a way that
the
one hot is encoding is set to true one
hot encoding right as i explained
earlier so in this case the label values
will be shown appropriately
and if we just check what is the type of
the data so you can see that this is a
data sets python
data sets and if we
check the number of
images the way it looks so this is how
it looks it is an array of type float32
similarly
the number if you want to see what is
the number of
training images there are
55 000 then there are test images 10 000
and then validation images 5000 now
let's take a quick look at the data
itself visualization so we will use
matplotlib for this
and
if we take a look at the shape now shape
gives us like the dimension of the
tensors or
or the arrays if you will so in this
case the training data set if we see the
size of the training data set using the
method shape it says there are 55 000
and
55 000 by 784 so remember the 784 is
nothing but the 28 by 28 28 into 28 so
that is equal to 784 so that's what it
is uh showing now we can take just
one image and just see
what is the
the first image and see what is the
shape so again size obviously it is only
similarly you can
look at the image itself the data of the
first image itself so this is how it it
shows so large part of it will probably
be zeros because as you can imagine
in the image only certain areas are
written rest is
black so that's why you will mostly see
zero say that it is black or white but
then there are these values are so the
values are actually they are scaled so
their values are between zero and one
okay so this is what you're seeing so
certain locations there are some values
and then other locations there are zeros
so
that is how the data is stored and
loaded
if we want to actually see what is the
value of the handwritten image
if you want to view it this is how you
view it so you
create like do this reshape and
matplotlib has this
feature to show you these images so we
will actually use the function called
i am show and then if you pass this
parameters appropriately you will be
able to see the different images now i
can change the values in this position
so which image we are looking at right
so we can say
if i want to see what is there in maybe
5 000
right so
5000 has 3
similarly you can just say 5 what is in
5 as 8
what is in 50
again 8 so basically by the way if
you're wondering how i'm executing this
code shift enter
in case you're not familiar with jupiter
notebooks shift enter is how you execute
each cell individual cell and if you
want to execute the entire program you
can go here and say run all
so that is how
the score gets executed
and
here again we can check what is the
maximum value and what is the minimum
value of this pixel values as i
mentioned this is it is scaled so
therefore it is between the values lie
between 1 and 0. now this is
where we create our model
the first thing is to create the
required placeholders and variables and
that's what we are doing here as we have
seen in the slides so we create
one placeholder and we create two
variables which is for the weights and
biases these two variables are actually
matrices so
each variable has 784 by 10 actual
values okay so
one for this 10 is for each neuron there
are 10 neurons and 784 is for the pixel
values inputs that are given which is 28
into 28
and the biases as i mentioned
one for each neuron so there will be 10
biases they are stored in a variable by
the name b
and this is the graph which is basically
the multiplication of these matrix
multiplication of x into w and then the
bias is added for each of the neurons
and the whole idea is to minimize
the error so let me just execute i think
this code is executed then we define
what is our the y value is basically the
label value
so this is another placeholder we had x
as one placeholder and white underscore
true as a second placeholder and this
will have values in the form of uh 10
digit 10 digit arrays
and
since we said one hot encoded the
position which has a one value indicates
what is the
label for that particular number all
right then we have cross entropy which
is nothing but
the
loss
loss function
and we have the optimizer we have chosen
gradient descent as our optimizer then
the training process itself so the
training process is nothing but to
minimize
the cross entropy which is again nothing
but the
loss function
so we define
all of this in the form of a graph so up
to here remember what we have done is we
have not exactly executed any tensorflow
code till now we are just preparing the
graph the execution plan
that's how the tensorflow code works so
the whole
structure and format of this code will
be completely different from how we
normally do programming so even with
people with programming experience may
find this a little difficult to
understand it and it needs quite a bit
of practice so you may want to
view this
video also maybe a couple of times to
understand this flow
because the way tensorflow programming
is done is
slightly different from the normal
programming some of you who
let's say have done
maybe spark programming to some extent
will be able to easily understand this
but even in spark the the programming
the code itself is pretty
straightforward behind the scenes the
execution happens slightly differently
but in tensorflow even the code has to
be written in a completely different way
so the code doesn't get executed
in the same way as you have written so
that that's something you need to
understand and a little bit of practice
is needed for this
so so far what we have done up to here
is creating
the variables and feeding the variables
and
rather not feeding but setting up the
variables and
the graph that's all defining maybe the
what kind of a network you want to use
for example we want to use a softmax and
so on so you have created the variables
how to load the data loaded the data
viewed the data
and prepared everything but you have not
yet executed anything in tensorflow now
the next step is the execution intensive
law so the first step for
doing any execution in tensorflow is to
initialize the variables so anytime you
have any variables defined in your code
you have to run this piece of code
always so you need to basically create
what is known as a node for initializing
so this is a node you still are not yet
executing anything here you just created
a node for the initialization
so let us go ahead and create that
and
here onwards is where you will actually
execute your code
in tensorflow and in order to execute
the code what you will need is a session
tensorflow session so tf.session will
give you a session and there are a
couple of different ways in which you
can do this but one of the most common
methods of doing this is with what is
known as a width loop so you have a
width
tf dot session as says and with the
colon here and this is like a block
starting of the block and these
indentations tell how far this block
goes and
this session is valid
till
this block gets executed so that is the
purpose of creating this width block
this is known as a width block so with
tf dot session as says you say says dot
run init now says dot run will execute
a node that is
specified here so for example here we
are saying says dot run says is
basically an instance of the session
right so here we are saying tf.session
so an instance of the session gets
created and we are calling that
says and then we run
a node within that one of the nodes in
the graph so one of the nodes here is
init
so we say run that particular node and
that is when the initialization of the
variables happens now what this does is
if you have any
variables in your code in our case we
have w
is a variable and b is a variable so any
variables that we created you have to
run this code you have to
run the initialization of these
variables otherwise you will get an
error okay so that is the that's what
this is doing then
we within this with block we specify a
for loop
and we are saying
we want the system to iterate for a
thousand steps and perform
the training
that's what this for loop does
run training for thousand iterations
and what it is doing basically is it is
fetching
the data or these images remember there
are about 50 000 images but it cannot
get all the images in one shot because
it will take up a lot of memory and
performance issues will be there so this
is a very common way of
performing deep learning training you
always do in batches so we have maybe 50
000 images but you always do it in
batches of 100 or maybe
500 depending on the size of your
system and so on and so forth so in this
case we are saying okay get me 100
images at a time and get me only the
training images remember we use only the
training data for training purpose and
then we use test data for test purpose
you must be familiar with machine
learning so you must be aware of this
but in case you are not in machine
learning also not this is not specific
to deep learning but in machine learning
in general you have what is known as
training data set and test data set your
available data typically you will be
splitting into two parts and using the
training data set for training purpose
and then to see how well the model has
been trained you use the test data set
to check or test the validity or the
accuracy of the model so that's what we
are doing here and you observe here that
we are actually calling an mnist
function here so we are saying mnist
train dot next batch
right so this is the advantage of using
mnist database because they have
provided some very nice helper functions
which are readily available otherwise
this activity itself we would have had
to write a piece of code to fetch this
data in batches that itself is a lengthy
exercise so we can avoid all that if we
are using mnist database and that's why
we use this for the initial learning
phase okay so when we say fetch what it
will do is it will fetch the images into
x and the labels into y and then you
use this
batch of 100 images and you run the
training so says dot run basically what
we are doing here is we are running the
training mechanism which is nothing but
it passes this through the neural
network passes the images through the
neural network finds out what is the
output and if the output obviously they
initially it will be wrong so all that
feedback is given back to the neural
network and thereby all the w's and b's
get updated
till it reaches thousand iterations in
this case
the exit criteria is thousand but you
can also specify probably accuracy rate
or something like that for the as an
exit criteria so here it is it just says
that okay this particular image was
wrongly predicted so you need to update
your weights and biases that's the
feedback given to each neuron and that
is run for 1000 iterations and typically
by the end of this thousand iterations
the model would have learned to
recognize these handwritten images
obviously it will not be 100 accurate
okay so once that is done
after so this happens for 1000
iterations once that is done
you then test the accuracy of these
models by using the test data set right
so this is what we are trying to do here
the code may appear a little complicated
because if you're seeing this for the
first time you need to understand uh the
various methods of tensorflow and so on
but it is basically comparing the output
with
what has been what is actually there
that's all it is doing so you have your
test data and you're trying to find out
what is the actual value and what is the
predicted value and seeing whether they
are equal or not tf dot equal right and
how many of them are correct and so on
and so forth and based on that the
accuracy is
calculated as well so this is the
accuracy and that is what we are trying
to see how accurate the model is in
predicting these numbers or these digits
okay so let us run this this entire
thing is in one cell so we will have to
just run it in one shot it may take a
little while let us see
and
not bad so it has finished the thousand
iterations
and what we see here as an output is the
accuracy so we see that the accuracy of
this model is around 91
okay now which is pretty good for such a
short exercise within such a short time
we got 90 percent accuracy however in
real life this is probably not
sufficient so there are other ways in to
increase the accuracy we will see
probably in some of the later tutorials
how to improve this accuracy how to
change maybe the hyper parameters like
number of neurons or number of layers
and so on and so forth and
so that this accuracy can be increased
beyond 90 percent all right so what is
the tensorflow object detection api this
is an open source framework which is
actually provided by the tensorflow team
and there are trained models available
and the sample code is also available
which we can use in order to easily
detect objects in images and videos this
is pretty robust and can detect objects
fairly quickly and this is very easy for
people to use as well people with very
less or no knowledge of machine learning
or deep learning can also with a little
bit of python programming knowledge can
actually use this api this library to
build object detection applications this
is a list of libraries that are required
and they have been shown in the code as
well the exact purpose of each of this
library why it is required is
out of the scope of this tutorial but we
will see in the code as we walk through
some of these libraries how and why they
are used the cocoa data set coco stands
for common objects in context so this
data set consists of 300 000 images of
90 most commonly found objects like
chairs and tables and so on and so forth
so
this model has been trained or in fact a
set of models have been trained on this
data set and this is pretty good to
detect the most common objects in the
images and videos so with that let's get
into the code all right so the first
part is to import all these libraries
and this we have shown you in the slides
as well again a large part of this will
be for doing some helper functions and
maybe for visualizing the images and so
on and so forth so that's the reason
they are required as i said the exact
details of each and every library
probably is out of scope but these are
needed so as a first step maybe you just
go ahead and include these libraries and
run the code and maybe a later point we
can discuss what each of these libraries
does now this will work with tensorflow
version higher than 1.4 so if you are
having tens flow version below 1.4 you
may have to upgrade to a higher version
so let me go ahead and execute the cell
and
we also need this line of code to make
sure that once we
run this object detection the labeled
images are displayed within this
notebook and many of you by now must be
familiar with this and we will import a
few utility libraries and you will see
that we will be using some of these
for visualization purpose so once the
objects are detected we need to display
the information what that object is and
then what percentage of confidence the
model has so all these details that's
the utility functions that stored here
and then the next part is to prepare the
model as i mentioned we will be using an
existing trained model
the tensorflow team has actually
provided these models the one that we
will be using is ssd with the mobile net
but you can actually use any one of the
ones that are listed in this url let me
just quickly take you through this url
these are a bunch of models trained
models that are readily available for
anybody to use it is open source and let
me scroll down the only thing is that if
there are some of them with the accuracy
is much higher but they take longer and
there are some where the accuracy is not
so high and they are much faster so they
are faster but the accuracy may not be
that very high so you can play around
with some of these and we in this
particular exercise or in this
particular tutorial we are using this
ssd model which is ssd mobile and
question one so that's the model that
we'll be using so in this cell we are
primarily creating a bunch of variables
with the various for example the name of
the model the path and so on and so
forth so that we will be using these
names in the next step which is to
download this model and install it
locally these are also referred to as a
frozen model so once they are trained
and then you kind of extract or you
freeze the model so that's the reason
they are called frozen model so that
others can just use this without any
further training so this is where we
download and extract our model locally
so this will take a little while let me
see if i can wait or maybe pause the
video and come back once it is done
might take a little while let's see if
it
completes i have a pretty high speed
network but even then it takes some time
so that's good but this part is over now
let us see this part and yes both are
done so once that is done we need to
load some label mapping our basically
what this will do is your model as you
may be aware by now if you do some
classification the model will actually
not give any output
text it will give some numbers so if
there are five classes it will say okay
this belongs to modern class one or two
or three or five and so on the numbers
now each of these will obviously the
numbers will not make any sense to the
outside world so we need to do some
small mapping so in this case let's say
one may be a chair two maybe a table
three maybe a balloon and so on so that
kind of number to text mapping we need
to do and that is what is being done in
this particular cell and then we have a
helper code which will load the image
and convert it into a numpy array so
that the number array is what gets
processed and used by the model to do
the detection part of it so that is what
this
method is all about so we will be the
later on we will be calling that
function and
next is preparation for detection so
here we are basically telling where the
images are stored and how many images or
what is the naming convention or format
of the images now if you want you can
modify this code for example currently i
have test underscore images as my folder
so let me go and show this to you so
this is under my object detection folder
i have another subfolder where i am
storing my images which is text
underscore images now you can rename
this folder and give some other name and
then in your code you can probably give
that particular name for the subfold
similarly the format of these files what
is the name and format of this files
here it is in a very simple format which
is the names of the files are like beach
one beach two b3 and so on so i have
taken beach as the theme so i have
images which are related to beaches so
this is beach one beach two and then
beach three are few others but we will
use these three for our demo and so
that's what i'm saying here the name of
the images will be beach something dot
jpeg which is uh jpeg format and in this
curly braces basically we will will be
filled with either
one two or three based on in this
particular for loop okay so that is what
this is doing all right so the next step
is to run inference on these images in a
loop and what we are basically doing
here is
getting these images one by one and then
running through the model to find out
what are the objects that can be
detected and then against each of the
object a box will be drawn and it will
be labeled with the name and the
percentage of accuracy or confidence
that the model detects these objects
okay so that is uh the function here and
so let me just run that piece of code
and here is basically where we are
calling this function so we are loading
this images and then we are calling this
function for each image and then we are
displaying this using the matplotlib
library so let's run this it will take
one image at a time and then detect the
images now the beauty is that the same
format of the code can be used for doing
object detection in a video so we have
another video for doing object detection
in a video so most of the code out there
will be reused from here and the only
thing is that instead of reading the
images from the local storage
we read the frames from the video and
there is a neat little video reader that
is available and it will be shown in the
other video and frame by frame we read
the video and then pass on to this
function and it will act as if each of
these frames is an image and then it
will do the same object detection on the
entire video so that's in a separate
video just look out for that and
actually the information about that is
uh provided in the cards the eye symbol
so that's the the video object detection
in video that's the separate tutorial
all right so now that we have all the
pieces together this the last cell is
where the whole action takes place so
let's run this and see how it looks so
it will take probably a little while and
there are about three images let's see
what it detects there we go so good so
the first one it has detected a person
and that too with 97 accuracy which is i
think pretty good
okay and then the next image it detects
umbrella
and chair there are a few other objects
but it's not able to detect it has
detected umbrella with 63 percent
accuracy or confidence rather and the
chair with the 58
again not bad
then let's see the next image so here
these are actually balloons hot air
balloons but the model thinks it is a
kite which is uh probably not that bad
it sees there's something in the sky and
therefore probably it thinks it is a
kite and it detects that with 65 percent
confidence okay so that was pretty much
all i wanted to show you in this
particular
tutorial about object detection in
images
hey everyone in this video called keras
tutorial we will teach you everything
that you need to know about keras in
machine learning and data analysis to
begin we will explain the concept of
keras to you we will answer the question
what is keras and how it is used in deep
learning then we will list out some
common differences between keras
tensorflow and pi torch so that you can
understand why keras is the superior
framework after this we will dive deep
into keras and see how you can use keras
to implement deep learning models with
hands-on tutorials
and finally we will take a look at keras
sequential models a type of model in
keras which makes implementing neural
networks extremely easy
so
let's get started the first question
that arises in our mind is what is deep
learning deep learning is generally
considered to be a subset of machine
learning which is nothing but a subset
of artificial intelligence what is
artificial intelligence artificial
intelligence is the intelligence which
is demonstrated by machines unlike the
natural intelligence which is displayed
by humans and animals which also
involves consciousness and emotionality
meanwhile machine learning is an
application of artificial intelligence
that provides systems the ability to
automatically learn and improve from
experience without being programmed to
specifically now deep learning as i said
is a class of machine learning
algorithms that uses multiple layers to
progressively extract higher level
features from raw input for example if
we have a system which we are using for
image processing lower layers in the
system may be used to detect the
outlines of images while higher layers
may identify the concepts which are
relevant
to the image in case of the picture of a
human it might recognize features such
as digits or letters or face now in deep
learning we use neural networks to use
multiple mathematical operations to
break down a complex problem into
smaller paths which are solved
individually each mathematical
expression is called a neuron
deep learning models are trained using
large sets of labeled data and neural
network architectures that learn
features directly from the data without
the need for manual feature extraction
one of the most popular types of deep
neural networks is known as a
convolution neural network a convolution
neural network convolves learned
features with input data and uses 2d
convolutional layers making this
architecture well suited processing 2d
data such as images
now in deep learning neural networks
will play a very important part what
exactly are neural networks
neural networks are modeled from the way
the human brain works in our brain we
have neurons which carry electrical
impulses from our brain to different
parts of our body and help in
transmitting instructions from the brain
all over our body in neural networks a
neuron acts as nothing more but a
mathematical operation
multiple neurons are required to break
down a complex problem into various
paths to make it easier to solve
now a neural network contains layers of
interconnected nodes each node in a
neural network is a perceptron and is
similar to a multiple linear regression
the perceptron feeds the signals which
are produced by multiple linear
regressions into an activation function
that may be non-linear hidden layers
will fine-tune the input weightings
until neural network's margin of error
is minimal and we get the optimal output
now what is keras
before we move on to keras let's take a
look at tensorflow tensorflow is a
software library which was created by
google to implement large-scale machine
learning models and to help solve
complex numerical problems tensorflow is
an end-to-end open source machine
learning platform which you can think of
as an infrastructure layer for
differentiable programming it combines
four key abilities
first efficiently executing lower level
tensor operations on cpu and gpu or tpu
computing gradient of arbitrary
differential expressions scaling
computation to many devices and
exporting programs to external runtimes
such as servers browsers or mobiles
but what does keras have to do with all
of this keras is nothing more than a
high level deep learning api which is
written in python for neural networks it
has multiple backend neural network
computations and it makes implementing
neural networks easy
as we know keras is a powerful and easy
to use free open source python library
for developing and evaluating deep
learning models
keras is a high level api of tensorflow
an approachable highly productive
interface for solving machine learning
problems with a focus on modern deep
learning it provides essential
abstractions and building blocks for
developing and shipping machine learning
solutions with high iteration velocity
keras empowers engineers and researchers
to take full advantage of the
scalability and cross-platform
capabilities of tensorflow 2. you can
run keras on tpu or on large classes of
gpu and you can export your keras model
to run in the browser or on a mobile
device keras provides a python interface
for artificial neural networks keras
acts as an interface for tensorflow
library and it helps in implementation
of commonly used neural network building
block layers such as objectives
activation functions and optimizers and
a host of tools to make working with
images and text data easier to simplify
the coding necessary for writing deep
neural network code
basically it wraps efficient numerical
computation libraries such as theano and
tensorflow and allows you to define and
change neural network models in just a
few lines of code in fact tensorflow and
keras are so tight together that even in
tensorflow the official get started with
tensorflow tutorial views high level
keras apis embedded in tensorflow
instead of just using tensorflow by
itself
some of the important features of keras
include keras being a high level
interface which uses theano or
tensorflow for its backend
keras can run smoothly on both cpu and
gpu
it supports almost all the models
required for you to create a complete
neural network
and it is extremely modular in nature
which means it is incredibly expressive
flexible and apt for innovative research
so why do we need keras
first of all keras is an api which is
designed for human beings not for
machines which means that it follows
best practices for reducing cognitive
load it offers consistent and simple
apis it minimizes the number of users
action required for common use cases and
it provides clear and actionable
feedback upon
user error it is extremely powerful and
easy to use and it also wraps numerical
computation libraries such as theano and
tensorflow and allows you to train and
define neural networks in a few lines of
code
this makes keras easy to learn and use
as a keras user you can be more
productive allowing you to try more
ideas than your competition faster which
in turn will help you win machine
learning competition this ease of use
does not come at the cost of reduced
flexibility because keras integrates
deeply with low level tensorflow
functionality it enables you to develop
highly hackable workflows where any
piece of functionality can be customized
or reused easily
building a model in keras let's take a
look at the basic pipeline which you
will have to follow when you are using
keras to define a neural network first
of all you will have to define a neural
network you will have to select the
activation functions and the various
mathematical operations that are gonna
be taking place in your neural network
along with the different weightages
next you will use keras to compile your
network which is basically you will use
keras to build it
after this you will fit to your network
you will fit all the training data that
you have to your network
and use your testing data to evaluate
how the network works
finally you will use this network to
make predictions
this entire five-step pipeline can be
executed in keras within two to three
lines of code neural networks which
would have taken people days or even
weeks to make can be executed in keras
in a couple of hours
now users of keras
the first use of keras is to productize
deep models on smartphones
deep models require a lot of computation
power to run but with the help of keras
we can literally make deep models a
product which can be sold and executed
on smartphones
the next use of keras is in distributed
training of deep learning models
distributed training means that we can
split our deep learning model into
different paths and train it on systems
all across the globe this makes training
of our deep learning model extremely
fast
along with saving time we are also
saving on the computational power of our
system as it is not only our system
which has to run such a heavy program by
distributing it across various systems
all the resources required to train a
deep learning model go down
significantly before we can see the
differences between these platforms we
first need to know what exactly each of
these platforms are let's start with
tensorflow
what is tensorflow tensorflow is a low
level software library which is created
by google to help implement machine
learning models and to solve complex
numerical problems
tensorflow is nothing but a free and
open source software library for machine
learning it can be used across a range
of tasks but has a particular focus on
training and inference of deep neural
networks
tensorflow is a symbolic math library
based on data flow and differential
programming it is used for both research
and production at google
what do you mean by data flow it
basically means that we perform
calculations by converting every element
into graphical form the variables of the
graph are called tensors and
mathematical operations are called
operators
here in the computational graph shown
you can see that x y and 2 are the
variables they will also be called
tensors and division multiplication and
addition are the operators
this graph basically shows us the
calculation that is gonna occur in a
machine learning model
where x and y are gonna be divided and y
and two are gonna be multiplied the
results of these two calculations are
then gonna be added to give us the final
output i told you that x y and 2 are
also called tensors
what exactly are tensors tensors are
multi-dimensional arrays with a uniform
type all tensors are immutable like
python numbers and strings which means
that you cannot update the contents of a
tensor you can only create a new tensor
next let's look at the api keras
what exactly is keras keras is a high
level deep learning api written in
python for easy implementation and
computation of neural networks keras is
an open source software library that
provides a tensorflow interface for
artificial neural networks keras acts as
an interface for the tensorflow library
which means that it runs on top of
tensorflow
up until version 2.3 keras supported
multiple back-ends
including tensorflow microsoft cognitive
toolkit
or cntk
r theano and played ml as of version 2.4
only tensorflow is supported
as a version 2.4 only tensorflow is
supported
designed to help enable fast
experimentation with deep neural
networks in it focuses on being
user-friendly modular and extensible
keras is a high-level api of tensorflow
an approachable highly productive
interface for solving machine learning
problems with the focus on modern deep
learning it provides essential
abstractions and building blocks for
developing
and shipping machine learning solutions
with high iteration velocity keras does
not perform its own low level operations
such as tensor products and convolution
it relies on back end engines for that
even though keras supports multiple back
back-end engines its primary back-end
engine is tensorflow and its primary
supporter is google which means that
keras acts as nothing more but a wrapper
class around tensorflow theano cntk
played ml or mxnet which are low level
apis next we will look at pi torch what
exactly is pytoch
pytorch is a low level api which is
developed by facebook for natural
language processing and computer vision
it is a more powerful version of numpy
it is an open source machine learning
library based on the torch library used
for applications such as computer vision
and natural language processing
primarily developed by facebook's ai
research lab it is free and open source
software released under the modified bsd
license although the python interface is
a more polished and the primary focus of
development pytorch also has a c plus
plus interface
python is a widely liked language
because it is easy to understand and
write pytorch emphasizes flexibility and
allows deep learning models to be
expressed in basic python
pytorch is mainly used for natural
language processing
and for computer vision
now let's move on to the differences
between tensorflow keras and pytorch
the first difference that we'll be
looking at is called level of api there
are two main types of apis a low level
api and a high level api api stands for
application programming interface
a low level application programming
interface is generally more detailed and
allows you to have
more detailed control to manipulate
functions within them on how to use and
implement them
while a high level api is more generic
and simple and provides more
functionality with one command
statements than a lower level api
high level interfaces are comparatively
easier to learn and to implement the
models using them
they allow you to write code in a
shorter amount of time and to be less
involved with the details
in this case tensorflow is a high and
low level api
pure tensorflow is a low level api while
tensorflow wrapped in keras is a high
level api
keras in itself is a high level api
which uses multiple low-level apis as a
back-end and simplifies the operation of
these low-level apis
pi torch is a low-level api
the next criteria that we'll be looking
at is speed
tensorflow is very fast and is used for
high performances
keras is slower as it works on top of
tensorflow not only does it have to wait
for tensorflow to finish implementation
it then starts its own implementation
meanwhile pi torch works at the same
speed as tensorflow as both of them are
both low level apis
now keras is a wrapper class for
tensorflow and has added abstraction
functionalities on top of tensorflow
which make it slower than tensorflow and
pi torch in computation speed both
tensorflow and pi torch are almost equal
and in development speed keras is faster
as it has built-in functionalities which
can significantly reduce your
development time
the next difference is on the
architecture
tensorflow is not very easy to use and
even though it provides keras as a
framework that makes it work easier
tensorflow still has a very complex
architecture which is hard to use
meanwhile keras has a simpler
architecture and is easier to use it
provides a high level of abstraction
which makes implementation of programs
in keras significantly easier
pie touch on the other hand also has a
complex architecture and the readability
is less when compared to keras
tensorflow uses computational graphs
which makes it very complex and hard to
interpret but it has amazing
computational ability across platforms
pytorch is a little hard for beginners
but is really good for computer vision
and deep learning purposes
data sets and debugging
tensorflow works with large data sets
due to its high execution speed and
debugging is really hard in tensorflow
due to its complex nature
meanwhile keras only works with very
small data sets as its speed of
execution is low
programs do not require frequent
debugging in keras as they are
relatively simpler and pi torch can
manage high level tasks in higher
dimension data sets and is easier to
debug than both qrs and tensorflow
next we'll be looking at ease of
development
as we said before tensorflow works with
many
hard concepts such as computational
graphs and tensors which means that
writing code in tensorflow is very hard
it is generally used by people when they
are doing research work and really need
very specific functionalities
keras on the other hand provides a high
level of abstraction which makes it very
easy to use it is best for people who
are just starting out with python and
machine learning pytorch is easier than
tensorflow but is still comparatively
hard than keras it is not very easy to
learn for beginners but is significantly
more powerful than just plain keras ease
of deployment tensorflow is very easy to
deploy as it uses tensorflow serving
tensorflow serving is a flexible high
performance serving system for machine
learning models designed for production
environments tensorflow serving makes it
easy to deploy new algorithms and
experiments while keeping the same
server architecture and apis
tensorflow serving provides
out-of-the-box integration with
tensorflow models but can be easily
extended to serve other types of models
and data
in keras model deployment can be done
with either tensorflow serving or flask
which makes it relatively easy but not
as easy as you as it would be with
tensorflow and pytorch
pytorch uses i torch mobile which makes
deployment easy but again for tensorflow
deployment is way easier as tensorflow
serving can update your machine learning
backend on the fly without
the user even realizing there's a
growing need to execute ml models on
edge devices to reduce latency preserve
privacy and enable new interactive use
cases in the past engineers used to
train models separately they would then
go through a multi-step error-prone and
often complex process to train the
models for execution on a mobile device
the mobile runtime was often
significantly different from the
operations available during training
leading to inconsistent developer and
eventually user experience
all of these frictions have been removed
by pytorch mobile by allowing a seamless
process to go from training to
deployment by staying entirely within
the pytorch ecosystem it provides an
end-to-end workflow that simplifies the
research to production environment for
mobile devices
in addition it paves the way for privacy
preserving features via federated
learning techniques
at the end of the day the question that
really matters is which framework should
you use keras tensorflow or pi touch
now tensorflow has implemented various
levels of abstraction to make
implementation of deep learning and
neural networks easy this has also made
debugging easier keras is simple and
easy but not as fast as tensorflow it is
more user-friendly than any other deep
learning api however and is easier to
learn for beginners
pytorch on the other hand is the
preferred deep learning api for teachers
but it is not as widely used in
production as tensorflow is it is faster
but it has lower gpu utilization
at the end of the day
the framework that we would suggest that
you use is tensorflow
why
while pi torch may have been the
preferred deep learning library for
researchers tensorflow is much more
widely used in day-to-day production
pytorch's ease of use combined with the
default ego execution mode for easier
debugging predestines it to be used for
fast hacky solutions and smaller scale
models
but tensorflow's extensions for
deployment on both servers and mobile
devices combined with the lack of python
overhead makes it the preferred option
for companies that work with deep
learning models
in addition the tensorflow board
visualization features offers a nice way
of showing the inner workings of your
model to say your customers
meanwhile between tensorflow and keras
the main difference isn't in performance
tensorflow is a bit faster due to less
overhead but also the level of control
you would like keras is much easier to
start with than plain tensorflow but if
you want to do something with keras that
doesn't come out of the box it will be
harder to implement that tensorflow on
the other hand allows you to create any
arbitrary computational graph providing
much more flexibility so if you're doing
more research type of work tensorflow is
the sure route to go due to the
flexibility that it provides if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
so we're going to dive right into what
is cross we'll also go all the way
through this into a couple of tutorials
because that's where you really learn a
lot is when you roll up your sleeves so
we talk about what is cross cross is a
high level deep learning api written in
python for easy implement implementation
of neural networks it uses deep learning
frameworks such as tensorflow pytorch
etc is back in to make computation
faster and this is really nice because
as a programmer there is so much stuff
out there and it's evolving so fast
it can get confusing and having some
kind of high level order in there we can
actually view it and easily program
these different neural networks
is really powerful it's really powerful
to
have something out really quick
and also be able to start testing your
models and seeing where you're going
so crossworks by using complex deep
learning frameworks such as tensorflow
pytorch
ml played etc as a backend for fast
computation
while providing a user-friendly and easy
to learn front-end
and you can see here we have the cross
api specifications and under that you'd
have like tf cross for tensorflow thano
cross and so on and then you have your
tensorflow workflow that this is all
sitting on top of
and this is like i said it organizes
everything the heavy lifting is still
done by tensorflow or whatever you know
underlying package you put in there and
this is really nice because you don't
have to
dig as deeply into the heavy end stuff
while still having a very robust package
you can get up and running rather
quickly
and it doesn't distract from the
processing time because all the heavy
lifting is done by packages like
tensorflow this is the organization on
top of it
so the working principle of cross
the working principle of karas is cross
uses computational graphs to express and
evaluate mathematical expressions
you can see here we put them in blue
they have the expression
expressing complex problems as a
combination of simple mathematical
operators
where we have like the percentage or in
this case in python that's usually your
left your remainder or multiplication
you might have the operator of x
to the power of 0.3 and it uses useful
for calculating derivatives by using
back propagation so if we're doing with
neural networks we send the error back
up to figure out how to change it
this makes it really easy to do that
without really having not banging your
head and having to hand write everything
it's easier to implement distributed
computation
and for solving complex problems specify
input and outputs and make sure all
nodes are connected
and so this is really nice as you come
in through is that as your layers are
going in there you can get some very
complicated
different setups nowadays which we'll
look at in just a second
and this just makes it really easy to
start spinning this stuff up and trying
out the different models
so we look across models across model we
have a sequential model
sequential model is a linear stack of
layers where the previous layer leads
into the next layer
and this if you've done anything else
even like the sk learn with their neural
networks and propagation and any of
these setups this should look familiar
you should have your input layer it goes
into your layer 1 layer 2 and then to
the output layer
and it's useful for simple classifier
decoder models
and you can see down here we have the
model equals across sequential this is
the actual code you can see how easy it
is
we have a layer that's dense your layer
one
as an activation they're using the relu
in this particular example and then you
have your name layer one layer dense
relu name layer two and so forth
and they just feed right into each other
so it's really easy just to stack them
as you can see here and it automatically
takes care of everything else for you
and then there's a functional model and
this is really where things are at this
is new make sure you update your cross
or you'll find yourself running this
doing the functional model you'll run
into an error code because this is a
fairly new release
and he uses multi-input and multi-output
model the complex model which forks into
two or more branches
and you can see here we have our image
inputs equals your cross input shape
equals 32 by 32 by 3.
you have your dense layers dense 64
activation relu
this should look similar to what you
already saw before
but if you look at the graph on the
right it's going to be a lot easier to
see what's going on
you have two different inputs
uh and one way you could think of this
is maybe one of those is a small image
and one of those is a full-sized image
and that feedback goes into you might
feed both of them into one note because
it's looking for one thing
and then only into one note for the
other one and so you can start to get
kind of an idea that there's a lot of
use
for this kind of split and this kind of
setup
we have multiple information coming in
but the information is very different
even though it overlaps and you don't
want it to send it through the same
neural network
and they're finding that this trains
faster and is also has a better result
depending on how you split the data up
and you and how you fork the models
coming down
and so in here we do have the two
complex models coming in
we have our image inputs which is a 32
by 32 by three or three channels or four
if you're having an alpha channel
you have your dense your layers dense is
64 activation using the relu very common
x equals dense inputs x layers dense x64
activation equals relu x outputs equals
layers dense 10
x model equals cross model inputs equals
inputs outputs equals outputs name
equals minced model
so we add a little name on there and
again this is this kind of split here
this is setting us up to
have the input go into different areas
so if you're already looking at crust
you probably already have this answer
what are neural networks
but it's always good to get on the same
page and for those people who don't
fully understand neural networks to dive
into them a little bit or do a quick
overview
neural networks are deep learning
algorithms modeled after the human brain
they use multiple neurons which are
mathematical operations
to break down and solve complex mathical
problems
and so just like the neuron one neuron
fires in and it fires out to all these
other neurons or nodes as we call them
and eventually they all come down to
your output layer
and you can see here we have the really
standard graph input layer a hidden
layer and an output layer
one of the biggest parts of any data
processing is your data pre-processing
uh so we always have to touch base on
that with a neural network like many of
these models
they're kind of uh when you first start
using them they're like a black box you
put your data in
you train it and you test it and see how
good it was
and you have to pre-process that data
because bad data in is
bad outputs so in data pre-processing we
will create our own data examples set
with keras the data consists of a
clinical trial conducted on 2100
patients ranging from ages 13 to 100
with a the patients under 65 and the
other half over 65 years of age
we want to find the possibility of a
patient experiencing side effects due to
their age
and you can think of this in today's
world with covid
uh what's going to happen on there and
we're going to go ahead and do an
example of that in our
live hands on like i said most of this
you really need to have hands-on to
understand so let's go ahead and bring
up our anaconda and
open that up and open up a jupiter
notebook for doing the python code in
now if you're not familiar with those
you can use pretty much any of your
setups i just like those for doing demos
and showing people especially
shareholders it really helps because
it's a nice visual so let me go and flip
over to our anacon and the anaconda has
a lot of cool two tools they just added
data lore and ibm watson studio clad
into the anaconda framework
but we'll be in the jupiter lab or
jupiter notebook i'm going to do a
jupiter notebook for this because i use
the lab for like large projects with
multiple pieces because the multiple
tabs where the notebook will work fine
for what we're doing
and this opens up in our browser window
because that's how jupiter helps our
jupiter
notebook is set to run
and we'll go under new
create a new python 3 and it creates an
untitled python we'll go ahead and give
this a title and we'll just call this a
cross
tutorial
and let's change that to capital there
we go i'm going to just rename that
and the first thing we want to go ahead
and do
is uh
get some pre-processing tools involved
and so we need to go ahead and import
some stuff for that like our numpy do
some random number generation
i mentioned sklearn or your site kit if
you're installing sk learn the sk learn
stuff it's a
scikit you want to look up
that should be a tool of anybody who is
doing data science if you if you're not
if you're not familiar with the sklearn
toolkit
it's huge but there's so many things in
there that we always go back to
and we want to go ahead and create some
train labels and train samples for
training our data
and then
just a note of what we're we're actually
doing in here let me go ahead and change
this this is kind of a fun thing you can
do we can change the code to markdown
and then markdown code is nice for doing
examples once you've already built this
our example data we're going to do
experimental
there we go
experimental drug was tested on 2100
individuals between 13 to 100 years of
age
half the participants are under 65 and
95 of participants are under 65
experience no side effects well 95
percent of participants over 65
experience side effects
so that's kind of where we're starting
at and this is just a real quick example
because we're going to do another one
with a little bit more complicated
information and so we want to go ahead
and generate
our setup
so we want to do for i and range and we
want to go ahead and create if you look
here we have random integers
train the labels append so we're just
creating some random data
uh let me go ahead and just run that
and so once we've created our random
data and if you if i mean you can
certainly ask for a copy of the code
from simplylearn they'll send you a copy
of this or you can
zoom in on the video and see how we went
ahead and did our train samples of pin
[Music]
and we're just using this i do this kind
of stuff all the time i was running a
thing on that had to do with errors
following a bell-shaped curve on
a standard distribution error
and so what do i do i generate the data
on a standard distribution error to see
what it looks like and how my code
processes it since that was the baseline
i was looking for in this we're just
doing uh generating random data for our
setup on here
and we could actually go in
print some of the data up let's just do
this print
we'll do
train
samples
and we'll just do the first
five pieces of data in there to see what
that looks like
and you can see the first five pieces of
data in our train samples is 49 85 41 68
just random numbers generated in there
that's all that is and we generated
significantly more than that
um let's see 50 up here 1 000 yeah so
there's 1 000 here 1000 numbers we
generated and we could also if we wanted
to find that out we could do a quick uh
print the length of it
and
so or you could do a shape kind of thing
and if you're using numpy
although the link for this is just fine
and there we go it's actually 2100 like
we said in the demo setup in there
and then we want to go ahead and take
our labels oh that was our train labels
we also did samples didn't we
so we could also print
do the same thing
labels
and let's change this to
and labels
and run that just to double check and
sure enough we have 2100 and they're
labeled one zero one zero one zero
i guess that's if they have symptoms or
not one symptoms zero none and so we
wanna go ahead and take our train labels
and we'll convert it into a numpy array
and the same thing with our samples
and let's go ahead and run that
and we also shuffle
this is just a neat feature you can do
in numpy right here
put my drawing thing on which i didn't
have on earlier
i can take the data and i can shuffle it
uh so we have our so it just randomizes
it that's all that's doing
we've already randomized it so it's kind
of an overkill it's not really
necessary but if you're doing a larger
package where the data is coming in and
a lot of times it's organized somehow
and you want to randomize it just to
make sure that that you know the input
doesn't follow a certain pattern
that might create a bias in your model
and we go ahead and create a scalar uh
the scalar range minimum max scalar
feature range zero to one
uh then we go ahead and scale the uh
scaled train samples so we're gonna go
ahead and fit and transform the data
so it's nice and scaled
and that is the age
so you can see up here we have 49 85 41.
we're just moving that so it's going to
be between 0 and 1. and so this is true
with any of your neural networks
you really want to convert the data
to zero and one otherwise you create a
bias
so if you have like a hundred creates a
bias versus
the math behind it gets really
complicated
if you actually start multiplying stuff
there's a lot of multiplication addition
going on in there
that higher end value will eventually
multiply down and it will have a huge
bias as to how the model
fits it and then it will not fit as well
and then one of the fun things we can do
in jupiter notebook is that if you have
a variable you're not doing anything
with it it's the last one on the line
it will automatically print
and we're just going to look at the
first five samples on here it's just
going to print the first five samples
and you can see here we go 0.9195
0.791 so everything's between 0 and 1.
and that just shows us that we scaled it
properly and it looks good
uh it really helps a lot to do these
kind of print ups halfway through uh you
never know what's going to go on there
i don't know how many times i've gotten
down and found out that the data sent to
me that i thought was scaled was not
and then i have to go back and track it
down and figure it out on there
so let's go ahead and create our
artificial neural network
and for doing that this is where we
start diving into tensorflow and cross
tensorflow
if you don't know the history of
it helps to jump into we'll just use
wikipedia
be careful don't quote wikipedia on
these things because you get in trouble
but it's a good place to start back in
2011 google brain built disbelief as a
proprietary machine learning setup
tensorflow became the open source for it
so tensorflow was a google product
and then it became
open sourced and now it's just become
probably one of the defactos when it
comes for neural networks as far as
where we're at
uh so when you see the tensorflow setup
it it's got like a huge following there
are some other setups like
the scikit under the sk learn has their
own little neural network
but the tensorflow is the most robust
one out there right now
and cross sitting on top of it makes it
a very powerful tool so we can leverage
both the cross
easiness in which we can build a
sequential setup
on top of tensorflow
and so in here we're going to go ahead
and do our input of tensorflow
and then we have the rest of this is all
cross here from number two down uh we're
gonna import from tensorflow the cross
connection
and then you have your tensorflow cross
models import sequential it's a specific
kind of model we'll look at that in just
a second if you remember
from the files that means it goes from
one layer to the next layer to the next
layer there's no funky splits or
anything like that
uh and then we have from tensorflow
cross layers we're gonna import our
activation and our dense layer
and we have our optimizer atom um
this is a big thing to be aware of how
you optimize
your data when you first do it atoms as
good as any atom is usually there's a
number of optimizer out there there's
about there's a couple main ones but
atom is usually assigned to bigger data
it works fine usually the lower data
does it just fine but atom is probably
the mostly used but there are some more
out there and depending on what you're
doing with your layers your different
layers might have different activations
on them and then finally down here
you'll see
our setup where we want to go ahead and
use the metrics
and we're going to use the tensorflow
cross metrics
for categorical cross entropy
so we can see how everything performs
when we're done that's all that is a lot
of times you'll see us
go back and forth between tensorflow and
then scikit has a lot of really good
metrics also for measuring these things
again it's the end of the day at the end
of the story how good does your model do
and we'll go ahead and load all that and
then comes the fun part
i actually like to spend hours messing
with these things
and uh
four lines of code you're like oh you're
gonna spend hours on four lines of code
um no we don't spend hours on four lines
of code that's not what we're talking
about when i say spend hours on four
lines of code uh what we have here i'm
going to explain that in just a second
we have a model and it's a sequential
model if you remember correctly we
mentioned the sequential up here where
it goes from one layer to the next
and our first layer is going to be your
input
it's going to be what they call dents
which is uh
usually it's just dense and then you
have your input and your activation
how many units are coming in we have 16
what's the shape
what's the activation and this is where
it gets interesting
because we have in here
uh relu
on two of these and soft max activation
on one of these
there are so many different options
for
what these mean
and how they function how does the relu
how does the soft max function
and they do a lot of different things um
we're not going to go into the
activations in here that is what really
you spend hours doing is looking at
these different activations
and just
some of it is just
almost like you're playing with it
like an artist you start getting a fill
for like a uh inverse tangent activation
or the 10 h activation
takes up a huge processing amount
so you don't see it a lot
yet
it comes up with a better solution
especially when you're doing when you're
analyzing word documents and you're
tokenizing the words
and so you'll see this shift from one to
the other because you're both trying to
build a better model
and if you're working on a huge data set
you'll crash the system it'll just take
too long to process
and then you see things like soft max
softmax
generates an interesting
setup
where a lot of these when you talk about
rayleigh oops let me do this
rayleigh there we go relu has
a setup where if it's less than zero
it's zero and then it goes up
and then you might have what they call
lazy
setup where it has a slight negative to
it so that the errors can translate
better same thing with soft max it has a
slight laziness to it so that errors
translate better all these little
details
make a huge difference on your model
so one of the really cool things about
data science that i like
is you build your
what they call you build to fail and
it's an interesting uh design setup oops
i forgot the end of my
code here
the concept of build a file is you want
the model as a whole to work so you can
test your model out
so that you can do
you can get to the end and you can do
your let's see where was it
over shot down here
you can test your test out how the
quality of your setup on there
and
see where did i do my tensorflow oh here
we go it was right above me there we go
we start doing your cross entropy and
stuff like that is you need a full
functional set of code so that when you
run it
you can then test your model out and say
hey it's either this model works better
than this model and this is why
and then you can start swapping in these
models and so when i say i spend a huge
amount of time on pre-processing data is
probably 80 of your programming time
well between those two it's like 80 20.
you'll spend a lot of time on the models
once you get the model down once you get
the whole code and the flow down
set
depending on your data your models get
more and more robust as you start
experimenting with different inputs
different data streams and all kinds of
things and we can do a simple model
summary here
here's our sequential here's a layer
output a parameter
this is one of the nice things about
cross is you just you can see right here
here's our sequential one model boom
boom boom boom everything's set and
clear and easy to read
so once we have our model built
the next thing we're going to want to do
is we're going to go ahead
and train that model
and so the next step is of course model
training
and when we come in here this a lot of
times it's just paired with the model
because it's so straightforward
it's nice to
print out the model setup so you can
have a tracking
but here's our model
uh the keyword in cross is compile
optimizer atom learning rate another
term right there that we're just
skipping right over
that really becomes the meat of
[Music]
the setup is your learning rate so
whoops i forgot that i had an arrow but
i'll just underline it
a lot of times the learning rate set to
0.00
set to 0.01
depending on what you're doing
this learning rate can overfit and
underfit uh so you'd want to look up
i know we have a number of tutorials out
on overfitting and underfitting that are
really worth reading once you get to
that point and understanding and we have
our loss
sparse categorical cross entropy
so this is going to tell keras how far
to go until it stops
and then we're looking for metrics of
accuracy so we'll go ahead and run that
and now that we've compiled our model
we want to go ahead and
run it fit it so here's our model fit
we have our scaled train samples
our train labels our validation
split in this case we're going to use 10
percent of the data for validation
batch size another number you kind of
play with not a huge difference as far
as how it works
but it does affect how long it takes to
run and it can also affect the bias a
little bit most of the time though a
batch size is between 10 to 100
depending on just how much data you're
processing in there we want to go ahead
and shuffle it we're going to go through
30 epics
and
put a verb rose of two let me just go
ahead and run this
and you can see right here here's our
epic here's our training
here's our loss now if you remember
correctly up here we set the loss let's
see where was it
compiled our data
there we go loss so it's looking at the
sparse categorical cross entropy
this tells us that as it goes how how
how much
how how much does the um
error go down uh is the best way to look
at that and you can see here the lower
the number the better it just keeps
going down
and vice versa accuracy we want let's
see where's my accuracy
value accuracy at the end
and you can see 0.619 0.69 0.74 it's
going up we want the accuracy would be
ideal if it made it all the way to 1
but we also the loss is more important
because
it's a balance
you can have 100 accuracy and your model
doesn't work because it's over fitted
again you won't look up
overfitting and under fitting models
and we went ahead and went through 30
epics it's always fun to kind of watch
your code going
to be honest i
usually
the first time i run it i'm like oh
that's cool i get to see what it does
and after the second time of running it
i'm like i like to just not see that and
you can repress those of course in your
code
repress the warnings in the printing
and so the next step is going to be
building a test set and predicting it
now uh so here we go we want to go ahead
and build our test set
and we have just like we did our
training set
a lot of times you just split your your
initial set up
but we'll go ahead and do a separate set
on here
and this is just what we did above
there's no difference as far as um
the randomness that we're using to build
this set on here
the only difference is that
we already
did our scalar up here well it doesn't
matter because the the data is going to
be across the same thing but this should
just be just transform down here instead
of fit transform
because you don't want to refit your
data
on your
testing data
there we go now we're just transforming
it because you never want to transform
the test data
easy to mistake to make especially on an
example like this where we're not doing
um you know we're randomizing the data
anyway so it doesn't matter too much
because we're not expecting something
weird
and then we want to go ahead and do our
predictions the whole reason we built
the model is we take our model we
predict
and we're going to do here's our x scale
data batch size 10 verbose
and now we have our predictions in here
and we could go ahead and do a
we'll print
predictions
and then i guess i could just put down
predictions in five so we can look at
the first five of the predictions
and what we have here is we have our
age
and uh the prediction on this age versus
on what is what we think it's going to
be but what we think is going to they
are going to have uh symptoms or not
and the first thing we notice is that's
hard to read because we really want a
yes no answer
uh so we'll go ahead and just
round off the predictions
using the arg max
the numpy arg max for prediction so it
just goes to zero one and
if you remember this is a jupiter
notebook so i don't have to put the
print i can just put in
rounded predictions and we'll just do
the first five
and you can see here zero one zero zero
zero so that's what the predictions are
that we have coming out of this
is no symptoms symptoms no symptoms
symptoms no symptoms
and just as we were talking about at the
beginning we want to go ahead and
take a look at this there we go
confusion matrixes for accuracy check
most important part
when you get down to the end of the
story how accurate is your model before
you go and play with the model and see
if you can get a better accuracy out of
it and for this we'll go ahead and use
the scikit
the sk learn metrics
site kit being where that comes from
import confusion matrix
some iteration tools and of course a
nice map plot library
that makes a big difference so it's
always nice to
have a nice graph to look at a
picture is worth a thousand words
and then we'll go ahead and call it cm
for confusion matrix why true equals
test labels why predict rounded
predictions
and we'll go ahead and load in our cm
and i'm not going to spend too much time
on the plotting
going over the different plotting code
you can spend
like whole we have whole tutorials on
how to do your different plotting on
there
but we do have here is we can do a plot
confusion matrix there's our cm our
classes normalize false title confusion
matrix
c map is going to be in blues
and you can see here we have uh to the
nearest c map titles all the different
pieces whether you put tick marks or not
the marks the classes the color bar
so a lot of different information on
here as far as how we're doing the
printing of the of the confusion matrix
you can also just dump the confusion
matrix into a seaborn and real quick get
an output
it's worth knowing how to do all this uh
when you're doing a presentation to the
shareholders
you don't want to do this on the fly you
want to take the time to make it look
really nice like our guys in the back
did and let's go ahead and do this
forgot to put together our cm plot
labels
we'll go ahead and run that
and then we'll go ahead and call the
little the
definition
for our mapping
and you can see here plot confusion
matrix that's our the little script we
just wrote and we're going to dump our
data into it
so our confusion matrix
our classes
title confusion matrix and let's just go
ahead and run that
and you can see here we have our basic
setup
no side effects 195
had side effects 200
no side effects that had side effects so
we predicted the 10 of them
who actually had side effects and that's
pretty good i mean i don't know about
you but you know that's five percent
error on this and this is because
there's 200 here that's where i get five
percent is
divide these both by by two and you get
five out of a hundred uh you can do the
same kind of math up here
not as quick on the fly because it's 15
and 195 not an easily rounded number but
you can see here where they have 15
people
who predicted to have no
with the no side effects but had side
effects
kind of set up on there and these
confusion matrix are so important at the
end of the day
this is really where where you show uh
whatever you're working on comes up and
you can actually show them hey this is
how good we are or not how messed up it
is
so this was a uh i spent a lot of time
on some of the parts uh but you can see
here is really simple uh we did the
random generation of data but when we
actually built the model coming up here
uh here's our model summary
and we just have the layers on here that
we built with our model on this and then
we went ahead and trained it and ran the
prediction
now we can get a lot more complicated
let me flip back on over here because
we're going to do another uh demo
so that was our basic introduction to it
we talked about the uh oops there we go
okay so implementing a neural network
with keras after creating our samples
and labels we need to create our cross
neural network model we will be working
with a sequential model which has three
layers and this is what we did we had
our input layer our hidden layers and
our output layers and you can see the
input layer coming in
was the age factor we had our hidden
layer and then we had the output are you
going to have symptoms or not
so we're going to go ahead and go with
something a little bit more complicated
training our model is a two-step process
we first compile our model and then we
train it in our training data set
so we have compiling compiling converts
the code into a form of understandable
by machine
we used the atom in the last example a
gradient descent algorithm to optimize a
model and then we trained our model
which means it let it
learn on training data
and i actually had a little backwards
there but this is what we just did is we
if you remember from our code we just
had let me go back here
here's our model that we created
summarized
we come down here and we compile it
so it tells it hey we're ready to build
this model and use it
and then we train it this is the part
where we go ahead and fit our model and
put that information in here and it goes
through the training on there
and of course we scaled the data which
was really important to do and then you
saw we did the creating a confusion
matrix with keras
as we are performing classifications on
our data we need a confusion matrix to
check the results a confusion matrix
breaks down the various
misclassifications as well as correct
classifications to get the accuracy
and so you can see here this is what we
did with the true positive false
positive true negative false negative
and that is what we went over let me
just scroll down here
on the end we printed it out and you can
see we have a nice printout of our
confusion matrix
uh with the true positive false positive
false negative true negative
so the blue ones
we want those to be the biggest numbers
because those are the better side and
then
we have our false predictions on here
as far as this one so had no side
effects but we predicted
let's see no side effects predicting
side effects and vice versa if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
now
saving and loading models with keras
we're going to dive into a more
complicated demo
and you're going to say oh that was a
lot of complication before well if you
broke it down we randomized some data we
created the kara setup we compiled it we
trained it we predicted and we ran our
matrix
so we're going to dive into something a
lot a little bit more fun is we're going
to do a face mask detection with karass
so we're going to build a cross model to
check if a person is wearing a mask or
not in real time and this might be
important if you're at the front of a
store this is something today which is
might be very useful as far as some of
our you know making sure people are safe
and so we're going to look at mask and
no mask and let's start with a little
bit on the data
and so in my data i have with a mask you
can see they just have a number of
images showing the people in masks and
again
if you want some of this information
contact simply learn and they can send
you some of the information as far as
people with and without masks so you can
try it on your own and this is just such
a wonderful example of this setup on
here
so before i dive into the mass detection
uh talk about being in the current with
a covid and seeing if people are wearing
masks
this particular example i had to go
ahead and update to a python 3.8 version
it might run in a 3.7 i'm not sure i
haven't i kind of skipped three seven
and installed three eight
uh so i'll be running in a three python
three eight
and then you also wanna make sure your
tensorflow is up to date
because the um they call functional
layers with that's where they split if
you remember correctly from back
let's take a look at this
remember from here the functional model
and a functional layer allows us to feed
in the different layers into different
you know different nodes into different
layers and split them a very powerful
tool
very popular right now in the edge of
where things are with neural networks
and creating a better model so i've
upgraded to python 3.8 and let's go
ahead and open that up and
go through
our next example which includes
multiple layers
programming it to recognize whether
someone wears a mask or not and then
saving that model so we can use it in
real time so we're actually almost a
full
um end-to-end development of a product
here of course this is a very simplified
version and it'd be a lot more to it
you'd also have to do like recognizing
whether it's someone's face or not all
kinds of other things go into this
so let's go ahead and jump into that
code and we'll open up a new python
three oops
python3 it's working on it there we go
and then we want to go ahead and train
our mask we'll just call this train mask
and we want to go ahead and train mask
and save it
so it's it's uh
save mask train mask detection
not to be confused with masking data a
little bit different we're actually
talking about a physical mask on your
face
and then from the cross standpoint we
got a lot of imports to do here
and i'm not going to dig too deep on the
imports
we're just going to go ahead and notice
a few of them so we have in here oops we
go alt d there we go
i have something to draw with a little
bit here
we have our
image processing
and the image processing right here let
me underline that
deals with how do we bring images in
because most images are like a
a square grid and then each value in
there has three values for the three
different colors
cross and tensorflow do a really good
job of
working with that so you don't have to
do all the heavy listening and figuring
out what's going to go on uh and we have
the mobile net average pooling 2d
this again is
how do we deal with the images and
pulling them uh dropout's a cool thing
worth looking up
if you haven't when you as you get more
and more into cross and tensorflow
it will auto drop out certain notes that
way you'll get a better
the notes just kind of die
and they find that they actually create
more of a bias and help
and they also add processing time so
they remove them
and then we have our flatten that's
where you take that huge array
with the three different colors and you
find a way to flatten it so it's just a
one dimensional array instead of a two
by two by three
uh dense input we did that in the other
one so that should look a little
familiar
oops there we go our input our model
again these are things we had on the
last one
here's our optimizer with our atom
we have some pre-processing on the input
that goes along with bringing the data
in more pre-processing with image to
array loading the image
this stuff is so nice it looks like a
lot of work you have to import all these
different modules in here but the truth
is is it does everything for you you're
not doing a lot of pre-processing you're
letting the software do the
pre-processing
and we're going to be working with the
setting something to categorical
again that's just a conversion from a
number to a category zero one doesn't
really mean anything it's like true
false
label binarizer the same thing uh we're
changing our labels around and then
there's our train test split
classification report
our
i im utilities let me just go ahead and
scroll down here a notch for these
this is something a little different
going on down here this is not part of
the
tensorflow or the sklearn this is the
site kit set up and tensorflow above
the path this is part of
opencv
and we'll actually have another tutorial
going out with the opencv so if you want
to know more about opencv you'll get a
glance on it in
this software especially the second
piece when we reload up the data and
hook it up to a video camera we're going
to do that on this round
but this is part of the opencv thing
you'll see cv2 is usually how that's
referenced
but the im utilities has to do with how
do you rotate pictures around and stuff
like that
uh and resize them and then the matte
plot library for plotting because it's
nice to have a graph tells us how good
we're doing and then of course our numpy
numbers array and just a straight os
access wow so that was a lot of imports
uh like i said i'm not going to spend i
spent a little time going through them
but we didn't want to go too much into
them
and then i'm going to create
some variables that we need to go ahead
and initialize we have the learning rate
number of epics to train for and the
batch size and if you remember correctly
we talked about the learning rate
to the negative 4.0001
a lot of times it's 0.001 or 0.001
usually it's in that
variation depending on what you're doing
and how many epochs and they kind of
play with the epics
the epics is how many times we're going
to go through all the data
now i have it as two
the actual setup is for 20 and 20 works
great the reason i have it for two is it
takes a long time to process
one of the downsides of jupiter
is that jupiter isolates it to a single
kernel so even though i'm on an eight
core processor uh with 16 dedicated
threads only one thread is running on
this no matter what so it doesn't matter
uh so it takes a lot longer to run even
though
tensorflow really scales up nicely and
the batch size is how many pictures do
we load at once in process
again those are numbers you have to
learn to play with depending on your
data and what's coming in and the last
thing we want to go ahead and do is
there's a directory with a data set
we're going to run
and this just has images of mass and not
masks
and if we go in here you'll see data set
and then you have pictures with mess
they're just images of people with mass
on their face
uh and then we have the opposite let me
go back up here
without masks so it's pretty
straightforward they look kind of askew
because they tried to format them into
very similar uh setup on there so
they're they're
mostly squares you'll see some that are
slightly different on here
and that's kind of important thing to do
on a lot of these data sets
get them as close as you can to each
other and we'll we actually will run in
the in this processing of images up here
and the cross layers and importing and
dealing with images it does such a
wonderful job of converting these that a
lot of it we don't have to do a whole
lot with
so you have a couple things going on
there
and so we're now going to be this is now
loading the
images and let me see
and we'll go ahead and create data and
labels here's our
here's the features going in which is
going to be our pictures and our labels
going out
and then for categories in our list
directory directory and if you remember
i just flashed that at you i had
face mask or or no face mask those are
the two options
and we're just going to load into that
we're going to append the image itself
and the labels so we'll just create a
huge array
and you can see right now this could be
an issue if you had more data at some
point
thankfully i have a 32 gig hard drive or
ram
even that
you could do with a lot less of that
probably under 16 or even 8 gigs would
easily load all this stuff
and there's a conversion going on in
here i told you about how we are going
to convert
the size of the image so it resizes all
the images that way our data is all
identical the way it comes in
and you can see here with our labels we
have without mask without mask without
mask
the other one would be with mask those
are the two that we have going in there
and then we need to change it to the one
not hot encoding
and this is going to take our
up here we had was it labels and data
we want the labels to be categorical so
we're going to take labels and change it
to categorical and our labels then equal
a categorical list
we'll run that and again if we do uh
labels and we just do the last or the
first 10 let's do the last 10 just
because
minus 10 to the end there we go
just so we can see where the other side
looks like we now have one that means
they have a mask one zero one zero so on
uh one being they have a mask and zero
no mask
and if we did this in reverse
i just realized that this might not make
sense if you've never done this before
let me run this
zero one
so zero
is uh do they have a mask on zero do
they not have a mask on one so this is
the same as what we saw up here without
mask one equals
the second value is without mass so with
mass without mask
and that's just a with any of your data
processing
we can't really zero if you have a zero
one output
it causes issues as far as training and
setting it up so we always want to use a
one hot encoder if the values are not
actual uh linear value or regression
values they're not actual numbers
if they represent a thing
and so now we need to go ahead and do
our train x test x train y test y
train split test data
and we'll go ahead and make sure it's
going to be random and we'll take 20
percent of it for testing and the rest
for
setting it up as far as training their
model
this is something that's become so cool
when they're training these set
they realize we can augment the data
what does augment mean
well if i rotate the data around and i
zoom in i zoom out i rotate it
share it a little bit flip it
horizontally
fill mode as i do all these different
things to the data it
is able to it's kind of like increasing
the number of samples i have
so if i have all these perfect samples
what happens when we only have part of
the face or the face is tilted sideways
or
all those little shifts cause a problem
if you're doing just a standard set of
data so we're going to create an augment
in our image data generator
which is going to rotate zoom and do all
kinds of cool things and this is worth
looking up this image data generator and
all the different features it has
a lot of times i'll the first time
through my models i'll leave that out
because i want to make sure there's a
thing we call build to fail which is
just cool to know
you build the whole process and then you
start adding these different things in
so you can better train your model and
so we go and run this and then we're
going to load um
and then we need to go ahead and you
probably would have gotten an error if
you hadn't put this piece in right here
um i haven't run it myself because the
guys in the back did this
we take our base model and one of the
things we want to do is we want to do a
mobile net v2
and this what we this is a big thing
right here include the top equals false
a lot of data comes in with a label on
the top row
so we want to make sure that that is not
the case
and then
the construction of the head of the
model that will be placed on the top of
the base model
we want to go ahead and set that up
and you'll see a warning here i'm kind
of ignoring the warning because it has
to do with the
uh size of the pictures and the weights
for input shape
um so they'll switch things to defaults
just saying hey we're going to auto
shape some of this stuff for you you
should be aware that with this kind of
imagery we're already augmenting it by
moving it around and flipping it and
doing all kinds of things to it
so that's not a bad thing in this but
another data it might be if you're
working in a different domain
and so we're going to go back here and
we're going to have we have our base
model we're going to do our head model
equals our base model output
and what we got here is we have an
average pooling 2d pool size 77 head
model
head model flatten
so we're flattening the data
so this is all
processing and flattening the images and
the pooling has to do
with some of the ways it can process
some of the data we'll look at that a
little bit when we get down to the lower
levels processing it
and then we have our dents we've already
talked a little bit about a dense just
what you think about and then the head
model has a drop out
of 0.5
what we can do with a dropout
the dropout says that we're going to
drop out a certain amount of nodes while
training
so when you actually use the model
it will use all the nodes but this drops
certain ones out and it helps
stop biases from forming so it's really
a cool feature in here they discovered
this a while back
we have another dense mode this time
we're using soft max activation lots of
different activation options here soft
max is a real popular one for a lot of
things
and so is a relu
and you know there's we could do a whole
talk on activation formulas
and why what their different uses are
and how they work
when you first start out you'll you'll
use mostly the relu and the softmax for
a lot of them
just because they're some of the basic
setups it's a good place to start
and then we have our model equals model
inputs equals base model dot input
outputs equals head model so again we're
still building our model here we'll go
ahead and run that
and then we're going to loop over all
the layers in the base model and freeze
them so they will not be updated during
the first training process
so for layer and base model layers
layers dot trainable equals false
a lot of times when you go through your
data
you want to kind of jump in part way
through
i i'm not sure why in the back they did
this for this particular example
but i do this a lot when i'm working
with series and specifically in stock
data i wanted to iterate through the
first set of 30 data before it does
anything
i would have to look deeper to see why
they froze it on this particular one
and then we're going to compile our
model
so compiling the model atom
init layer decay
initial learning rate over epics
and we go ahead and compile our loss is
going to be the binary cross entropy
which we'll have that print out
optimizer for opt metrics is accuracy
same thing we had before not a huge jump
as far as
the previous code
and then we go ahead and we've gone
through all this and now we need to go
ahead and fit our model
so train the head of the network print
info training head run
now i skipped a little time because it
you'll see the run time here is at 80
seconds per epic takes a couple minutes
for it to get through on a single kernel
one of the things i want you to notice
on here while we're well it's finishing
the processing
is that we have up here our augment
going on so anytime the train x and
trading y go in
there's some randomness going on there
and it's jiggling it around what's going
into our setup
uh of course we're batch sizing it so
it's going through whatever we set for
the batch values how many we process at
a time
and then we have the steps per epic
the train x the batch size validation
data here's our
test x and test y where we're sending
that in
and this again it's validation
one of the important things to know
about validation is
our
when both our training data and our test
data have about the same accuracy that's
when you want to stop that means that
our model isn't biased
if you have a higher accuracy on your
testing
you know you've trained it and your
accuracy is higher on your actual test
data then something in there is probably
has a bias and it's over fitted
so that's what this is really about
right here with the validation data and
validation steps
so it looks like it's let me go ahead
and see if it's done processing looks
like we've gone ahead and gone through
two epics again you could run this
through about 20
with this amount of data and it would
give you a nice refined model at the end
we're going to stop at 2 because i
really don't want to sit around all
afternoon and i'm running this on a
single thread
so now that we've done this we're going
to need to evaluate
our model and see how good it is and to
do that we need to go ahead and make our
predictions
these are predictions on our test x
to see what it thinks are going to be so
now it's going to be evaluating the
network and then we'll go ahead and go
down here
and we will need to
turn the index in because remember it's
it's either 0 or 1 it's a
0 1 0 one so you have two outputs uh not
wearing uh wearing a mask not wearing a
mask
and so we need to go ahead and take that
argument at the end and change those
predictions to a
zero or one coming out
and then
to finish that off we want to go ahead
and let me just put this right in here
and do it all in one shot we want to
show a nicely formatted classification
report so we can see what that looks
like on here
and there we have it we have our
precision uh it's 97 with the mask
there's our f1 score support without a
mass 97 percent
um so that's pretty high
set up on there you know you three
people are going to sneak into the store
who are without a mask and
thinks they have a mask and there's
going to be three people with a mask
that's going to flag the person at the
front to go oh hey look at this person
you might not have a mask
that's if i guess it's just set up in
front of a store
so there you have it and of course one
of the other cool things about this is
if someone's walking in to the store and
you take multiple pictures of them
um
you know this is just an it would be a
way of flagging and then you can take
that average of those pictures and make
sure they match or don't match if you're
on the back end and this is an important
step because we're gonna this is just
cool i love doing this stuff uh so we're
gonna go ahead and take our model and
we're gonna save it
so model save mass detector.model we're
going to give it a name
we're going to save the format
in this case we're going to use the h5
format
and so this model we just programmed has
just been saved
so now i can load it up into say another
program what's cool about this is let's
say i want to have somebody work on the
other part of the program well i just
saved the model they upload the model
now they can use it for whatever and
then if i get more information
and we start
working with that at some point
i might want to update this model and
make a better model and this is true of
so many things where i take this model
and maybe i'm running a prediction on
making money for a company and as my
model gets better
i want to keep updating it and then it's
really easy just to push that out to the
actual end user
uh here we have a nice graph you can see
the training loss and accuracy as we go
through the epics
we only did the you know only shows just
the one epic coming in here but you can
see right here as the
value loss train accuracy and value
accuracy
starts switching and they start
converging and you'll hear converging
this is the convergence they're talking
about when they say you're you're
i know when i work in the
scikit with sk learn neural networks
this is what they're talking about a
convergence is our
loss and our accuracy come together and
also up here and this is why i'd run it
more than just two epochs as you can see
they still haven't converged all the way
so that would be a cue for me to keep
going
but what we want to do is we want to go
ahead and create a new
python 3
program
and we just did our train mask so now
we're going to go ahead and import that
and use it and show you in a live action
get a view of both myself in the
afternoon along with my background of an
office which is in the middle still of
reconstruction for another month
and we'll call this a mask
detector
and then we're going to grab a bunch of
a few items coming in
uh we have our
mobile net v2 import pre-processing
input so we're still going to need that
we still have our tensorflow image to
array we have a load model that's where
most of the stuff's going on
this is our cv2 or opencv again i'm not
going to dig too deep into that we're
going to flash a little open cv code at
you
and we actually have a tutorial on that
coming out our numpy array our im
utilities which is part of
the opencv or cv2 setup
and then we have of course time and just
our operating system so those are the
things we are going to go ahead and set
up on here and then we're going to
create
this takes just a moment
our module here which is going to do all
the heavy lifting uh so we're going to
detect and predict the mask we have
frame face net mass net
these are going to be generated by our
open cv we have a frame coming in and
then we want to go ahead and create a
mask around the face it's going to try
to detect the face
and then set that up so we know what
we're going to be processing through our
model
and then there's a frame shape here this
is just our height versus width that's
all hw stands for
they've called it blob which is a cv2
dnn blob form image frame
so this is reformatting this frame
that's going to be coming in literally
from my camera and we'll show you that
in a minute that little piece of code
that shoots that in here
and we're going to pass the blob through
the network and obtain the face
detections
so face net dot set import blob
detections face net forward
print detections shape
uh so these is this is what's going on
here this is that model we just created
we're going to send that in there and
i'll show you in a second where that is
but it's going to be under face net and
then we go ahead and initialize our list
of faces their corresponding locations
and the list of predictions from our
face mass network
we're going to loop over the detections
and this is a little bit more work than
you think
as far as looking for different faces
whatever the view of a crowd of faces
um so we're looping through the
detections and the shapes going through
here
and probability associated with the
detection here's our confidence of
detections
we're going to filter out weak detection
by ensuring the confidence is greater
than the minimum confidence
so we've said it remember 0 to 1 so 0.5
would be our minimum confidence probably
is pretty good
[Music]
and then we're going to put in compute
bounding boxes for the object if i'm
zipping through this it's because we're
going to do an open cv and i really want
to stick to just the cross part
and so i'm just kind of jumping through
all this code you can get a copy of this
code from simply learn and take it apart
or look for the opencv coming out
and we'll create a box the box sets it
around the image
ensure the bounding boxes fall within
the dimensions of the frame
uh so we create a box around what's
going to what we hope is going to be the
face extract the face roi convert it
from bgr to rgb channel
again this is an open cv issue not
really an issue but it has to do with
the order i don't know how many times
i've forgotten to check the order colors
when working with opencv
because there's all kinds of fun things
when red becomes blue
and blue becomes red
and we're going to go ahead and resize
it process it frame it
face frame
setup again the face the cbt color we're
going to convert it
we're going to resize it
image to array pre-process the input
pin the face locate face start x dart y
and x boy that was just a huge amount
and i skipped over a ton of it but the
bottom line is we're building a box
around the face
and that box because the opencv does a
decent job of finding the face and that
box is going to go in there and see hey
does this person have a mask on it
uh
and so that's what that's what all this
is doing on here and then finally we get
down to this where it says predictions
equals mass net dot predict faces batch
size 32.
uh so these different images of where
we're guessing where the face is are
then going to go through and
generate an array of faces if you will
and we're going to look through and say
does this face have a mask on it and
that's what's going right here is our
prediction that's the big thing that
we're working for
and then we return the locations and the
predictions the location just tells
where on the picture it is
and then the
prediction tells us what it is is it a
mask or is it not a mask
all right so we've loaded that all up
so we're going to load our serialized
face detector model from disk um
and we have our the path that it was
saved in obviously you're going to put
it in a different path depending on
where you have it or however you want to
do it and how you saved it on the last
one where we trained it
then we have our weights path
and so finally our face net here it is
equals cb2.dnn.readnet
prototextpath weights path and we're
going to load that up on here so let me
go ahead and run that
and then we also need to i'll just put
it right down here i always hate
separating these things in there
and then we're going to load the actual
mass detector model from disk this is
the the model that we saved so let's go
ahead and run that on there also so this
is pulling on all the different pieces
we need for our model
and then the next part is we're going to
create open up our video
and this is just kind of fun because
it's all part of the opencv
the video set up
and we just put this all in as one
there we go
so we're going to go ahead and open up
our video we're going to start it and
we're going to run it until we're done
and this is where we get some real like
kind of live action stuff which is fun
this is what i like working about with
images and videos
is that when you start working with
images and videos it's all like right
there in front of you it's visual and
you can see what's going on
so we're going to start our video
streaming this is grabbing our video
stream source zero start
that means it's grabbing my main camera
i have hooked up
and then you know starting video you're
going to print it out
here's our video source equals 0 start
loop over the frames from the video
stream
oops a little redundancy there um let me
close
i'll just leave it that's how they
headed in the code so uh so while true
we're going to grab the frame from the
threaded video stream and resize it to
have the maximum width of 400 pixels so
here's our frame we're going to read it
from our visual
stream
we're going to resize it
and then we have we're returning
remember we return from the our
procedure the location and the
prediction so detect and predict mask
we're sending it the frame
we're sending it the face net and the
mast net so we're sending all the
different pieces that say this is what's
going through on here
and then it returns our location
predictions and then for our box and
predictions in the location and
predictions
and the boxes is again this is an open
cv set that says hey this is a box
coming in from the location
because you have the two different
points on there and then we're going to
unpack the box and predictions and we're
going to go ahead and do mask without a
mask equals prediction
we're going to create our label
no mask and create color if the label
equals mask l0 l0225
and you know it's going to make a lot
more sense when i hit the run button
here
but we have the probability of the label
we're going to display the label and
bounding box rectangle in the output
frame
and then we're going to go ahead and
show the output from the frame cv2 i am
show frame frame and then the key equals
cp2 weight key one we're just going to
wait till the next one comes through
from our feed
and we're going to do this until we hit
the stop button pretty much
so you're ready for this to see if it
works we've distributed our our model
we've loaded it up into our distributed
uh code here we've got a hooked into our
camera and we're going to go ahead and
run it
and there it goes it's going to be
running and we can see the data coming
down here and we're waiting for the
pop-up
and there i am in my office with my
funky headset on
and you can see in the background my
unfinished wall and it says up here no
mask oh no i don't have a mask on
i wonder if i cover my mouth
what would happen
you can see my no mask
goes down a little bit i wish i brought
a mask into my office it's up at the
house but you can see here that this
says you know there's a 95 98 percent
chance that i don't have a mask on and
it's true i don't have a mask on right
now and this could be distributed this
is actually an excellent little piece of
script that you could start you know you
install somewhere on a video feed on a
on a security camera or something and
then you'd have this really neat setup
saying hey do you have a mask on when
you enter a store or
public transportation or whatever it is
where they're required to wear a mask
let me go ahead and stop that
now if you want a copy of this code
definitely give us a hauler we will be
going into opencv in another one so i
skipped a lot of the opencv
code in here as far as going into detail
really focusing on the cross
saving the model uploading the model and
then processing a streaming video
through it so you can see that the model
works we actually have this working
model that hooks into the video camera
which is just pretty cool a lot of fun
so i told you we're going to dive in and
really roll up our sleeve and do a lot
of coding today we did the basic
demo up above for just pulling in across
and then we went into a cross model
where we pulled in data to see whether
someone was wearing a mask or not so
very useful in today's world as far as a
fully running application sequential
models in keras
so what is cross
cross is a high level python deep
learning api
which is used for easy implementation of
neural networks it has multiple
low-level back-ends like tensorflow
fano
pi torch etc which are used for fast
computation
so you can think of this as cross being
almost its own little programming
language and then it sits on neural
networks in this case uh the ones listed
were tensorflow thano and pytorch which
can all integrate with the cross model
this makes it very diverse and also
makes it very easy to use and switch
around with different things
cross is very
user friendly as far as neural network
software goes as a high level api
computational graphs
so computational graphs are really the
heart and soul of neural networks
we talk about a computational graph
they are a visual representation of
expressing and evaluating mathematical
equations
the nodes and data flow in a graph
correspond to mathematical operations
and variables
you'll hear a lot
some of the terms you might hear are
node and edge the edge being the data
flow in this case
it could also represent an actual value
they have
oh i think in spark they have a graph x
which works just on computing edges
there's all kinds of stuff that has
evolved from computational graphs we're
focusing just on cross and on neural
networks so we're not going to go into
great detail on everything a
computational graph does
it is the core component of a neural
network is what's important to know on
this
so cross offers a python user-friendly
front-end while maintaining a strong
computation power by using a low level
api
like tensorflow pi torch etc which use
computational graphs as a back end
so one this allows for abstraction of
complex problems while specifying
control flow
if you've ever looked at some of the
backend or the original versions of
tensorflow
it's really a nightmare you have all
these different settings you have to put
in there and create
it's a lot a lot of back in programming
this is like the old computers when you
had to
tell it how to dispose of a variable and
how to properly re-allocate the memory
for use
all that is covered nowadays in our
higher level programming well this is
the same thing with
is it covers a lot of this stuff and
does things for you that you could spend
hours on just trying to figure out
it's useful for calculating derivatives
by using back propagation
we're definitely not going to teach a
class on derivatives
in this little video
but understanding
a derivative is the rate of change so if
you have a particular function you're
using in your neural network
a lot of them is just simple
y equals mx plus b
your euclidean geometry where you just
have a simple slope times the intercept
and they get very complicated they have
the inverse tangent function for
activation as opposed to just a linear
euclidean model and you can think about
this as you have your data coming in and
you have to alter it somehow
well you alter it going down to get an
answer you end up with an error and that
error goes back up and you have to have
that back propagation with the
derivative you want to know how it
changed so that you can figure out how
to adjust it for the error
a lot of that's hidden so you don't even
have to worry about it with cross and in
today's cross it'll even if you create
your own
formula for computing an answer it will
automatically compute the back prop the
the derivative for you in a lot of cases
it's easier to implement distributed
computation
so cross is really nice way to package
it and get it off on different computers
and share it and it allows parallelism
which means that two operations can run
simultaneously
so as we start developing these
back-ends it can do all kinds of cool
things and utilize multiple cores gpus
on a computer to get that parallel
processing up
what are neural networks
well like i said there are already we've
talked about in computational edges you
have a node and you have a connection or
your edge so neural networks are
algorithms fashioned after the human
brain which contain multiple layers each
layer contains a node called a neuron
which performs a mathematical operation
they break down complex problems into
simple operations
so one an input layer takes in our data
and pre-processes it
when we talk about pre-processing when
you're dealing with neural networks you
usually have to pre-process your data so
that it's between
-1 and one or zero and one
um into some kind of value that's usable
that occurs before it gets to the neural
network
in fact eighty percent of data science
is usually in prepping that data and
getting it ready for your different
models
two you have hidden layer performs a
non-linear transformation of input
now it can do a hidden a linear
transformation it can use just a basic
euclidean geometry and you could think
of a node adding all the different
connections coming in
so each connection would have a weight
and then it would add to that weight
plus an intercept in the note itself so
you can actually use euclidean geometry
but a lot of these get really
complicated they have all these
different formulas and they're really
cool to look at but when you start
looking at them look at how they work
you really don't need to know the high
math behind it
to figure them out and figure out what
they're doing
which is really cool that means a lot of
people can use this without having to go
get a phd in mathematics
number three the output layer takes the
results from hidden layer transform them
and gives a final output
so sequential models
so what makes this a sequential model
sequential models are linear stacks of
layers where one layer leads to the next
it is simple and easy to implement and
you just have to make sure that the
previous layer is the input to the next
layer
so you have used for plain stack of
layers where each layer has one input
and one output tensor and this is what
tensorflow is named after is each one of
these layers is like a tensor each each
node is a tensor and the layer is also
considered a tensor of values
and it's used for simple classifier
declassifier models you can it's also
used for regression models too so it's
not just about
this is something this is a teapot this
is a cat this is a dog
it's also used for generating
regret the actual values you know this
is worth ten dollars that's worth thirty
dollars uh the weather is going to be 90
degrees out or whatever it is so you can
use it for both classifier and
declassifier models
and one more note when we talk about
sequential models the term sequential is
used a lot and it's used in different
areas and different notations when
you're in data science so when we talk
about time series we'll talk about
sequential that is something very
different sequential in this case means
it goes from the input to layer 1 to
layer 2 to the output so it's very
directional
it's important to note this because if
you have a sequential model can you have
a non-sequential model and the answer is
yes
if you master the basics of a sequential
model you can just as easily have
another model that shares layers
you can have another model where you
have an input coming in and it splits
and then you have one set that's doing
one set of nodes maybe they're doing a
yes no kind of node where it's either
putting out a 0 or a 1 a classifier and
the other one might be regression it's
just processing numbers and then you
recombine them for the output
that's what they call across the cross
api
so there's a lot of different
availabilities in here and all kinds of
cool things you can do as far as
encoding and decoding and all kinds of
things and you can share layers and
things like that
we're just focusing on the basic cross
model with the sequential model
so let's dive into the meat of the
matter let's do and do a demo on here
uh today's demo in this demo we'll be
performing flower classification using
sequential model and cross and we'll use
our model to classify between five
different types of flowers
now for this demo and you can do this
demo on whatever platform you want or
whatever
user interface for developing python
i'm actually using anaconda and then i'm
using jupyter notebooks to develop in
and if you're not familiar with this you
can go under environment once you've
created environment you can come in here
to open a terminal window
and if you don't have the different
modules in here you can do your conda
install whatever module it is
just happened that this particular setup
didn't have a seaborn in it which i
already installed
so here's our anaconda and then i'm
going to go back
and start up my jupiter notebook
where i already created a new
python project python 3 i'm in python
3.8 on this particular one
sequential model for flowers
so lots of fun there
so we're going to jump right into this
the first thing is to make sure you have
all your modules installed
so if you don't have uh numpy pandas
matplot library and seaborn in the cross
an sklearn or site kit it's not actually
sklearn you'll need to go ahead and
install all of those
now having done this for years and
having switched environments and doing
different things
i get all my imports done and then we
just run it and if we get an error we
know we have to go back and install
something
right off the bat though we have numpy
pandas matplot library seaborn these are
built on top of each other panda's a
data frame and built on top of numpy the
data array
and then we bring in our sk learn or
scikit this is the site kit setup sci
kit
even though you use sklearn to bring it
in it's the site kit and then our cross
we have our pre-processing the images
image data generator
our model this is our basic model or
sequential model
and then we bring in from cross layers
import dents
optimizers
these optimizers a lot of them already
come in these are your different
optimizers and it's almost a lot of this
is so automatic now
atom
is the a lot of times the default
because you're dealing with a large data
and then we get our sgd which is uh
smaller data does better on smaller
pieces of data
and i'm not going to go into all of
these uh different optimizers we didn't
even use these in the actual demo you
just have to be aware that they are
different optimizers and the digger the
more you dig into these models
you'll hit a point where you do need to
play with these a little bit but for the
most part leave it at the default when
you're first starting out
and we're doing just the sequential
you'll see here layers dense
and then if we come down a little bit
more when they put this together and
they're running the dense layers you'll
also see they have drop out they have
flattened they have activation
they have the convolutional
layer 2d max pooling 2d
batch normalization
what are all these layers and we get to
the model we're going to talk about them
a lot of times when you're just starting
you can just
import cross dot layers and then you
have your dropout your flatten
your convolutional
neural network 2d
and we'll we'll cover what these do
in the actual example when we get down
there
what i want you to take from here though
is you need to run your imports
and load your different aspects of this
and of course your tensorflow tf because
this is all built on tensorflow
and then finally import random is rn
just for random
generation and then we get down here we
have our
cv2
that is your
open image or your opencv they call it
for processing images that's what the
cvd2 is
uh we have our tqdm
the tqdm is for uh it's a progress bar
just a fancy way
of adding when you're running a process
you can view the bar going across in the
jupiter
setup not really necessary but it's kind
of fun to have
we want to shuffle some files
again these are all different things
pill is another
image processor it goes with the cv2 a
lot of times you'll see both of those
and so we run those we've got to bring
them all in
and the next thing is to set up our
directories
and so we come into the directories
there's an important thing to note on
here other than we're looking at a lot
of flowers which is fun
uh
as we get down here we have our
directory
archive flowers that just happens to be
where the different
files for different flowers are put in
we're denoting an x and a z
and the x is the date of the image and
the z is the tag for it what kind of
flower is this
and the image size is really important
because we have to re-size everything if
you have a neural network and if you
remember from our neural networks uh let
me flip back to that slide
we look at this slide we have two input
nodes here with an image you have an
input node
depending on how you set it up for each
pixel and that pixel has three different
color schemes usually in it sometimes
four so if you have a picture that's 150
by 150
you multiply 150 times 150 times three
that's how many nodes input layers
coming in i mean so this is a massive
input a lot of times you think oh yeah
it's just a small amount of data or
something like that
no it's a full image coming in and then
you have your hidden layers a lot of
times they match what the image size is
coming in so each one of those is also
just as big and then we get down to just
a single output
so that's kind of a thing to note in
here what's going on behind the scenes
and of course each one of these layers
has a lot of processes and stuff going
on
and then we have our different uh
directories on here let me go and run
that so i'm just setting the directories
that's all this is
archive flowers daisy sunflower tulip
dandelion rose
just our different directories that
we're going to be looking at
uh and then we want to go ahead and we
need to assign labels remember we
defined x and z
so we're just going to create a
definition here
and the first thing is a return flower
type okay
it just returns it what kind of flower
it is i guess a sign label to it
but we're going to go ahead and make our
train data
and when you look at this there's a
couple things to take away from here the
first one is we're just appending right
onto our numpy array the image
we're going to let numpy handle all that
different
aspects as far as 150 by 150 by three
we just dump it right into the numpy
which makes it really easy we don't have
to do anything funky on the processing
and we want to leave it like that and
i'm going to talk about that in a minute
and then of course we have to have the
string a pin the label on there and i
want you to notice right here we're
going to read the image in
and then we're going to size it and this
is important because we're just changing
this to 150 by 150 we're resizing the
image so it's uniform every image comes
in identical to the other ones
this is something that's so important is
when you're resizing or reformatting
your data you really have to be aware of
what's going on
with
images it's not a big deal because with
an image you just resize it so it looks
squishy or spread out or stretched
the neural network picks up on that and
it doesn't really change how it
processes it
so let's go ahead and run that
and now we've got our definition set up
on there
and then we want to go ahead and make
our
training data
so make the train data
daisy flower daisy directory print
length of x so here we go let's go ahead
and run that
and we're just loading up the flower
daisy so this is going all in there and
it's setting
it's adding it in to the our setup on
there
to our x and z setup
and we see we have 769
um and then of course you can see this
nice bar here this is the bar going
across is that little added
code in there that just makes it really
cool for doing demos
not necessarily
when you're building your own model or
something like that but if you're going
to display this to other people
adding that little what was it called
tqdm i can never remember that but the
tqdm module in there is really nice and
we'll go ahead and do sunflowers and of
course you could have just
created an array of these
but this has an interesting problem
that's going to come up and i want to
show you something
it doesn't matter how good the people in
the back are how good you are
programming
errors are going to come up and you got
to figure out how to handle them
and so when we get all the way down to
the
where is it dandelion here's our
dandelion directory we're going to build
jupiter has some cool things it does
which makes this really easy to deal
with
but at the same time you want to go back
in there depending on how many times you
rerun this how many times you pull this
so when you're finding errors
uh going in here there's a couple things
you can do and we're just gonna um oh it
wasn't there it is there's our error i
knew there was an error
this processed
1062 out of 1065
now i can do a couple things one i could
go back into our definition
and i can just put in here try and so if
it has a bad conversion this is where
the error is coming from
uh just skip it that's one way to do it
um
when you're doing a lot of work in data
science and you look at something like
this where you're losing three points of
data at the end you just say okay i lost
three points who cares
or you can go in there and try to delete
it
it really doesn't matter for this
particular demo
and so we're just going to leave that
error right along and skip over because
it's already added all the other files
in there and this is a wonderful thing
about jupiter notebook
is that i can just continue on there and
the x and z which we're creating
is still
running and we'll just go right into the
next flower rose so all these flowers
are in there
that's just a cool thing about jupiter
notebook
and then we can go ahead and just take a
quick look
and see
what we're dealing with and this is of
course really when you're dealing with
the other people and showing them stuff
this is just kind of fun where we can
display it on the plot library here
and we're just going to go through and
let's see what we got here
uh looks like
we're going to do like five of each of
them i think
is that how they set this up um
plot library five by two okay oh i see
how they did it okay so two each so we
have five by two set up on our axes and
we're just going to go in and look at a
couple of these flowers
it's always a good thing to look at some
of your data
no matter what you're doing
we've reformatted this to 150 by 150
you can see how it really blurs this one
up here on the tulip
that is that resize to 150 by 150.
and these are what's actually going in
these are all 150 by 150 images you can
check the dimensions on the side
and you can see just a quick sampling of
the flowers we're actually going to
process on here and again like i said at
the beginning most of your work in data
science is reprocessing
this different information so we need to
go ahead and take our labels
and run a label encoder on there
and then we're just going to let's label
encoder one of the things we imported
and then we always use the fit
to categorical y comma five x here's our
array
x so if you look at this here's our fit
we're going to transform z
that's our z array we created
and then we have y which equals that and
then we go ahead and do to categorical
we want five different categories
and then we create our x
in p array of x x equals x over 255.
so what's going on here there's two
different transformations one we've
turned our categories into
0 1 2 3 4 5 as the output
and we have taken our x array
and remember the x array is three values
of your different colors
this is so important to understand when
we do this across a numpy array this
takes every one of those three colors so
we have 150 by 150 pixels
out of those 150 by 150 pixels they each
have three
um color arrays and those color arrays
range from 0 to 250. so when we take the
x equals x over 255
i'm sorry range from 0 to 255.
this converts all those pixels to a
number between 0 and 1.
and you really want to do that when
you're working with neural networks
now if you do a linear regression model
it doesn't affect it as much and so you
don't have to do that conversion if
you're doing straight numbers but when
you're running neural networks if you
don't do this you're going to create a
huge bias and that means they'll do
really good on predicting one or two
things and they'll just totally die on a
lot of other predictions
so now we have our
x and y values
x being the data in y being our known
output
and with any good setup we want to
divide this data into our training
so we have x train
we have our x test this is the data
we're not going to program the model
with
and of course your y train corresponds
to your x train and your y test
corresponds to your x test the outputs
and this is uh when we do the train test
split this was from the site kit sklearn
we imported train test split and we're
just going to go ahead and do the test
size at about a quarter of the data 0.25
and of course random's always good
this is such a good tool i mean
certainly you can do your own division
um
you know you can just take the first you
know 0.25 of the data or whatever do the
length of the data not real hard to do
but this is randomized so if you're
running this test a few times you can
kind of get an idea whether it's going
to work or not
sometimes what i will do is i'll just
split the data into three parts
and then i'll test it on two with one
being the uh or i train it on two of
those parts with one being the test and
i rotate it so i come up with three
different answers which is a good way of
finding out just how good your model is
but for setting up let's stick with the
x train x test and the sk learn package
and then we're going to go ahead and do
a random seed
now a lot of times the cross actually
does this automatically but we're going
to go ahead and set it up on here and
you can see we did an np random seed
from 42 and we get a nice rn number
and then we do tf random we set the seed
so you can set your randomness at the
beginning of your tensorflow and that's
what the
tf.random.set is
so that's a lot of prep
all this prep and then we finally get to
the exciting part this is where you
probably spend once you have the data
prepped and you have your pipeline going
and you have everything set up on there
this is the part that's exciting is
building these models
and so we look at this model one we're
going to designate a sequential um they
have the api which is across the cross
tensorflow api versus sequential
sequential means we're going one layer
to the next so we're not going to split
the layer and bring it back together it
looks almost the same with the exception
of
bringing it back together so it's not a
huge step to go from this to an api
and the first thing we're going to look
at is
our convolutional neural network in 2d
so what's going on here there's a lot of
stuff that's going on here
um the default for well let's start with
the beginning what is a convolutional 2d
network
well convolutional 2d network creates a
number of small windows and those small
windows float over the picture
and each one of them is their own neural
network and this basically
becomes like a
a categorization and then it looks at
that and it says oh if we add these
numbers up a certain way
uh we can find out whether this is the
right flower based on this this little
window floating around which looks at
different things
and we have filters 32 so this is
actually creating 32 windows is what
that's doing
and the kernel size is five by five so
we're looking at a five by five square
remember it's 150 by 150 so this narrows
it down to a 5x5 it's a 2d so it has
your xy coordinates
and we look at this 5x5 remember each
one of these is is actually looking at 5
by 5 by 3.
so we're actually looking at 15 by 15
different
pixels
and padding is just
usually just ignore that
activation by default is relu we went
ahead and put the relu in there
there's a lot of different activations
relu is for your smaller uh
when you remember i mentioned atom when
you have a lot of datum data use an atom
kind of activation or using atom
processing
we're using the relu here
it kind of gives you a yes or no but it
it doesn't give you a full yes or no it
has a
zero and then it kind of shoots off at
an angle
very common it's the most common one and
then of course here's our input shape
150 by 150 by three pixels
and then we have to pool it so whenever
you have a two convolutional 2d
layer we have to bring this back
together and pull this into a neural
network and then we're going to go ahead
and repeat this
so we're going to add another network
here
one of the cool things if you look at
this is that it as it comes in it just
kind of automatically assumes you're
going down to the next layer
and so we have another convolutional
null network 2d
here's our max pooling again we're going
to do that again max pooling
and we're just going to filter on down
now one of the things they did on this
one is they changed the kernel size they
changed the number of filters and so
each one of these steps
kind of looks at the data a little bit
differently
and that's kind of cool because then you
get a little added filtering on there
this is where you start playing with the
model you might be looking at a
convolutional neural network which is
great for image classifications
we get down to here one of the things we
see is flattened so we add we just
flatten it remember this is 150 by 150
by three
well and actually
the pool size changes so it's actually
smaller than that flattened just puts
that into a 1d array
so instead of being
you know a tensor of this really
complexity with the the pixels and
everything is just flat
and then the dense
is just another activation on there
by default it is probably relu
as far as its activation
and then oh yeah here we go in
sequential they actually added the
activation as relu so this just because
this is sequential this activation is
attached to the dents
uh and there's a lot of different
activations but relu is the most common
one and then we also see a soft max
soft max
is similar
but it has its own kind of variation
and one of the cool things you know what
let me bring this up because if we if
you don't know about these activations
this doesn't make sense
and i just did a quick google search on
images of tensorflow activations
um i should probably look at which set
website this is
but this is the output of the values uh
so as your x as it adds in all those uh
weighted x values going into the node
it's going to activate it a certain way
that's a sigmoid activation and you can
see it goes between 0 and 1 and has a
nice curve there this also shows the
derivatives
if we come down the seven popular
activation functions non-linear
activations there's a lot of different
options on this let me see if i can find
the
[Music]
oops let's make sure we can find the
specific to relu
so this is a leaky relu
and you can see instead of it just being
zero and then a value between going up
it has a little leaky there otherwise
your relu loses some nodes they just
become inactive
but you can see there's a lot of
different options here here's a good one
right here with the rayleigh you can see
the rayleigh function on the upper on
the upper left here and then the leaky
railway over here on the right which is
very commonly used also
one of the things i use with processing
um
language is the sig is the exponential
one
or the tangent h the hyperbolic tangent
because they have that nice uh funky
curve that comes in that has a whole
different meaning and captures word use
better
again these are very specific to domain
and you can spend a lot of time
playing with different models
for our basic model we'll stick to the
relu and the softmax on here and we'll
go ahead and run and build this model
so now that we've had fun playing with
all these different models that we can
add in there
we need to go ahead and have a batch
size on here
epochs 10
this means that we're going to send 128
rows of data or flowers at a time to be
processed
and the epics 10 that's how many times
we're going to loop through all the data
and then there's all kinds of stuff you
can do again this is now built into a
lot of cross models already by default
so there's different ways to reduce the
values and
verbose verbose equals one means that
we're going to show what's going on
value the monitor what we're monitoring
we'll see that as we actually train the
model this is what's what's going to
come out of there if you set the verbose
equal to 0
you don't have to watch it train the
model
although
it is kind of nice to actually know
what's going on sometimes
and since we're still working on
bringing the data in here's our batch
side here's our epics we need to go
ahead and create a data generator
this is our image data generator
and it has all the different settings in
here almost all of these are defaults so
if you're looking at this going oh my
gosh this is confusing
most the time you can actually just
ignore most of this
vertical flip so you can randomly flip
pictures you can randomly horizontally
flick them
you can shift the picture around this
kind of helps gives you multiple data
off of them
zooming rotation there's all kinds of
different things you can do with images
most of these we're just going to leave
as false we don't really need to do all
that
setup because we already have a huge
amount of data
if you're short data you can start
flipping like a horizontal picture and
it will generate it's like doubling your
data almost
so the upside is you double your data
the downside is that if you already have
a bias in your data you already have
[Music]
5 000 sunflowers and only two roses
that's a huge bias it's also going to
double that bias
that is the downside of that
and so we have our model compile and
this you're going to see in all the
cross we're going to take this model
here
we're going to take all this information
as far as how we want it to go and we're
going to compile it
this actually builds the model and so
we're going to run that
and i want you to notice uh
learning rate
very important this is the default 0 0
1.
there's there you really don't this is
how
slowly it adjusts to find the right
answer
and the more data you have you might
actually make this a smaller number
with larger with you have a very small
sample of data you might go even larger
than that
and then we're going to look at the loss
categorically categorical cross entropy
most commonly used
and this is uh how how much it improves
the model is improving is what this
number means or yeah that's that's
important on there and then the accuracy
we want to know just how good our model
is on the accuracy
and then
one of the cool things to do is if
you're in a group of people who are
studying the model if you're in
shareholders you don't want to do this
is you can run the model summary
i do this by default and you can see the
different layers that you built into
this model just a quick summary on there
so we went ahead and we're going to go
ahead and create a
we'll call it history but we want to do
a model fit generator
and so what this history is doing is
this is tracking what's going on as
while it fits
the model
now there's a lot of new setups in here
where they just use fit and then you put
the generator in here
we're going to leave it like this even
though the new default
is a little different on that
doesn't really matter does the same
thing and we'll go ahead and just run
that
and you can see while it's running right
here uh we're going through the epics we
have one of ten now we're going through
six to 25.
here's our loss we're printing that out
so you can see how it's improving and
our accuracy the accuracy gets better
and better and this is 6 out of 25 this
is going to take a couple minutes to
process
because we are training 150 by 150 by 3
pixels across
six layers or eight layers whatever it
was
that is a huge amount of processing so
this will take a few minutes to process
this is when we talk about the hardware
and the problems that come up in data
science and why it's only now just
exploding being able to do neural
networks this is why this process takes
a long time
now you should have seen a jump on the
screen here because i did
pause the recorder to let this go ahead
and run all the way through its epics
let's go ahead and take a look and see
what these epics are and if you set the
verbose to
zero instead of one it won't show what's
going on in the behind the scenes as
it's training it
so we look at this epic tin epic so we
went through all the data 10 times
if i remember correctly there's roughly
a gig of data there so that's a lot of
data
the first thing you're going to notice
is the
270 seconds
that's how much each of those epics took
to run
and so if you divide
60 in there you roughly get about five
minutes worth of each epic so if i have
10 epics that's 50 minutes almost an
hour of run time
that's a big deal we talk about
processing uh in on this particular
computer
i actually have what is it uh
eight cores with 16 dedicated threads so
it runs like a 16 core computer it
alternates the threads going in
and it still takes it five minutes for
each one of these epics so you start to
see that if you have a lot of data
this is going to be a problem if you
have a number of models you want to find
out how good the models are doing and
what model to use
and so each of those models could take
all night to run in fact i have a model
i'm running now that takes over
it takes about a day and a half to test
each model
it takes four days to do with the whole
data
so what i do is i actually take a small
piece of the data
test it out to find out
get an idea of how the different setups
are going to do
and then i increase that size of the
data and then increase it again and i
can just take that that curve and kind
of say okay if the data is doing this
then i need to add in more dense layers
or whatever
so you can do a small chunks of data and
then figure out what it costs to do a
large set of data and what kind of model
you want
the loss as we see here continues to go
down
this is the error this is how much error
is in there it really isn't a
user-friendly number other than
the more it trends down the better and
so if you continue to see the loss going
down
eventually get to the point where it
stops going down and it goes up and down
and kind of wavers a little bit at that
point you know you've run too many epics
you're starting to get a bias in there
and it's not going to give you a good
model fit
the accuracy just turns us into
something that uh we can use
and so the accuracy is what percentage
of guesses in this case is categorical
so this is the percentage of guesses are
correct
um value loss is similar you know it's a
minus a value loss
and then you have the value accuracy and
you'll see the value accuracy is pretty
similar to the accuracy um just rounds
it off basically and so a lot of times
you come down here and you go okay we're
doing point five point six
point 0.7 and that is 70 accuracy or in
this case 68.59
accuracy that's a very usable number and
it's very important to have
if you're identifying flowers that's
probably good enough if you can get
within a close distance in knowing what
flower you're identifying
if you're trying to figure out whether
someone's going to die from a heart
attack or not you might want to rethink
it a little bit or re-key how you're
building your model
so
if i'm working with a
a group of
clients
shareholders in a company or something
like that
you don't really want to show them this
you don't want to show them hey you know
this is what's going on with the
accuracy these are just numbers and so
we want to go and put the finishing
touches just like when you are building
a house and you put in the frame and the
trim on the house it's nice to have
something a nice view of what's going on
and so we'll go ahead and do a pie plot
and we'll just plot the history of the
loss
the history of the
value loss
over here
epics train and test and so we're just
going to compute these
this is really important and what i want
you to notice right here
is when we get to about oh
five epics a little more than five six
epics you see a cross over here
and it starts crossing as far as the
value loss and what's going on here is
you have the loss in your actual model
and your actual data and you have the
value loss where it's testing it against
the the test data the data wasn't used
to program your model it wasn't used to
train your model on
and so when we see this crossing over
this is where the bias is coming in this
is becoming over fitted and so when you
put these two together uh right around
five and six you start to see how it
does this this switch over here and
that's really where you need to stop
right around five yeah six
um
it's always hard to guess because at
this point the model is kind of a black
box
uh see but you know that right around
here if you're saving your model after
each run you want to use the one that's
right around five epics because that's
the one that's going to have the least
amount of bias so this is really
important as far as guessing what's
going on with your model and its
accuracy and when to stop
it also is you know i don't show people
this mess up here um i show somebody
this kind of model i say this is where
the training and the testing comes in on
this model
it just makes it easier to see and
people can understand what's going on
so that completes our demo and you can
see we did what we were set out to do we
took our flowers and we were able to
classify them uh within about you know
68 70 accuracy whether it's going to be
a dahlia sunflower cherry blossom rose
a lot of other things you can do with
your output as far as a
different tables to see
where the errors are coming from and
what problems are coming up
companies across the globe are
generating data at a rapid rate and data
science is helping them draw valuable
insights and make business decisions
hello everyone welcome to this video
tutorial on data science interview
questions
in this video we will learn some of the
important questions that are often asked
in any data science interview
we'll discuss questions related to
various aspects of data science such as
programming sql mathematics statistics
linear algebra and probability
finally we'll get an idea about the top
machine learning and deep learning
interview questions that are frequently
asked in interviews so let's begin
hi everyone
welcome to this live session by simply
learn today we are going to talk about
some of the essential programming
interview questions for a data scientist
role
now since python is widely used
programming language for data science
machine learning and deep learning we
will be solving our problems in the
python programming language using
jupyter notebook
so let's wait for a few minutes for
people to join in
also if you haven't subscribed to our
channel yet then please make sure to
subscribe to it now and stay updated
with all the recent trending
technologies
and if you want to get the code file
that we will use in this session then
please put your email id in the chat
section of the video our team will share
the interactive ipython notebook with
you
so let's begin with our first question
our first question is
how do you get a list of all the keys in
a dictionary
now in python for data science data
structures play an important role to
store and manipulate data
dictionary is one such data structure
that is declared using curly braces and
they are written as key value pairs
you can see on the screen i have my
dictionary called d
and it is assigned using curly braces
now to get a list of all the keys in a
dictionary we use the dot keys function
now let me take you to my jupyter
notebook so here is my jupyter notebook
and you can see my first cell i have my
dictionary defined
so the name of the dictionary is d
and
it has the key values the keys are the
country names and the values are
the capitals of each country so i have
india and the capital is new delhi then
i have usa
the capital is washington
similarly i have spain madrid and we
have germany and berlin
now
india usa france spain all these are my
keys so to get the keys i'll use the dot
keys function so i'll write my
dictionary name that is d
dot
i'll give keys
close the brackets and hit shift enter
you can see these are the list of my
keys
in the dictionary d
all right
okay
now let's move to our next question
so our next question is
what do you mean by list comprehension
in python
so list comprehensions are a sort and
easy way to define and create new lists
based on existing lists
so suppose you want to iterate through a
list and find all the even numbers in
the list you can either use a for loop
and an if condition as
shown here or you can write a list
comprehension to do it in one line of
code you can see this is my list
comprehension
so let me show you both the ways
all right so here on my jupyter notebook
let me declare my list as l equal to
i'll pass in a few numbers let's say 5
comma 12
we have 14
9 and let's see the last element in the
list is 6
all right let me run this
list
okay
now
let me create an empty list let's say
list1
and let this be an empty list
with square brackets
then
i'll use the looping construct to find
the
even elements in the list so i'll write
a for loop called
for
item in
my list l
i'll give
colon then i'll give my condition if
item
percentage
2 is equal to equal to 0 which means if
the remainder is 0
then
i'll
append the items
to my empty list which is list1 so i'll
write list1 dot append
and i'll pass in
the argument my item now
let me go ahead and
print my list
i'll write print
the
final list
using a
for loop
i'll give colon
give a comma
and pass in my new list name which is
list1
now let's run this
you can see
using this for loop and the if condition
i have got all the even elements in my
list which was l you can see my original
list
and
12 10 14 and 6 where all the even
numbers present in my list now this task
you can do it using list comprehensions
as well
so let me show you how to do that
so i have my list
defined let me just copy this here
i'll paste it
and now
i'll create another variable which is
list 1
i'll write equal to
now here
using square brackets i'll write
item
for
item in
l
and i'll give my if condition as if
item
percentage
is equal to equal to 0
then
i'll print my resultant list so i'll
write print
let's say
resultant
list
using
list comprehension
i'll give a colon
then a comma and i'll pass in my new
list which is list
so here
whatever is there
in my square brackets
is called the list comprehension
technique
let me just print this
and i'll get the same result so these
are my even numbers
all right
so let's move to the third question so
our third question is
given a list of numbers find the squares
of the numbers using the map function in
python
now the map function calls the specified
function for each element of an iterable
and returns a result
so let me show you
an example to find out squares of a list
of numbers using the map function
okay
so let's first define a function called
square so i'm using my def keyword and
i'll
pass in my user defined function name as
square
and i'll give my parameter as x
and
i want to return
the square of x which is
x
star
all right
and then
let me define
my list of numbers
so i'll
pass in a variable called num and let's
say i want to find the squares of
five numbers one two three comma four
comma five
here
i'll pass in another variable which will
store the resultant list
so i'll write
num underscore
squared
equal to
here i'll use my map function
so map function takes in two parameters
first it will take in
the user defined function name which is
square here
and
the list of numbers which is num
i'll run a for loop i'll write for let
me just scroll down
i'll write for
num in
num underscore squared
print
num
so this is my map function
so
it will map all the elements in the list
to this function which is square
i'll just print it
you can see
we have the list of squares from the num
list which has
the elements 1 2 3 4 and 5.
now moving ahead
coming to our fourth question
the fourth question is on to write a
program that will filter out the numbers
divisible by 3 from a tuple using the
lambda functions
so lambda functions are anonymous
functions that are not defined by the
def keyword in python
so here you can see i have the example
so this is a tuple i have defined and
using filter along with the lambda
function i am trying to find out the
numbers that are divisible by 3 and
finally i am printing those numbers so
let's do it on our jupyter notebook
all right so we are on the jupyter
notebook so first
i'll define a tuple
let's say
the variable name is my underscore top
which stands for my tuple
and
using brackets i'll pass in my double
values let's say 5
we have 43 9
11 and let's say six
so you can see
these are the numbers present in my
tuple
now
i'll create
another variable called new tuple
and i'll use my tuple
function and inside the tuple function
i'll use the filter function that will
filter out only the values
that are divisible by 3
and now i'll write my lambda function
so notice this clearly
how to use a lambda function i'll use
the keyword
lambda
and then
i'll pass in a variable x
now this
should consider only those values
that are divisible by 3 so i'll write x
percentage 3 should be equal to equal to
and
i'll give
my tuple
as the variable here
all right
now we have declared our lambda function
let's just go ahead and print my new
tuple which is new underscore tup
so here you can see i have my
double function
inside the tuple function i'll use my
filter function that will filter only
those values divisible by 3
and to filter those values i have used
my lambda function here and passed in my
original tuple which is my tuple
it's actually my tup so let's delete the
last two letters
let's just go ahead and print this
there you go you can see we have 12 18 9
and 6 are the only numbers that are
divisible by 3 from this tuple
moving to the next question
so our next question is how to create a
data frame from a dictionary
now to create a data frame from a
dictionary you can use the pandas
library and the dot data frame function
now pandas is a popular library in
python that is used for data
manipulation
so let me show you
how you can create an employee
dictionary and then convert that into a
data frame
okay
so here on my jupyter notebook let me go
ahead and import my pandas library so
i'll write import
pandas as
pd
and
next let's create my
employee dictionary so i'll write emp
which stands for employee
and
and within curly braces i'll give my key
value pairs
so my first column would be the name of
the employee
and
let's pass in a list of employee names
i'll write ami
let's say we have
angela
the third employee's name let's say we
have
samuel
and
let dany be our fourth employee
i'll give a comma
now the second attribute in our
dictionary will be the age of the
employee
so my key would be age
and let's create a list of
age values
i am assigning random values to those
employee
age
30 and let's say 32
and let's create another
variable called
city
here variable refers to the column name
of the data frame
let's say ami is from new york
then we have
angela from chicago
let's say
samuel is from boston
and we have
danny from let's say seattle
okay
so if i run this i have my employee
dictionary created
so if you want to see the dictionary you
can write print and pass
the variable name which is emp here
so this is my dictionary
now to convert this dictionary into a
data frame you can simply write df
and
you can give the pandas library
as pd and use the data frame function
so i'll write
data frame
and
i'll pass in my dictionary name which is
emp here
let's run it
okay so we have successfully created our
data frame now let me just print the
data frame i'll write df
there you go you can see i have a nice
table here which is actually a data
frame
here you can see the indices
and you can see our column names as name
age and city and these are the
values or the rows all right
now let's see the sixth question we have
so the question is
what is the difference between
loc and iloc in python
now as data scientists you would often
want to analyze a chunk of data and not
all the rows in it
so loc and iluc functions can help you
fetch specific rows and columns from
your data frame
loc function uses row or column labels
to select and slice data from a data
frame
while iloc uses integer index to select
specific rows and columns remember iloc
stands for index location
i'll use a card data frame to show how
loc and iloc works
now on your screens you can see the data
frame
so it has a column called brand which
has different brand name such as ford
this hyundai tata mahindra this maruti
the sky motors
then we have
the year in which the car was
manufactured
we have the number of kilometers the car
has run
we have the city and the mileage the car
gives
so let me first create this data frame
on my jupyter notebook
okay so here on my notepad i have my
code written to create the data frame
that is car i'll just copy this code and
i'll paste it
to this cell
okay let me just run it
if i go on top you can see we have
successfully created our car data frame
now let me go ahead and print this data
frame so i'll write print
in brackets i'll give my data frame scar
let me run it all right so here is my
data frame
now suppose you want to see the data
from second row till the fifth row for
brand and city columns so you can use
the loc function so i want my data from
the second row till the fifth row for
brand and city columns so let me show
you how to do that
so first i'll write my data frame name
that is car and then i'll give my
function as loc
and
within brackets i'll give my
row index values so i'll give from two
to five which is second row to fifth row
and
i'll give my
column names as
brand
you give a comma
and my second column which i want is
city
so here
i'm using the
labeled beast indexing
let me just run it there you go you can
see we have the information available
for
the second row third row fourth row and
the fifth row
all right
similarly let's see one more example for
index location based
slicing
so suppose you want to see the data from
second
third and fourth row for year kilometers
and city columns so for that you can use
the iloc function
so i want the value for
second third and fourth row
and the columns that i want are years
kilometers and the city column
so for
that i'll give my data frame name as car
dot this time i'll use iloc
and within
square brackets i'll give my
row values
and the column values
now one thing you should notice here is
if you use iloc python
will exclude the last index which is the
fifth row and similarly here it will
exclude the
last index from the column which is the
fourth column
if i run this
you get the desired result
now
let's see another example let's say this
time i want to print the rows that have
mileage less than 25 for brand and city
columns
so you can use a print function
and i'll pass in my data frame as car
and use
luc
here
i'll give my condition as
car
and i want my condition that is mileage
should
be less than 25
and
i want
the brand name
so i'll use a square bracket and give my
brand column
and i also want the city column
okay
let me
close it
if you run this
now these are the brand names renault
tata and kia which have
mileage less than 25 let me just verify
this
you can see all these values are less
than 25
similarly you can use the
iloc function as well
i can write print
i'll give car dot iloc
within square brackets i'll give
car
and my
condition column is mileage
now this should be less than 25
i'll use
dot
values
and
then i'll give my
column numbers as 0 comma 2
let me run it
there you go
the same result we have got it using
iloc function this time
and you can see the columns were 0 comma
2 which means we wanted the
first column which is brand
and the second column which was
kilometers
all right
now moving to our seventh question in
the list of questions that we have
the question is how is list dot append
different from list dot extend
now list dot append adds its arguments
as a single element to the end of the
list
the length of the list increases by one
here
and list dot extend iterates over its
arguments and adds each element to the
list the length of the list increases by
the number of elements in its arguments
so let me show you
the difference
on my jupyter notebook
okay
so let's create a list called list one
equal to
i'll create a list let's say it has some
country names like
india
then we have
usa
and i'll consider one more country let's
say
canada
okay
now let me print the length of this list
also
i'll use the length function for that
all right
now
let me append one more list so i'll use
the append function
i'll write list one dot append
and
within
brackets i'll give my new list which has
two more country names let's say
france and
spain
okay
and here let me print
list one
and let's also print the length of the
list again
i'll use the length function
and my list name which is list1
so just mark we are using append here
let me run this
there you go
so here you can see
my original list had three elements
since the length is three now when i
appended this new list which had two
elements
france and spain
our size increased by one and the length
of the new list is four
now
let me just copy this code
and
instead of append let me write extend
so that we can see the difference
between append and extend
so scroll down
run it
here you can see
our original list had three elements
but after we extended our
list with two more elements the length
of the new list became five so these are
the
five elements in the list
and here you can see
there were total four elements in the
list
when we appended the new list
okay
now moving to our eighth question
suppose you have a car data set which
has a mileage column
you need to create a new field called
mlg
that will accept two
values if mileage is less than 25 then
the value should be low mlg
and if the mileage is greater than or
equal to 25 then the mileage should be
high mlg or the value should be high mlg
now while analyzing data data scientists
often need to create extra columns in
the data frame to add more values that
will help you make your data analysis
more efficient
so this question is related to one such
instance or one such idea
so here
you can see
my data set
it has the brand name year kilometers
city and the mileage column
now if mileage is less than 25 i'll add
the value low mlg to my new column else
if mileage is greater than or equal to
25 i'll add high mlg to my new column
so here you can see
my final output
wherever the mileage is less than 25 it
should print low mlg else it should
print high mlg and now let's do this on
my jupyter notebook
so we'll use lambda functions that we
learnt earlier to perform this task
i'll write a function let's say f is
equal to
you can call this as a function or a
variable
i'll
give the keyword lambda and
use x as my
parameter
now x should be
low mlg
if
x is less than 25 which is mileage here
else
if it's not less than 25 it should
return high mlg
now what i'll do is
i'll give my
data frame scar
and i'll create my new column that is
mlg
then i'll write
equal to
car dot
i'll give my
column name from the original data frame
which is mileage
and i use my apply function
and pass in the variable f
now let's just print this
data frame
if i run it
you can see the output here we have
created a new column which is mlg you
can see our new column name was mlg
and
these are the results so
for renault tata and kia for the last
three rows
since the mileage is less than 25 it
returned
low mlg for the remaining it gave us
high mlg
now moving to the ninth question
so this is our next question we want to
create a 4 cross 4 matrix and find the
sum of all the diagonal elements in the
matrix
data scientists often work with multiple
dimensional arrays or multi-dimensional
arrays and matrices to build models this
question is related to an operation on a
4 cross 4 matrix so first we need to
create an array which will be a numpy
array of 4 cross 4
shape
and then we'll see how to calculate the
diagonal elements
or the sum of the diagonal elements
so i am on my jupiter notebook
first let's import the numpy library so
i'll write import
numpy or numpy as np
let me run it
ok
now
i'll create my 4 cross 4 trick so i'll
write
m is equal to
np dot
array
and i'll create my 4 cross 4 matrix
let's see the values are 1 2 3 4 in the
first row
and in the second row i'll pass 5 comma
6 comma 7 comma 8.
in the third row we'll have
9 10 and 11
also 12
and finally we'll have
14 15 and 16
the fourth row
i'll just run it
now if i print m
you can see this is a 4 cross 4 matrix
so this is one way of creating a 4 cross
4 matrix which is a bit tedious and
lengthy
instead of that you can also use a range
function
so if i write m is equal to
np dot
a range function
and here i will give my values starting
from 1 till
17 so this will actually exclude 17 and
take from 1 to 16.
and i'll give my
shape
as 4 comma 4
let me print it
there you go it has printed the exact
same matrix that we saw above
all right
now to print the diagonal elements we'll
use the diagonal function
so i'll write print
m dot
diagonal
let me just run it
so 1 6 11 and 16 are my diagonal
elements you can see this matrix
6 11 and 16 are my diagonal elements
now to print the sum of all the diagonal
elements i'll use the sum function
so i'll write m dot
diagonal
along with that i'll pass my sum
function
if i run it
so the sum of 1 6 11 and 16 is 34.
okay
so coming to the last question on this
interesting session on programming
interview questions for data scientists
our question is
given a vehicle data frame find the
average and maximum mileage of the
vehicles using pandas
so here
data scientists use statistical measures
to analyze their data so it is important
to have knowledge of the statistical
functions in python
here is my vehicle data set
and for each brand of vehicle we want to
find the average and the maximum mileage
so let me show you how to do it
okay so here on the notepad i have my
code written
to create the vehicle data frame i'll
just copy it
and paste it on this cell
you can see
we have the brand column the year column
kilometers city mileage
here you can see the different
brand of vehicles let me just create
this data frame first and
let me go ahead and print the
vehicle data frame so i'll write vehicle
and run it
so here is the data frame
now
i want to find the average and maximum
mileage for
each of the brands
so for this we'll use the group by
function and the aggregate function that
is available in the pandas library of
python
so let me show you how to do it
i'll give
a variable
called result
and then i'll use my
data frame name as
vehicle
followed by the group by function
i'll write group by
and since i want to
check for all the brands so i'll group
all the
brand of vehicles
then i'll use an aggregate function
which is eg
and
within curly braces i'll give my column
as mileage
i'll give a colon
and pass in
mean which is for average
and i'll use max to find the maximum
mileage
now
let's print it i'll write print
i'll give
a message as the
average
and
maximum
mileage
of
vehicles
let me just print the result
i'll run it
you can see it has resulted in an error
the reason is
in vehicle the v is capital
if i run it
there you go here you can see on the
left we have the brand names
we have hyundai this maruti and tata
because those were the only three brand
of vehicles we had
and for each brand you can see
the mean mileage and the maximum mileage
for maruti it was
26.33
and the maximum mileage is 28 similarly
you can see for
tata vehicle as well hello everyone
welcome to this live session by simply
loan
in our previous session we looked at
some of the important python programming
questions for data scientists today we
will learn some of the crucial sql
interview questions for data scientists
now if you want to get the sql script
file that we are going to use in this
demo then please put your email ids in
the chat section our team will send the
sql file via email
sql is a widely used language for
querying data from databases
it allows you to store retrieve
manipulate and update data present in
the form of rows and columns
data scientists often work with
structured data that is stored in mysql
databases microsoft sql servers oracle
databases or even nosql databases such
as mongodb
today
we will look at a variety of sql
questions
we'll be using the mysql database for
our demo throughout the video we'll be
using mysql workbench and the mysql
command line to solve the sql queries
let me show you the database that we
will be using for this demo and the
tables we are going to use
okay so here i am on my sql workbench
and below you can see i have a local
instance created i'll just click on it
now it's asking me to enter the password
i'll give my password
and hit ok
now this will take me to
the sql editor
now this is the sql workbench so let me
first create a new
sql query file
all right
so first and foremost
let me show you the databases we have
for that i'll use the command so
databases
if i hit tab it will auto complete
i'll give a semicolon
and hit control enter to run this there
you go
here you can see the list of databases
that we already have
and
from the list of databases we are going
to use
the sql underscore iq database
so to use this database i'll write the
command
use
sql underscore
iq
i'll give a semicolon
i'll select this
and i'll click on this execute button
if i run this
you can see
now i'm using sql underscore iq database
now if you want to see all the tables
present in sql underscore iq database
we'll use the following command so i'll
write show
tables
now this will list all the tables
present inside sql underscore iq
database if i run it
you can see here it has executed
successfully and it has given us seven
rows which means we have a total of
seven tables
in this database you can see there's an
author table there's a table called
books we have customers email
employee players and weather table so
all these tables we are going to use in
the course of this video
now if you want to
have a look at
the data present in one of the tables
you can just use the select statement so
i'll write select star from let's say i
want to see
the data present inside
the employee table so i'll write
employee
so this is my table name i give a
semicolon if i select this
hit the execute button
there you go
it shows me
that it has returned six rows
and
these are
the column names we have the name of the
employee the age of the employee we have
the employee's salary and the employee
id
so there are total six employees in the
table
all right
now i can do the same operations on my
sql command line as well now let me open
the command line first
okay so this is the mysql command line
client it is asking me to enter the
password so i'll give my password first
all right now here you can see i have
come inside mysql now the operations
that we performed on
the mysql workbench the same operations
can be performed on the command line as
well
so i'll write
use
sql underscore
iq
i'll hit enter
you can see the message it says database
changed now if you want to
display the tables present inside this
database i can use
show tables command
i have to give a semicolon and hit enter
there you go you can see the list of
tables we have inside the database
now if you want to
have a look at the content of one of the
tables i can just write select star from
let's say players
if i give a semicolon hit enter
you can
see the rows and columns in the data set
all right
and with that
let's move on to our first question on
sql
okay
so our question is what is the
difference between where and having
clause in sql
so where clause is used to filter the
records based on the specified condition
while the having clause is used to
filter the records from groups based on
specified conditions you need not worry
we'll do the demo for
wherein having clause
using the employee table
so where clause cannot have aggregate
functions
such as count sum min or maximum
having clause can operate on aggregate
functions
now where clause is implemented on rows
while having clauses implemented on
columns now let me show you an example
of how a where clause is different from
an having clause
so i'll
take you to my
mysql workbench
all right so we are on the sql workbench
so suppose
i want to get the records of the
employees whose age is greater than 30
for this i can use a where clause
so since i want to get the employees
whose age is greater than 30 i'll use a
where clause i'll write my
sql query as select
star
from
employee
where i'll write age
is greater than
30.
if i give a semicolon and
run this
it will return all the employees
whose age is greater than 30 you can see
36 36 and 35
these are the employees whose age is
greater than 30.
now
i have intentionally kept some
duplicate rows because we are going to
use this in our next questions
again i can also do the same task using
the having clause so let me just copy
this
query
i'll paste it here
now instead of where
i'll write having
so you will see
that even this query will return the
same result if i run it you can see it
gives me the same result
now
let's say i want to find all the records
where the count of age for all the
employees is greater than 1.
in this case i can't use a where clause
it will throw me an error since where
clause cannot be used with aggregate
functions so let's
try using an aggregate function
in the where clause so i'll write select
star from
employee
where
count of age
is greater than one
so the idea is to find all the records
where the count of age for all the
employees is greater than one
so if i run this
sql query you can see
it has given me an error it says invalid
use of group function
now instead we need to use a having
clause along with the group by clause to
solve the problem
so i'll group all the age values and
then find the count of each each value
so let me just
paste this
and here
i'll edit my sql query
instead of where i'll write having
and
just after the table name i'll use the
group by clause
so i'll write group by each
now let's run it
all right you can see
our sql query has returned only those
employees
whose age occurs more than once
now let me just verify this if i
run my
employee table
you can see angela's age that is 36 has
has been repeated twice you can see
angela here as well and similarly we
have
mic also repeated
twice
all right
now let's see the second question
now this is a multiple choice question
where you need to answer the correct sql
query based on the question
so the question is
the correct sql query to select all the
records of employees with ari in the
names is
so we have a list of four options given
and out of that you need to find the
correct option
now
the answer to this question is
this
so if you write select star from the
table name which is employ here
where
name like
then if you give this condition it will
return
all the records where employees have ari
in their names
now like is an operator in sql that is
used to search a specified pattern
so here our pattern is we want all those
employees who have eri in their names
the first percentage means that the name
can have any number of letters in the
beginning followed by eri in the middle
and the last percentage means the name
can have any number of letters in the
end
so let's
do this on our my sequel workbench
let me first display all the employees
in the table so i'll write
select star from
employee
i'll run this
if you see my table
i have one employee who has
ari in its name
and that person is karen
i now want to get this particular record
so what i can do is
i'll write a select query select star
from
employee
where
name
then i'll use the like operator where
name like
within double quotes
i'll give
percentage
ari
again a percentage close the double
quotes and give a semicolon if i run
this you can see
my sql query will return only karen
now let's do one more example
suppose
i want to find the employee whose name
starts with d
so
the way to do is something similar to
what we saw
just now
so
here in my condition
i'll just
replace this with d
this means
the name should start with d
and after that it can contain any number
of letters
now let's run it
there you go
so our table had one employee called
dany whose name started with d
now moving to our third question
so the question is we want to write a
query to find the players with the least
number of goals
so there are two methods to do it
one where you can use
a sub query and the other method to use
the limit operator so let me show you
both the methods
first let me go ahead and display all
the tables present
in my database that is sql or sql
underscore iq
all right if i scroll down you can see
we have
a table called players so i'm going to
use the players table to find the player
with the least number of goals
so
let me show you
the first method that is by using a sub
query
so i'll write select
star
from my table name which is
players
where
goals
equal to
and in this
i'll write my sub query using
brackets so i'll select
minimum goals
from
the table that is players
i'll close the bracket
and then i'll give a semicolon
now let me go ahead and run this
you can see
matt was the player from scotland who
scored
the least number of goals that is three
now let's
break it down so what we did was
first
my sql query
found out what was the minimum goal
scored by
a player so if i run this
you will see it will return me 3 so 3
was the least number of goals scored by
one of the players
now
in my outer query
what sql did was it searched for
those goals
where the value was equal to 3 so we
wrote select star from players where
goals equal to 3
hence
if i run this
you will find the player who scored only
3 goals
and that player is matt
all right
now the other way to do is using the
limit operator
so this is more simpler than the
previous method
i can write select star from players
order by
goals
now let me first run
this sql statement
if i run this
you can see
we have ordered this in ascending order
so the person who has scored
the least number of goals appears
at the top
and the person with the or the player
with the highest number of goals appears
at the bottom
and from this table i only want the
first row and for that i can use the
limit operator so if i write limit
it will display only the first row
if i run it
you can see it shows me only the record
for mat
moving ahead now let's see the fourth
question in our list
the question
is write the sql query to find the
player with the second highest number of
goals
now again there are two methods to do it
one is by using
limit and offset and the other method is
to use a sub query so let's see both the
methods
i'll first
write my sql query using limit and
offset
so
my query will be select
star from
players
order by
goals
descending
let me just run this
all right so here you can see
my table has been ordered
in descending order of goals so anthony
has scored the most number of goals then
comes daniel followed by sam
and
at the end we have matt who scored the
least number of goals
now out of this i want the player who
scored the second highest number of
goals which is daniel
so i want my sql query to return
this row that has player id 103
name is daniel
country is england and goals is 7.
for that
mysql has
two features
so i can use
limit 1
followed by
offset
one
so what
this query does is
it will offset
one row that is it is going to offset
the first row or it is going to skip the
first row and then print only the second
row because i have set my limit to 1 so
let me just run it
you will see
we get the desired result the player
name is daniel and the number of goals
scored is
7. now the other method to do is using a
sub query now let me write my sub query
first i'll write my outer query which is
select
star from
and here i'll write my sub query select
star
from
players
order by
my column name which is goals
in descending order
here i'll limit it to
then i'll give my alias name as
t
then i'll use
order by
goals
limit
one
let me just run it first
if i run this
you see here i get the same result
now let's first break it down
i'm going to run this sub query first so
here i have
select star from players
order by goals
descending and limit is to
let me just run it
so the selected sql query returns
the first two rows
ordered by goals
and
if you see here clearly
we have again ordered
the value returned
in ascending order which means
from this table
if i order this table in ascending order
daniel should appear first
and out of that i am limiting my
result to 1 so it will print only daniel
if i run this again you can see i have
the desired output
now let's check the fifth question in
our list
given the below email table
write a sql query to find the distinct
domain names from the email column so if
you consider this as my email table the
domain names are gmail.com yahoo.in and
we have hotmail.com these are the
distinct domain names
now to solve this task
again we have two methods either you can
use the substring underscore index
function or you can use the substring
function
now the substring underscore index
function returns a substring of a given
string before a specified number of
delimiters
so let me first use the first method
okay so here on my
sql workbench i'll write
select
i'll use
the keyword that is dextent
then i'll use my function which is
substring underscore index
here
substring underscore index will take
three parameters
the first is the original column name
which is email
followed by the delimiter i am looking
for that is at the rate so i'll put at
the rate with single quotes since it is
a text or a character and then
i'll give the number of times to search
for the delimiter here it is going to be
-1
so you can either give
a positive value or a negative value if
it is a positive number
then this function will return all
to the left of the delimiter
if it is a negative number the function
returns all to the right of the
delimiter
all right
and then i'll give an alias name as
say domain name
from my table that is email
if i run this
you can see i have the list of all
unique domain names or distinct domain
names that we saw in our table
this is one of the ways
the other way is to use the substring
function
now the substring function extracts the
substring from a string starting at any
position
so
let me write my sql query
i'll write select
dextent
i'll then give my function as substring
here substring will take in two
parameters
the first parameter is the column name
which is email id here so i'll write
email
i'll give a comma
next
i want to find my delimiter so for that
i'm going to use another function called
locate
and here i want to locate the index
position of at the rate
so i want to
give my delimiter as add the rate
followed by the column name which is
email
and then
i want to fetch everything after the
delimiter and for that i am giving plus
one
again let me give a domain name as the
alias name
from
email
if i run this
you will see will get all the unique
domain names
gmail yahoodin and hotmail.com
so these were the two ways to
solve the same problem
now moving ahead
let's look at our sixth question
so our question is
write the sql query to find duplicate
records from a table without using a
temporary table
now
one of the other variants of this
question is
to delete all the duplicate records from
a table without using a temporary table
now to solve such queries you can use
the group by and the having clause
let's look at how to do it
so
here on my sql workbench i'll write my
select query as select
star
and then
i want to count all the duplicate values
let me give it an alias name as
frequency
from
my table name which is employ here
and then i want to group by
name
having
count
star
greater than one
let me just run it
all right you can see it has returned me
two rows
the name is angela in mike
and
the frequency is 2. let me just verify
this to see
all the repeated records that were
present in my employee table so i'll
write select star from
employee
if i run this
and scroll down here you can see angela
is present
here
as well as at the bottom similarly we
have mic present twice in the table and
hence
our sql query returned only angela and
mike because they were repeated twice
you can see the frequency here
so let's now look at our seventh
question
given the below employee table
i want to write a query to find all the
even and odd records from the table
so as you can see there are two ways to
do it
one is to use a sub query and another
you can use the mod function so let me
show you both the ways
all right so let me run this sql query
to see all the values present in the
employee table
so if you see the last column which is
the employee id column has
all the employee ids as unique values so
i am going to use this in my where
condition
so
to find out all the even records
i'll write my sql query something like
this
i'll write select star
from employee which is my table name
where
employee id
then i'm going to give my
in operator
and inside the in operator i am going to
write my sub query which is select
employee id
from employee
where
employee id
percentage 2 is equal to
this means
wherever my employee id is divisible by
it will return only those records so let
me just run it
there you go so here we have easily
fetched only the even records from the
table
similarly
if you want to get only the odd records
from the table you can use the mod
function also so i'll write select
star
from
employee
where
here i am using the mod function
mod
emp id
comma
is not equal to 0 so i'll use the
exclamation mark
is equal to 0
so if i run this it will return only the
odd employee ids
you can see it here
so those were the two ways in which you
can fetch the even and odd records from
the table
now
let's see our eighth question
so here is the
question below is the customer table
write a query to get the first purchase
of each customer
now if you look at the table
there are three customer ids
101 102 and 103.
now customer101
made its first purchase on 2nd october
2018 which is this one
and customer 102
made its first purchase on
5th of october 2018. and since we have
just one record for customer id 103 so
this is going to be
his or her first purchase
so i want to return
phone 102 tablet and 103 books
to do this
we are going to use an inner join
if you can see i have used an inner join
and i have also used a sub query
let's write this query on my
sql workbench
okay
so this query is going to be a little
complicated if you have any questions
then please put it in the chat section
we'll be happy to help you
so i'll start with select
i am going to take an alias name as t
dot
i'll write
cust underscore id
comma
t dot
purchased at
comma
the next field i am going to select is t
dot item
from
customers
as t
next i'm going to write my inner join
and
inside the inner join i'll write my sub
query
it's going to be
customer id
comma
i am going to take the
minimum value from the purchased at
column which is
my date column
close this
i'll give another alias as
min underscore
purchased
underscore add
from
my table name is customers
then i'm going to group it
by one
here one means
the first column that you have put in
the select statement which is customer
ids so i'm grouping by customer id
i close the bracket
and everything
i'm going to give an alias name as t1
now i'm going to join on
t dot
customer id
is equal to
t1 dot
customer id
and
my next condition would be
t dot
purchased
at
is equal to
t one dot
min underscore
purchased
underscore
at
i'll give a semicolon
i would request you to go through this
sql query in a
detailed manner so that you understand
it line by line let me just run it now
if i run it
okay
it has thrown me an error which says
table sql underscore iq customer
does not exist the reason is my table
name is customers
all right
so let me run it once again
okay so there's one more error it says
unknown column purchases add so we had
made a spelling mistake here it should
be purchased at
now let's try and run it
all right there you go
so for customer id 101
the first purchase was made on 2nd of
october 2018
likewise for customer id 103 the first
purchase was made on 5th of october
and similarly for customer id 102
the first purchase was made on 5th of
october again
now moving to the 9th question
so
here we have a weather table we want to
write an sql query to find all the date
ids with higher temperature compared to
its previous dates
so if you see
we have a date id column
we have
the date
and the temperature
using this table i want to find
those ids with higher temperature
compared to its previous dates so if you
look for date id 1 the temperature is 32
for data id2 the temperature is 31.
for data id3 the temperature is
30.8
now if you clearly notice for date id 4
the temperature is 31.5 which is
actually higher than the previous
date id which is 30.8
similarly for date id5
the temperature is 33 which is again
higher than the previous date which is
31.5
now if you look at the date values they
start from 10th of march till 15th of
march 2020.
now to solve this query we are going to
use
sql joins again
and i am going to use a function called
to underscore days
now my sequel to underscore days
function returns the number of days
between a given date
and year 0.
so let's go ahead and write this sql
query
all right
so first
let me select
all the rows from the temperature table
which we are going to use for this
particular question
i'll run it
all right there's some error
actually the name of the table is
weather and not temperature so i'll
write weather
let me run it
okay so here you can see
these are all the rows present in the
weather table
and
as i explained i want to return only the
date id
and this date id which is 5. now one
thing i want to
make it clear here
that this date id should actually be 6
so there was a mistake while creating
the tables please consider this date id
as 6 and not 5.
so i want to return data id4 and data d5
all right so let me go ahead and
write my sql query so i'll write select
i'll write
a dot
date underscore
id
from
weather
as
a
comma
i'll join
weather as
b
where
a dot
temperature
is greater than
b dot temperature
and i'll give my condition
and
i'll use the function to underscore
days
and give my value a dot date underscore
val
is equal to
i'll use the function again to
underscore days
b dot
date
underscore val
plus one
now i would like to know from our
viewers
why have we used plus one in the where
condition so please put your comments in
the chat section
let me just run it
there you go so here you can see
my sql query has returned the date id 4
and 5
which means these are the date ids where
the temperature is higher compared to
the previous dates
all right
now coming to the last question on this
interesting session on sql interview
questions for data scientists
so there are two tables
one is the authors table and the other
is the books
table i want to write an sql query to
find the second highest author who sold
the most number of books
now
this is going to be my sql query again
we are going to use
joins
on both tables author and books
along with
limit and offset
operators so let me show you how to do
it
so first i am going to join my author
table and the book table so i'll write
select
a dot
author underscore name comma
i'm going to find the
sum of
copies sold from the books table so i am
giving my alias name as
b
dot
copies underscore sold which is my table
name
i'll given alias as
some underscore sold
from
author as a
join
books as
b
on
i'll write
b dot
book underscore name
is equal to
[Music]
a dot
book underscore name
i'm using book underscore name as my
criteria because
book underscore name
is the common column to both the tables
then i'll use a group by clause
i'll write group by
a dot
author name
then again i'm going to use an order by
clause i'll write order by
some underscores hold and i'm going to
order it in descending order so i'll
write dsc
i'll set my limit as 1
and
offset
as 1.
if i run this
you will find
that mysql query has thrown an error the
reason is we have used
a column called bull underscore name so
it should be
book underscore name
there was an error here
let me run it again
okay there was another small error
this would be some underscore sold
let's run it
there you go
so mysql query has returned
author 3
because
author 3 sold the second highest number
of books
now let me just remove the last
few lines in the
script let me just run it now
if i
run this you can see
author one sold the highest number of
books followed by author 3 who sold the
second highest number of books and then
it was author 2 who sold the
least number of books
so if i write
limit 1 and
offset 1
what this line of code will do is
it will skip the first row and print the
next row
so let's just run it
and you can see it has written me the
author who sold the second highest
number of books if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
hi everyone welcome to this live session
by simply learn
in today's session we'll be discussing
some of the top mathematics interview
questions for data science
these questions are based on various
topics in mathematics such as statistics
probability and linear algebra so let's
begin with our first
question the first question we have is
what is normal distribution
now normal distribution is a probability
distribution that is used to check how
your data is distributed
your data could be spread out to the
left or to the right but in many cases
the data tends to be around a central
value with no bias left or right
as you can see on your screens now this
is called a normal distribution where
half of the points are to the left and
another half of the points are to the
right of the center now such a
distribution this contributes to 68
percent of the data falling within one
standard deviation of the mean
then we have 95 percent of the data
falls within second standard deviation
of the mean so if you add up 13.6
percent and the sixty eight percent plus
thirteen point six percent
this will result in ninety five percent
of data falling within two standard
deviations of the mean and finally we
have
close to ninety nine point seven percent
of the data falling within three
standard deviations of the mean
so this is
what a normal distribution is all about
now moving on to the next question
so what are the different measures that
are used to summarize the distribution
now to get more idea about the data and
summarize the distribution
you can use three types of statistical
measures the first we have central
tendency measures then we have variation
measures and finally we have shape
measures
now under central tendency measures we
have mean median and mode
now the mean is the most frequently used
measure of central tendency in a data
set let me take you to the wikipedia
page and explain you what mean exactly
is
okay so here you can see
on the wikipedia page it has the formula
to calculate the mean of a
distribution
so this is basically the summation of
all the data points divided by the total
number of data points
so here you can see an example we want
to find the arithmetic mean of 5 values
which are 4 36
we'll pick the fourth element from our
ordered set of points that is 6 here and
hence 6 is the median for this ordered
set of points
now if you have an even number of
observations as you can see here
total we have eight observations
now the median becomes
x n by two plus x n by two plus one
divided by two
so your median becomes the mean of the
middle two numbers that is 4 plus 5 by 2
which is 4.5
all right
now the next statistical measure we have
under central tendency is called the
mode
so the mode is the most frequently
occurring value in a set of data points
so here you can see an example we have a
set of data points six three nine six
six five nine three so your mode is
going to be six here since
six is occurring thrice in the set of
data points
okay
now under variation measures we have
variance standard deviation and
interquartile range so first look at
what variance is
so variance is the average of the
squared differences from the mean
now this is the formula for variance you
can see
x i represents the individual set of
data points
and mu represents the average value so
mu is nothing but the summation of all
the data points divided by the total
number of data points so this is your
formula for variance
next we have standard deviation
so standard deviation is a measure of
the amount of variation or dispersion of
a set of values a low standard deviation
suggests that the values tend to be
close to the mean while a high standard
deviation suggests that the values are
very spread out
now here you can see the
formula for variance now this is denoted
by sigma
and
your standard deviation is nothing but
the square root of variance so here you
can see the formula for variance you
have x i minus
your mu square which is the mean of all
the data points
divided by n
then we have the interquartile range
which is also known as iqr so iqr is a
measure of variability based on dividing
a data set into quartiles so an
interquartile range measures where the
bulk of values lie
so the formula for iqr is q3 which is
the third quartile minus the first
quartile so here you can see we have a
list of data points then
we are ordering the data points first
and then
we cut the list into quarters so first
you have the q1 then you have q2 and
finally you have q3 so for these set of
data points
your iqr is going to be 7 minus 4 that
is 3
then
we have
shape measures so under shape measures
we have skewness and kutosis
so skewness is a measure of symmetry
your distribution is symmetric if it
looks the same to the left and the right
of a center point
now they are majorly of two types one is
called negative skew or which is also
known as left skew
then we have positive skewed or right
skewed
and finally we have ketosis so ketosis
is a measure of the tailness of a
probability distribution it defines how
heavily the tails of a distribution
differ from the tails of a normal
distribution so if you consider these
distributions the kutosis will calculate
the tailglass which is actually these
areas of a distribution
now let's look at a third question
so the question is
create a sparse matrix in python
now in numerical analysis a sparse
matrix or a sparse array is a matrix in
which most of the elements are 0. now
there are multiple ways to create a
sparse matrix
i'll show you two ways to create a
sparse matrix so let me take you to my
jupiter notebook where i'll create a
matrix first and then we'll see how to
create sparse matrix out of it
so i am on my jupyter notebook here
first let me import the necessary
libraries so first i am going to input
numpy as np
and then
from
scipy will import
sparse
i'll run this cell okay next let me go
ahead and create a
matrix
i'll use the np dot array function
and within this function i'll create a 3
cross 3 matrix
and i'll assign the elements
so
my first row will have one two three
next we'll have
four comma five comma six
then
we'll have
seven eight and nine
all right
let me run this cell
okay
now
let me go ahead and
print my matrix so i'll use
the print function and
let's say i'll pass in a message that is
original
matrix
comma and then pass in my variable name
that is matrix let's run it
so here you can see i have my original
matrix it is a three cross three matrix
and has nine elements in it
first
let's see how using dictionary of keys
you can create a sparse matrix
so for that
i'll write the print statement
and then
i'm going to use a function which is
called dok that stands for dictionary of
case
underscore
matrix
and i'll pass in my variable name which
is my original matrix so if i run this
you can see
i have got my dictionary of keys sparse
matrix
next
i'll show you how using diagonal storage
paste you can create a spot
that i am going to use another function
that is sparse dot
dia which stands for diagonal underscore
matrix
and within this function i'll pass in my
original matrix
variable name
if i run this
you can see we have created
diagonal storage based sparse matrix
all right
now moving to the next question
so given below
is a matrix
we need to find the inverse of this
matrix
now the inverse of a square matrix a
which is sometimes called as a
reciprocal matrix is a matrix a inverse
such that the dot product of a and a
inverse is always i which is an identity
matrix now in numpy we have a function
which you can see here that is np dot
lin alg dot inv that helps you find the
inverse of a matrix let me show you on
the jupiter notebook
first let me print my original matrix
all right
now here
i'll use the function with min that is
np
dot
lin alg
inv which stands for inverse and then
pass me my
variable name that is matrix
if i run this you can see i have got the
inverse of my original matrix
now moving to our fifth question
so this question is related to
probability
you call 2 over x and three lifts if the
time that each takes to reach you is iid
what is the probability that all the
lips arrive first
next we want to find what is the
probability that all the uber x arrive
first
now this is fairly
a simple question
first let's look at the lifts arrive
first
then first we need to find the
probability that the first car is a lift
which is going to be three by five since
we have three lifts and total we have
five
vehicles
next we want to find the probability
that the second car is the lift which is
going to be two by four
third we need to find the probability
that the third car is also a left which
is one by three now arrive first is
going to be the multiplication of the
product of
the above three probabilities that is 3
by 5 into 2 by 4 into 1 by 3 which is
nothing but 1 by 10.
next
let's say you want to find for all the
ubers that arrive first so you need to
find the probability that the first car
is uber which is nothing but two by five
since we have 2 ubers
next
the probability that the second car is
an uber is going to be 1 by 4. so the
total probability that all the ubers
arrive first is going to be the product
of 2 by 5
and 1 by 4 which is also 1 by 10.
now moving to the sixth question
the mean median and mode of a
distribution are
30 25 and 20
we need to determine if the distribution
plot will be positively skewed or
negatively skewed
so you can see from the distribution
graph the mean is to the right
median to the middle and more to the
left
so since the value of mode is less than
the mean and median the data will be
positively skewed and similarly the
skewness of the distribution is on the
left if the mean value is less than the
median and the mode occurs at the
highest frequency of the distribution
now the next question we have is
what are covariance and correlation
so covariance and correlation are
measures that help you understand the
relationship between two continuous
variables
so covariance
tells the direction of the linear
relationship between two random
variables
the direction means
if the variables are directly
proportional or inversely proportional
to each other
so increasing the value of one variable
might have a positive or a negative
impact on the value of the other
variable
now covariance can take any value
between minus infinity and plus infinity
so below you can see the formula to
calculate the covariance so you have
summation x i minus x bar x bar or x
dash here represents the mean x i
represents the individual points
then this is multiplied by y i minus y
dash or the mean of y divided by the
total number of observations
next we have correlation so correlation
explains the change in one variable
leads to how much proportion changes in
the second variable correlation tells
how strongly two random variables are
related to each other
it takes values between minus one and
plus one a negative correlation means
they are inversely proportional to each
other a positive correlation means they
are directly proportional to each other
if the correlation coefficient is zero
then there is no linear relationship
between the variables so here below you
can see the formula to calculate the
correlation
now moving to the eighth question
so what are the sampling methods used in
data science
now sampling is a statistical technique
that is used to select manipulate and
analyze a subset of data points and find
patterns and trends in the large data
set been examined
now there are two types of sampling
methods
we have probability sampling and
non-probability sampling
now under probability sampling we have
something called as random sampling
so in random sampling every individual
is chosen entirely by chance and each
member of the population has an equal
chance of being selected
then we have
stratified sampling so in stratified
sampling subsets of the population are
created based on a common factor and
samples are randomly collected from each
other
now talking about systematic sampling so
in systematic sampling a sample is
created by setting an interval
at which to extract data from the larger
population
an example could be selecting every
fifth row in a spreadsheet of 100 items
and creating a sample size of 20 rows
for analysis
and finally under probability sampling
we have
cluster sampling so in a cluster
sampling subgroups of the population are
used as the sampling unit rather than
individuals
so the population is divided into
clusters and a whole cluster is randomly
selected to be included in the analysis
now let's look at the sampling methods
that are
present under non-probability sampling
so first we have convenience sampling
so for convenience sampling the samples
are selected based on the availability
so this method is used when the
availability of samples is rare and
costly
so based on convenience samples are
selected
second we have quota sampling so quota
sampling depends on some preset standard
the proportion of characteristics in
sample should be the same as the
population
next we have purposive sampling
it is also known as judgmental sampling
you select members of sampling on the
basis of the objective of the study
it is very useful when you want to reach
a particular or targeted sample quickly
finally we have snowball sampling so the
snowball sampling technique is used in
situations where the population is
completely unknown and rare
now coming to the ninth question in our
list
so explain what p-value tells about
statistical significance
so p value is a statistical test that is
used in hypothesis testing
it helps you to decide whether to accept
or reject the null hypothesis
the null hypothesis
represented as h0
is a commonly accepted fact
it is the opposite of alternative
hypothesis
researchers and scientists work to
reject or disapprove the null hypothesis
they come up with an alternative
hypothesis that they think explains a
phenomenon and they work to reject the
null hypothesis
for example null hypothesis or h0 could
be the world is flat and an alternative
hypothesis could be the world is round
so lower the p value the greater the
statistical significance of the observed
difference
now the p-value is just one piece of
information you can use when deciding if
your null hypothesis is true or not the
p-value lies between 0 and 1 as you can
see here
the threshold for p is set to 0.05 when
the value is below 0.05 the null
hypothesis is rejected
now coming to the
final question in our list of
mathematics interview questions for data
science
the question is what do you understand
by type 1 versus type 2 error
now in statistical theory the idestical
error is an integral part of hypothesis
testing
in statistical hypothesis testing no
test is ever 100 certain
that's because we rely on probabilities
to experiment
even though hypothesis tests are meant
to be reliable there are two types so
type 1 error occurs when the null
hypothesis is true and we reject it it
is also known as a false positive
finding or conclusion an example could
be an innocent person is convicted
and type 2 error occurs when the null
hypothesis is false and we accept it it
is also known as false negative finding
or conclusion an example could be a
guilty person is not convicted so here
you can see we have a reality where your
null hypothesis is true and here we have
the null hypothesis is false and this is
where the type 1 error lies
so
this can also be represented as false
positive where the null hypothesis is
true and be rejected and this could be
false negative where the null hypothesis
is in reality it's false and we accept
it
welcome to this video tutorial series on
data science interview questions
in our previous video we had discussed
the important interview questions on
mathematics statistics probability and
linear algebra that are often asked in
any data science interview
today we will learn about some of the
machine learning and deep learning
interview questions
so let's begin with our first question
the first question is how to detect
outliers in data
so in data analytics and machine
learning
you often find data points that lie at
an abnormal distance from other points
in a random sample from a population
those are called outliers
now outliers in data can significantly
impact any prediction analysis
there are majorly three different
methods to treat outliers
first we have the univariate method
it is one of the simplest methods for
detecting outliers the univariate method
uses box plots a box plot is a graphical
display for describing the distributions
of the data
box plots use the median and the lower
and upper quartiles
this method looks for data points with
extreme values on one variable
next we have the multivariate method
so the multivariate outliers can be
found in an n-dimensional space having n
features
we look for unusual combinations of all
the variables in this method finally we
have minkowski error
this method reduces the contribution of
potential outliers in the training
process
the minkowski error is a loss index that
is more insensitive to outliers than the
standard mean squared error now moving
on to the second question
what is a confusion matrix
so a confusion matrix is a table that is
used to describe the performance of a
classification model and a set of test
data for which the true values are
already known
the target variable has two values
positive or negative
the columns represent the actual values
of the target variable which you can see
here
the rows represent the predicted values
of the target variable
which you can see here now there are
four important terms that are related to
confusion matrix
first we have
true positive which is this one
so in true positive the predicted value
matches the actual value
so the actual value was positive and the
model also predicted a positive value
then we have true negative
which is also represented as tn the true
negative depicts the predicted value
matches the actual value
now the actual value was negative and
the model predicted a negative value
next we have false positive now false
positive is also known as type 1 error
in false positive the predicted value
was falsely predicted the actual value
was negative but the model predicted a
positive value
finally we have false negative the false
negative is also known as type 2 error
so in false negative the predicted value
was falsely predicted the actual value
was positive but the model predicted a
negative value
now moving to our third question
which is explain the roc curve
now the roc curve is one of the most
important evaluation matrix for checking
the performance of any classification
model
roc stands for receiver operating
characteristic
receiver operating characteristic or roc
curve is a method to compare the
diagnostic tests
the roc curve was created by plotting
the true positive rate against the false
positive rate at various threshold
settings so here on the y-axis you have
the true positive rate on the x-axis we
have the false positive rate the true
positive rate indicates the proportion
of observations that were correctly
predicted to be positive out of all
positive observations similarly the
false positive rate is the proportion of
observations that are incorrectly
predicted to be positive out of all
negative observations
you can take an example suppose in
medical testing the true positive rate
is the rate in which people are
correctly identified to test positive
for the disease in question let's say
the coronavirus testing roc does not
depend on any class distribution this
makes it useful for evaluating
classifiers predicting rare events such
as diseases or disasters now moving to
the fourth question we have
what are the assumptions for linear
regression
so linear regression analysis is used
for modeling the relationship between a
single dependent variable y
and one or more feature or predictor
variables
some of the important assumptions for
linear regression are
so first
they should have linearity so linear
regression needs the relationship
between the independent and the
dependent variables to be linear
it is also crucial to check for outliers
since linear regression is sensitive to
outlier effects next we have
homocydasticity
homoscedasticity
illustrates a situation in which the
error term that is
the noise or random disturbance in the
relationship between the features and
the target variable is the same across
all levels of the dependent variables
third we have independence so
observations should be independent of
each other
finally we have no multi-collinearity
so there should be little or no
multi-co-linearity independent variables
should not be too highly correlated
now moving to our fifth question in our
list of interview questions
the question is
what is regularization in machine
learning explain the l2 regularization
so regularization is a machine learning
technique that is used to reduce the
errors by fitting the function
appropriately on the training set in
order to avoid overfitting of data so
overfitting happens when a model learns
the detail and noise in the training
data to the extent that it negatively
impacts the performance of the model on
new data so here you can see we have
a nice plot which shows how overfitting
of data can be visualized
and here
we have
a good fit line over the same data
points
so this is also known as the regression
line
now l2 regularization is also known as
ridge regression
so ridge regression modifies the
overfitted model by adding the squared
magnitude of coefficient as a penalty
term to the loss function so on the
right you can see
a set of data points plotted and we have
our linear regression line
and here we are calculating the cost
function for the ridge regression line
so our cost function is actually loss
plus lambda into summation of w squared
where loss is actually the sum of
squared errors or squared residuals
lambda stands for penalty for the errors
w is called the slope of the curve or
line
okay
now consider a case
where there are two points
passing through the linear regression
line
now if you calculate the cost function
we get the value as 1.69 so here we have
assumed that loss is zero since the two
points lie directly on the line
we have taken lambda to be one and w is
one point three
so if you use this function
or this formula
you get the cost function as one 1.69
now moving ahead
let's consider another situation where
we'll calculate the same cost function
for the ridge regression line
there is some loss for both the points
as they are not on the same line so here
you can see the sum of squared residuals
is
0.05 is actually is the sum of 0.2
square i'm assuming this as 0.2
and 0.1 for this one
so if you square both and add it the
value is 0.05 and lambda is again 1 and
w we have assumed to be 0.6
now if you find the cost function the
value is 0.41
let's draw the linear regression line
and the ridge regression line with all
the points we find that the ridge
regression line as the best fit since
its cost function is less
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now coming to the sixth question
what are the different methods to split
a tree in a decision tree algorithm
so there are three methods to split a
decision tree first we have variance
so reduction in variance is an algorithm
that is used for continuous target
variables
this algorithm uses the standard formula
of variance to choose the best split so
here you can see the standard formula
variance which is summation of x that is
all the
individual points minus x bar which is
the mean
squared divided by the total number of
observations
now the split with lower variance is
selected as the criteria to split the
population
now the steps to calculate variances you
need to calculate variance for each node
and then you need to calculate for each
split as the weighted average of each
node variance
moving ahead
the second method we have is information
gain
so information gain is used for
splitting the nodes when the target
variable is categorical
it works on the concept of entropy
now the degree of disorganization in a
system is known as entropy
so here you can see the formula for
information gain which is 1 minus
entropy
finally we have
gini impurity
so gini impurity is the probability of
incorrectly classifying a randomly
chosen element in the data set if it
were randomly labeled according to the
class distribution in the data set so
below you can see the formula for gene
impurity
so we have one minus summation of p i
whole square
where n represents the number of classes
and p of i represents the probability of
randomly picking an element of class i
now moving to the seventh question
so the question is how do we find the
optimum cluster value in k-means
clustering algorithm
now there are two methods to find the
optimum cluster value
so first we have the elbow method which
is one of the most well known for
finding the optimum number of clusters
so in this method you need to calculate
the
within cluster sum of squared errors for
different values of k and choose the k
for which within clusters sum of squared
errors first starts to diminish
so in the below plot of squared errors
versus the number of clusters k
you can see
at k is equal to 4 the squared error
starts to diminish so hence our optimum
k value is 4.
next we have the silhouette method
so the celoid method measures how
similar a point is to its own cluster
compared to other clusters
the average silhouette method computes
the average steroid of observations for
different values of k
the optimum number of clusters k is the
one that maximizes the average solid
over a range of possible values for k
the solid score reaches its global
maximum at the optimal k so in our case
the average silhouette reaches maximum
at key is equal to 2 which you can see
here so
our optimum cluster value will be 2 here
moving ahead
the eighth question in our list is
how does the pooling layer work in a
convolutional neural network
so the pooling layer performs a down
sampling operation in order to reduce
the dimensionality of the feature map
so in the pooling operation you slide
a two-dimensional filter over each
channel of feature map and summarize the
features lying within the region covered
by the filter
it is a common practice to periodically
insert a pooling layer in between
successive convolutional layers in a
convolutional neural network
architecture
so the pooling layer operates
independently on every depth slice in
the input and resizes it spatially using
the max operation
so in the diagram shown here you can see
we have a rectified feature map we are
using a 2 cross 2 filter and performing
a max pooling operation
so consider this as the filter if you
perform the max operation over the
values
let's say
zero five three and one so considering
this one our pool feature map
maximum value will be five similarly for
this chunk of data it is going to be
seven
next if you slide the filter over this
square frame you get eight and similarly
here you get six so this is also known
as a pooled feature map
moving ahead
the ninth question in our list is how
does lstm network work so long
short-term memory networks are a type of
recurrent neural networks that are
capable of learning order dependence and
sequence prediction problems so
remembering information for long periods
of time is practically their default
behavior now lstms also have
this chain like structure which you can
see here
but the repeating module has a different
structure so instead of having a single
neural network layer there are four
interacting in a very special way
now you can see these are called as
gates these gates contain sigmoid
activations
a sigmoid activation is similar to the
tannage activation
instead of
squishing values between minus one and
plus one it squeezes values between zero
and one
and lstm has four gates
now these are called forget remember
learn and use or output so if you see
this in the first step we use the forget
gate that decides what information
should be thrown away or kept
the information from the previous hidden
state and the information from the
current input is passed through the
sigmoid function
values come out between 0 and 1.
so if the value is closer to 0 it means
you need to forget that information
and if the value is closer to 1 it means
you need to keep that information
next we have the input gate so the input
gate is used to update the cell state
first we pass the previous hidden state
and the current input into a sigmoid
function
that decides which values will be
updated by transforming the values to be
between 0 and 1
0 means not important and one means
important
you also pass the hidden state and
current input into the tanh function to
flatten the values between -1 and plus
1.
this helps to regulate the network
then you multiply the tanh output with
the sigmoid output the sigmoid output
will decide which information is
important to keep from the tanh output
and finally in step 3 we have the output
gate this output gate is used to decide
what the next hidden state should be
first we pass the previous hidden state
and the current input into a sigmoid
function then we pass the newly modified
cell state into the tanh function
we then multiply the tanh output with
the sigmoid output to decide what
information the hidden sheet should
carry
the output is the hidden state
the new cell state and the new hidden
state is then carried over to the next
time step
finally
talking about the last question in our
list of interview questions we have
explained the concept of gradient
descent in deep learning now gradient
descent is an optimization algorithm
which is mainly used to find the minimum
of a function
in machine learning gradient descent is
used to update the parameters in a model
parameters can vary according to the
algorithm such as coefficients in linear
regression and weights in neural
networks
you can see
we have these maps and on the
y-axis we have the loss
on the x-axis we have the weight
and here we are trying to find the local
minimum or the global minimum
now this gradient decent method is used
to minimize the cost function and update
the parameters of the learning model
the gradient always points in the
direction of the steepest increase in
the loss function
the gradient descent algorithm takes a
step in the direction of the negative
gradient in order to reduce the loss as
quickly as possible
to determine the next point along the
loss function curve the gradient descent
algorithm adds some fraction of the
gradient's magnitude to the starting
point now this process is repeated to
find the global minimum
and that brings us to the end of this
video on data science 2022 full course
by simplyload i hope you liked it if you
have any queries then please feel free
to put them in the comment section of
the video thank you for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you